hello everyone welcome to this full
course video on python for data science
in this video we will cover everything
you need to know to become a data
scientist our experienced instructors
with good industry experience will take
you through this course
first
you will understand the basics of data
science in 5 minutes from an animated
video you will then learn the important
libraries in python for data science
such as numpy pandas and matplotlib
you will get an idea about the data
science concepts along with mathematics
statistics and linear algebra
we will then focus on some of the
essential data science algorithms such
as linear regression logistic
regressions decision trees and random
forests k nearest neighbors and k-means
clustering
you will also learn about feature
selection cost functions and principal
component analysis
finally you will learn how to become a
data scientist in 2021 so let's begin
are you one of the many who dreams of
becoming a data scientist
keep watching this video if you're
passionate about data science because we
will tell you how does it really work
under the hood emma is a data scientist
let's see how a day in her life goes
while she's working on data science
project well it is very important to
understand the business problem first in
our meeting with the clients emma asks
relevant questions understands and
defines objectives for the problem that
needs to be tackled she is a curious
soul who asks a lot of eyes one of the
many traits of a good data scientist
now she gears up for data acquisition to
gather and scrape data from multiple
sources like web servers logs databases
apis and online repositories oh it seems
like finding the right data takes both
time and effort after the data is
gathered comes data preparation this
step involves data cleaning and data
transformation data cleaning is the most
time consuming process as it involves
handling many complex scenarios here
emma deals with inconsistent data types
misspelled attributes missing values
duplicate values and what not then in
data transformation she modifies the
data based on defined mapping rules in a
project etl tools like talent and
informatica are used to perform complex
transformations that helps the team to
understand the data structure better
then understanding what you actually can
do with your data is very crucial for
that emma does exploratory data analysis
with the help of eda she defines and
refines the selection of feature
variables that will be used in the model
development but what if emma skips this
step she might end up choosing the wrong
variables which will produce an
inaccurate model thus exploratory data
analysis becomes the most important step
now she proceeds to the core activity of
a data science project which is data
modeling she repetitively applies
diverse machine learning techniques like
knn decision tree knife base to the data
to identify the model that best fits the
business requirement she trains the
models on the training data set and test
them to select the best performing model
emma prefers python for modeling the
data however it can also be done using r
and sas well the trickiest part is not
yet over visualization and communication
emma meets the clients again to
communicate the business findings in a
simple and effective manner to convince
the stakeholders she uses tools like
tableau power bi and click view that can
help her in creating powerful reports
and dashboards and then finally she
deploys and maintains the model she
tests the selected model in a
pre-production environment before
deploying it in the production
environment which is the best practice
right after successfully deploying it
she uses reports and dashboards to get
real-time analytics further she also
monitors and maintains the project's
performance well that's how emma
completes the data science project we
have seen the daily routine of a data
scientist is a whole lot of fun has a
lot of interesting aspects and comes
with its own share of challenges now
let's see how data science is changing
the world data science techniques along
with genomic data provides a deeper
understanding of genetic issues in
reaction to particular drugs and
diseases logistic companies like dhl
fedex have discovered the best rules to
ship the best suited time to deliver the
best mode of transport to choose thus
leading to cost efficiency with data
science it is possible to not only
predict employee attrition but to also
understand the key variables that
influence employee turnover also the
airline companies can now easily predict
flight delay and notify the passengers
beforehand to enhance their travel
experience well if you're wondering
there are various roles offered to a
data scientist like data analyst machine
learning engineer deep learning engineer
data engineer and of course data
scientist the median base salaries of a
data scientist can range from 95 000 to
165 000
so that was about the data science are
you ready to be a data scientist if yes
then start today the world of data needs
you python is the most widely used
programming language today when it comes
to solving data science tasks and
challenges python never ceases to
surprise its audience most data
scientists out there are already
leveraging the power of python every day
hi i'm abeksha from simplylearn and well
after some thought and a bit more
research i was finally able to narrow
down my choice of top python libraries
for data science what are they let's
find out so let's talk about this
amazing library tensorflow which is also
one of my favorites so tensorflow is a
library for high performance numerical
computations with around 35 000 github
comments and a vibrant community of
around 1500 contributors and it's used
across various scientific domains it's
basically a framework where we can
define and run computations which
involves tensors and tensors we can see
are partially defined computational
objects again where they will eventually
produce a value that was about
tensorflow let's talk about the features
of tensorflow so tensorflow is majorly
used in deep learning models and neural
networks where we have other libraries
like torch and theano also but
tensorflow has hands down better
computational graphical visualizations
when compared to them also tensorflow
reduces the error largely by 50 to 60
percent in neural machine translations
it's highly parallel in a way where can
train multiple neural networks and
multiple gpus for highly efficient and
scalable models this parallel computing
feature of tensorflow is also called
pipelining also tensorflow has the
advantage of seamless performance as
it's backed by google it has quicker
updates frequent new releases with the
latest of features now let's look at
some applications tensorflow is
extensively used in speech and image
recognition text based applications time
series analysis and forecasting and
various other applications involving
video detection so favorite thing about
tensorflow that it's already popular
among the machine learning community and
most are open to trying it and some of
us are already using it now let's look
at an example of a tensorflow model in
this example we will not dive deep into
the explanation of the model as it is
beyond the scope of this video so here
we are using amnest dataset which
consists of images of handwritten digits
handwritten digits can be easily
recognized by building a simple
tensorflow model let's see how when we
visualize our data using matplotlib
library the inputs will look something
like this then we create our tensorflow
model to create a basic tensorflow model
we need to initialize the variables and
start a session then after training the
model we can validate the data and then
predict the accuracy this model has
predicted 92 accuracy let's see which is
pretty well for this model so that's all
for tensorflow if you need to understand
this tutorial in detail then you can go
ahead and watch our deep learning
tutorial from simply learn as shown in
the right corner interesting right let's
move on to the next library now let's
talk about a common yet a very powerful
python library called numpy numpy is a
fundamental package for numerical
computation in python it stands for
numerical python as the name suggests it
has around 18 000 comments on github
with an active community of 700
contributors it's a general purpose
array processing package in a way that
it provides high performance
multi-dimensional objects called arrays
and tools for working with them also
numpy addresses the slowness problem
partly by providing these
multi-dimensional arrays that we talked
about and then functions and operators
that operate efficiently on these arrays
interesting right now let's talk about
features of number it's very easy to
work with large arrays and mattresses
using numpy numpy fully supports object
oriented approach for example coming
back to nd array once again it's a class
possessing numerous methods and
attributes ndra provides for larger and
repeated computations numpy offers
vectorization it's more faster and
compact than traditional methods i
always wanted to get rid of loops and
vectorization of numpy clearly helps me
with that now let's talk about the
applications of numpy numpy along with
pandas is extensively used in data
analysis which forms the basis of data
science it helps in creating the
powerful n-dimensional array whenever we
talk about numpy the mention of the
array we cannot do it without the
mention of the powerful n-dimensional
array also number is extensively used in
machine learning when we are creating
machine learning models as in where it
forms the base of other libraries like
sci by scikit learn etc when you start
creating the machine learning models in
data science you will realize that all
the models will have their basis numpy
or pandas also
when number is used with scipy and
matplotlib it can be used as a
replacement of matlab now let's look at
a simple example of an array in numpy as
you can see here there are multiple
array manipulation routines like there
are basic examples where you can copy
the values from one array to another we
can give a new shape to an array from
maybe one dimensional we can make it as
a two dimensional array we can return a
copy of the array collapsed into one
dimension now let's look at an example
where this is a jupiter notebook and we
will just create a basic array and
for detailed explanation you can watch
our other videos which targets on these
explanations of each libraries so first
of all whenever we are using any library
in python we have to import it so now
this np is the alias which we will be
using let's create a simple array
let's look what is the type of this
array
so this is an end array type of array
also let's look what's the shape of this
array
so this is a shape of the array now here
we saw that we can expand the shape of
the array
so this is where you can change the
shape of the array using all those
functions now let's create another using
arrange functions if i give arrange 12
it will give me a 1d array of 12 numbers
like this now we can reshape this array
to 3 comma 4 or we can write it here
itself
so this is how arrange function and the
reshape function works for numpy now
let's discuss the next library which is
scipy so this is another free and open
source python library extensively used
in data science for high level
computations so this library as the name
suggests stands for scientific python
and it has around 19 000 comments on
github with an active community of 600
contributors it is extensively used for
scientific and technical computations
also as it extends numpy it provides
many user-friendly and efficient
routines for scientific calculations now
let's discuss about some features of
scipy so scipy has its collection of
algorithms and functions which is built
on the numpy extension of python
secondly it has various high level
commands for data manipulation and
visualization also the ndmh function of
scipy is very useful in
multi-dimensional image processing and
it includes built-in functions for
solving differential equations linear
algebra and many more so that was about
the features of sci-fi now let's discuss
its applications so cyber is used in
multi-dimensional image operations it
has functions to read images from disk
into number arrays to write arrays to
discuss images resize images etc solving
differential equations fourier
transforms then optimization algorithms
linear algebra etc let's look at a
simple example to learn what kind of
functions are there in sci by here i'm
importing the constants package of scipy
library so in this package it has all
the constants
so here i am just mentioning c or h or
any and this library already knows what
it has to fetch like speed of light
blanks constant etc so this can be used
in further calculations data analysis is
an integral part of data science data
scientists spend most of the day in data
munching and then cleaning the data also
hence mention of pandas is a must in
data science life cycle yes pandas is
the most popular and widely used python
library for data science along with
numpy and matplotlib the name itself
stands for python data analysis with
around 17 000 comments on github and an
active community of 1200 contributors it
is heavily used for data analysis and
cleaning as it provides fast flexible
data structures like data frames series
which are designed to work with
structured data very easily and
intuitively now let's talk about some
features of pandas so panas offers this
eloquent syntax and rich functionalities
like there are various methods in pandas
like drop n a fill n a which gives you
the freedom to deal with missing data
also partners provides a powerful apply
function which lets you create your own
function and run it across a series of
data now forget about writing those for
loops while using pandas also this
library's high level abstraction over
low level numpy which is written in pure
c then it also contains these high level
data structures and manipulation tools
which makes it very easy to work with
pandas like their data structures and
series now let's discuss the
applications of pandas so panas is
extensively used in general data
wrangling and data cleaning then pandas
also finds its usage in edl jobs for
data transformation and data storage as
it has excellent support for loading csv
files into its data frame format then
pandas is used in a variety of academic
and commercial domains including
statistics finance neuroscience
economics web analytics etc then pandas
is also very useful in time series
specific functionality like date range
generation moving window linear
regression date shifting etc now let's
look at a very simple example of how to
create a data frame so data frame is a
very useful data structure in pandas and
it has very powerful functionalities so
here i'm only enlisting important
libraries in data science you can
explore more of our videos to learn
about these libraries in detail so let's
just go ahead and create a data frame
i'm using jupyter notebook again and in
this before using pandas here i'm
importing the pandas library
let me go and run this so in data frame
we can import a file a csv file excel
file so there are many functions doing
these things and we can also create our
own data and put it into data frame so
here i am taking random data and putting
in a data frame also i'm creating an
index and then also giving the column
names so pd is the alias we've given
pandas random data of 6x4 index which is
taking a range of six numbers and column
name i'm giving as abcd now let's go
ahead and look at it
so here it has created a data frame with
my column names up abcd
my list has six numbers zero to five and
a random data of six by four so
dataframe is just another table with
rows and columns where you can do
various functions over it also i can go
ahead and describe this data frame to
see so it's giving me all these
functionalities where count and mean and
standard deviation etc okay so that was
about pandas now let's talk about next
library and the last one so matplotlib
for me is the most fun library out of
all of them why because it has such
powerful yet beautiful visualizations
we'll see in the coming slides plot and
matplotlib suggests that it's a plotting
library for python it has around 26 000
comments on github and a very vibrant
community of 700 contributors and
because of such graphs and plots that it
produces it's majorly used for data
visualization and also because it
provides an object oriented api which
can be used to embed those plots into
our applications let's talk about the
features of matplotlib the pi plot
module of matplotlib provides
matlab-like interface so matplotlib is
designed to be as usable as matlab with
an advantage of being free and open
source also it supports dozens of
back-ends and output types which means
you can use it regardless of which
operating system you're using or which
output format you wish pandas itself can
be used as droppers around matplotlibs
api so as to drive matplotlib via
cleaner and more modern apis also when
you start using this library you will
realize that it has a very little memory
consumption and a very good runtime
behavior now let's talk about the
applications of matplotlib it's
important to discover the unknown
relationship between the variables in
your data set so this library helps to
visualize the correlation analysis of
variables also in machine learning we
can visualize 95 percent confidence
interval of the model just to
communicate how well our model fits the
data then matlab finds its application
and outlier detection using scatter plot
etc and to visualize the distribution of
data to gain instant insights now let's
make a very simple plot to get a basic
idea i've already imported the libraries
here so this function matplotlib inline
will help you show the plots in the
jupiter notebook this is also called a
magic function i won't be able to
display my plots in the jupiter notebook
if i don't use this function i am using
this function in
numpy to fix random state for
reproducibility now i'll take my n as 30
and will assign random values to my
variables so this function is generating
30 random numbers here i'm trying to
create a scatter plot so i want to
decide the area
let's
put this so this is multiplying 30 with
random numbers to the power 2 so that we
get the area of the plot which we will
see in just a minute so using the
scatter function and the alias of
matplotlib as plt i've created this if i
don't use this and i have very small
circles as my scatter plot it's colorful
it's nice so that's one very easy plot i
suggest that you explore more of
matplotlib and i'm sure you will enjoy
it let's create a histogram so i'm using
my the style as ggplot and assigning
some values to these variables any
random values
now we are assigning bars and colors and
alignment to the plot and here we get
the graph so we can create different
type of visualizations and plots and
then work upon them using matplotlib and
it's just that simple so that was about
the leading python libraries in the
field of data science but along with
these libraries data scientists are also
leveraging the power of some other
useful libraries for example like
tensorflow keras is another popular
library which is extensively used for
deep learning and neural network modules
keras drafts both tensorflow and theano
backends so it is a good option if you
don't want to dive into details of
tensorflow then scikit learn is a
machine learning library it provides
almost all the machine learning
algorithms that you need and it is
designed to interpolate with numpy and
sci-by then we have c bond which is
another library for data visualization
we can say that seaborn is an
enhancement of matplotlib as it
introduces additional plot types so
let's start with what is numpy numpy is
the core library for scientific and
numerical computing in python it
provides high performance
multi-dimensional array object and tools
for working with arrays and i'll go a
step further and say there are so many
other modules in python built on numpy
so the fundamentals of numpy are so
important to latch on to for the python
so you can understand the other modules
and what they're doing numbies main
object is a multi-dimensional array it's
a table of elements usually numbers all
of the same type indexed by a tuple of
position integers in numpy dimensions
are called axes
take a one-dimensional array or we have
remember dimensions are also called axes
you could say this is the first axis
zero one two three four five and you can
see down here it has a shape of six why
because there's six different elements
in it in the one dimension array and
they usually denote that as six comma
with an empty node on there and then we
have a two dimensional array where you
can see zero one two three four five six
seven and in here we have two axes or
two dimensions and the shape is two four
so if you were looking at this as a
matrix or in other mathematical
functions you can see there's all kinds
of importance on shape we're not going
to cover shape today but we will cover
that in part 2. did you know that
numpy's array class is called in the
array for numpy data array
now we're going to take a detour here
because we're working in python and two
of my favorite tools in python is the
jupiter notebook and then i like to use
that sitting on top of anaconda and if
you flip over to
jupiter.org that's j-u-p-y-t-e-r.org
you can go in here you can install it
off of here if you don't want to use the
anaconda notebook but this is the
jupiter setup the documentation on the
jupiter jupiter opens up in your web
browser that's what makes it so nice is
it's portable the files are saved on
your computer they do run in ipython or
iron python and you can create all kinds
of different environments in there which
i'll show you in just a minute i myself
like to use anaconda that's
www.anaconda.com
if you install anaconda it will install
the jupiter notebook with the anaconda
separate and you can install jupyter
notebook and it'll run completely
separate from anaconda's jupiter
notebook and you can see here i've now
opened up my anaconda navigator what i
like about the navigator and this is a
fresh install on a new computer which is
always nice i can launch my jupyter
notebook from in here i can bring other
tools so the anaconda does a lot more
and under environments i only have the
one environment and i can open up the
terminal specific to this environment
this one happens to have python37 in it
the most current version as of this
tutorial in the open terminal if you're
gonna do your pip installs and stuff
like that for different modules you can
also create different environments in
here so maybe you need a python three
six python three five you can see we're
having a nice framework like anaconda
really helps so you don't have to check
track that on your own in the jupiter
notebook in your different jupiter
notebook setups we'll go ahead and
launch this jupyter notebook and then
i've set my browser window for a default
of chrome so it's going to open up in
chrome and you can see here this opens
up a folder on my computer we have a
couple different options on here
remember i set the environment up as
python 3.7 you would install any
additional modules that aren't already
installed in your python on this and it
keeps them separate so you do have to
for each environment install the
separate modules so they match the
environment on there and in here we have
a couple things we can look up what's
running
you have your different clusters again
this is i just installed this on a new
machine so i just have the one a couple
things in here that were run on here
recently
and what we go on here is we then have
on the upper right new and from the pull
down menu you'll see python three
and this will open up a new window
and now we're in jupiter python so this
is a python window and we'll just do a
print
and this of course is let's go hello
world
and we'll run that and it prints out
hello world in the command line there's
a couple special things you have to know
we're not going to do today which is on
graphics if you've never seen this
one of the things you can do you can
also do a equals hello world and if you
just put the a in there now if you do a
bunch of these we have a equals hello
world b equals goodbye world and you put
a b a then return b it'll only run the
last one but you can see here if you put
the variable down here it will show you
what's in that variable
and that has to do with the jupyter
notebook inline coding so that's not
basic python that's just jupiter
notebook shorthand which you'll see in a
little bit
so back to our numpy number array versus
python list python list being the basic
list in your python why should we use
numpy array when we have python list
well first it's fast the numpy array has
been optimized over years and years by
multiple programmers and it's usually
very quick compared to the basic python
list setup it's convenient so it has a
lot of functionality in there there's
not in the basic python list and it also
uses less memory so it's optimized both
for speed and memory use
and let's go ahead and jump into our
jupyter notebook since we're coding best
way to learn coding is to code just like
the best way to learn how to write is
right and the best way to learn how to
cook is cook so let's do some coding
here today
and just like any modules we have to
import numpy we almost always import it
as np that is such a standard so you'll
see that very commonly we can just run
that and now we have access to our numpy
module inside our python and then the
most common thing of course is to go and
create a number array
and in here we can send it a regular
list
and so we'll go ahead and send this a
regular array uh let's do one two three
to make it simple and then i'm just
going to type in a and we'll run this
and so you can see down here the output
is an array of one two three
and we could also do
print just a reminder that this is an
inline command so that wouldn't work if
you're using a different editor you can
see that it's an array one two three but
we'll go and leave it as a
kind of a nice feature so you can see
what you're doing really quick in the
jupyter notebook
and just like all your other standard
arrays i can go
a of 0
which is going to be a value of 1.
of course we do a of 1. you go all the
way through this
i have 1 has a value of 2 in it
so whether you're using the numpy array
or the basic python list that's going to
be the same that should all look pretty
familiar and it'd be pretty
straightforward remember the first value
is always 0
and when we set on there so let's take a
look why we're using numpy because we
went over the slide a little bit but
let's just take a look and see what that
actually looks like and what we want to
look at is the fact that it's fast
convenient and uses less memory so let's
take a glance at that in code and see
what that actually looks like when we're
writing it in python and what the
differences are
and to do this i'm going to go ahead and
import a couple other modules we're
going to import the time module so we
can time it and we're going to import
the system module so that we can take a
look at how much memory it uses and
we'll go and just run those so those are
imported
so we'll do b equals oh range of one
yeah one thousand is fine
and so that's going to create a list of
one thousand zero to nine hundred ninety
nine remember it starts at zero and it
stops right at the 1000 without actually
going to the 1000.
and let's go ahead and print
and we want system.getsizeof
and we'll pick any integer because we
have you know zero to
a thousand we'll just throw one in there
five it doesn't matter because it's
gonna whatever integer we put in there's
gonna generate the same value because
we're looking the size of how how much
memory it stores an integer in
and then we want to have the length of
the b that's how many integers are in
there
and if we go ahead and execute this and
run this in a line we'll see oops i did
that wrong comma
if we multiply them together
we'll see it generates 28
000 so that's the size we're looking at
is 28 000 i believe that's bytes that
sounds about right
so let's go ahead and create this in
numpy
and we'll go with c equals np
and this is a range
so that's the numpy command to do the
same thing that we were just doing in a
list
and we'll also use the same value on
there the 1000
and then once we've created the
c
value of c for np dot a range let's go
ahead and print
and we can do that by doing c dot size
times
c dot
item size
that's very similar we did before we did
get the size of so the c size is the
size of the array and each item size
just reversed
so it's the size of an integer 5 item
size is going to be the integers and c
size
let's just take a look and see what that
generates
and wow okay we got four thousand versus
twenty eight thousand
that's a significant difference in
memory how much memory we're using with
the array and then let's go ahead and
take a look at uh speed let's do um oh
let's do size we tried this with lower
values and it would happen so fast that
the np array kept coming up with zero
because it just rounded it off so size
and let's create an l1
pulse
range of size
and we'll do an l2
i'll just set up to the same thing it's
also range
of size on there there we go
and then we can do on a1
equals
np dot
a range size
and then let's do an a
2 equals n p dot
a range
we'll keep it the same size
and what we're going to do is we're
going to take these two different arrays
and we're going to perform some basic
functions on them
but let's go ahead and actually just
load these up now we'll go ahead and run
this so those are all set in memory
except for the typo here
quickly fix that
there we go so these are now all loaded
in here and let's do a start
equals
time dot time
so it's just going to look at my clock
time and see what time it is
and we'll do result equals and let's do
oh let's say we got
an array and we're going to say
let's do some addition here x
plus y
for x comma y
and
and we'll zip it up here
two different arrays so here's our two
different arrays we're going to multiply
each of the individual things on here l1
l2
there we go so that should add up each
value so l1 plus l2 each value in each
array
then we want to go ahead and print
and let's say
python list took
and then we'll do
time
dot time
we'll just subtract the start out of
there so time whoops i messed up on some
of the quotation marks on there
okay there we go
time minus the start
and we'll convert that to second so
we'll go because in milliseconds or
times one thousand
and let's hit the run on there it's kind
of fun because you also get a view while
we're doing this
of some ways to manipulate the script
and as you can see also my bed typing
there we go okay so we'll go ahead and
run this
and we can see here that the python list
took 34
actually i have to go back and look at
the conversion on there but you can see
it takes roughly 0.34 of a second and we
go ahead and print the result in here
too
let's do that
i'll run that just so you can see what
the what kind of data we're looking at
and we have the zero two four six eight
so it's just adding them together it
looks pretty straightforward on there
and if we scroll down to the bottom of
the answer again we see python list took
46 a little different time on there
depending on what
core because i have this is on an eight
core computer so it just depends on what
core it's running on what else is
pulling on the computer at the time
and let's go back up here and do our
start time
paste that into here
and this time we're going to do a result
equals and this is really cool notice
how elegant this is it's so
straightforward this is a lot of reason
people started using numpy is because i
can add the two arrays together by
simply going a1 plus a2 it makes a lot
of sense both looking at it and it's
just very
convenient remember that slide we're
looking at fast convenient and less
memory
so look how convenient that is
really easy to read real easy to see
and i don't know if we don't need to
print the result again so let's just go
ahead and print
the time on here and we'll borrow this
from the top part
because i really am a lazy typer
and this isn't the python list this is
the numpy list or number array
and let's go ahead and see how that
comes out
and we get 2.99
so let's take a look at these two
numbers 46 versus 2.99 so we'll just
round this up to 3. that's a huge
difference that's that's like
more than 10 times faster that's like 15
times roughly at a quick glance i'd have
to go do the math to look at it and it's
going to vary a little bit depending on
what's running in the background the
computer obviously so we've looked at
this and if we go back here we found out
it's much faster
yes there's different going to be
different speeds depending on what
you're doing with the array very
convenient easy to read and it uses less
memory so that's the core of the numpy
that's why a lot of people base so many
other modules on numpy and why it's so
widely used
so we did glance at a couple operations
when we were looking at speed and size
let's dive into a little bit more into
the basic operations
and these are always nice to see i mean
certainly you want to go get a cheat
sheet if you're using it for the first
time you know look things up google is
your friend
we did this we're the most basic numpy
dot array or np.array
and we'll go ahead and create an array
let's do
pairs
one comma two
and then let's do three comma four and
if we're gonna do that let's do five
comma six
there we go and if we go ahead and take
this
and run this i can go ahead and do our a
down here so it's in line and i'll print
that out
you can see it makes a nice array for us
so we have a and if you look at that we
have three different objects each with
two values in them and hopefully you're
starting to think well how many
dimensions or indexes is that and you'll
see three by two so let's go ahead and
take a look and let's go how about a dot
in dimensions speaking of which
we'll run that and we have two
dimensions for each object
and then we can do the item size so a
dot
we saw this earlier we looked up how
many items it was up here where we want
to multiply item size times the actual
size of the object so the memory is
being used versus the item size
and we should see
four there
memory is compressed down that's always
a good thing
and then the shape the shape is so
important when you're working with data
science and you're moving it from
one format to another
so we have our shape we just talked
about that we have three by two three
rows by two objects in each one
generally i don't look too much at the
size but the dimensions i'm always
looking up this is nice you can automate
it so you might be converting something
you might need to know how many
dimensions are going into the
next machine learning package so that
you can automatically just have it send
that information over
so we looked at a shape
let's go and create a slightly different
array np dot array let's go ahead and
just do as our original
setup here
and one of the features we can do which
is really important is we can do d type
equals in this case let's do
np
float
64. and so what we've done is converting
all of these into a float and we type in
a
and now instead of having one two three
four five six you see they're all float
values one dot zero there's no actual
zero in there just so it's the one dot
or the one period two three period four
period five period six period
and this again data science i don't know
how many times i've had to convert
something from an integer to a float so
that's going to work correctly in the
model i'm using
so very common features to be aware of
and to be able to get around and use
and we'll also do let's just curiosity
item size
we'll go ahead and run that
and we see that it doubled in size so
it's not a huge increase well doubling
is always a big increase in computers
but it's not a huge increase compared to
what it would be if you're running this
in the python list format
and then we did the shape earlier
without having it set to the float 64.
let's go ahead and do a shape with it
set to 64. and it should be the same
three comma two so it all matches
so we've gone through and remember if
you really if this is all brand new to
you
according to the cambridge study at the
cambridge university if you're learning
a brand new word in a foreign language
the average person has to repeat it
163 times before it's
memorized so a lot of this you build off
of it so hopefully you don't have to
repeat it 163 times but we did manage to
repeat it at least twice here if not a
little bit more
and let's go ahead and take this we're
going to look at one more setup on here
and let me just take this last statement
here on the converting our properties of
our data
and instead of float 64
let's do complex let's just see what
that looks like and let's go and print
that out and run it
and so we now have a complex data set up
and you'll see it's denoted by the one
dot plus zero dot j
and if we flip over here and do a basic
search for numpy data types better to go
to the original web page but pull up a
bunch of these you can see there's a
whole list of different numpy data types
shorthand complex we have complex
complex 64 complex 128
complex number represented by 64-bit
floats real and imaginary components
one option on there float16 float32
float shorthand for float64 most
commonly used and of course all the
different ones that you can possibly put
into your numpy array so we covered a
basic addition up there we're comparing
how fast it runs but some very basic
components how to set up a numpy array
how many dimensions it has item size
data type item again we went to item
size and there's also
the
shape probably one of the more used i
used a shape all the time very commonly
used
and then down here you can see where we
actually created a numpy complex data
type
so let's look at some other features in
numpy one of them is you could do numpy
dot
zeros
and we're gonna do three comma four
there we go and we'll go ahead and run
this and you can see if i do
np.0s i create a numpy array of zeros
this is really important i was
rebuilding my own neural network and i
needed to create an array where i
initialized the weights and i want them
all to be the same weight in this case i
wanted them to start off as zero for the
particular project i was working on and
there's other options like you can do
numpy ones
and we'll do the same thing three comma
four we'll run that
and you can see i've created an array of
numpy ones in this case it comes out as
a float array
and this is an interesting to note
because we have let's go back to our
python and do lrange 5
and we'll print the l so as our list
and if i run that
it doesn't create the range until after
the fact until you actually execute it
that's an upgrade in python python 2 7
actually created the array zero one two
three four this one actually creates the
script and then once it's used it then
actually generates the array
and if we do that in numpy a range
remember that from before
and if we do numpy a range five
and let's do uh l equals
or we can just leave it as numpy that's
fine there we go just run that
you can see there we actually get an
array 0 two three four for the value the
don't be arranged a range five generates
the actual array
and for part one we're going to do just
one more section on basic
setup
and we're going to concatenation
do a concatenation out example
there we go we're going to do strings
let's take a look at strings what's
going on with there
and let's do
oh let's see print
let's do an
character something new here
and we're going to add
and then here's our brackets for what
we're going to add
oh and let's say
let's do
hello comma hi
and
in the brackets on there let's create
another one
and this one's going to be
abc
and we'll do
xyz so we're just creating some randomly
making some up on here and then we'll go
ahead and just print this
if we run that and come down here
and of course make sure all your
brackets are open and closed correctly
and then
you can see in here when we concatenate
the example in numpy
it takes the two different arrays that
we set up in there and it combines the
hello with the abc and the high with xyz
and if we can also do something like
print
oh let's do
np character dot
multiply
so there's a lot of different functions
in here again you can look these up it's
probably good to look them all up and
see what they are but it's good to also
just see them in action let's do hello
space comma three
and we'll run this one
and run that without the error you'll
see it does hello hello hello so we
multiplied it by three and we can also
let's just take this whole thing here
instead of retyping it
and we can do character
center so instead of multiply let's do
center
and over here
keep our hello going
take the space out of there
and let's do center it 20
and fill
character
equals and we'll fill it with dashes
so if we run this
you can see it prints out the hello with
dashes on each side and we keep going
with that we can also addition to doing
the fill function we can play with
capitalize we can title we can do
lowercase we can do uppercase we can
split split line strip join these are
all the most common ones and let's go
ahead and just look at those and see
what those look like each one of them
here we're going to do the hello world
all-time favorite of mine i would like
to say hello universe and you can see
here we did a capital h with the world
but so we want to capitalize so
capitalize is the first one in the array
so we get hello world on there and we
can also take this and instead of
capitalizing
another feature in here is title and
let's just change this to how are we
doing
how
are you doing instead of
do you
let's run that
and you can see here because we created
as a title it capitalizes the first
letter in each word
and in this one we're going to do
character lower
two different examples here we have an
array we have hello world all
capitalized and we have just hello and
you can see that one is an array and one
is just a string if we run that
you get a an array with hello world
lowercase and hello lowercase
and if we're going to do it that way we
can also do it the opposite way there's
also upper
and let's paste those in there and you
can see here we have
character.upper opposite there
python.data and we'll do python is easy
hopefully you're starting to get the
picture that most of the python and the
scripting is very simple
it's when you put the bigger picture
together and starts building these
puzzles and somebody asks you hey i need
the first letter capitalized unless it's
the title and then we have you start
realizing that this can get really
complicated so numpy just makes it
simple and we like that
and so in this case we did python data
it's all uppercase python is easy like
shouting in your messenger python is
easy and then if you're ever processing
text and tokenizing it
a lot of times the first thing you do is
we just split the text and we're just
going to run this in p dot character dot
split are you coming to the party if we
do that returns an array of each of the
individual words are you coming to the
party splitting it by the spaces
and then if we're going to split it by
spaces we also need to know how to split
it by lines
and just like we have the basic split
command we also have split lines
hello and you'll see here the scoop in
for our new line
and when we run that if you're following
the split part with the words you should
see hello how are you doing the two
different lines are now split apart
and let's just review three more before
we wrap this up commonly used string
variable manipulations we have strip and
in this case we have
nina admin anita and we're going to
strip a off of there let's see what that
looks like
and then you end up with nin diminish it
basically takes up all leading and
trailing letters in this case we're
looking for a
more common would be a space in there
but it might also be punctuation or
anything like that that you need to
remove from your letters and words
and if we're going to strip and clean
data we also need to be able to reformat
it or join it together so you see here
we have a character join we'll go ahead
and run this
and it has on the first one it splits
these letters up by the colon and the
second one by the dash and you can see
how this is really useful if you're
processing in this case a date we have
day month year year month date very
common things to be have to always
switch around and manipulate depending
on what they're going into what you're
working with
and finally let's look at one last
character string we're going to do
replace
if you're doing misinformation this is
good pulling news articles replacing
is and what in this case we're just
doing here's a good dancer and we're
going to replace is with was
and you can see here he was a good
dancer hopefully that's not because he
had a bad fall he just was from like you
know 1920s and it's gotten old
so there we go we covered a lot of the
basics in numpy as far as creating an
array very important stuff here when
you're feeding it in how do we know the
shape of it the size of it what happens
when we convert it from a regular
integer into a float value as far as how
much space it takes we saw that that
doubled it item size you have your n
dimensions and probably the most used is
shape we'll cover more on shape in part
two so make sure you join us on part two
because there's a lot of important
things on shaping in there and setting
them up we also saw that you can create
a
zeros based array you can create one
with ones if we do a range you can see
how it is a lot easier to use to create
its own range or a range as it is in
numpy
you saw how easy it was to add two
arrays we saw that earlier just plus
sign then we got into
doing strings and working with strings
and how to concatenate so if you have
two different arrays of strings you can
bring them together we also saw how you
can fill so you can add a nice headline
dash dash dash
we saw about capitalize the first letter
we saw about turning it into a title so
all the first letters are capitalized
doing lowercase on all the letters upper
for all the letters just lower and upper
nice abbreviation we also covered how to
split the character set how to strip it
so if you want to strip all the a's out
from leading ai a's and ending a's or
spaces you can do that very easily also
how to join the data sets so here's a
character join option for your strings
and finally we did the character replace
pandas really is a core python module
you need for doing data science and data
processing there's so many other modules
that come off of it there it actually
sits kind of on numpy so if you've
already had our numpy array hopefully
you've already gone through the numpy
tutorial one and two so today we're
going to cover what is pandas we'll
discuss series we'll discuss basic
operations on series then we'll get into
a data frame itself basic operations on
the data frame file related operations
on a data frame visualization and then
some practice examples roll up our
sleeves and get some coding underneath
there and let's start with just some
real general what is pandas pandas is a
tool for data processing which helps in
data analysis it provides functions and
methods to efficiently manipulate large
data sets
now this is a step down from say using
spark or hadoop in big data so we're not
talking about big data here but we are
talking about pandas when there is some
connections there's like an interface
going on with that so there is
availability but you really should know
your pandas because if you're working in
big data you'll know there's data frames
well pandas is a data frame primarily it
has a couple different pieces we'll look
at here and if you've never worked with
data frames before a data frame is
basically like an excel spreadsheet you
have rows and columns you can access
your data either by the row or the
column and you have an index and
different that kind of setup and we'll
dig more into that as we get deeper into
pandas but think of it as like a giant
excel spreadsheet that's optimized to
run a larger data on your computer and
then i said it that it's a data frame so
the data structures in pandas are series
one dimensional arrays and then we have
data frame two-dimensional array and it
really centers around the data frame the
series just happens to be part of that
data frame and here's a closer look at a
pandas series series is a
one-dimensional array with labels it can
contain any data type including integers
strings floats python objects and more
so it's very diverse if you remember
from numpy we studied they had to be all
uniform not in pandas and pandas we can
do a lot more and pen is actually kind
of sits on numpy so you really need to
know both of those if you haven't done
the numpy tutorials and you can see here
we have our index one two three four
five and then our data a b c d and e
very straightforward it's just two
columns and we have a nice index label
and a column label for the data and then
a data frame is a two dimensional data
structure with labels we can use labels
to locate data and you can see here we
had if we go back one we had our index
one two three four five so in each one
of these series they would share the
same index over there the row index so
you have your row index df dot index and
then you have a column index df.columns
and this should look like i said this
would be really familiar if you've done
any work with spreadsheets excel so it
kind of resembles that this does make it
a lot easier to manipulate data and add
columns delete columns move them around
same thing with the rows so you have a
lot of control over all of this now
we're of course going to do this in our
jupiter notebook you can use any of your
python editors but i highly suggest if
you haven't installed jupiter and
haven't worked with it it is probably
one of the best ways for easily
displaying a project you're working on i
skip between a lot of different user
interfaces or ides for editing my python
and it's just simply jupiter.org
j-u-p-y-t-e-r.org
and then i always let mine sit on
anaconda anaconda.com
and just real quick we'll open that up
for you oops offline mode don't show me
that again but you can see here that i
have different tools that i can actually
install in my anaconda including the
jupyter notebook which comes by default
and then i have access to the
environments
and again that's
anaconda.com named after the very large
one of the largest world's largest
snakes and then jupiter notebook in this
case jupiter.org and when we're in our
i'm going to go in here to our jupiter
notebook and we're going to go ahead and
just do new and a python 3
and this will open up a python 3
untitled folder
so diving right in let's go ahead and
give this a title pandas tutorial and
we'll go up to cell and we'll change the
cell type to mark down so it doesn't
execute it as actual code
one of those wonderful tools when you
have jupiter notebook so you can do
demos with this and let's go ahead and
import
pandas
and usually people just call it pd that
has become such a standard in the
industry so we'll go ahead and run that
now we have our pandas has been imported
into our jupyter notebook
and then oh we can go ahead and let me
do the control plus since it's internet
explorer i can enlarge it very easily so
you have a nice pretty view oops too big
there we go and whenever you're working
with a new module it's good to check
your version of the module in pandas you
just use the in this case pd dot
underscore underscore version underscore
underscore but that's actually pretty
common in most of our python modules
there's different ways to look up the
version but that's one of the more
common ones and we'll go ahead and run
that we get 0.23.4
and if we go to the pandas site we see
0.23 0.23.4 as the latest release and of
course a reminder that if you're going
to environment you need to install it so
you'll need to do pip install pandas if
you're using the pip installer we'll
close out of that
and the first thing we want to do is
we're going to work with series a lot of
stuff you do in series you can then do
on the whole data set we need to do what
create one we need to manipulate it
take pieces of it so query it query
it delete so you can delete different
parts of it so we want to do all those
things with the series and we'll start
with the series and then almost all the
code in fact all the code does transfer
right into
the actual data table so we go from a
series of a single list of one column
and then we'll take that and we'll
transfer that over to the whole table
and we'll start by creating let's put up
there we go
creating a series from
list
and let's just call this arr equals
and we'll do
0 1 2 3 4. if you remember from our last
one we could easily do
r equals
range of 5 which would be zero to four
but we'll do r equals zero to four and
we'll call this s1 and we'll go pd
and
series is capitalized this one always
throws me is which letters do you
capitalize on these modules they're
getting more and more uniform but you
got to watch that with python and we're
just going to go ahead and do arr so
we're just going to take this python
list and we're going to turn it into a
series
and then because we're in jupiter we
don't have to put the print statement we
can just put s1 and it'll print out this
series for us
and let's go ahead and run that and take
a look
and you'll see we have two rows of
numbers so the first one is the index
now it automatically creates the index
starting with 0 unless you tell it to do
differently so we get 0 index row 0 0 1
1 2 2 3 3 4 4. and because it's a series
it doesn't need a title for the column
there's only one column so why title it
and this also lets you know that it's a
data type of integer 64. so we print
this out this is our series our basic
series we've just created
and let's do a second series
pd and we'll use the same
data list and let's go ahead and do
order we'll give it an order
equals oh let's do it this way
let's go
index
equals order
and it helps if we actually give it an
order so we'll do order
equals and let's do one two three four
five so instead of starting with zero
we're going to give it an order starting
with one we're going to run that and
we'll go ahead and print it out down
here s2
and we'll see that we now have an index
of one two three four five and that
represents zero one two three four in
the series and we're still data type
integer 64. and very common as you're
missing with numpy arrays is we can
import our numpy as np remember that
from our numpy tutorials we can go ahead
and create a numpy out of random with
the random numbers of five
and let's just see what that end looks
like so we see what our number looks
like so we have some nice random float
values here 2.33 so on and that's from
our last tutorial the numpy tutorial 1
and 2. and instead of calling it order
let's call it index
and we're going to set our index equal
to a b c d and e
i want to show you that the index
doesn't have to be an integer so it can
be something very different here and
then let's go ahead and create our we'll
just use s2 again and here's our np for
numpy series capital s
and n is our
np for numpy
pd for pandas there we go switching my
anachronisms so we have pd.series of n
and we want to do our index equals our
index we just created
and then let's go ahead and see what
that looks like s2 is a print it and
let's run that
and we can see here we have a nice
series going on a b c d and e for our
indexes so instead of being 0 1 2 3 or 4
we can make this index whatever we want
and you can see the numbers here going
down that we randomly generated from the
number array so we use numpy to create
our panda series right here
and so continuing on with creating our
series this one i use so often we create
a series from a dictionary so we have
our dictionary in this case we went
ahead and did a of 1 b is 2 c of 3 d4
ef5 so each one of those is a key and
then a value and then we're going to use
oh let's use s3 equals pd for pandas
series
and then we want to go ahead and just do
d in here
print out s3 here and let's go ahead and
run this and you can see we got a is one
b is two c is three d is four e is five
and it's still of integer sixty four
because the actual data is one two three
four five and it's all integers
sixty-four type sixty-four and the last
thing we want to do in the creating
section of our series is to go ahead and
modify the index because we're going to
start modifying all this data so let's
start with modifying the index of the
series and if you remember let's do a
print this time s1
i'll go ahead and run this and the
reason i did print is because it only
prints out the last variable so if i put
s1 up here and we're going to do another
variable back down lower it won't print
the first one just the last one and
we're going to go ahead and take s1
the index and we're just going to set it
equal to a new index and obviously
the number of objects in our index has
to equal the number of objects in our
data and then because it's the last
variable we can go ahead and just do an
s1 and let's run that and you can see
how we went from 0 to 0 0 1 2 3 4 as our
index we've now altered it to a b c d
and e
so this would be much more readable or
might be representational of a larger
database you're working with
so cool tools we've covered creating a
database based on
a basic array python array we've showed
you how to
reset the index
then we showed you how to use a numpy
array so you can put a numpy array in
there it's all the same you know
pd.series a numpy array and then we can
set the index on there and the same
thing with the dictionary so it's very
versatile how it pulls in data and you
can pull in data from different sources
and different setups and create a new
series very easily in
the pandas and then we looked on
changing your index so now we have a new
index on here
and then we want to go ahead and do some
selection let's do some basic
slicing most common thing you'll
probably do on here and we'll just do s1
this notation should start to look
really familiar again this is going to
put an output so i'd usually it doesn't
change s1 this just selects it so we
might do a equals s1 and then print a
and you'll see that it just looks at the
first three zero one two and we can do
the same thing by not having the a in
there
i'll go ahead and take that out but just
a reminder that it's not actually
changing s1 it's just viewing s1 so
simple slicing on here and we can
likewise do an append oops before we do
a pen let's just do a quick kind of fun
one we'll do two minus one and you'll
see it covers everything but the e of
course you can do minus two on this side
so one another way to select it is to go
how far from the end and likewise we can
do a two here
cde to the end so it starts at the
second one and another way we can do
this is we can do a minus two over here
and that looks at just the last two in
the slice so you can see how easy it is
to slice the data and of course
there's no reason to do this but you
could select all of them
if you wanted to view all of them on
there helps 32 there's not 32 so it's
just going to show the first three there
we go and then we can also append so i
can take and oh let's create another
series and append one to it
and if you remember we had s3 there's
our s3 and we have our s1 we'll go ahead
and do s1
and let's go ahead and do
oh let's call it s4
equals s1
a pin
s3
so we're just going to combine those two
into s4
and if we go ahead and print s4 on here
you'll now see that we have a b c d e a
b c d e zero one two three four one two
three four five because we started the
data at one
so very easy to append one series to the
next
and if we're going to append one series
to the next we need to go ahead and drop
or delete one and drop is a key word for
that and let's just do e or index e and
so if i run this
you'll see that it'll print it out and
a b c d there's no e
and remember all these changes if i type
in s4 again you'll see that s4 still has
e in it so this change does not affect
the series unless you tell it to so i'd
have to do like x s4 equals s4 dot drop
e and there's another way to do that
which we'll show you later on let me
just cut this one out
there we go
all right so we've covered all kinds of
cool tools here we have appending we
have slicing we did all the creating
stuff earlier as you can see here on the
setup how easy it is to manipulate the
series
so next what we want to get into is we
want to get into
operations that happen on the series let
me go ahead and change this cell to
markdown there we go and run that so
series operations what can we do with
the series and let's start by creating a
couple arrays we'll call it array one
and we'll do zero through seven and
array two six through six seven eight
nine
five i don't know i threw the five on
the end let's go ahead and run those so
those load up into jupiter
and uh we'll do this a little backwards
we're gonna do s5 equals a panda series
of array two so i'm doing this in
reverse and then when we do s5 you'll
see that we have zero to four it
automatically assign the index
for our series
and let's go ahead and do the same and
we'll call this s6 and we'll set this
equal to pd series for
our first array
and if we do an s6 down here to print it
out
we'll see something similar i got zero
through six
zero one two three four five seven for
the data so those are two series we just
created series six five and six
and one of the first things we can do is
we can add one series to the next so i
can do s5 dot add s6 and let's see what
that generates and just a quick thing if
you never use pandas what do you think
is going to happen with the fact that
this only has five different values in
it and this one has seven values
so let's see what that does
and we end up with 6 8 10 12 9 and it
goes oh i can't add this there's nothing
there so it gives us a null return
very different than the numpy that would
have given you an error this instead
tells you there's no value here because
we couldn't generate one so we can
easily add s5 dot add s6 and likewise we
can do s5 dot
sub for subtract s6
and we'll run that and on the add the
subtract and you guessed it we're going
to do multiply and divide next again you
can see there's the null values where it
can't subtract the two because there's
no values there to subtract we can also
do s5 multiply mul they're all three
letters on these that's one of the ways
to remember how they figured out the
code for this so remember these are all
three letters mole we'll go ahead and
run this
and you can you can see how they're
multiplied together and then we can also
do the s5 div three letters again
s6 and run that
and you'll see here this goes to
infinity because we have zero in the
wrong position so it actually gives you
a whole different answer here that's
important to notice and then in the null
values because there's no data and it
can't actually produce an answer off of
null off of missing data and since we're
in data science let's do s6
median so let's look at the median data
which is simply median sorry for those
who are following the three letters
because median is not three letters and
you can see an s6 is 3.0 and let's do a
print here and we'll do median
or average
s6
and let's print max
comma s6
and just like median there's max value
and if we're going to have a max value
we should also have a minimum value so
let's pop in minimum
we'll go ahead and run this
and you're starting to see something
that would be generated like say an r
where you're starting to get your
different statistics we have a median
value of 3 max value of 7 and a minimum
value of 0. and what it does when it
hits these null values if there is no
values in there because we could still
do that we could actually you know what
let's go up here and do
let's pick this one we multiplied let's
go s7
equals
i'll go and print the s7 just so i keep
it nice and uniform so i still have my
s7 down there and run it
and then i want to take the s7
because s7 now has
null values and an infinity value and
let's see what happens
this is gonna be interesting cause i
wanna see what it does with infinity
and we end up with a median of six
maximum of 27 and minimum of zero which
is correct it drops those values so when
it gets to there and it doesn't know
what to do with them it just drops those
values and then it computes it on the
remaining data on there so that's
important to know when you're making
these computations you're looking at min
and max and median
you're not going to know that there's no
values unless you double check your data
for the null values it's a very
important thing to note on there so just
a real quick
review on there we've done our created
our pd series and we've
gone ahead and done addition subtraction
multiplication division all those are
three letters so sub min div add
and then we looked at median maximum and
minimum so we're going to go ahead and
jump into the next big topic which is to
create a data frame
so now we're going to go from series and
we're going to create a number of series
and bundle them together to make a data
frame
there we go cell type markdown let me go
ahead and run that so we have a nice
title on there it's always good to have
a good title all right so our first data
frame we'll jump in with some stuff that
looks a little complicated we'll break
it down first i'm going to create some
dates and you know what let's just go
ahead and do this i want you to see what
that looks like what i'm creating here
i've created a series of dates pd date
range and we're going to use these for
the index okay
so when you look at this you'll see that
it's just basically it comes out kind of
like a basic python list or a number
however you want to look at it with our
different dates going down and we've
generated six of them and it's going to
have whatever time it is right now on
your on the thing for the date for the
time that's that time stamp right there
and then you'll see we have 11 19 2008
11 20 11 19 and looking into the future
there so that's all this is is
generating a series of dates that we're
going to use as our index and this is a
pandas command so we have a date range
which is nice that's one of the tools
hidden in there in the pandas that you
can use
and next we're going to use numpy to go
ahead and generate some random numbers
in this case we'll do the
np.random.random
in 6 comma 4. you can look at this as
rows and columns as we move it into the
pandas and of course you could reshape
this if you had those backwards on your
data but we want the six to match the
rows and we have six periods so our
indexes should match along with the rows
on there and then you know before we do
the next one let's go ahead and just
print out our numpy arrays and see what
that looks like here we have it one two
three four by one two three four five
six four by six
so it's a nice little setup on there and
since working with data frames can be
very visual let's give our columns we
have four columns and we're going to
give them names a b c and d so now we
have columns on there also and then
let's put this all together in a data
frame and we can actually you know what
let's do this since i did it with
everything else let's go ahead and do
columns and you can see there's our
columns on there and we'll go ahead and
do df1 equals
pandas dot
data frame and note that the d and the f
are capitalized series it was just the s
and i always highlight this because you
don't know how many times these things
get retyped when you forget what's
capitalized on there it's a minor thing
you'll pick it up right away if you do a
lot of it and the first thing we want to
do is we want to go ahead and take our
numpy array because that's what we're
going to create our data frame off of
it's a numpy array and then we want our
index equal to our dates so there's our
index in there and then we also have
columns equals
columns
and then finally let's see what that
looks like
remember we had all the different data
that just looked like a jumble of data
we have our column names and everything
else our numpy array kind of just a
jumble array over there 4x6 you could
sort of read it but look how nice this
looks i mean this is you come into a
board meeting you're working with your
shareholders
this is pretty readable this is you know
this is our date this is our a b c d
whatever it is maybe each one of these
dates has your leads
closures lost leads total dollar made
you know whatever it is if it's in a
business maybe it's measurements on some
scientific equipment whether searching
material you know where this is like
higher the temperature low of the day
humidity of the day whatever it is so
you can see that we can really create a
nice clear chart and it looks just like
a spreadsheet you know we have our rows
and we have our columns and we have our
data in there now this one i use all the
time if we're going to create we can
create it like you saw here with our
numpy array very easy to do that and
reshape it you can also create it with a
dictionary array so here we have some
data let me just go down a notch so you
can see all the data on there we have an
animal in this case cat cat snake dog
dog cat snake cat dog we have the age so
we have an array of ages we have the
number of visits and the priority was it
a high priority yes
no
and then we're going to take that we're
going to create some labels we have a b
c d e f g h i and what i want you to
notice on this is we have a title animal
and then we have basically a python list
and these lists they don't necessarily
have to be equal because we can have
non-data you know np.nand numpy array
null value but we want to go ahead and
create labels that are equal to the
number in the list so a
the first cat b the second cat c the
snake d the dog and so on so we'll go
ahead and create our labels which we're
going to use as an index
and we'll call this df let's do it this
way we'll call this df2
equals pd for pandas
data frame
and then we have our data just like we
did before and we have our index equals
labels and if we're going to go from
there let's go ahead and print it out so
we can see what that looks like df2 so
let's go ahead and run that another
again you have a nice very clean chart
to look at we've gone from this mess of
data here to what looks like a very
organized spreadsheet very visual and
easy to read
animal age visits priority and then a
through j cats and all your different
animals so on and so on and then when
you do programming a lot of times it's
important to know what the data types
are so we can simply do df2
d types
and if we run that we can see that our
animal
is an object because it's just a string
but it comes in as an object age is a
float64 integer 64 and then priority
again is just an object
and exploring this this one's very
popular let's go df to
[Music]
head
and if we print that out the df2 head
returns the first five and we can change
this you don't have to do five you might
want to just look at the top two maybe
you want to look at
let's see let's do six so maybe we'll
look at just the top six in the database
in your data frame and you can actually
this creates another data frame so i
could have a df three equal to df2 and
this now takes the df2 and just the
first six values
so if we do df3
run get the same answer
and if we do it the head of the data we
can also do the tail it's the same thing
df tail you can look at the last we'll
just do the tail which by default does
five the last five and of course you can
just look at the last three of those
real quick just to see what's at the end
of the data and this is i need to tell i
love doing the tell of one because i'll
have like the index or something like
that and it will just show me the last
whatever the last entry was looking at
stock values and i might want to look at
just the last five days of the stock
values i can do that with the data frame
tail
and some other key things to look up
are the index so we can do df2.index
and i want you to notice that this isn't
a call function so if i put the brackets
on the end it'll give me an error
because index is not callable it's just
an object in there
so we do
df2.end there's also columns
so we can go ahead and let's do a let's
print this
remember the first one is not going to
show unless i print it and then df2
column so now we can see we have our
indexes and we have our columns listed
here df2.columns animal age visits
priority it tells you what kind of
object it is
or what kind of data type it is and
they're both object
and then finally df2 dot values and
again there's no brackets on the end of
df2.values
because this is an actual object it's
not a callable function so we'll go
ahead and run that and it creates just
displays a nice array a very easy way to
convert this back to a numpy array
basically so before i go into the next
section let's just take a quick look at
what we covered so far with the data
frame we came up here we created our
data frame we did it from a numpy array
first
setting the columns and the index the
index is setting it up is the same as
when we set up the series so that should
look very familiar so is the whole
format the numpy array the index dates
and the columns columns and remember in
our numpy array we're looking at row
comma column so six rows four columns is
how that reads in the data frame
and we went ahead and also did that from
a dictionary in this case animal was the
column name with all the date data
underneath that column and then age with
that data visits that data priority that
data and then of course we added our
labels in there for our index so there's
no difference in there but it
automatically pulled the column names
important to know when you're dealing
with a data frame and importing a data
frame this way
and then we did looking up d type we
looked at head and tail looking at your
data really quick
we also did index and columns and values
and note these don't have the brackets
on the end
so the next thing we want to do is go
ahead since we're dealing with data
science is we want to go and describe
the data so we have df2 dot describe to
do that and we're going to manipulate it
in just a minute but let's just see what
this generates
and you can see right here we have age
and visits
so looking at our data from up above let
me just go all the way up here
animal age visits priority
and it does a nice job generating your
age versus visits which has all the data
you have your account your means your
standard deviation your minimum value
25 or in this group 50 75 and your
maximum value so this should look
familiar as a data science setup with
your describe for a quick look at your
data frame data so let's start
manipulating this data frame moving
stuff around and we'll start with
transposing and it is simply capital t
for transpose and when we run that it
flips the columns and the indexes so now
the indexes are all column names and the
columns are all indexes animal age
visits priority
so if we had come in here with our data
shaped wrong up above where we had a 4x6
we can quickly just swap it if we had it
backwards not a big deal and we can also
sort our data something that you can't
do which is more difficult to do with a
lot of other packages in the data frame
it's really easy to do take our data
frame df2 and we're going to sort
underscore values
by equals age and so when we run this
you'll see the default is ascending so
we have 0.52 2.53 and everything else is
organized so if you look at your indexes
they've been moved around because each
index it moves a whole row not just the
one piece of data is not being sorted so
a very quick way to sort by age our
different data in the data frame and in
addition to sorting it we can also slice
the data frame so i could do df2 and
this should look familiar from earlier
we'll just do one
to three so we're going to pull out
oops it does help if i use a df instead
of just d and we're going to pull up
just between one and three so we have no
zero which is a we have b which is two
or b which is one and c which is two so
one 2 and then it does not include 3
which is the standard in python and we
can even do something like this we can
combine them which is always fun because
remember this returns a data frame so if
i take df2 dot
sort
values and we'll do by
equals age this is just kind of fun and
then i'm going to slice it
there we go double check my typing and
run it
and now you should see fa because fa are
now one and two on there
so you can very quickly create a whole
string on here which narrows it you know
that you can sort it then slice it and
do all kinds of fun things with your
data frame we'll just go back to the
original one run there we go and if we
can slice it by row we can also query
the data frame so we can do df2 and this
is a little different because i'm going
to create an array within an array and
in this case we're going to look at oh
let's do age comma
visits
so look at the different format in here
we have one to three so we've done this
by slicing by an integer value and then
on here i've done df2 age comma visits
in an array and when i run this
you can see that we get just these two
columns on here we get agent visits so
it's a quick way to select just two
columns or select number of columns
you're working with and if you stop
there we did the slicing almost
identical to slice is i location which
uses the integer location one comma
three
there's a push in pandas to move to this
particular setup instead of doing just a
regular slice and that's because this
can be confusing when we slice one to
three and then we select age and visits
so there is a push to go ahead and move
to an eye location which does the same
thing you can see here bc it's the same
as up above there's also copy command so
we can do df3 equals df2 copy we're just
going to create a straight copy of it
and of course if we do df3
it'll be the same as the df2 on there so
df3 equals df2.copy
and then let's do df3 dot is null so
we're looking for null values
and this will return a nice map and
you'll see that everything is false
except when you go up here under the cat
or h they had a null there and so if we
go down a couple up here also underneath
of let's see the dog okay there's a
bunch of nulls in here there's d up here
so let's look at d down here and you'll
see false true there it is there's our
null value so we can create a quick
chart of null values you can use this to
do other things we can leverage that
null value to maybe take an average or
something and fill those null spaces
with data
and we can also modify the location so
here's our df3
location
and notice this is location not i
location ilocation has i for integer
location uses the in this case the
variables on the left and what we can do
on here and we're going to set this
equal to
1.5
and then let's um i'll pick a spot
let's go back up here where we had let's
do f
a just let's see what are we looking at
oh here we go let's do f and h
and up here f is set to age of 2.0 and
we find out that that's incorrect data
so we go ahead and switch to df3
equal and then we're going to print out
our df3
and if we go to f and age it is now 1.5
so we're just changing the value in the
df3 and this is changing the actual data
frame remember a lot of our stuff we do
a slice
and like it returns another data frame
this changes the actual data frame and
that value in the data frame
so we've covered location and eye
location is null making a copy here's
our eye location which is equivalent of
a slice and also selecting columns
so now we want to dive just take a
little detour here and let's look at df3
means
and this is kind of nice because you can
do this
you can either do this by as you can
select a single column here by the way
you can just add the column selection
right here like we did before
so we could have age
look up the mean that just creates a
series if i run that there's our age
but if i take that out instead of
selecting it we can do the whole setup
and it has age and visits so why doesn't
it have priority or animal
well those are not integers so it's
really hard
they're non-numerical values so what is
the average i guess you could do a
histogram which uh probably we'll look
at that later on but the only two things
we can really look at is age and visits
and we have
the average or the mean on the age is
3.375
and the mean on visits is 1.9
and let's do df3
visits we'll go ahead and steal the
visits again
and remember all those different
functions we looked at for a series well
we can do those here we can do the sum
so if we run that we'll see that these
sum up to 19. we could also look up
minimum if you remember that from before
the minimum is one
max
so all that functionality is here
i'll just go back to summing it up and
adding it all together so real quick
we've shown you how to take the series
operations and put them into the data
frame and then we can actually this is
interesting one we can just do df3 sum
run and you'll see the different
summations on there
it just combines them i like the way it
just combines the strings on there for
priority and animal we've looked at is
null we've also looked at copying along
with the different slices which we
talked about earlier so let's talk about
strings let's dive into the string set
up on there and let's go ahead and
create a string series string equals pd
series and we just put it right in there
we have a c d a a b a c a popped in a
null value
cow and al i don't know why they picked
cal and al in the background someone
must like those animals and of course we
can just do string if we run that you'll
see
leave the r out we'll get an error but
if we put it in there you'll see that we
have a simple series 0 a 1c 2d and it
automatically indexes it 0 to 8.
and then we can go string dot lower so
when we're talking about our data frame
in this case or our data series string
in this case we use the string
function str and we're going to make it
lower and if we go ahead and put the
brackets on there and you'll see that
we've gone from capital a capital c so
on to abc and baca cba cow al they were
all lower case already and of course if
you want to go lower you can also do
upper we'll go ahead and run that
and you can see we now have a c d a a
everything's capitalized except for the
null value which is still null all right
so we looked at a few basic string you
can see that string functions upper and
lower
we're going to jump into a very
important topic i'm even going to give
it its own
header on here because it's such an
important topic what do you do with
missing values
panda has some great tools for that so
we'll dive into those we'll call we'll
work with df4 and if you remember the df
copy from above we're just going to make
a copy of df3 and let's just take a
quick look at the data we're working
with oops df3 forgot the three on there
there we go
so here we have our cats snakes and dogs
hopefully not all in the same container
because that would be just probably mean
to all of them so we made a copy we're
going to be working with df4 and the
reason we made a copy is we want to go
ahead and fill the data and we just
simply do fill in a and then we're going
to give it the value we want to put in
there we'll give it the value 4. so i
can run in here and you'll see now that
df4
now has where the n a was is filled with
a value of 4. same thing down here
a lot of times we'll compute the mean
first so i might do a mean
age
equals df4 and then we want to go ahead
and do age
and dot mean
and then i'll do something like this df4
i only want to select the age
and i want to fill that
with the mean
h
and i run in there and you'll see that
our df4h now has the means in there just
a quick way of showing you how you can
combine these
let me go back to our original one there
we go and run that
and keeping with good practices df5
equals df three dot copy
and we'll print our df5 which should be
the original one
and then on the df5 we can now drop our
missing data
i'm going to simply drop in a and we're
going to use how equals any so i'm going
to drop any row that has missing data in
it and you'll see we had d here with
missing data and h
and then let's go ahead and see what df5
looks like when we do that
there we go and there it is d is gone
and so is h so we create a new data
frame off of this missing those values
now if you have a lot of data dropping
values is a good way to take care of it
because you don't miss some data if you
have not a whole lot of data you're
working with like the iris data set or
something like that or something small
you want to start trying to find a way
to fill that data in so you don't lose
your computational power the data you
got
so just a quick look at processing null
values or missing values you can fill
them usually with the means some people
use medium or the mode there's different
ways you can fill it one way is means
and we can also just drop those rows
those are the two main things we do with
missing data
here we go we're going to cover next
this is i so love data frames for this
file operations
it saved me so much time because they
have so many different tools for
bringing data in and saving data
so we're looking at the data frame file
operations it's really streamlined i
don't know how many times they'll go on
to
different data downloads and they'll
have panda download standard on there
just because it's so widely used so
let's start with the most common file is
a csv so we have df3 to csv or animal
and let me just show you what the
folders going into
right now i have some untitled a few
things in here so we go ahead and run
this
and this has now saved the animal to
my hard drive and you can now see the
animal folder up here and if i uh let's
do edit with a notepad oh let's open up
with just a regular notepad there we go
or wordpad if i open that up you can see
it's comma separated our titles they
don't have an index on the categories on
the top and the index comma then all the
different data is separated by commas
standard csv file on there and if we're
going to send it to csv and notice the
format is dot 2 underscore csv
and it's just the name of the file we're
sending it to you can also put the
complete path by default it's going to
go whatever the active directory this
program is running on that's why those
other folders are in there so we have
our df3 to csv and then if we're going
to put it in there we want to also get
it back out and we'll call this one df
underscore animal equals pd read
underscore csv
i always have to remember is 2
underscore csv and read underscore csv i
always want to do like a capital in
there and not the underscore we're going
in here again it's the active directory
so if i now do print out my df
animal
and let's just do the ahead we only want
to look at the first three lines so if i
go ahead and run this
we'll see the first three lines and they
should match up here what we saved to
our csv
so very easy to save and import from our
csv files on here
and it turns out df
3 also has a 2 xl they actually have a
lot of different formats but you know
old school
excel was real popular for so long still
is we can go ahead and save it as
animal.xlsx
we're going to call the sheet named
sheet1
and then i can also do df we'll call it
animal2
animal2 and this one's going to come
from
in the same format on here there we go
so we still have our animal xlsx
the sheet1 that's where it's coming from
index columns equals none so we're not
going to we're going to suppress the
indexing on the columns n a values and
it'll just assign its zero one up on
your indexes so if it says index columns
equals none that's what it does and then
we've added null values because there's
no values in here and we want to just
make sure that they're marked as n a and
we'll go ahead and just print out the
animal animal two there we go and let's
run that let's make this let's just do
the whole thing so we'll go ahead and
run that
and it probably doesn't help that i
completely forgot the read so animal two
equals pd.read
excel there we go excel so now we go
ahead and run it
and what we expect is happening here we
have the same data frame on here and if
i flick back to my folder you can now
see that we have the animal one of these
is in excel and one of these is a csv on
here and so there's our two file types
on there and they have other formats
these are just the two most common ones
used and i don't know how many times
i've had stuff from excel i need to pull
out if you've ever played with excel
it's a nightmare in the back end because
of the way they do the indexing
so this just makes it quick and easy to
pull in an excel spreadsheet so we
looked at two different ways to bring
data in and save it to files we've
looked at all kinds of different ways of
manipulating our data set and slicing it
and creating it for our data frame let's
get in there put your visualization
always a big thing at the end because
one it lets you check to see what you
did make sure it looks right and then
also if you're going to show somebody
else it makes it very clear what's going
on if they see something visual so this
is where really important part of data
science is
so let's go ahead and bring in our tools
we're going to do import numpy as np we
want to make sure we have our amber sign
matplot library in line this just lets
jupiter know that we're going to print
it on this page if you're using a
different ide you don't really
necessarily need that but this does help
it displays correctly in jupiter
notebook and if you remember for earlier
we could create a uh we're gonna call it
ts we're gonna create a pandas which are
cute cuddly creatures versus a pandem
short for pandemonium no so we have ts
equals pd series and we're just going to
create a random
setup of 50. we'll do an index we'll set
it equal to the panda's date range today
periods equals 50. so the 50 should
match and i want you to notice something
here i did not import the matplot
library why because it's already in
there pandas already has its built-in
connection and interface with matplot
library so you don't have to import it
and we'll go ahead and do ts
equals ts dot
cumulative sum we're gonna do the
cumulative sum
so a little reformatting there and we'll
go ahead and plot it and let's take a
look at what that looks like
so we have a nice graph here we have the
dates on the bottom we set this up so we
have a nice range between in this case
minus four to looks like about two maybe
or one minus four and one so what we've
done here we plotted a basic series just
a single row of data when we've set our
indexes on there but we can also do the
whole data frame on there and let's see
what that looks like
so first let's go ahead and create the
data frame we have here random numbers
we're going to do 50 by 4 and then we'll
go ahead and create columns a b x and y
just because we can index is the
ts.index on there so we're going to use
the same index as before
just to keep it nice and uniform we've
already generated the dates to go with
it and then we can do just like we did
with the series
we can also do with the data frame
df equals df cumulative sum
so we're going to sum the whole data
frame and then we'll do simply df plot
and let's put that in and let's go ahead
and run this and look how easy and quick
that was to generate a nice graph with
all the different data on there so we
have our shared index we have the shared
columns and then we have the different
data from each one that we can easily
look at and compare so very quick way of
displaying data you can imagine if you
were working in oh i think i mentioned
stock earlier because i've been doing
some analysis of stock lately so you'd
have your date down here and then you
would have stock a stock b stock x y
whatever it is and you can put them all
on one chart and see how they
what they look like next to each other
and this isn't too far off from what
some of those graphs look like and this
is just randomly generated so stock has
a lot of randomness in it which is one
of the reasons i actually play with it
for doing some of my models on for
testing them out
now there are a lot of features in
pandas so we're going to show you one
more thing on here there's some of the
things like i didn't go too deep we
looked at the top two for importing data
from a csv and from an excel spreadsheet
showed you how to quickly plot the data
there's more settings in there you can
do we're going to do one more thing down
here and this is kind of a fun one
changes to a markdown and run that
so how would you remove repeated data
using pandas
and this is where you have a data set
that comes in and maybe it's feeding
from one location and instead of noting
that it's repeated the date like oh
let's go back to stocks that's a good
visual we have this docs from the 23rd
and it adds another row and it's the
same row it's importing the 23rd again
and again so now you have that data
repeated three times and you need to go
back and figure out how to get rid of it
how do you track that down
so let's start by creating a quick
database or data frame not a database i
keep saying databases a data frame and
we'll just make this data frame has
using our dictionary going in this data
frame only has one data series in it
which is fine so if we do df to print it
out you'll see a
one two two two two four five four five
six seven so on so how would you remove
that well there is a neat feature in
data frames called shift
along with another feature that lets us
select just certain date information and
we'll go with
the location function put that in
brackets remember that from above
location and then in the location let me
just spread this out a little bit so
it's really easy to read in fact i'm
going to go upscale on that since we're
doing some a little bit more complicated
here
what you can see on this on the location
is i have
dfa.shift so this is going to shift up
one by default you can actually change
this to two or three you can even do a
minus one and it shifts the other way
but it's gonna shift up by one by
default that's going to say if that does
not equal
df of a
then we want that if you look down here
we had one two two two two two when we
run this logic on here and we do the
shift
it now gets rid of all the duplicates so
we went from one two two two two four
four five whatever it was here it is one
two two two four four four five five
five six six six two one two four five
six seven eight
and you'll see on the index it just
deletes them out of there so the index
stays the same obviously you don't want
the dates to change if you're working
with an index dated setup so it just
deletes those duplicates out of there
this is just a quick way to introduce
you to one the fact that you can add
logic gates into here and two the eye
location
allows you to use shift so there's the
shift function and then the i location
selects that based on true or false
wow so we've actually covered a lot
today in pandas we've really covered
into the basics of selecting your
different series out of your column out
of your data frame how to index rows how
to slice how to plot
hopefully you'll take this beyond that
and start combining these different
things and you can create long strings
and really explore your data generate
some nice graphs if you're in jupiter
notebook it's a great demo to show
others
and i didn't know this about jupiter
notebook you can do this in jupyter
notebook and then you can download and i
always i never really look too closely
at all the downloads
which you download as an html and post
it to your blog so it's got a neat
feature in there but any of this is
really powerful tool all of this is
really powerful tools for doing your
data science today we're going to study
the matte plot library and the python
code so what's in it for you what is
matte plot library types of plots
plotting graphs and sub graphs adding a
graph inside a graph graph parameters
title label legend line graphs line
types color and transparency canvas grid
and axis range 2d plots scatter step bar
fill between radar chart histogram
contour image 3d surface image and then
we'll hit a practice example pie chart
so let's start with what is matte plot
library map plot library is an open
source drawing library which supports
rich drawing types it is used to draw 2d
and 3d graphics
and there are so many packages in the
matplot library we're going to cover the
basics and there are so many packages
that sit on top of the maplight library
that we can't even cover them all today
but we'll hit the main one so you have a
good understanding of what the matplot
library is and what the basics can do
you can understand your data easily by
visualizing it with the help of matplot
library you can generate plots
histograms bar charts and many other
charts with just a few lines of code and
here we have some basic types of plots
you can see here that we'll go into we
have the bar chart the histogram boy i
use a lot of histograms in my stuff
scatter plot line chart pie chart and
area graph let's start plotting them and
to do this i'm going to be using jupiter
notebook you can use any of your python
interfaces for programming or scripting
and running it of course we here really
like the jupiter notebook for doing
basic a lot of basic stuff because it's
so visual and in our jupyter notebook
which opens up in this case i'm using
google chrome you can go up here to new
and we'll create a new python 3 and set
that up
if you're not familiar with jupiter
notebook we do have a tutorial that
covers some of the basics of that and
you'll look at any of our tutorials i
usually cover a number of them showing
how to set up jupiter and anaconda i
myself use jupiter through anaconda in
fact let's go ahead and open that up and
just take a look this see what that
looks like you can see your anaconda
navigator if you install it it will
automatically install the jupyter
notebook and that also installs a lot of
other things i know some people like the
qt console for doing python or spyder
i've never used them i actually use
notepad plus plus as one of my editors
and then i use the jupyter notebook a
lot because it's so easy to have a
visual while i'm programming and even
simple script in python i'll take it
from the jupyter notebook and then do a
save as you always go under file and you
can download as a python program so that
will download it as an actual python
versus the ipython that this saves it as
so let's go ahead and dive in and see we
got going here and let's go ahead and
put matplot library tutorial and i'm
going to turn this cell into a mark down
so it doesn't actually run it
you can see it has a nice little title
there that's all jupiter notebook
and then from mat plot library
let's
import pi lab
back one and then let's go ahead and
just print
we'll go pi lab
and the version let's go ahead and run
this so we're going to import our pi lab
module from the matplot library and we
find out that we're in version 1.15.1
always important to note the version
you're in probably i was reading an
article that said the number one thing
that python programmers struggle with is
remembering what version they're working
in and making sure that they're going
from one platform to the other with the
same version and if we're going to graph
things i think we need some data to
graph so we're going to import numpy as
np now if you're not familiar with numpy
definitely go back and check out our
numpy tutorial there's so many different
things you can do with it dealing with
reshaping the data and creating the data
we're just going to use it to create
some data for us
and there is a lot of ways to create
data but we're going to use the np.line
space
so we're going to create a numpy array
and the way you read this is we're going
to create numbers between 0 and 10 and
we're going to create 25 of these
numbers so we're just going to divide
that equally up between 0 and 10. and if
we have x coordinates we should probably
have some y coordinates i will do
something simple like x times x
plus two and let's just take a look
we're going to print x
and print
y
let me go ahead and run this
and let's see we got going on here so we
have our x coordinates which is zero
zero point four point eight three et
cetera and you can look at this as an xy
plot so we have zero we have two we have
point four one six we have two point one
seven and just as a quick reminder we're
going to do print np array x comma y dot
reshape 25 comma 2. and the reason i
want to do this is i want to show you
something here
a lot of times a program returns x comma
y and it's an array of x comma y x comma
y x comma y
and so when you're working with the pi
plot
you have to separate it out and reshape
it so if i start off with pairs like
this i can reshape them if i know
there's 25 pairs in there i can switch
the 2 and the 25 and this is kind of
goofy but we'll do it anyways reshape so
i'm going to reshape my 25 by 2 back to
2 by 25
and if i run that you'll see i end up
with the same output as the x y the two
different arrays in here
and this is important that we want x and
y separate
again that's all numpy stuff but it's
important to understand that this is a
format that matplot library works with
it works with an array of x's and they
should match your array of y's so each
one has 25 different entities in it
and then for our basic plotting of this
data it only takes one command to draw
graph of this data
and so we use our from up here where we
imported pi lab we take our pi lab and
the key under there is plot for plotting
a line and we want our x coordinates and
our y coordinates and we'll throw in r
and the r simply means red so we're
going to draw the line in red let me go
and run that
you can actually switch this around if
you wanted to do different there's b
for blue we have a lot of fun yellow
hard to see yellow there we go but we'll
go ahead and stick with red
run
and when you're doing presentations with
these try to be consistent you know if
the business and the shareholders send
you a
spreadsheet and they have losses in red
use red for losses in your graph
try to be consistent use green for
profit for money you don't have to
necessarily use green but it's whatever
they're using whatever the company's
using try to mirror that that way people
aren't going to be confused if you
switch your data around every time one
graph has red for loss and one graph has
blue for loss it gets really confusing
so make sure you're consistent in your
graphs and your coloring and something
to know because we're going to cover
this in a minute this is your canvas
size so we have a canvas here and what
we're going to do next is we're going to
look at sub graphs okay
so let's take our pi lab and create a
sub plot
and one of the things also to know when
we're working with the
matplot library i'm not setting when i
do this this is my drawing canvas the pi
lab so once i've imported the pi lab i'm
drawing my images on there very
important to know and with the subplot
we're going to give it some different
values
and we're going to represent by rows
columns and indexes and let's do one two
one so it's going to be the first row
second column and the index is like you
can stack your graphs and things like
that we don't worry too much about
indexes but rows and columns we want to
go ahead and use row one and column two
and if we're going to have one object we
should probably have two but before we
do that we have to plot data onto the
subplot so the order is very important
and we're going to stick with our x
comma y
and let's do this we're going to add in
a third parameter here remember we did
red we're going to add shorthand dash
dash for dashed lines so this plots the
data into row one column two
and if we're going to do that let's do
another one pi
lab.subplot and if we're gonna do row
one let's do
column two and index two
and this time we're going to add g for
green and this denotes a style and if
we're going to set up our pilab
subplot there we go all right lab we
gotta go ahead and plot that pi
lab plot
and instead of x y we want y comma x
oops i messed up this is in the wrong
spot there we go we'll move that down
here real quick because that goes in the
plot part so the subplot tells it the
row column and index and the pi plot
tells it what data in this case we
switched them and the color and then the
style shorthand now let's go ahead and
run that
and you'll see it takes this canvas
splits it in two and now we have two
different graphs and we have the red one
with dashed lines and we have the green
one which is has a little stars going up
and if we take this and let's just um
just for fun let's change this and run
that with an index of one it puts them
both on the same index and also gives me
a warning because it's a strange way of
doing two subplots there's depreciated
there's another way to do it but most
people just ignore that warning because
it's not going to go away anytime soon
now that's using the same setup what
happens if we do
instead of
this let's change the column on here and
find out what happens
and if we do the column
i didn't really like that on the setup
it just disappears so let's keep our
column as two and let's change the row
on the second one to two
and run that
and you'll see again it kind of squishes
everything together and causes some
issues so let's take the index so these
need a unique index and you can see here
where i made some changes i said row two
and look what happens when i change to
column two so i now have row two column
two index two it squished it up here so
you could put another graph underneath
is what that does and there's all kinds
of different things you really have to
just play with these numbers till you
get a handle on them because
you know we have to repeat it 164 times
according to cambridge university if
it's completely new to you and you can
see right here where we go three
run there we go but you can see it takes
a little bit sometimes to play with
these and get the numbers right
hopefully hit the wrong one that's why
let's go three there three there run
there we go now it's overlapping so i
have this doubled over here on the right
for now we'll just go ahead and leave
this with the
where we have column and row two and the
two different indexes so they appear
nice and neatly side by side
and then as we just saw as we were
flashing through them we can put them on
top of each other
and let me just highlight that and copy
it down here
paste it down there and here we have one
two one and then we'll do one two one
also for this one and that puts the two
subplots directly on top of each other
gives us that warning and you can see we
now have two different sets of data
graphed on top of each other and you can
also see how it did the indexes since
one of them is from zero to 10 that's
the green one on the x axis and the
other one is from 0 to 10 on the y axis
so it took the greatest value of either
one and then used those as a shared
value
so let's
next look at operator description and
we'll go ahead and turn this cell into a
markdown and run that so it looks nice
so fig and you remember i talked about
the canvas earlier i briefly mentioned
it we're going to look a little bit more
at the canvas later on but that's what
the figure is fid we're going to add
axes so we're going to initialize a
subplot add the subplot
in rows and columns and all kinds of
different things with this you can do
let's look at that code and see exactly
what's going on and i want you to notice
that there's fig which is the actual
canvas in the matplot library and ax is
commonly used to refer to the subplots
so we're creating subplots you'll see ax
equals plt subplot
earlier we did the pi lab so let's go
ahead and import pi plot from matplot
library and we're going to do it as plt
you'll see that a lot that's really the
standard in the industry is to call it
plt just like pandas as pd and numpy
array as np certainly you can import it
as whatever you want but i would stick
to the standards and we're going to do
the same graph as we did above
with the pi lab but with the plt so if
it looks familiar there's reason we're
doing this because we want to show you
how the figure part works and working
with the canvas goes but we're going to
do the same plot as we did before and
we'll call it fig and we're going to set
that equal to plot figure so there's our
figure or canvas on there and let's
create a variable called axes and we're
going to set that equal to fig dot add
axes
and in this we're going to control the
left right the width the height of the
canvas from zero to one
and so we can go ahead and i'm just
gonna put some stuff in there i got
point five point one point eight point
eight so when you're looking at this
this is a zero to one or you could say
fifty percent ten percent eighty eighty
percent but it's a control it's going to
control your left and your right along
with the width and the height so the
width and the height we're going to use
80 percent and we're going to have like
a little indent on the left and the
right and this should look familiar from
above x is dot plot
x comma y
and then let's give it a color how about
red since we're recreating the same
graph let's keep it uniform oops and it
helps if i use a axis instead of ax es i
don't know where that came from but this
looks identical to the one we had up
above so here's our axis plot x comma y
of red
same graph same setup but this time
we've added a variable equal to the
figure dot add axes so our plot figures
our canvas our axes is what we're
working in and then our axis.plot x
comma y
and again we can draw sub graphs we put
that down here
[Music]
just like we did before and a little
different temptation here we're going to
fig comma
axes equal
plt.subplots
and in here it's going to be the number
of rows
we're going to do one row
and columns equals 2. so if you remember
before that's what we did we had one row
with two different graphs on it we're
going to do the same thing but know how
we did this here's our figure our canvas
and our axes we're going to create
actually two different axes we're going
to create row one column two and so axis
is an array of information so we can
simply do
for well let's do x in axes
this will look familiar x dot plot we're
going to do x comma y we'll go ahead and
make it red keep everything looking the
same remember nice uniform graphs
everything looks the same and if we go
ahead and run this
you'll see we get two nice side-by-side
graphs so just as we had before the same
look the same setup
and just for fun let's change in columns
to three we'll run that and now you see
we'll have three on there and let's see
if we make it a little bit more
interesting we'll do in rows equals to
two and you can see down here we're
going to get an attribute error because
it's trying to scrunch everything
together
so it does have a limit how much stuff
you can put in one small space that's
important to know you can fix that by
changing the canvas size which we'll
look at in just a minute and there's
other ways to change it on here but here
we go we can do in rows two and columns
equals one you can see two nice images
right above each other we'll go back to
the original one row two columns side by
side left to right and
we can also
draw a picture
or graph
inside
another graph
and that's kind of a fun thing to do
it's important to note that we can layer
our stuff on top of each other which
makes for a really nice presentation
so let's start by a fig we'll create
another figure so we're going to start
over again with our canvas we set that
equal to plt.figure
so there's our new canvas and let's do
axes we'll call it axes one and two axis
one equals fig dot add axes remember
this from earlier and
this here similar numbers we used before
saying how big this axis is this figure
in the axis is so this is going to be
the big
axes and let's do axes 2 equals
another figure add axes and then point
two point five point four point three
and if we're going to do this they need
data on them so let's go ahead and plot
some data on our axis so axis one dot
plot
and we'll make this simply x comma y
comma make it red
and then let's go axes two dot plot and
let's reverse them y comma x comma green
there we go doing what i told you not to
do you shouldn't be swapping axes around
and plotting your data in five different
directions because it's confusing let's
go ahead and run this and see what this
looks like and then let's talk a little
bit about this we talked about the point
two point five point four point three
and let me just grab the annotation for
that that's left right width and height
so we have in here that this is going to
be left right so here's our left is
point one in point five and we you know
what let's just play with this a little
bit what happens when i change this to
point one moves it way over to the left
so there's our point one so we can make
this point four run that there we go so
you can see how you can move it around
the branches on here point two
point five is the
left so that's our right so see what
happens when we do point oh let's make
this point one and that actually is they
had it down at left right i thought this
was wrong it's actually how far from the
bottom let me switch that on here bottom
there we go so we had here on this we
can go ahead and put that back to 0.5
and run that and this is point three
let's make this point three also and
that is the width and then of course
there's the height we can make that
really tiny actually let's do point two
and let's run that and you can see it
changes the height on there we make it
even smaller 0.2 by 0.2 and as you can
see you can get stuck playing with this
to make it look just right it can
sometimes take a little bit
certainly once you have the settings if
you're doing a presentation you try to
keep it uniform unless it doesn't make
sense for the graph you're working on
try to keep the same colors the same
position and the same look and feel
and i mentioned earlier we can adjust
the canvas size so this is from earlier
i just copied it down below we're going
to re-plot the same data we've been
looking at
and what we can do is we can change the
figure size to 16 by nine let me run
that and show you what that looks like
so it fills the whole screen and then if
you are normally when you're working on
the screen you don't worry too much
about this but we can set the dpi to 300
run that
there it goes this is your dots per inch
and if you are doing an output of this
and you're printing a hard copy you want
the higher quality i would suggest
nothing under 300 if it's a professional
print you might get a little less than
that but whenever i'm doing professional
graphics and printing them out on
something 300 dots per inch is kind of
the minimal on there you can go a lot
higher too but keep in mind the higher
you get the more memory it takes the
more lag time and the more resources you
use so usually 300 is a good
solid number to use your dots per inch
and you can see it drills a nice it
draws a nice large canvas here which is
16 by 9 and then the dpi is 300 on here
it's a little higher quality and just
out of curiosity i wonder how long it
takes to draw something double that size
600 and you can see here where at 600
dpi it's going to take a while there it
goes just because it's utilizing a lot
more graphics on there and let me just
go back to the 300 now we'll actually do
let's do a 100 you're not going to see a
difference on this because it is web
based graphics are pretty low
and up here you saw i did this with the
plot figure this works the same if i do
figure axes subplot figure size and then
we'll go ahead and do axes
dot plot
x comma y comma we'll stick to red
let's go ahead and run this and you
should get almost the same thing here
here's our
axis on the subplot on here with the
fixed size and the dpi let me take this
all out let me just remove all that real
quick run it again there we go now we're
back to our original figure and let's
look at some of the other things you can
do with this
one things we do is we can set a title
for the axis so axis set title you'll
see right here since i put this on the
axis it's the main title for the whole
graph and if you're going to have a
title you should also label so we can
label our x label and we can set our y
label in this case we're just going to
call it x and y keep it nice and uniform
and if we run this you'll see that we've
added a nice x label and y label whoops
where'd they go and it turns out in this
environment that you have to put it
before the title so let me go ahead and
put it before the title and there's our
x y and we run that and of course we can
also do upper size a little bit and see
what's going on a little better so here
we have x label x if you come down here
you'll see our x label and our y label
we can of course change this to x
label you can change this to y
maybe whatever you want on here of
course and our title graph there we go
run so here we have our title graph our
y label and our x label all set up on
our nice little plot and then before we
move on to the next section let's do one
more thing on here we have a thing
called the legend and we're going to do
we're going to set our ax legend label 1
label 2 up here that's a format for it
but let's go down here and actually use
it i'm going to do two different plots
we're going to have axes plot x by x
times x squared and x cubed and if i run
this you'll see it puts two nice graphs
on the setup on there but it's nice to
have a legend telling you what's going
on so for the legend we can actually do
axes since we have the two plots legend
and on here we've created an array
and we have y equals x squared y equals
x cubed you can actually put this as
whatever you want those are just strings
and then location two and let's go ahead
and run this and see what that looks
like and you can see it puts a nice
legend on the upper left hand corner
location two we can do location three
and run it and it drops it down to the
bottom location one i can't remember
where that's at there we go upper right
so each one of these is a number that
refers to the different locations on the
screen zero kind of have to play with
them or look them up to remember where
they're at but they do work it just kind
of moves around depending on where you
want your legend out on there so on this
section we cover the title of the graph
the y labels and legends this is we're
getting into some starting to look
really fancy here so we now have
something we can actually put out you'll
see the title the graph looks a little
fuzzy so i might in a web setup put the
dpi up a couple notches maybe put it at
200 100 might work fine just so you know
something to notice on here when you're
playing with these different things we
had our subplots dpi equals oh let's do
200 to see what that looks like
so you can see now it's a lot clearer
it's also larger so it's a nice little
feature you can throw in there with your
dpi dots per inch
so the next section is let's look at
some graph features we're going to look
at line color transparency size and a
few more things on here and oops i
forgot the main title so we have our
figure in our axes equals our plot and
subplots and i'm going to do a dpi
equals 150 so the graph comes out nice
and large and easy for you to see
and let's go ahead and do three plots on
here we'll do x by x plus one so it's
just going to be a straight line plot
x plus x plus two
and
dot plot
x x
plus three this looks like we're doing
nearest neighbor setup we're showing how
it uh located data putting your lines on
there between the nearest neighbors
there we go so it draws a nice little
graph with three lines on it one of the
things we can do is we can control the
alpha on this oops and you can actually
see the when they did these lines it
automatically pulls in different colors
for your setup so some automatic
automatic things going on in there and a
lot of times we do that comma r but
we're going to do color equals red
another notation on here let's go ahead
and run this now we have a bright red
line down there and with the map plot
library you're not limited to red you
can also use the one of many different
color references as you see here with
the pound sign one one five five dd
which just is just blue and we can do
the same thing with another color on
here which it turns out to be green i
can just as easily do this green
blue oops there we go blue and run that
and you'll see here we have red blue and
green and what i want to do is i want to
make this we're going to set what's
called the alpha on this and we're going
to set this equal to 0.5 so this is
halfway see-through when i run this and
it's almost going to look pink because
you can see through it and let's change
this just a little bit just to make this
kind of fun let's square it there we go
run it so now we have this nice square
that comes up and you can see when it
crosses it because i plotted these two
lines after it and they have no alpha
the red is behind those lines or in this
case pink because we did the alpha
halfway through so let's go ahead and do
this alpha equals 0.5
and oh you know what instead of squaring
it let's take it to the 0.5 power
that'll be kind of interesting to see
what that does we'll just go to keep it
squared there we go
and run that and let's go back and look
at this where it crosses over and the
first thing you see right here is on the
blue it's kind of light blue now you can
see how the two colors add together you
get almost a purple on there so i can
clearly see where the red cross is the
blue line and then the green
just blanks it over because i didn't do
any opaqueness no alpha on there
so this is great if you have lots of
data that crosses over and you need to
be able to track those lines better and
we'll go ahead and do this point five
and we'll run that oops i did equals 0.5
let me go ahead and run that and so you
can see right here now you can easily
see the red line how it crosses the
green and the blue down here and if we
want to we can do this as the default is
one solid so we can change this all to
point eight let me just do that
oops 58 there we go run
oops i must have hit a wrong button
there let me try that again i actually
get rid of a bracket and let's go ahead
and run that
and we come down here and look at this
you can still see where it passes behind
them but the green dominates and the
blue dominates because we're now at
eighty percent instead of fifty percent
when you can do less that's kind of fun
although at some point the lanes kind of
fade
so point five is usually the best
setting on there we have a nice pastel
here at 0.3 and you can easily see where
they cross over and just like you can
play with the colors we can play with
line width and you know let's do
let's try dpi 100 and see what that
looks like on my screen equals 100 and
we'll go ahead and just take our ax plot
let's do four of these lines just you
can see how they look next to each other
real quick here there we go
and if i run this they should all appear
the same it automatically does different
colors on there so let's do color equals
blue
i forgot my quotation marks there we go
and we'll go ahead and just make these
all blue just for purposes of being nice
and uniform and then what i want to do
is i want to do the line
width
width equals
0.25
and let's just copy and paste that down
here
let's do equals one
about 1.5 and let's do one let's make
this equal to two let's see what that
looks like and we do that you can see it
goes from a very thin line a 0.5 a 1 our
1.5 and 2 which is twice the width of
the one and if we're going to do
different sizes we had different colors
we had our alpha scheme let's take this
whole thing here
let's paste it down here and do another
one
but instead of line width let's look at
styles and something to know here you
can actually abbreviate this with lw so
line width can also be point let's just
do everything point two and let's set up
a line style we'll do the first one
dashes and let me just paste that down
here
so i'm not doing a lot of extra typing
there we go
take this out so we have our dashed
we can do a dash dot we'll just do the
dash dot here and a colon here there we
go and there's a lot of different
options we'll look at a few more as we
go down for different ways of
highlighting data
but when you look at this we have
everything is a line width of two and
now we have a straight line we have a
dashed line or a dot dash and a dot dot
dot line
and then another thing we can add on
here is we're going to do here's our ax
plot and we did x let's do x plus um
four so it goes right on the top and do
color black line width 1.5 so it's a
smaller line and we're going to take the
line and we're going to set dashes so
look i've changed some of the notation
here for my line and my axe plot so i
can set my line comma equal to x plot
and then i can change the line settings
this way and when i run this
run that on here you'll see the 5 10 15
creates a series of dashes
that are buried in link
link in this case they alternate between
a short dash and a long dash we can play
with these numbers curiosity always has
me what happens when you play with the
numbers just to see what they look like
let's do this let's paste this down here
i'll do two of these just because
they're kind of fun to play with and
let's change this from 10 to
3 and we're going to change this one
from 15
to
4. and let's run that
and you can see the differences in the
lines oops very a little bit confusing
on there because i forgot to change the
lines are all on top of each other so
let me change that really quick here and
let's run that and now you can see
here's our original dashed line
alternating when i change these numbers
on the second one the very end value to
three you can see now we have dashes of
five let's see i'm going to guess this
is a dash is a five skip ten dashes of
15 skip three and then it goes back to
the beginning dash is five dashes skip
ten fifteen dashes skip three and of
course the last one we just switched up
a little bit it looks a lot more uniform
because i'm using two sets of ten or if
i did something like this and change it
to 30 it really becomes pronounced as
far as the distances between them and
instead of 4 let's go oh let's put 30
here also 30 by 30 there we go really
pronounced on that one and let's look at
one more important group for plotting
our data and in this we're gonna here's
our plot we started with with the x plus
one x plus two x plus three and did it
in blue on this one's three or four
different blue lines
and this property we want to add the
actual plots so you can see where the
plots are on the graph and for that we
might have marker equals o and if we run
this let's see it puts a dot for each of
these and there's 25 dots because we
have 25 x values so we actually have
zero and each of the different values of
x y are then plotted here with the dots
and we don't want to just limit
ourselves to dots
we can also do
plus sign that's another option dots is
most common i'll actually like the dots
the best
if we do the plus sign you see it puts a
nice crosshairs or a plus sign on there
and we can do a marker there's a number
of different markers you can use
and i think this one was it s is another
one
which is a nice square and that's
actually a good one that's for square o
for
period okay that's just kind of weird so
you can see that probably on these
markers another one is uh number one so
if we run that you'll see we now have
these little hatch marks
and let's take oh let's just go with the
o on this one
by the way this works with square really
nicely some stuff we're gonna do here on
just a second let's do
marker
size equals
change that to five and run that and you
can see here it puts a nice little tiny
dot versus uh the size dot here and this
is interesting because it said two i
thought it would be bigger
but if you do 0.5 it gets even smaller
and let's just do 10 to see what that
looks like run that looks huge so marker
size a lot of these are dependent on the
dpi and the setup so there's things that
switch around as far as the way the size
shows up you got to be a little careful
when you change one setting it can
change all the other markers and then
let's take our square on here
and we'll do we had marker size so we
also have marker base
we'll set that equal to red of course we
need to take change the so it's up one
notch we'll run that whoops must have
mistyped something on here and i did
it's marker face color equals red and so
when i run that you can now see i have
the squares on there with the marker
face color of course we can mix and
match these come down here and we'll
make this instead of let's make this
plus 7 and we'll make this
size 15
marker face color
equals
and we'll do what green just because
there we go run very hard to actually
see what's going on there still 25 dots
they kind of overlap as you can see they
print them over each other of course if
we really wanted to make it look
horrible we could just make that really
huge generally though you want something
a little bit smaller and cuter we'll
just try doing it this way there we go
that's too small to even see the face so
four
you can start to see the face on there
around four and maybe an eight eight
might be a good number for this there we
go eight again that all just depends on
what you're trying to show and display
so we've covered a lot of stuff here as
far as our lines we've covered
opaque with our alpha setting on there
give us some nice pastels you can see
how they overlap and how they cross over
we covered the line with different size
on there different formats for the line
itself and these are all you can combine
all these so you can have our line width
equals two line style equals dash you
can bring this down here also to the
markers and then we added markers in
just entered a circle a
plus sign the square a little tick which
uses a one then we had a marker size and
a marker color face and we combine those
you see we get a nice different series
of representations
we also briefly mentioned color where
you didn't have to use like in here we
used color black
someplace up here and have to find it we
use the actual number for the color as
opposed to i changed them to red and
blue so you get very precise on the
color if you have a very specific color
set that you need to match your website
or whatever you're working on
all those are tools in the map plot
library so we have
one more piece to formatting the graph
so we want to show you and then we have
two big sections we're going to go over
the different graphs that they have
along with a challenge problem so let's
go to the last section we're going to
look at is limits we're going to limit
our data
so this first primer is going to paste
in there we're going to create our
subplots one two so one row two columns
we're going to do a figure size of 10
comma five this should all look familiar
now since we've done a number of them
and we're going to go ahead and plot and
this is an interesting notation you
should notice here our axis zero so one
we've used instead of you can just
iterate through them but they're just an
array so it's an array of zero is still
the axes of the first axes out of two
and we're going to plot x
x squared x x cubed lined with two so
we're going to go ahead and just plot
two graphs right on top of each other
without doing multiple plots on here and
we'll set the grid equal to true one
here let's go ahead and run that
and you can see here are two plots with
the x value going across
and i'm going to do
something similar and by the way as you
can just if you look at it you can see
the grid on there that's all that is
easier to spot the data going across
we're going to take the same data for
axes one so we have our plot of x x
squared x and x cubed line with two
and this time we're going to take our
axis one and do y
limit
let's actually set underscore y limit
this is the y-axis so it's going to be
an array of two two values and we'll do
0 comma
60 i'm just making these numbers up the
guys in the back actually made them up
i'm just using their numbers
we're going to set the x limit
and we'll set the x limit as
don't forget our brackets there
two comma five
so it's the same data going in and but
we're setting a limit on it let's go
ahead and run that and let's see what it
comes out of and here we have the y
limit 0 to 60 so we're looking at just
the lower part of this curve here up to
here and we have the x limit 2 to 5. so
that starts right here at 2 and you can
see very different graphs this is kind
of nice because you could actually put
one of these on top of the other if you
wanted to draw focus to one part of a
graph remember how we did that earlier
one inside the other but just a quick
note you can easily limit your graph and
re-kind of reshape the way it looks
quite easily and we can also add that
grid down there if you want a grid
we'll run that and add the grid in there
oops i guess you have to do the grid
beforehand
switch that there we go sometimes the
order on this is really important so you
may double check your order when you're
printing these things out it also helps
if i change it to one so in this case
might not be the order i wonder if we'll
go back here as one there we go so it
doesn't matter the order and grid but
you can set the grid for easy viewing
here nice setup on there but you can see
how we can limit the data
so let's start looking at some other 2d
graphs and make this cell a markdown so
we run it as a nice pretty title to it
and let's go ahead and create some data
with an np array we'll do
zero to five on here there we go and
let's look at uh four common graphs
we'll put them side by side so we'll do
a figure our axes equals plot subplots
one four columns and then figure size
hopefully it'll fit nicely on here it
seems to do a pretty good on here and
i'll go and just run that since we're in
there run you'll see i have my four
blank plots on here
and we'll start with axes of zero let's
set title
and we want this to be a scatter plot
a scatter plot just means it has a bunch
of dots on it so here's our axis of
zero
dot scatter easy to remember scatter a
bunch of plots on there we'll do our
in we can do x or n there we go and
let's go ahead and do axis set title
scatter i've already did that we're just
gonna do
scatter that's how you do it on there
notice how you create a scatter plot
with simply with the scatter control and
we'll do let's do the variable x
x
plus let's throw some randomness in here
usually scatter plots are have a lot of
random numbers connected to them that's
why they do them on there and so the
bigger the x gets the bigger the
randomness so 0.25 times the randomness
and what we should end up doing here is
with the scatter plot and you can see as
you go up it just kind of has some
random numbers and moves up and down the
line
but plus just the points so if you
remember from back up here where we did
marker
this is plotting basically just the
marker so it's a scatter plot
probably less used is a step plot so for
x is one we'll go ahead and do a step
plot so you can see what that looks like
and this time we'll use our n value
instead of x we generated that n value
up here and so for this we have n n
times two r n squared n times two n
squared line width equals 2 and if we
run that it creates a nice step up
let's see so we've got a scatter plot
we've got a steps
plot let's do a bar plot
and we'll use the same formula n n
squared alignment centered because you
can have them left or right with 0.5 and
alpha if you remember correctly that's
how opaque it is
let's see what that looks like on there
so we have some nice you can see here a
nice bar plot it should look very
similar to the step plot but colored in
and we can change the width let's see
what happens we do 0.9 run
and if we take width out completely
run that you can see it starts coming
together on there and we can change the
alpha we can take the alpha out too and
run that
so now you have the solid colors and if
we take out the center
and run that
everything you really can't see the
shift on here because that's actually
the default on this but these are common
settings for the bar graph let me just
put them back in there there we go
alignment center and alpha now i can't
say i have used the step craft very much
there's certain other certain i guess
domains of expertise require a step
graph but the scatter plot and the bar
graph very common especially the bar
graph and we'll look at histograms here
in just a minute so i use histograms a
lot especially in data science but this
is nice if you have very concrete
objects somebody how many people wearing
yellow hats that kind of thing but if
we're going to do that let's go ahead
and do the last one which i see a lot
more in the sciences certainly using the
data science but more like for mapping i
saw publication on
solar flares and they were discussing
the energy and so filling in the graph
gives it a very different luck so we're
going to do the fill between
and it's just like you think it'd be
it's fill between but with a underscore
between them and we'll do x and x
squared and x and x cubed and we'll do
color green and alpha again in case you
had other data you want to plot on there
you can see it forms a nice squared
coming up here and also if you look at
the bottom one is your squared value the
upper line is your cubed value and then
it fills in everything in between
if you remember from calculus this would
be if you had like a car a motor an
efficiency they would talk about the
efficiency going up and the loss and
you're looking for the space or the area
between the two lines so it gives you a
nice visual of that now let's look at a
few more basic two dimensionals so we
have our figure figure size on here
we're going to do a radar chart to be
honest i've never used a radar chart in
business or in data science i have to
find a reason to use one now so the
first line for doing a radar chart we
have to add axes and the figure and with
this this actually creates our
oh let's let's run it so you can see
what it creates
it creates a nice looks like you're on a
submarine and you're tracking the hunt
for red october or something like that
and it needs all of these the polar is
the fact that we're doing polar
coordinates
zero zero point six point six has to do
with the size if you take out any of
these things and run them you get just a
box if you take out the other half you
pretty much get nothing in there and if
you change these numbers and change them
a little bit you can see it gets bigger
they had 0.6 on here i'll go ahead and
leave it as one because that's just kind
of fun that's all about the size on here
the height and the width and then let's
create some data t equals np line space
and this is 0 to 2 times np times pi so
if you remember that is the
distance across and we're going to
generate a hundred points
so this is just a thing of data we're
putting together then we can simply do
an ax dot plot and in this case let's do
t comma t which would be a diagonal line
on a regular chart and we'll give it a
nice color equals blue
and line width equals three let's see
what that looks like and we can see here
a spiral coming out remember this would
be just a diagonal line on a regular
chart what happens if we take this and
instead of t
times 0.5 there we go
and you can see it slightly alters the
way it spirals out we could do t times
two spirals that a little quicker so
it's kind of just a fun i guess i said
i've never used a uh radar chart it's a
column but you can always think of radar
submarine kind of looks like one of
those or in an airplane
and none of this would be complete if we
didn't discuss histograms oh my gosh do
i use a histogram so much
and we'll use our numpy that we have set
as np to generate oh looks like we have
a hundred thousand variables we're going
to set equal to n and of course we
create our figure and our axes from
subplots 1 2 figure size 1214 so we're
going to look at two different
variations of the histogram and we'll
set a title default histogram set our
title there
and then this is simply
hist for histogram and we'll just go
ahead and put in our n in there and let
me run this and see what that looks like
and let's talk about what is going on
here
so we generated an array here of data
1000 random arrays
it looks like they're mostly between
minus four and four
and then it adds up each one it says
zero you have 35 000 that are zero so
that's what's most common on here and we
have 20 000 that are somewhere in this
range right here between the minus 2 and
well it looks like 1 minus 2 and
somewhere between 0 and 1 there's 30 000
numbers so all this is saying is this is
how common these variables are and this
gives you this point in so many
directions when you're looking at data
science to go ahead and run your
histogram so you should always have your
histogram and you can always put limits
and all the other different things on
your array just like you did on the
other graphs on there and then we're
going to do a cumulative detailed
histogram
and all it is is a histogram let me just
do that
and we set cumulative equal to true
and bins equal 50. and i really want to
highlight the um the cumulative equals
true is important but we can now choose
how many bins we have in the first one
it kind of selected them for us in this
case let me go ahead and run this and
you'll see it has a prints of data out
for us and here's our whoops
must have missed oh there we go it
doesn't help that i put it over the old
one there we go okay
so now you have your default histogram
and then we have a cumulative histogram
and we should have 50 steps in there and
let's just find out if that's true not
so much by counting them i'm not going
to count them if you want to you can
count them let's just change it to 10
and see what happens and we see here we
have now 10 counts of that
and we could set that for 5
and run that
and then we have our 5 on there and we
go ahead and take the cumulative equals
true out just so you can see what that
looks like and let me run that on here
too
that looks just like it did before i
think there's what one two three four
five six seven eight they have eight
different bins on here is what the
default came out of
put that back in there run
and so now it should look almost
identical and it does and then we can
put the cumulative back in see what that
looks like with the cumulative
and run that and we can see how that
shifts everything over and has a
slightly different luck
wait it shifts it all to the right no it
doesn't actually shift it to the right
it's cumulative so it's the total of the
different occurrences and so what that
means is like if you consider this like
for the year of rainfall we have like
day one you had a little bit of rain day
two we have more rain and so if you look
at the number this is a hundred thousand
thirty five thousand so it's a
cumulative detail the histogram the
currents as it grows and rainfall is a
good one because that would be a
cumulative histogram of how much rain
occurred throughout the year and we're
going to look at two more graphs we've
already looked at a bunch of them we
looked at our radar graph we've looked
at scatter step bar fill in basic plots
we've looked at different ways of
showing the data you know we can
increase the size of the line the look
the color the alpha setting
so let's look at contour maps let's put
that in there there we go draw a contour
map and before we draw a contour map
we need to go ahead and create data for
it and if you have contours your data is
all going to have three different values
so let's go ahead and create the data
here we have our you'd import your
matplot library your numpy so we have
our numbers array
and we'll import matplot.cm
and that's your color maps so you have
all these different color maps you can
look at there's like hundreds of color
maps so if you don't want to do your own
color you can even do your own color map
they're pretty
diverse and of course our plt we're
going to our pi plot and to generate our
different data we're going to create a
delta
0.025 and we'll start with x and we're
going to create an array between -3 and
3 and delta increments of 0.025
and we'll have our y we'll do something
similar and then we'll create our xy
into a mesh grid again these are all
numpy commands so if you're not familiar
with these you'll want to go back and
review our numpy tutorial and we'll do
an exponential on here minus x squared
minus y squared for our z1 we'll do a z2
so we have two different areas and z
equals 1 minus z2 times 2.
so we've created a number of values here
and let me go ahead and run this and
let's plug that in so you can see where
those values are going so once we've set
these we're going to create our figure
and our x from our plt subplots we're
going to create the variable cs
and this is going to be our contour so
right here cs is our contour surface and
we're feeding it x y and z if you
remember x y we created as our x and y
components using our mesh grid and you
know what let's do this just because
it's kind of good to see this let's go
ahead and print
x
and let's print
y and i always like to do this when i'm
working with something that's either is
really complicated in this case is what
we're looking at or you don't understand
yet so we've created a mesh grid we have
x y and when we're done with this we end
up with here's our x
and this set of values and our y so
there's our x and y coordinates and then
we've also created z based on our x and
y so we have x capital x capital y and
capital z is our three components x and
y be in the coordinates while z is going
to be our actual height since we're
doing a contour map so we created our
contour map from our x y and z
coordinates we want to go ahead and put
in a c label maybe we want to go ahead
and do a title on here
we'll put that in our set title and this
is a
contour there we go contour map
and let's go ahead and run this and see
what that looks like
and you'll see we generated a nice
little contour map there's different
settings you can play with on this but
you can picture this being you're on a
mountain climb and here we have a line
that's represents zero maybe that's sea
level and then moving on up you have
your contours of 0.5 and then -1 and
different setups little hills i guess if
it's minus that's like a pit so i guess
you're going down into a pit at -5 and
minus one but on the other side you can
see you're going up in levels so here's
a mountaintop and here's like a basin of
some kind
and in data science this could represent
a lot of things this could also be
representing two different values and
maybe profits and loss i don't know if
i'd ever really do that as a contour map
but i'm sure you can be creative and
find something fun to do with a contour
map and then we're going to look at one
last map which is the 3d map and those
are can be really important as a final
product because they can show so much
additional information that you can't
fit on two dimensional graphs
there we go draw a 3d image and so we're
going to import from our
mpl toolkits the implant 3d and the axis
3d we're going to import axis 3d this is
what's going to let us work with the 3d
image and this should look familiar
we're going to create another figure
just like we did before figure size 14
by 6. that's a good fit on the screen
we'll go ahead and run that
so we have our figure and let's go ahead
and take our x and we're going to set
that equal to fig dot add subplot that
should also be familiar from earlier and
we're going to work with this sets the
settings for the projection we're going
to use one two one projection 3d and
we'll see what that looks like in just a
minute and we just created some
three-dimensional data here before
where we had x y and z capital x y and z
so we're going to reuse that data we're
just going to use that since this also
this is also a three-dimensional image
so let's use that for a
three-dimensional graph and we simply do
ax plot underscore
surface
and our capital x
capital y capital z so there's our data
coming in and we're going to add some
settings in here we're going to do r
stride 4 c stride 4 and line width 0.
i'll show you what that is here in just
a minute let's go ahead and run that so
we can see our graph
and of course it helps if i don't add an
extra comma in there and you can see it
generates this really beautiful
three-dimensional graph
so let's take a little bit time to
explore some of these numbers we have
going in here
we have the r stride 4 the c stride 4
and the projection 3d projection 3d is
the important one because that's telling
us that this is a 3d graph here
so what are these first numbers one two
one let's just change one of these i'm
going to change this to 5
and it's going to give me an error let's
change it to 1.
and oh that didn't work let's change
this middle one to 3 instead and you're
going to see how it starts reshaping the
size and how it fits on the screen and
we'll change the first one to two we'll
run that one
and again it's changed the dimensions
and the size and how it fits on here
play with these numbers to get a nice
look and feel for it part of it is the
tilt and the angle
i'll do seven on this one
there we go you can see it really
shifted it there
but again that changes the size now it
fits on the canvas
but we'll leave it at the one
two and just so you get a good look at
what we're talking about here this is
column width and index from before
if we do one one one you can see that it
now spreads it out all the way across
uses the whole set up on there so this
has to do with the size and how big you
want it to be now there's one term that
we didn't cover in this yet but we've
used it throughout the whole setup
and i'm just going to type that down
here even though we're not going to go
into detail and that's the term heat
map you might see that it's kind of
starting to lose ground as far as a
common reference but there sure are a
lot of people who still talk about heat
maps what is a heat map well it is
simply a color map that's all it is so
if you ever see the term heat map
that refers to the fact this is in
different colors representing different
heights
that one is in the heat map but you can
see up here we switched into
let me go back up here here we go this
one has different colors for the
different values
a lot of times you'll use like instead
of x and y you might do a heat map
where you have a fourth value and the
fourth value represents the color and so
you'll see this 3d image in the nice
colors represented by heat map that's
all it is so if you see the term heat
map that only means we're plotting some
of the data in color to make it stand
out or to give it a fourth dimension in
this case
so we've covered a lot of things on
matplot and that brings us cover all the
basics so that brings us to practice
example and this is going to be the
challenge for you and let me go ahead
and change our cell
cell type mark down and run that so it
looks pretty
practice example write a python program
to create a pie chart of the popularity
of programming languages
okay excellent
and if you're going to have a challenge
we need some data and i'll just throw in
our import our map library at the
beginning you should do that
automatically and so for our data to
plot we're going to have our languages
we're going to have python we're going
to have java php javascript c-sharp c
plus so those are six categories and
then we have our popularity oops
misspelling there popularity we'll give
the first one 22.2 percent java 17.6 and
i don't know if these are real numbers
they pulled
my guess is that they might have just
been made up because i don't know if
python's really that much more popular
than the other ones maybe specific to
data science because python is very
popular in data science right now
because it has so many options the only
other program that's highly used and
exclusively for data science is r so
python's big and python also does a lot
more it's a full programming language
where r is primarily for data science
they didn't put r in here so we have
python we have java we have a php and
you can see the different values they've
given it or different percentages
and i did add these up does not add up
to 100 it adds up to 71 percent or
something like that
and then we're going to give colors and
we've chosen these guys in the back
brought in these colors i'm not sure
what these colors are we'll find out in
a minute so i'll be exciting but you can
see they're using the actual color
values you can pull off of a color wheel
or something like that
you could have just as easily done blue
red green if you're too lazy to pick the
exact colors
and then let's go ahead and solve this
and see we got here we're going to do
something a little fancy just because we
can
the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to use a variable called
explode and you'll notice that there's
six variables in here so that matches
our six different categories and the
first one we've done is point one and
then zero zero zero zero zero point one
when we put this in here under the
explode in the plot it will actually
push that square out so it's a really
cool feature to highlight certain
information on a pie chart
and this is simply
plt dot pi
and we're plotting
popularity there we go and before we add
in all the really cool settings for this
let's go ahead and run it and you'll see
we generate a nice flat pi
not too exciting there and then we'll go
ahead and put in all the extras i talked
about explode we can explode one of the
values out so here's our explode equals
explode labels as languages because we
want to know what the different colors
mean here's our colors equals colors
our auto picture and this is standard
print format so that's a python setup on
there and that's just going to put the
value on the pie slice and then we're
going to add shadow because it just
looks cooler with a shadow gives a
little 3d look and we'll do a start
angle of 140. let's go ahead and run
this and take a look and see what comes
out of that
and look how that changes the whole
setup so here's our labels there's our
value we put on there there's our slice
it's pushed out there's our shadow a 3d
effect
and then we started at 140. we could
also rotate this let's just do this
angle
and if we run it
you'll see the blue pie slices moved up
a little bit we could actually do
actually let's just take the whole
starting triangle out and run it'll
default to zero
this is what it looks like if it
defaulted to zero so depending on where
you want the highlighted slice to appear
usually you want that appear on the left
because people read left to right and so
it draws a focus onto in this case
python and how great python is i'm a
little biased we're teaching a python
tutorial so it should be understandable
that we're looking at python and one
last reference before we close
you can go over to the matplot library
dot pi plot set up and if you go
underneath there the different functions
on there you can look this up on their
website you'll see a full list and this
is why it's so important to go through a
tutorial like this because this list is
just so massive i'm trying to figure out
like here's our bar plot there's a bar h
you can add barbs there's a box plot we
didn't cover
c labels a totally different kind of for
your contour plot you can set up in
there if you go down here we have our
figures we used on there we showed you
the basics how to do the figure you'll
see some
closer references on those
there's a histogram down here hist
there's also the hiss 2d makes a 2d
histogram plot h lines all of this these
are all the different commands that are
underneath of here and you can see it's
pretty extensive
we've covered all the basic ones so that
you know have a solid ground to look at
these different options so when you come
to these functions some of them are
going to look a little off or not off
will look unfamiliar but you'll still
have the availability to probably
understand most of this and have a basic
understanding of your matplot library
what does a data scientist do these are
some of the activities data acquisition
data preparation data mining data
modeling and then model maintenance we
will talk about each of these in a great
detail but at a very high level the
first step obviously is to get the raw
data which is known as data acquisition
it can be in all kinds of format and it
could be multiple sources but obviously
that raw data cannot be used as it is
for performing data mining activities or
data modeling activities so the data has
to be claimed and prepared for using in
the data models or in the data mining
activity so that is the data preparation
then we actually do the data mining
which can also include some exploratory
activities and then if we have to do
stuff like machine learning then you
need to build a machine learning model
and test the model get insights out of
it and then if
the model is fine you deploy it and then
you need to maintain the model because
over a period of time it is possible
that you need to tweak the model because
of change in the process or changing the
data and so on so that all comes under
the model of maintenance so let's take
deeper look at each of these activities
let's start with data acquisition so the
stage of data acquisition basically the
data scientist will collect raw data
from all possible sources so this could
be typically an rdbms which is a
relational database or it can also be a
non-rdbms or it could be flat files or
unstructured data and so on so we need
to bring all that data from different
sources if required we need to do some
kind of homogeneous formatting so that
it all fits into
a
looks at least format from a format
perspective it looks homogeneous so that
may be requiring some kind of
transformation very often this is loaded
into what is known as data warehouse so
this can also be sometimes referred to
as etl or extract transform and load so
a data warehouse is like a common place
where data from different sources is
brought together so that people can
perform data science activities like
reporting or data mining or statistical
analysis and so on so data from various
sources is put in a centralized place
which is known as a data warehouse so
that is also known as etl and in order
to do this there can be data scientists
can take help of some etl tools there
are some existing tools that a data
scientist can take help of like for
example data stage or talent or
informatica these are pretty good tools
for performing these etl activities and
getting the data the next stage now that
you have the raw data into a data
warehouse you still probably are not in
a position to straight away use this
data for performing the data mining
activities so that is where data
preparation comes into play and there
are multiple reasons for that one of
them could be the data is dirty there
are some missing values and so on and so
forth so a lot of time is actually spent
in this particular stage so a data
scientist spends a lot of time almost 60
to 70 percent of the time in
this part of the project or the process
which is data preparation so there are
again within this there can be multiple
sub activities starting from let's say
data cleaning you will probably have
missing values the data there is some
columns the values are missing or the
values are incorrect there are null
values and so on and so forth so that is
basically the data cleaning part of it
then you need to perform certain
transformations like for example
normalizing the data and so on right so
you could probably have to modify a
categorical values into numerical values
and so on and so forth so these are
transformational activities then we may
have to handle outliers so the data
could be such that there are a few
values which are way beyond the normal
behavior of the data for whatever reason
either people have keyed in wrong values
or for some reason some of the values
are completely out of range so those are
known as outliers so there are certain
ways of handling these outliers and
detecting and handling these outliers so
this is a part of what is known as
exploratory analysis so you quickly
explore the data to find out other so
and you can use visual tools like plots
and identify what are the outliers and
see how we can get rid of the outliers
and so on then the next part could be
data integrity data integrity is to
validate for example if there are some
primary keys that all the primary keys
are populated there are some foreign
keys and at least most of the foreign
keys should be populated and otherwise
when we are trying to query the data you
may get wrong values and so on so that
is the data integrity part of it and
then we have what is known as data
reduction sometimes we may have
duplicate values we may have columns
that may be
duplicated because they are coming from
different sources the same values are
there and so on so a lot of this can be
done using what is known as data
reduction and thereby you can reduce the
size of the data drastically because
very often this could be written in data
which can be removed and so on so let's
take a look at what are the various
techniques that are used for data
cleaning so we need to ensure that the
data is valid and it is consistent and
uniform and accurate so these are the
various parameters that we need to
ensure as a part of the data cleaning
process now what are the techniques that
that are used for data cleaning or so we
will see what each of these are in this
particular case and so what is the data
set that we have we have data about a
bank and its customer details so let's
take an example and see how we go about
cleaning the data and in this particular
example we are assuming we are using
python so let's assume we loaded this
data which is the raw file dot csv this
is how the customer data looks like and
we will see for example we take a closer
look at the geography column we will see
that there are quite a few blank spaces
so how do we go about when we have some
blank spaces or if it is a string value
then we put an empty string here or we
just use a space or empty string if
there are numerical values then we need
to come up with a strategy
for example
we put the mean value so wherever it is
missing we find the mean for that
particular column so in this case let's
assume we have credit score and we see
that quite a few of these values are
missing so what do we do here we find
the mean for this column for all the
existing values and we found that the
mean is equal to
638.6 so we kind of write a piece of
code to replace wherever there are blank
values nan is basically like null and
we just go ahead and say fill it with
the mean value so this is the piece of
code we are writing to fill it so all
the blanks or all the null values get
replaced with the mean value now one of
the reasons for doing this is that very
often if you have some such situation
many of your statistical functions may
not even work so that's the reason you
need to fill up these values or either
get rid of these records or fill up
these values with something meaningful
so this is one mechanism which is
basically using a mean there are few
others as we move forward we can see
what are the other ways for example we
can also say that any missing value in a
particular row if even one column the
value is missing you just drop that
particular row or delete all rows where
even a single column has missing values
so that is one way of dealing now the
problem here can be that if a lot of
data has let's say one or two columns
missing and
we dropped many such rows then overall
you may lose out on let's say 60 of the
data has some value or the other missing
sixty percent of the rows then it may
not be a good idea to delete all the
rows like in that manner because then
you're losing pretty much sixty percent
of your data therefore your analysis
won't be accurate but if it is only five
or ten percent then this will work
another way is only to drop values where
or rather dropped rows where all the
columns are empty which makes sense
because that means that record is of
really no use because it has no
information in it so there can be some
situations like that so we can provide a
condition saying that drop the records
where all the columns are blank or not
applicable we can also specify some kind
of a threshold let's say you have 10 or
20 columns in a row you can specify that
maybe five columns are blank or null
then you drop that record so again we
need to take care that such a condition
such a situation the amount of data that
has been removed or excluded is not
large if it is like maybe five percent
maximum ten percent then it's okay but
by doing this if you're losing out on a
large chunk of data then it may not be a
good idea you need to come up with
something better what else we need to do
next is so the data preparation part is
done so now we get into the data mining
part so what exactly we do in data
mining primarily we come up with ways to
take meaningful decisions so data mining
will give us insights into the data what
is existing there and then we can do
additional stuff like maybe machine
learning and so on to get perform
advanced analytics and so on so one of
the first steps we do is what is known
as data discovery and
which is basically like exploratory
analysis so we can use tools like
tableau for doing some of this so let's
just take a quick look at how we go
about that so tableau is excellent data
mining or actually more of a reporting
or a bi tool and you can download a
trial version of tableau at tableau.com
or there is also tableau public which is
free and you can actually use and play
around however if you want to use it for
enterprise purpose then it is a
commercial software so you need to
purchase license and you can then run
some of the data mining activities say
your data source your data is in some
excel sheet so you can select the source
as microsoft excel or any other format
and the data will be brought into the
tableau environment and then it will
show you what is known as dimensions and
measures so dimensions are all the
descriptive columns so and tableau is
intelligent enough to actually identify
these dimensions and measure so measures
are the numerical values so as you can
see here customer id gender geography
these are all dimensions non-limited
values whereas age balance credit score
and so on are numeric values so they
come under measures so you've got your
data into tableau and then you want to
let's say build a small model and you
want to let's say solve a particular
problem so what is the problem statement
all right let's say we want to analyze
why customers are
leaving the bank which is known as exit
and we want to analyze and see what are
some of the factors for exiting the bank
and we want to let's assume consider
these three of them like let's say
gender credit card and geography these
as a criteria and analyze if these are
in any way impacting or have some
bearing on the customer exiting or the
customer exit behavior okay so let's
use tableau and very quickly we will be
able to find out how these parameters
are affecting all right so let's see so
this is our customer data so from our
excel sheet we have data set about let's
say 10 000 rows and we want to find out
what is the criteria let's start with
gender let's say we want to first use
gender as a criteria so tableau really
offers an easy drag and drop kind of a
mechanism so that makes it really really
easy to perform this kind of analysis so
what we need to do is exited says
whether the customer has exited or not
so it has a value of zero and one and
then of course you have gender and so on
so we will take these two and simply
drag and drop okay so exit it and then
we will put gender and if we drag and
drop into the analysis side of tab loop
all right so here what we are doing is
we are showing male female as two
different columns here and zero for
people who did not exist and one for
people who exited and that is color
coded so the blue color means people who
did not exist and
this yellow color means people who did
exit all right so now if we pull the
data here create like bar graphs this is
how it would look so what is yellow
let's go back so yellow is
who exited and
for the male only 16.45
percent have exited and we can also draw
a reference line that will help us or
even provide aliases so these are a lot
of fancy stuff that is
provided by tableau you can create
aliases and
so that it looks good rather than basic
labels and you can also add a reference
line so you add a reference line
something like this from here we can
make out that on an average female
customers exit more than the male
customers right so that is what we are
seeing here on an average so we have
analyzed based on gender we do see that
there is some difference in the male and
female behavior now let's take the next
criteria which is the credit card so
let's see if having a credit card has
any impact on the customer exit behavior
so just like before we drag and drop the
credit card has credit card a column if
we drag and drop here and then we will
see that there is pretty much no
difference between people having credit
card and not having credit card twenty
point eight one percent of people who
have no credit card have exited and
similarly twenty point one eight percent
of people who have credit card have also
exited so the credit card is not having
much of an impact that's what this piece
of analysis shows last we will basically
go and check how the geography is
impacting so once again we can drag and
drop geography column onto this site and
if we see here there are geographies
like i think there are about three
geographies like france germany and
spain and
we see that there is some kind of
impact with the geography as well okay
so what we derive from this is that the
credit card is really we can ignore the
credit card variable or feature from our
analysis because that doesn't have any
impact but gender and geography we can
keep and do further analysis okay all
right so what are some of the advantages
of data mining bit more detailed
analysis can help us in predicting the
future trends and it also helps in
identifying customer behavior patterns
okay so you can take informed decisions
because the data is telling you or
providing you with some insights and
then you take a decision based on that
if there is any fraudulent activity data
mining will help in quickly identifying
such a fraud as well and of course it
will also help us in identifying the
right algorithm for performing more
advanced data mining activities like
machine learning and so on all right so
the next activity now that we have the
data we have prepared the data and
performed some data mining activity the
next step is model building let's take a
look at model building so what is model
building if we want to perform a more
detailed data mining activity like maybe
perform some machine learning then you
need to build a model and how do you
build a model first thing is you need to
select which algorithm you want to use
to solve the problem on hand and also
what kind of data that is available and
so on and so forth so you need to make a
choice of the algorithm and based on
that you go ahead and create a model
train the model and so on we look at
data science components there's the
mathematics statistics
domain expertise
data engineering data visualization and
machine learning when we sum this up in
data science really
this point
in all of this you want to focus on
first is domain expertise
now when you're taking your classes
obviously you want to go through the
mathematics the statistics the data
engineering the data visualization the
machine learning and learning all those
tools
but it really in the job field the
domain expertise comes in
because if you're really good with
business and you go into business with
these tools
then you're able to ask the right
questions and deal with it when we talk
about the tools in data science and
where they sit
there is a data analysis
data analysis focuses more on statistics
and mathematics
where the data science size
where the data science side focuses more
on the machine learning data
visualization
and then there's database management
which really focuses on the data
engineering part of it and how to manage
that data in the data flow
and you can see all these components
come together and then they form the
data science
and we talk about tools in data science
we have sas we have matlab we have sql
you have your apache spark your r table
python
right now in the programming languages
python is probably the most widely used
with r coming in a close second
the reason for that is these are both
open source and anybody can use them we
look at sas and tableau those are two
packages that are paid for which have a
lot of automation behind them so a lot
of the larger companies will pay for
those packages because they help work
out a lot of the the back end stuff
before you even need to use them
and of course we have apache spark
you almost have to know apache spark in
the growing data lakes today that's your
big data how do you distribute this if
you're going to process it over a large
amount of data we look at data science
applications there's internet search
very common you enter your google thing
and it uses the data science algorithms
to figure out what to return voice
assistance
analyzing the voice coming in and
connecting it with whatever patterns
they need to activate so you can ask it
to turn your lights on in the living
room healthcare biggest field growing
right now how do we analyze health data
from a smart watch and figure out how to
know when a disease is being spread
across the world
health care how do we identify
cancer versus non-cancer so we know who
to prioritize and get them in for
surgery where other people might not
need that immediate care and even
identifying
problems somebody might have with their
health long before they even happen what
a neat thing to do instead of waiting
until you have a heart attack
to know months ahead of time that you're
having heart conditions logistics how do
we get from point a to point b
if you ever look at some of the major
distributors they pre-ship things based
on what they guess people are going to
need
this way you get your stuff right in the
mailbox the day after you order it
e-commerce
huge in there because you have to know
what kind of marketing we're going to
put out who are we selling to what's our
target audience
robotics
one of the funner ones when you're
coming up into the future is how do we
automate the different
tasks we have from self-driving cars to
manufacturing lines to maybe even a
self-robotic chef
in the kitchen so we talk about solving
problems with data science
we have to ask possible questions and
the desired algorithms and these really
are
kind of an overview of some of the
terminology you'll want to know in data
science
so we talk about that how much or how
many we're talking about regression
regression basically means a number if
you've ever seen stock charts you see
[Music]
the guess at what the next sales price
is or buy price is
that's all on your regression side
is it a or b classification
is that a dog or a cat that my photo
took a picture of how is this organized
clustering this is where we take things
that look alike and put them together so
that we can then make predictions on it
how difference is this
just like you have clustering you have
the opposite anomaly detection how do we
find things that don't fit in where are
the outliers what are things we might
need to look at that aren't in our model
and what to do next reinforced learning
this is probably the newest market is
how do we set something up whereas the
data comes in it learns from the new
data as to what the next action is going
to take
most of these are combined so when we
talk about regression classification
clustering anomaly detection reinforced
learning
a lot of times when you put your model
together you might have multiple parts
of this we might look at the clustering
of data
and then feed it into a classification
is this a bad loan to make it the bank
or is this a good loan to give
and from there we might start looking at
when we start clustering these things as
good and bad and what kind of setup is
we then might run it through a
regression model to say hey what is the
amount dollar amount this person
should be allowed to take a loan out
and you can see that all of these start
coming in and then
a lot of the models
reinforced learning
we talk about like bank loans and things
like that once a year
they have to rerun those algorithms and
so that's like a human run reinforced
learning
now we're starting to automate that so
that as the data comes in real time the
models start updating themselves
they start figuring out a way to solve
new problems as they occur
and of course in robotics reinforced
learning is one of the biggest growing
fields
logarithms used in data science linear
regression
logistic regression when you're looking
at both of these uh think numbers we're
talking regression models and so linear
regression figures out the best line
through the data maybe it's looking for
a curved line
logistic regression starts looking at
data
on a continuum
so that
it goes to an exponential you have a
spot where it might be one or the other
and then you know what it is as it goes
to one side or the other
decision tree wonderful tool if you
used to call it a hack now it's becoming
mainstream to look at the back end what
made the decision so it's really easy to
trace back to how you arrived at the
decision decision trees are kind of nice
that way
nearest neighbors k nearest neighbors is
your clustering k means clustering
hierarchical clustering
so hierarchical starts dividing them and
builds a hierarchy where the k-means and
the k-nearest neighbor look for things
that kind of connect each other how
close are they in data format
db scan another form of clustering your
data principle component analysis so we
start breaking up and looking at the
different components in our data coming
in these are all algorithms used in data
science and there are more these are
kind of the mainline ones and each one
of these has many settings which you can
play with
to build a better model to predict your
data and where you want it to go let's
go ahead and take a hands-on demo and
just see what does this look like
now i'm going to go ahead and use the
anaconda navigator and the
which is your jupiter notebook which
will then open up in google chrome
this is one of the ides or ways of
editing python code i like this one
because it one protects my computer and
creates its own kind of container
and two it's got a really nice visual
demo for doing python certainly you can
use a number of other different tools
like pycharm
there's another real popular one you can
actually access pycharm code through the
anaconda navigator now and there's a lot
of other tools on there that each have
their benefit and we come into our
jupiter notebook go and create a new
python i've already done that
and we'll start with a lot logistics
regression model just so you can see
what this looks like in code we'll
actually do two of these
as we go through this and take a look
and see what that code looks like in
python
now the first thing we want to go ahead
and do is
load up all our parts modules that we
need in our python code
i'll go and run that and you'll see here
i'm going to ignore warnings because
some of the stuff we're doing
we're just looking at it and as you go
from one
version of python to one version of
whatever
the site kit or in this case the sc
package
you'll see some warnings come up they're
not really important right now
and then we're going to go ahead and use
the german credit data csv
and so when i run this this is all
loaded up now let's go ahead and just
open up this csv file so you can see
what that looks like
and here it is here's our german credit
data file
we'll go ahead and just open that up
with
let's do
wordpad just fine because it's a word
document
and when we open that up
you can see right here it's just a bunch
of comma separated values
we have across the top
it actually has columns on here so our
first row is a bunch of columns
and then of course we look down here
oops i just move stuff around but that's
okay i'm not going to save it and you
can see the values al1 al4 whatever that
means or a14 i guess
and then some sort of numbers on here
and we'll take a closer look when we get
into the program
and looking at the data for right now
we've loaded that under credit df
and at this point i want to just kind of
take a detour back to the life cycle of
data science so we can see how that fits
in there
and so we've already done our data
discovery
we have a little data prep but the data
is pretty clean
it already comes in preset on there
we'll make do a little data preparation
in here we're going to start looking at
exploring the data
analysis and building a data model and
then interpreting the results so really
we're focusing on the last three steps
of this
the data discovery would be asking uh
start asking questions of what do we
want in there is this going to be
is this going to be a good loan a bad
loan what do we want to get out of this
data where are we going with it that
would be part of the data discovery and
a lot of times that might be a meeting
you have with the management in the
office or whatever
and then data preparation is of course
cleaning the data up
making sure you know where the source
came from
all those kind of fun things that go
into making sure you have good data
coming in
we're going to cover mathematics for
machine learning so today's agenda is
going to cover data and its types and
we're going to dive into linear algebra
and its concepts
calculus statistics for machine learning
probability for machine learning
hands-on demos
and of course throwing in there in the
middle is going to be your matrixes and
a few other things to go along with all
this
data and as types
data denotes the individual pieces of
factual information collected from
various sources it is stored processed
and later used for analysis
and so we see here just a huge grouping
of information a lot of tech stuff money
dollar signs numbers
and then you have your performing
analytics to drive insights and
hopefully you have a nice share your
shareholders gather it at the meeting
and you're able to explain it in
something they can understand
so we talk about data types of data we
have in our types of data we have a
qualitative categorical
you think nominal or ordinal and then
you have your quantitative or numerical
which is discrete or continuous
and let's look a little closer at those
data type vocabulary always people's
favorite is the vocabulary words okay
not mine
uh but let's dive into this what we mean
by nominal nominal they are used to
label various uh
label our variables without providing
any measurable value
country gender race hair color etc it's
something that you either mark true or
false this is a label it's on or off
either they have a red hat on or they do
not
so a lot of times when you're thinking
nominal data
labels
think of it as a true false kind of
setup and we look at ordinal this is
categorical data with a set order or a
scale to it
and you can think of salary range as a
great one movie ratings etc you see here
the salary rates if you have 10 000 to
20 000
number of employees earning that rate is
150 20 000 to 30 100 and so forth some
of the terms you'll hear is bucket uh
this is where you have 10 different
buckets and you want to separate it into
something that makes sense into those 10
buckets
and so
we start talking about ordinal a lot of
times when you get down to the brass
bones again we're talking true false
so if you're a member of the 10 to 20 k
range
so forth those would each be either part
of that group or you're not
but now we're talking about buckets so
we want to count how many people are in
that bucket
quantitative numerical data
falls into two classes discrete or
continuous and so data with a final set
of values which can be categorized class
strength questions answered correctly
and runs hit and cricket
a lot of times when you see this you can
think integer
and a very restricted integer i
you can only have 100 questions
on a test so you can it's very discreet
i only have 100 different values that it
can attain
so think usually you're talking about
integers but within a very small range
they don't have an open end or anything
like that
so discrete is very solid
simple to count set number
continuous on the other hand continuous
data can take any numerical value within
a range so water pressure weight of a
person etc usually we start thinking
about float values where they can get
phenomenally small in their in what
they're worth
and there's a whole series of values
that falls right between discrete and
continuous
you can think of the stock market you
have dollar amounts it's still discrete
but it starts to get complicated enough
when you have like you know jump in the
stock market from 525.33
to
580.67
there's a lot of point values in there
it'd still be called discrete but you
start looking at it as almost continuous
because it does have such a variance in
it now
we talked about no we did we went over
nominal and ordinal
almost true false charts and we looked
at quantitative and numerical data which
we're starting to get into numbers
discrete you can usually a lot of times
discrete will be put into it could be
put into true false but usually it's not
uh so we want to address this stuff and
the first thing you want to look at is
the very basic which is your algebra so
we're going to take a look at linear
algebra you can remember back when your
euclidean geometry we have a line well
let's go through this we have a linear
algebra is the domain of mathematics
concerning linear equations
and their representations in vector
spaces and through matrixes i told you
we're going to talk about matrix is
so a linear equation
is simply
2x plus 4y minus 3z equals 10. very
linear 10x plus 12.4y equals z and now
you can actually solve these two
equations by combining them
and this we're talking about a linear
equation
in the vectors we have a plus b equals c
now we're starting to look at a
direction
and these values usually think of an x y
z plot um so each one is a direction and
the actual
distance of like a triangle a b is c
and then your matrix can describe all
kinds of things
i find matrixes
confuse a lot of people
not because they're particularly
difficult but because of the magnitude
and the different things are used for
and a matrix is a chart
or a
you know think of a spreadsheet but you
have your rows and your columns
and you'll see here we have a times b
equals c
very important to know your counts
so depending on how the math is being
done what you're using it for making
sure you have the same rows and number
of columns or a single number there's
all kinds of things that play in that
that can make matrixes confusing
but really it has a lot more to do with
what domain you're working in are you
adding in
multiple polynomials where you have like
a x squared plus b y plus you know you
start to see that can be very confusing
versus a very straightforward matrix
and let's just go a little deeper into
these because these are such primary
this is what we're here to talk about is
these different math uh mathematical
computations that come up
so we're looking at linear equations
let's dig deeper into that one an
equation having a maximum order of one
is called a linear equation
so it's linear because when you look at
this we have ax plus b equals c which is
a one variable we have two variable ax
plus b y equals c a x plus b y plus z c
z equals d
and so forth but all of these
are to the power of one you don't see x
squared you don't see x cubed so we're
talking about linear equations that's
what we're talking about in their
addition if you have already dived into
say neural networks you should recognize
this a x plus b y plus c z
setup plus the intercept which is
basically your your neural network each
node adding up all the different inputs
and we can drill down into that most
common formula is your y equals mx plus
c
so you have your y
equals the m which is your slope
your x value plus c
which is your
y-intercept you kind of labeled it wrong
here
threw me for a loop but the the c would
be your y-intercept so when you set x
equal to zero y equals c and that's
that's your y-intercept right there
uh and that's they they just had a
reverse value of y when x equals zero
equals the y-intercept which is c and
your slow gradient line which is your m
so you get your y equals 2x plus 3.
and there's lots of easy ways to compute
this this way this is why we always
start with the most basic one when we're
solving one of these problems and then
of course the one of the most important
takeaways is the slope gradient of the
line
so the slope is very important that m
value
in this case we went ahead and solved
this
if you have y equals 2 x plus 3 you can
see how it has a nice line graph here on
the right
so matrixes a matrix refers to a
rectangular representation of an array
of numbers arranged in columns and rows
so we're talking m rows by n columns
here a11 is denotes the element of the
first row in the first column similarly
a12 and it's really pronounced a11 in
this particular setup so it's row one
column one a 12 is a
row one column two
first row and second column and so on
and there's a lot of ways to denote this
i've seen these as like a capital letter
a smaller case a for the top row or i
mean you can see where they can go all
kinds of different directions as far as
the value
you just take a moment to realize
there's need to be some designation as
far as what row it's in and what column
it's in
and we have our basic operations we have
addition so when you think about
addition you have uh
two matrixes of two by two and you just
add each individual number in that
matrix and then when you get to the
bottom you have in this case the
solution is 12 10 plus 2 is 12 5 plus 3
is 8 and so on and the same thing with
subtraction
now again your counting matrix is you
want to check your
dimensions of the matrix
the shape you'll see shape come up a lot
in programming so we're talking about
dimensions we're talking about the shape
if the two shapes are equal
this is what happens when you add them
together or subtract them
and we have multiplication when you look
at the multiplication you end up with a
very uh a slightly different setup going
now
if we look at our last one we're uh
we're like why
this always gets to me when we get to
matrixes because they don't really say
why you multiply matrixes
you know my first thought is 1 times 2 4
times 3 but if you look at this we get 1
times 2 plus 4 times 3
1 times 3 plus 4 times 5
six times two plus three times three six
times three plus three times five if
you're looking at these matrixes uh
think of this more as an equation
and so we have if you remember we move
back up here for our multiple line
equations let's just go back up a couple
slides where we were looking at a two
variable so this is a two variable
equation a x plus b y equals c
and this is a way to make it very quick
to solve these variables and that's why
you have the matrix and that's why you
do
the multiplication the way they do
and this is the dot product of one times
two
plus four times three
one times three plus four times five
six times two plus three times three
six times three plus three times five
and it gives us a nice little
14 23 21 and 33 over here which then can
be used and reduced down to a sample
formula as far as solving the variables
as you have enough inputs
and then in matrix operations when
you're dealing with a lot of matrixes
now keep in mind multiplying matrixes is
different than finding the product of
two matrixes okay so we're talking about
multiplication we're talking about
solving uh for equations when you're
finding the product you are just finding
1 times 2. keep that in mind because
that does come up i've had that come up
a number of times where i'm altering
data and i get confused as to what i'm
doing with it
uh transpose flipping the matrix over is
diagonal comes up all the time where you
have you still have 12 but instead of it
being a 12 8 it's now 12 14
8 21 you're just flipping the columns
and the rows
and then of course you can do an inverse
changing the signs of the values across
this main diagonal and you can see here
we have the inverse a to the minus 1 and
ends up with
instead of 12 8 14 12 is now minus 22
minus 12.
vectors
vector just means we have
a value and a direction and we have down
four numbers here on our vector
uh in mathematics a one dimensional
matrix is called a vector uh so
if you have your x plot and you have a
single value that values along the
x-axis and it's a single dimension
if you have two dimensions you can think
about putting them on a graph you might
have x and you might have y and each
value denotes a direction and then of
course the actual distance is going to
be the hypothesis of that triangle
and you can do that with three
dimensionals x y and z
and you can do it all the way to nth
dimensions so when they talk about the k
means
for categorizing and how close data is
together they will compute that based on
the pythagorean theorem so you would
take
the square of each value add them all
together and find the square root and
that gives you a distance
as far as where that point is where that
vector exists or an actual point value
and then you can compare that point
value
to another one it makes a very easy
comparison versus comparing 50 or 60
different numbers
and that brings us up to i gene vectors
and i gene values
hygiene vectors the vectors that don't
change their span while transformation
and i-gene values the scalar values that
are associated to the vectors
conceptually you can think of the vector
as your picture you have a picture it's
uh
two dimensions x and y
and so when you do those two dimensions
and those two values or whatever that
value is
that is that point but the values change
when you skew it and so
if we take and we have a vector a
and that's a set value uh b is um your
is your you have a and b which is your i
gene vector 2 is the i gene value so
we're altering
all the values by two that means we're
maybe we're stretching it out one
direction making it tall if you're doing
picture editing
that's one of the places this comes in
but you can see when you're transforming
uh your different information how you
transform it is then your hygiene value
and you can see here vector after line
transit transition
we have 3a a is the hygiene vector 3 is
the aging value
so a doesn't change that's whatever we
started with that's your original
picture and 3
is skewing it one direction and maybe
a b is being skewed another direction
and so you have a nice tilted picture
because you altered it by those by the
aging values
so let's go ahead and pull up a demo on
linear algebra and to do this i'm going
to go through my trusted anaconda into
my jupiter notebook
and we'll create a new uh notebook
called linear algebra
since we are working in python we're
going to use our numpy i always import
that as np or numpy array probably the
most popular
module for doing matrixes and things in
given that this is part of a series i'm
not going to go too much into numpy we
are going to go ahead and create two
different variables a for a numpy array
10 15 and b 29
we'll go ahead and run this and you can
see there's our two arrays 10 15 29 and
i went and added a space there in
between
so it's easier to read
and since it's the last line we don't
have to put the print statement on it
unless you want we can simply but we can
simply do a plus b so when i run this
uh we have 10 15 29 and we get 30
24 which is what you expect 10 plus 20
15 plus 9
you could almost look at this addition
as being
just adding up the columns on here
coming down and if we wanted to do it a
different way we could also do a dot t
plus b dot t
remember that t flips them and so if we
do that we now get them
we now have 30 24 going the other way
we could also do something kind of fun
there's a lot of different ways to do
this
as far as a plus b i can also do a plus
b
dot t
and you're going to see that that will
come out the same the 30 24 whether i
transpose a and b or transpose them both
at the end
and likewise we can very easily subtract
two vectors i can go a minus b
and we run that and we get minus 10 6.
now remember this is the last line in
this particular section that's why i
don't have to put the print around it
and just like we did before
we can transpose either the individual
or we can transpose the main set up and
then we get a minus 10 6 going the other
way
now we didn't mention this in our notes
but you can also do a scalar
multiplication
and just put down scalar so you can
remember that
uh what we're talking about here is i
have
this
array here u
and if i go a
times u
we'll take the value 2 we'll multiply it
by every value in here so 2 times 30 is
60 2 times 15
and just like we did before
this happens a lot because when you're
doing matrixes you do need to flip them
you get 60 30 coming this way
so in numpy uh we have what they call
dot product
and uh with this this is in a two
dimensional vectors it is equivalent of
two matrix multiplication remember we
were talking about matrix multiplication
uh where it is the
well let's walk through it
we'll go ahead and start by defining two
numpy arrays we'll have uh 10 20 25 6 or
our u and our v
and then we're going to go ahead and do
if we take
the values
and if you remember
correctly an array like this would be 10
times 25 plus 20 times 6.
we'll go ahead and
print that
there we go
and then we'll go ahead and do the np
dot dot
of u comma
v
and we'll find when we do this we go and
run this we're going to get
370 370.
so this is a strain multiplication where
they use it to solve
linear algebra when you have multiple
numbers going across and so this could
be very complicated we could have a
whole string of different variables
going in here but for this we get a nice
value for our dot multiplication
and we did
addition earlier which is just your
basic addition
and of course the matrix you can get
very complicated on these or
in this case we'll go ahead and do
let's create two
complex matrixes
this one is a matrix of
you know 12 10 4 6 4 31.
we'll just print out a so you can see
what that looks like here's print
a
we print a out you can see that we have
2 by 3
layer matrix for a
and we can also put together
always kind of fun when you're playing
with print values
we could do something like this we could
go in here
there we go uh we could print a we have
it end with uh equals a
run
and this kind of gives it a nice look uh
here's your matrix that's all this is
comma n means it just tags it on the end
that's all all that is doing on there
and then we can simply add in what is a
plus b and you should already guess
because this is the same as what we did
before there's no difference
when we do a simple vector addition we
have 12 plus 2 is 14 10 plus 8 is 18 and
so on
and just like we did the
matrix addition we can also do a minus b
and do our matrix subtraction
and we look at this uh we have what 12
minus 2 is 10 10 minus 8 um where are we
oh there we go eight minus uh
confusing what i'm looking at i should
have reprinted out the original numbers
but we can see here 12 minus two is of
course 10
10 minus 8 is 2
4 minus 46 is minus 42 and so forth so
same as a subtraction as before we just
call it matrix subtraction is identical
now if you remember up here we had a
scalar addition we're adding just one
number
to a matrix you can also do scalar
multiplication
and so simply if you have a single value
a and you have b which is your array we
can also do a times b
when we run that
you can see here we have 2 times 4 is 8
5 times 4 is 20 and so forth you're just
multiplying the 4 across each one of
these values
and this is an interesting one that
comes up
a little bit of a brain teaser is matrix
and vector multiplication
and so when we're looking at this
we are
just doing regular array it doesn't
necessarily have to be a numpy array
we have a
which has our
array of arrays and b which is a single
array and so we can from here
do the dot
a b
and this is going to return two values
and the first value is that is you could
say it's like uh
we're doing the
this array b array
first with a and then with a second one
and so it splits it up so you have a
matrix of vector multiplication and you
can mix and match
when you get into really complicated uh
back-end stuff this becomes more common
because you're now you've got layers
upon layers of data and so you'll end up
with a matrix and a set of bolt
vector matrices do you want to multiply
now keep in mind
that if you're doing data science a lot
of times you're not looking at this this
is what's going on behind the scenes so
if you're in
the scikit looking at sk learn where
you're doing linear regression models
this is some of the math that's hidden
behind the scenes that's going on
other times you might find yourself
having to do part of this and manipulate
the data around so it fits right and
then you go back in and you run it
through the psi kit and if we can do
up here where we did a
matrix and vector multiplication we can
also do matrix two matrix multiplication
and if we run this where we have the two
matrixes
you can see a very complicated array
that of course comes out on there for
our dot
and just to reiterate it we have our
transpose matrix which is your dot t and
so if we create a matrix a and we do
transpose it you can see how it flips it
from
5 10 15 20 25 30 to 5 15 25 10 20 30
rows and columns
and certainly with the math uh this
comes up a lot
it also comes up a lot with xy plotting
when you put in the pi plot you have one
format where they're looking at pairs
and numbers and then they want all of
x's and all y's so you know the
transpose is an important tool both for
your math and for plotting and all kinds
of things
another tool that we didn't discuss
is your identity matrix
and this one is more
definition
uh the identity matrix
we have here one where we just did uh
two
so it comes down as one zero zero one
uh one zero zero zero one zero it
creates a diagonal of one and what that
is is when you're doing your identities
you could be comparing
all your different features to the
different features and how they
correlate
and of course when you have feature one
compared to feature one to itself it is
always
one uh where
usually it's between zero one depending
on how well correlates so when we're
talking about identity matrix that's
what we're talking about right here is
that you create this preset matrix and
then you might adjust these numbers
depending on what you're working with
and what the domain is
and then another thing we can do
to kind of wrap this up we'll hit you
with the most complicated uh
piece of this
puzzle here is an inverse
a matrix
and let's just go ahead and put the um
it's a lengthy description
let's go and put the description this is
straight out of the
the website for numpy
so given a square matrix a here's our
square matrix a which is 2 1 0 0 1 0 1 2
1. keep in mind 3 by 3 is square it's
got to be equal it's going to return the
matrix a inverse satisfying dot a
um a inverse so here's our
matrix multiplication
um and then of course it equals the dot
yeah a inverse of a
with an identity shape of
a dot shape 0. this is just reshaping
the identity
that's a little complicated there
so we're going to have our here's our
array
we'll go ahead and run this
and you can see what we end up with
is we end up with
an array 0.5 minus 0.5 and so forth with
our 2 1 1 going down 2 1 0 0 1 0 1 2 1.
getting into a little deep on the math
understanding
when you need this is probably really is
is what's really important when you're
doing data science
versus uh handwriting this out and
looking up the math and handwriting all
the pieces out you do need to know about
the linear algorithm inverse of a
so if it comes up you can easily pull it
up or at least remember where to look it
up we took a look at the algebra side of
it let's go ahead and take a look at the
calculus side of what's going on here
with the machine learning so
calculus oh my goodness and differential
equations you got to throw that in there
because that's all part of the
bag of tricks especially when you're
doing large neural networks but also
comes up in many other areas the good
news is most of it's already done for
you in the back end
so when it comes up you really do need
to understand from the data science not
data analytics data analytics means
you're digging deep into
actually solving these math equations
and a neural network is just a giant
differential equation
uh so we talk about calculus
we're going to go ahead
and understand it by talking about cars
versus time and speed
so helps to calculate the spontaneous
rate of change
so suppose we plot a graph of the speed
of a car with respect to time so as you
can see here
going down the highway probably merged
into the highway from an on-ramp so i
had to accelerate so my speed went way
up
stuck in traffic merged into the traffic
traffic opens up and i accelerate again
up to the speed limit
and
maybe peter's off up there so you can
look at this as as
the speed versus time i'm getting faster
and faster because i'm continually
accelerating and if i hit the brakes you
go the other way
so the rate of change of speed with
respect to time is nothing but
acceleration how fast are we
accelerating
the acceleration is the area between the
star point of x and the endpoint of
delta x
so we can calculate a simple
if you had x and delta x we could put a
line there and that slope of the line is
our acceleration
now that's pretty easy when you're doing
linear algebra but i don't want to know
it just for that line and those two
points i want to know across the whole
of what i'm working with
that's where we get into calculus
so we talk about the distance between x
and delta x it has to be the smallest
possible near to zero in order to
approximate the acceleration
uh so the idea is that instead of i mean
if you ever did took a basic calculus
class
they would draw bars down here and you
would divide this area up
let's go back up the screen you divide
this area of this time period up into
maybe 10 sections and you'd use that and
you could calculate the acceleration
between each one of those 10 sections
kind of thing
and then we just keep making that space
smaller and smaller until delta x is
almost
infinitesimally small
and so we get a function of a
equals a limit as h goes to 0 of a
function of a plus h minus a function of
a over h and that is you're computing
the slope of the line
we're just computing that slope and
they're smaller and smaller and smaller
samples
and that's what calculus is calculus is
the integral you can see down here we
have our nice
integral sign looks like a giant s
and that's what that means is that we've
taken this down to as small as we can
for that sampling
so we're talking about calculus we're
finding the area under the slope is the
main process in the integration
similar small intervals are made of the
smallest possible length of x plus delta
x where delta x approaches almost an
infinitesimally small space
and then it helps to find the overall
acceleration by summing up all the links
together so we're summing up all the
accelerations from the beginning to the
end
and so here's our integral we sum of a
of x times d of x
equals a plus c
that is our basic calculus here
so when we talk about multivariate
calculus
multivariate calculus deals with
functions that have multiple variables
and you can see here we start getting
into some very complicated equations
change in w over change of time
equals change of w over change of z
the differential of z to dx differential
of x to dt it gets pretty complicated uh
it really translates into the
multivariate integration using double
integrals and so you have the the sum of
the sum of f of x of y of d of a equals
the sum from c to d and a to b of f of x
y d x d y equals
the sum of a to b sum of c to d of f x
or y d y d x
understanding the very specifics of
everything going on in here and actually
doing the math is usually calculus one
calculus 2 and differential equations
so you're talking about three
full-length courses to dig into
and solve these math equations
what we want to take from here is we're
talking about calculus
we're talking about summing of all these
different slopes and so we're still
solving a linear uh expression we're
still solving
y equals m x plus b
but we're doing this for infinitesimally
small x's and then we want to sum them
up that's what this integral sign means
the sum of a of x d of x equals a plus c
and when you see these very complicated
multivariate differentiation using the
chain rule
when we come in here and we have the
change of w to the change of t equals
the change of w dz
uh and so forth that's what's going on
here that's what these means we're
basically looking for the area under the
curve which really comes to
how is the change changing
speeds going up how is that changing and
then you end up with a multiple layer so
if i have three layers of neural
networks how is the third layer changing
based on the second layer changing which
is based on the first layer changing and
you get the picture here that now we
have a very complicated
multivariate integration
with integrals
the good news is we can solve this
mathematically and that's what we do
when you do neural networks and reverse
propagation
so the nice thing is that you don't have
to solve this on paper unless you're a
data analysis and you're working on the
back end of integrating these formulas
and building the script to actually
build them so we talk about applications
of calculus it provides us the tools to
build an accurate predictive model
so it's really behind the scenes we want
to guess at what the change of the
change or the change is
that's a little goofy i i know i just
threw that out there's kind of a meta
term but if you can guess how things are
going to change then you can guess what
the new numbers are
multivariate calculus explains the
change in our target variable in
relation to the rate of change in the
input variables
so there's our multiple variables going
in there if one variable is changing how
does it affect the other variable
and then in gradient descent calculus is
used to find the local and global maxima
and this is really big uh we're going to
actually going to have a whole section
here on gradient descent because it is
really i mean i talked about neural
networks and how you can see how the
different layers go in there but
gradient descent is one of the most
key things for trying to guess the best
answer to something
so let's take a look at the code behind
gradient descent
and before we open up the code let's
just do real quick
gradient descent
let's say we have a curve like this and
most common
is that this is going to represent your
error oops
error there we go there
ah hard to read there and i want to make
the error as low as possible
and so what i'm looking at it is i want
to find this line here
which is the minimum value so we're
looking for the minimum
and it does that by
sampling there
and then based on this it guesses it
might be someplace here and it goes hey
this is still going down
it goes here and then goes back over
here and then goes a little bit closer
and it's just playing a high low until
it gets to that spot that bottom spot
and so we want to minimize the error
and
on the flip note you could also want to
be maximizing something you want to get
the best output of it uh that's simply
minus the value uh so if you're looking
for where the peak is
this is the same as a negative for where
the valley is looking for that valley
that's all that is this is a way of
finding it so
the cool thing is um all the heavy
lifting's done
i actually
ended up putting together one of these a
while back is when i didn't know about
sidekick and i was just starting
boys a long while back
and uh
is playing high low how do you play high
low not get stuck in the valleys
figure out these curves and things like
that well you do that and the back end
is all the calculus and differential
equations to calculate this out
the good news is you don't have to do
those
so instead we're going to put together
the code and let's go ahead
and see what we can do with that
so uh guys in the back put together a
nice little piece of code here which is
kind of fun
uh some things we're going to note and
this is this is really important stuff
because when you start doing your data
science and digging into your machine
learning models
you're going to find
these things are stumbling blocks
the first one is current x where do we
start at
keep in mind
your model that you're working with is
very generic so whatever you use to
minimize it the first question is where
do we start um and we started at this
because the algorithm starts at x equals
three
so we are arbitrarily picked five
learning rate is uh how many bars to
skip going one where the other i'm in
fact i'm going to separate that a little
bit because these two are really
important
um if we're dealing with something like
this where we're talking about um
well here's our here's the function
we're going to use our
gradient of our function
2 times x plus 5 keep it simple so
that's a function we're going to work
with so if i'm dealing with increments
of a thousand 0.1 is going to be a very
long time and if i'm dealing with
increments of 0.001
0.1 is going to skip over my answer so i
won't get a very good answer
and then we look at precision this tells
us when to stop the algorithm so again
very specific to what you're working on
if you're working with money
and
you don't convert it into a float value
you might be dealing with 0.01 which is
a penny that might be your precision
you're working with
and then of course the previous step
size max iterations we want something to
cut out at a certain point usually
that's built into a lot of minimization
functions
and then here's our actual
formula we're going to be working with
and then we come in we go while previous
step size is greater than precision and
iters is less than max and max iters
say that 10 times fast
um
we're just saying if it's uh if we're if
we're still greater than our precision
level we still got to keep digging
deeper
um and then we also don't want to go
past a thou or whatever this is a
million or ten thousand uh running
that's actually pretty high i almost
never do max iterations more than like a
hundred or two hundred
rare occasions you might go up to four
or five hundred if it's depending on the
problem you're working with uh so we
have our previous equals our current
that way we can track time wise
uh the current now equals the current
minus the rate times the formula of our
previous x
so now we've generated our new version
uh previous step size equals the
absolute current previous
uh so we're looking for the change in x
errors equals iterations plus one that's
so we know to stop if we get too far
and then we're just going to print the
local minimum occurs at x on here and if
we go ahead and run this
you can see right here it gets down to
this point and it says hey
local minimum is minus 3.3222
for this particular series we created
this is created off of our formula here
lambda x2 times x plus 5.
now
when i'm running this stuff
you'll see this come up a lot
in with the sk learn kit
and one of the nice reasons of breaking
this down the way we did is i could go
over those top pieces uh those top
pieces are everything when you start
looking at these minimization tool kits
in built-in code
and so from um we'll just do it's
actually
docs
dot
scipy.org
and we're looking at
the scikit
there we go
optimize minimize
you can only minimize one value
you have the function that's going in
this function can be very complicated
so we used a very simple function up
here
it could be
there's all kinds of things that could
be on there and there's a number of
methods to solve this as far as how they
shrink down
uh and your x naught there's your
there's your start value so your
function your start value
there's all kinds of things that come in
here that you can look at which we're
not going to
optimization automatically creates
constraints bounds
some of this it does automatically but
you really the big thing i want to point
out here is you need to have a starting
point
you want to start with something that
you already know is mostly the answer
if you don't then it's going to have a
heck of a time trying to calculate it
out
or you can write your own little script
that does this and does a high low
guessing and tries to find the max value
that brings us to statistics what this
is kind of all about is figuring things
out a lot of vocabulary and statistics
ah so statistics well i guess it's all
relative it's definitely not an edel
class
so a bunch of stuff going on statistics
statistics concerns with the collection
organization analysis interpretation
and presentation of data
that is a mouthful um so we have from
end to end
where does it come from is it valid what
does it mean how do we organize it um
how do we analyze it and then you got to
take those analysis and interpret it
into something that people can use kind
of reduce it to understandable
and nowadays you have to be able to
present it if you can't present it then
no one else is going to understand what
the heck you did
so we look at the terminologies
there is a lot of terminologies
depending on what domain you're working
in
so clearly if you're working in um a
domain that deals with
viruses and t cells and and
how does you know where does that come
from you're studying the different
people then you can have a population
if you are working with um
mechanical gear
you know a little bit different if
you're looking for the wobbling
statistics to know when to replace a
rotor on a machine or something like
that that can be a big deal you know we
have these huge fans that turn
in our sewage processing systems and so
those fans they start to wobble and hum
and do different things if the sensors
pick up at one point do you replace them
instead of waiting for it to break in
which case it costs a lot of money
instead of replacing a bushing you're
replacing the whole fan unit
an interesting project that came up for
our city a while back
so population all objects are
measurements whose properties are being
observed uh so that's your population
all the objects it's easy to see it with
people because we have our population
large
but in the case of the sewer fans we're
talking about how the fan units that's
the population of fans that we're
working with
you have a parameter a matrix that is
used to represent a population or
characteristic
you have your sample a subset of the
population studied you don't want to do
them all because then you don't have a
if you come up with a conclusion for
everyone you don't have a way of testing
it so you take a sample
sometimes you don't have a choice you
can only take a sample of what's going
on you can't
study the whole population
and a variable a metric of interest for
each person or object in a population
types of sampling
we have a probabilistic approach
selecting samples from a larger
population using a method based on the
theory of probability
and we'll go into a little bit more
deeper on these we have random
systematic stratified
and then you have a non-probabilistic
approach selecting samples based on the
subjective judgment of the researcher
rather than random selection
has to do with convenience trying to
reach a quota
or snowball
and they're very biased that's one of
the reasons you'll see this big stamp on
it says biased uh so you gotta be very
careful on that
so probabilistic sampling uh when we
talk about a random sampling we select
random size samples from each group or
category so it's as random as you can
get we talk about systematic sampling
we're selecting random size samples from
each group or category with a fixed
periodic interval
so we kind of split it up this would be
like a time set up or our different
categories
and you might ask your question what is
a category or a group
uh if you look at i'm going to go back a
window let's say we're studying um
economics of different of an area
we know pretty much that based on their
culture where they came from
they might need to be separated and so
uh and why i say separated i don't mean
separated from their place where they
live i mean as far as the analysis we
want to look at the different groups and
make sure they're all represented
so if we had like an 80 percent
of a group that is
say hispanic
or indian and also in that same area we
have 20 percent 20 percent who are uh
let's call our expatriates they left
america and they're nice and uh your
caucasian group
we might want to sample a group that is
representative of both
uh so we're talking about stratified
sampling and we're talking about groups
those are the groups we're talking about
and that brings us to stratified
sampling selecting approximately equal
size samples from each group or category
this way we can actually separate the
categories and give us an insight into
the different cultures and how that
might affect them in that area
so you can see these are very very
different kind of
depends on what you're working with
as far as your data and what you're
studying and so we can see here just a
little bit more we'd have selecting 25
employees from a company of 250
employees randomly don't care anything
about them what groups are in which
office they're in nothing
and we might be selecting one employee
from every 50 unique employees in a
company of 250 employees
and then we have selecting one employee
from every branch in the company office
so we have all the different branches
there's our group or our categories by
the branch and the category could depend
on what you're studying so it has a lot
of variation on there
you see this kind of grouping and
categorizing is also used to generate a
lot of misinformation
so if you only study one group and you
say this is what it is
then everybody assumes that's what it is
for everybody and so you've got to be
very careful of that and it's very
unethical thing to kind of do
so types of statistics we talk about
statistics
we're going to talk about descriptive
and inferential statistics
there are so many different terms and
statistics to break it up
so we so we're talking about a
particular
setup
so we're talking about descriptive
inferential statistics
the base of the word describe
is pretty solid you're describing the
data what does it look like with
inferential statistics we're going to
take that from the small population to a
large population so if you're working
with a drug company you might look at
the data and say these people were
helped by this drug
they did uh 80 better
as far as their health or 80 percent
better survival rate than the people
who did not have the drug so we can
infer that that drug will work in the
greater populace and will help people so
that's where you get your inferential so
we are predicting how it's going to
affect the greater population
so descriptive statistics it is used to
describe the basic features of data and
form the basis of quantitative analysis
of data
so we have a measure of central
tendencies we have your mean median and
mode
and then we have a measure of spread
like your range your interquartile range
your variance and your standard
deviation
and we're going to look at all these a
little deeper here in a second
but one of them you can think of is
how the data difference
differences you know what's the max min
range all that stuff is your spread
and anything that's just a single number
is usually your central
tendencies measure of central tendencies
so we talk about the mean it is the
average of the set of values considered
what is the average outcome of
whatever's going on
and then your median
separates the higher half and the lower
half of data
so where's the center point of all your
different data points
so your mean might have some a couple
really big numbers that skew it uh so
that the average is much higher than if
you took those outliers out
where the median would by separating the
high from the low might give you a much
lower number you might look at and say
oh that's that's odd why is the average
so much higher than the median well it's
because you have some outliers or why is
it so much lower
and then the mode is the most frequent
appearing value
this is really interesting if you're
studying economics and how people are
doing you might find that the most
common
income like in the u.s was 1.24 000 a
year
where the average was closer to 80 000
and it's like wow what a difference well
there's some people have a lot of money
and so that skews that way up so the
average person is not making that kind
of money and then you look at the median
income and you're like well the median
income is a little bit closer to the
average so it does create a very
interesting way of looking at the data
again these are all
central tendencies single numbers you
can look at for the whole spread of the
data
and we look at the measure of central
tendencies the mean is the average marks
of a students in a classroom so here we
have the mean sum of the marks of the
students total number of students and as
we talked about the median
if we have
0 through 10
and we take half the numbers and put
them on one side of the line half the
numbers on the other side of the line
we end up with five in the middle and
then the mode what mark was scored by
most of the students in a test
in a simple case where most people
scored like an 82 percent and got
certain problems wrong easy to figure
out uh not so easy
when you have different areas where like
you have like the um oh let's go back to
economy a little bit more difficult to
calculate if you have a large group the
scores that makes 30 000 and a slightly
bigger group that makes 26 000 so what
do you put down for the mode
uh certainly there's a number of ways to
calculate that and there's actually a
different variations depending on what
you're doing
so now we're looking at a measure of
spread uh range what's the difference
between the highest and the lowest value
first thing you want to look at you know
it's uh we had everybody in the test
score between 60 and 100 somebody got
100 or maybe 60 to
90 percent it was so hard that a lot of
people could not get a hundred percent
you have your
inter-quartile range quartiles divide a
rank ordered data set into four equal
parts
very common thing to do as part of all
the basic packages whether you're
working in
data frames with pandas whether you're
working in scala whether you're working
in r
you'll see this come up where they have
range your min your max and then it'll
have your interquartile range how does
it look like in each quarter of data
variance measures how far each number in
the set is from the mean and therefore
from every other number in the set
uh so you have like a how much
turbulence is going on in this data
and then the standard deviation
it is to measure the variance or the
dispersion of a set of values from the
mean
and you'll usually see if i'm doing a
graph i might have the value graphed
and then based on the the error i might
graph graph the standard deviation in
the error on the graph as a background
so you can see how far off it is
so standard deviation is used a lot
so measurement of spread marks of a
student out of a hundred we have here
from 50 to 63 or 50 to 90.
so the range maximum marks minimum marks
we have 90 to 45 and the spread of that
is 45 90 minus 45. and then we have the
interquartile range using the same marks
over there you can see here where the
median is and then there's the first
quarter the second quarter and the third
quarter based on splitting it apart by
those values
and to understand the variance and
standard deviation we first need to find
out the mean
so here's our you know calculating the
average there we end up approximately 66
for the average and then we look at that
the variance once we know the means we
can do equals the marks minus the mean
squared
why is it squared uh because one you
want to make sure it's you don't have
like if you if you're
putting all this stuff together you end
up with an error as far as one's
negative one's positive one's a little
higher one's a little lower
so you always see
the squared value and over the total
observations and so the standard
deviation equals the square root of the
variance which is approximately 16. and
if you were looking at
a predictable model you would be looking
at the deviation based on the error how
much error does it have
that's again
really important to know if your if your
prediction is predicting something
what's the chance of it being way off or
just a little bit off
now that we've looked at the
tools as far as some of the basics for
doing your statistics that we're talking
about
let's go ahead and pull up a little demo
and show you what that looks like in
python code
so you can get some little hands-on here
for that let's go in back into our
jupiter notebook and python now almost
all of this you can do in numpy last
time we worked in numpy this time we're
going to go ahead and use pandas and if
you remember from pandas on here
this is basically a data frame rows
columns let's just go ahead and do a
print
df.head
and run that
and you can see we have the name jane
michael william rosie hannah sat in
their salaries on here and of course
instead of having to do all those hand
calculations and add everything together
and divide by the total
we can do something very simple on this
like
use the command mean in pandas and so if
i go ahead and do this print df
pick our column salary because we want
to find the means of that calorie
we want to find the means of that column
and we go and print this out and you can
see that the
average income on here is 71 000.
and let's just go ahead and do this
we'll go ahead and put in
means
and if we're going to do that we also
might want to find the median
and the median is
very similar
except it actually is just median uh
we're used to means in average it's kind
of interesting that those are they use
the two different words
uh there can be in some computation
slight differences but for the most part
the means is the average uh and then the
median
oops let's put a
median here
df salary that way it displays a little
better we can see the median is 54
000. so the halfway mark is
significantly below the average why
because we have somebody in here who
makes 189 000.
darn you rosie for throwing off our
numbers
but that's something you'd want to
notice this is this is the difference
between these is huge and so is what is
the meaning behind that when you're
studying a populist and looking at
the different data coming in and of
course we also want to find out hey
what's the most
common
income that people make
in this little tiny sample and so we'll
go ahead and do the mode
and you can see here with the mode uh
it's at 50 000.
so this is this is very telling that
most people are making 50 000
the middle point is at 54 thousand so
half the people are making more than
that
what that tells me is that if the most
common income is weight is below the
median
then
there's a few there's a scale there's a
lot of high salaries going up but
there's some really low salaries in
there
and so this trend which is very common
in statistics when you're analyzing
the economy in different people's income
is pretty common and the bigger
difference between these is also
very important when we're studying
statistics
and when you hear someone just say hey
the average income was you might start
asking questions at that point why
aren't you talking about the median
income why aren't you talking about the
mode the most common income
what are you hiding
uh and if you're doing these analysis
you should be looking at these saying
hey why are these discrepancies why are
these so different and of course with
any analysis it's important to find out
the minimum
and the maximum so we'll go ahead it's
just simply uh
dot min
will pull up your minimum and then dot
max pulls up the maximum
pretty straightforward on as far as
translating it and knowing which you
know what the
lowest value which your highest value is
here
um which you'll use to generate like a
spread later on and real quick on no
mode uh note that it puts mode 0. like i
said there's a couple different ways you
can compute the mode
although the standard one is pretty good
we can of course do the range which is
your max minus your min so now we have a
range of 149 000 between the
upper end and the lower end and you
might want to be looking up the
individual values on all of these but it
turns out there is a describe
feature in pandas
and so in pandas we can actually do df
salary describe and if we do this you
can see we have that there's seven uh
setups here's our mean
our standard deviation which we didn't
compute yet which should just be a dot
std
and you gotta be a little careful
because when it computes it it looks for
axes and things like that
we have our minimum value and here's our
quartiles
our maximum value and then of course the
name salary
so these are these are the basic
statistics you can pull them up and like
just describe
this is a dictionary so i could actually
do something like
in here i could actually go uh count
and run
and now it just prints the count
so because this is a dictionary you can
pull any one of these values out of here
it's kind of a quick and dirty way to
pull all the different information and
then split it up and depending on what
you need
now if i just walked in and gave you
this information
in a meeting
at some point you would just kind of
fall asleep
that's what i would do anyway
so we want to go ahead and see about
graphing it here and we'll go ahead and
put it into a histogram and plot that
graph on it
of the salaries and let's just go ahead
and put that in here so
we do our matplot inline remember that's
a jupiter's notebook thing a lot of the
new version of the matplot library does
it automatically
but just in case i always put it in
there import matplot library pipeline is
plt that's my plotting
and then we have our data frame i don't
i guess i really don't need to respell
the data frame maybe we could just
remind ourselves what's in it so we'll
go ahead and just
print
df that way we still have it
and then we have our salary df salary
salary.plot history title salary
distribution color gray
uh plot ax v line salary the mean value
so we're going to take the mean value
color violet
line style dash this is just all making
it pretty
what color dashed line line width of 2
that kind of thing
and the median and let's go ahead and
run this just so you can see what we're
talking about
and so up here we are taking on our plot
so here's the data here's our our data
frame print it out so you can see it
with the salaries we'll look at the
salary distribution
and just look at this the way the salary
is distributed
you have our
in this case we did
let's see we had red for the median
we have violet
for our average or mean
and you can just see how it really
i mean here's our outlier here's our
person who makes a lot of money here's
the
average and here's the median
and so as you look at this you can say
wow um
based on the average it really doesn't
tell you much about what people are
really taking home all it does is tell
you
how much money is in this you know what
the average salary is
so
some of the things you want to take away
in addition to this is that it's very
easy to plot
an ax v line
these are these up and down lines for
your markers
and as you just display the data i mean
you can add all kinds of things to this
and get really complicated keeping it
simple is pretty straightforward i look
at this and i can see we have a major
outlier out here we can definitely do a
histogram and stuff like that
but you know pictures worth a thousand
words what you really want to make sure
you take away is that we can do a basic
describe
which pulls all this information out and
we can print any of the individual
information from the describe
because this is a dictionary
and so if we want to go ahead and look
up
um the mean value we can also do
describe mean so if you're doing a lot
of statistics
uh being able to
it doesn't have the print on there so
it's only going to print the last one
which happens to be the mean
you can very easily reference any one of
these and then you can also if you're
doing something a little bit more
complicated and you don't need just the
basics you can come through and pull any
one of the individual um
from the from the pandas on here so now
we've had a chance to describe our data
uh let's get into inferential statistics
inferential statistics allows you to
make predictions or inferences from data
and you can see here we have a nice
little picture movie ratings and
if we took this group of people and said
hey how many people like the movie
dislike it can't say and then you ask
just a random person who comes out of
the movie who hasn't been in this study
uh you can infer that 55 chance of
saying liked
35 chance of saying disliked or a 10 or
11 percent chance of can't say so that's
real basics of what we're talking about
is you're going to infer that the next
person is going to follow these
statistics
so let's look at point estimation
it is a process of finding an
approximate value for a population's
parameter like mean
or average from random samples of the
population
let's take an example of testing
vaccines for covid19
vaccines and flu bugs all that it's a
pretty big thing of how do you test
these out and make sure they're going to
work on the populace
a group of people are chosen from the
population medical trials are performed
results are generalized for the whole
population
so here's a protected there's our small
group up here where we've selected them
we run medical trials on them and then
the results work for the population
nice diagram with the arrows going back
and forth and the very scary coveted
virus in the middle of one
and let's take a look at the
applications of inferential statistics
very central is what they call
hypotheses testing
and the confidence interval which go
with that and then as we get into
probability we get into our binomial
theorem our normal distribution in
central limit theorem
hypothesis testing hypothesis testing is
used to measure the plausibility of a
hypothesis
assumption by using sample data
now when we talk about theorem's
theory
hypothesis
keep in mind that if you are in a
philosophy class
theory
is the same as hypothesis where theorem
is a scientific uh statement that is
something that has been proven
although it is always up for debate
because in science we always want to
make sure things are up to debate so
hypothesis is the same as a
philosophical class calling a theory
where theory in science is not the same
theory in science says this has been
well proven gravity is a theory so if
you want to debate the theory of gravity
try jumping up and down if you want to
have a theory about why the economy is
collapsing in your area
that is a philosophical debate
very important i've heard people mix
those up and it is a pet peeve of mine
we talk about hypotheses testing the
steps involved in hypotheses testing is
first we formulate a hypothesis
we figure out the right test to test our
hypothesis we execute the test and we
make a decision and so when you're
talking about hypothesis you're usually
trying to disprove it if you can't
disprove it
and it works for all the facts then you
might call that a theorem at some point
so in a use case uh let's consider an
example we have four students we're
given a task to clean a room every day
sounds like working with my kids they
decided to distribute the job of
cleaning the room among themselves they
did so by making four chits which has
their names on it and the name that gets
picked up has to do the cleaning for
that day
rob took the opportunity to make chits
and wrote everyone's name on it so
here's our four people nick rob emilia
emilia and summer
now rick emilia and summer are asking us
to decide whether rob has done some
mischief in preparing the chits i.e
whether rob has written his name on one
of the chit
for that we will find out the
probability of rob getting the cleaning
job on first day second day third day
and so on till 12 days
the probability of rob getting the job
decreases every day i.e his turn never
comes up then definitely he has done
some mischief while making the chits
so the probability of rob not doing work
on day one is a three out of four
there's a 0.75 chance that he didn't do
work uh two days three fourths times
three fourths equals point five six
three days you have three fourths three
fourths three fourths which equals point
four two
uh when you get to day twelve it's .032
which is less than 0.05
remember this .05 that comes up a lot
when we're talking about
certain values when we're looking at
statistics
rob is cheating as he wasn't chosen for
12 consecutive days that's a very high
probability when
on day 12 he still hasn't gotten the job
cleaning the room
so we come up to our important important
terminologies
we have null hypothesis
a general statement that states that
there is no relationship between two
measured phenomena or no association
among the groups
alternative hypothesis
contrary to the null hypothesis it
states whenever something is happening a
new theory is preferred instead of an
old one and so the two hypotheses go
hand in hand uh so your null this is
always interesting in and when talking
about data science and the math behind
it
it's about proving that the things have
no correlation null hypothesis says
these two have zero relation to each
other where the alternative hypothesis
says hey we found a relation this is
what it is
we have p-value the p-value is a
probability of finding the observed or
more extreme results when the null
hypothesis of a study question is true
and the t-value it is simply the
calculated difference represented in
units of standard error the greater the
magnitude of t the greater the evidence
against the null hypothesis and you can
look at the t values being specific to
the test you're doing
where the p value is derived from your t
value and you're looking for what they
call the five percent or the 0.05
showing that it has a high correlation
so
digging in deeper let's assume that a
new drug is developed with the goal of
lowering the blood pressure more than
the existing drug
and this is a good one because the null
value here isn't that you don't have any
drug the null value here is that it's
better than the existing drug the new
drug doesn't lower the blood pressure
more than the existing drug
now if we get that
that says our null hypothesis is correct
there is no correlation and the new drug
is not doing its job the alternative
hypothesis the new drug does
significantly lower the blood pressure
more than an existing drug
uh yay we got a new drug out there and
that's our alternative hypothesis or the
h1 or ha
and we look at the p-value results from
the evidence like medical trials showing
positive results which will reject the
null hypothesis
and again they're looking for
a 0.05 or 5 percent and the t value
comparing all the positive test results
and finding means of different samples
in order to test hypothesis so this is
specific to the test how what percentage
of increase did they have
and this leads us to the confidence
intervals
a confidence interval is a range of
values we are sure our true values of
observations lie in
let's say you asked a dog owner around
you and asked them how many cans of food
do you buy for your per year for your
dog
through calculations you got to know
that the on an average around 95 percent
of the people bought around 200 to 300
cans of food hence we can say that we
have a confidence interval of 2 300
where 95 of our values lie in that
spread data spread
and this the graph really helps a lot so
you can start seeing what you're looking
at here where you have the 95 percent
you have your peak in this case it's a
normal distribution so you have a nice
bell curve equal on both sides it's not
asymmetrical and ninety-five percent of
all the values lie within a very small
range and then you have your outliers
the 2.5 percent going each way
so we touched upon hypothesis
and we're going to move into probability
so you have your hypothesis once you've
generated your hypothesis we want to
know the probability of something
occurring probability is a measure of
the likelihood of an event to occur any
event can be predicted with total
certainty and can only be predicted as a
likelihood of its occurrence so any
event cannot be predicted with total
certainty can only be predicted as a
likelihood of its occurrence
score prediction how good you're going
to do in whatever
sport you're in weather prediction stock
prediction
if you've studied physics and chaos
theory even the location of the chair
you're sitting on has a probability that
it might move three feet over
granted that probability is one in like
uh i think we calculated as under one in
trillions upon trillions so it's
the better the probability the more
likely it's going to happen there are
some things that have such a low
probability that we don't see them so we
talk about a random variable a random
variable is a variable whose possible
values are numerical outcomes of a
random phenomena so
we have the coin tossed how many heads
will occur in the series of 20 coin
flips
probably you know the on average they're
10 but you really can't know because
it's very random
how many times a red ball is picked from
a bag of balls if there's equal number
of red balls and blue balls and green
balls in there how many times the sum of
digits on two dice
results are five each
so you know there's how often you're
going to roll two fives on your pair of
dice
so in a use case let's consider the
example of rolling two dice we have a
random variable outcome equals y you can
take values two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
so we have a random variable and a
combination of dice
and instead of looking at how many times
both dice were roll five let's go ahead
and look at total sum of five and you
have in as far as your random variables
you can have a one four equals five four
one two three three two
so four of those rolls can be four if
you look at all the different options
you have four of those random rolls can
be a five
and if we look at the total number
which happens to be 36 different options
uh you can see that we have four out of
36 chants every time you roll the dice
that you're gonna roll a total of five
you can have an outcome of five
and uh we'll look a little deeper as to
what that means but you could think of
that at what point if someone never
rolls a five or they always roll a five
can you say hey that person's probably
cheating
we'll look a little closer at the math
behind that but let's just consider this
is one of the cases is rolling two dice
and gambling
there's also binomial distribution is
the probability of getting success or
failure as an outcome in an experiment
or trial that is repeated multiple times
and the key is is by meaning two
binomial so passing or failing an exam
winning or losing a game and getting
either head or tails so if you ever see
binomial distribution it's based on a
true false kind of setup you win or lose
let's consider a use case and let's
consider the game of football between
two clubs
barcelona and dortmund the teams will
have to play a total of four matches and
we have to find out the chances of
barcelona winning the series
so we look at the total games and we're
looking at five different games or
matches
let's say that the winning chance for
barcelona is 75 percent or 0.75
that means that each game they have a 75
chance that they're going to win that
game and losing chances are 25 or 0.25
clearly 0.75 plus 0.25 equals 1. so that
accounts for 100 of the game probability
for getting k wins in in matches is
calculated
and we we're talking like so if you have
five games uh and you want to know if i
play um how many wins in those five
games should i get what's a percentage
on those and the probability for getting
k wins and in matches is calculated by p
x equals k equals n c k p to the k q to
the n minus k
here p is the probability of success and
q is the probability of failure and so
we can do total games of n equals 5
where k equals zero one two three four
five
p which is the chance of winning is
point seven five q the chance of losing
equals one minus p
which equals one minus .075 which equals
point 0.25 the probability that
barcelona will lose all of the matches
can then just plug in the numbers
and we end up with a 0.0009765625
so very small chance they're going to
lose all their matches
and we can plug in the value for two
matches probability that barcelona will
win at least two matches is
0.0878 and of course we can go on to
probability that barcelona will win
three matches the 0.26 and course four
matches and so on and it's always nice
to take this information
and let's find the accumulated discrete
probabilities for each of the outcomes
where barcelona has won three or more
matches x equals three x equals four x
equals five
and we end up with the p equals point
two six four plus point three nine five
plus two three seven which equals point
eight nine
in reality the probability of barcelona
winning the series is much higher than
0.75
and it's always nice to
put out a nice graph so you can actually
see the number of wins to the
probability and how that pans out with
our binomial case
continuing in our important terminology
location the location of the center of
the graph depends on the mean value and
this is some very important things so
much of the data we look at and when you
start looking at probabilities almost
always has a normalized look like the
graph in the middle
but you do have left skewed where the
data is skewed off to the left and you
have more stuff happening off to the
left and you have right skewed data
and so when this comes up and these
probabilities come up where they're
skewed it's really important to take a
closer look at that
mostly you end up with a normalized set
of data but you've got to also be aware
that sometimes it's a skewed data
and then the height height of the slope
inversely depends upon the standard
deviation
so you can see down here the standard
deviation is really large it kind of
squishes it out and if the standard
deviation is small then most of your
data is going to hit right there in the
middle you can have a nice peak
and so being aware of this that you
might have a probability that fits
certain data but it has a lot of
outliers so you're if you have a really
high standard deviation
if you're doing stock market analysis
this means your predictions are probably
not going to make you much money
where if you have a very small deviation
you might be right on target and set to
become a millionaire
which leads us to the z-score z-score
tells you how far from the mean a data
point is it is measured in terms of
standard deviations from the mean around
68 percent of the results are found
between one standard deviation
around 95 percent of the results are
found between two standard deviations
and you read the symbols of course they
love to throw some greek letters in
there we have mu minus two sigma
mu is just a quick way it's a kind of
funky u it just means the mean
uh and then the sigma is the standard
deviation and that's the o with the
little arrow off to the right or the
little
wagy tail going up the o with it with
the line on it uh so mu minus two sigma
is your
uh 95 of the results are found between
two standard deviations
central limit theorem
this goes back to the skew if you
remember we were looking at the skew
values on this previous slide have left
skewed normalized and right skewed when
we're talking about it being skewed or
not skewed the distribution of the
sample means will be approximately
normally distributed evenly distributed
not skewed if you take large random
samples from the population with the
mean mu and the standard deviation sigma
with replacement
and you can see here
of course we have our
mu minus two sigma and the spread down
here the mean the median and the mode
and so you're talking about very large
populations
these numbers should come together and
you shouldn't have a skewed value if you
do that's a flag that something's wrong
that's why this is so important to be
aware of what's going on with your data
where your samples are coming from
and the math behind it
if we're going to do all this we've got
to jump into conditional probability
the conditional probability of an event
a is the probability that the event will
occur
given the knowledge that an event b has
already occurred and you'll see this as
bayes theorem b-a-y-e-s base
and this is red
i mean you have these funky looking
little
p brackets a b
this is the probability of a being true
while b is already true
and you have the probability of b being
true when a is already true so p b of a
probability of a being true divided by
the probability of b being true
and we talk about bayes theorem which
occurred back in the 1800s when he
discovered this this is such an
important formula and it's really it's
not if you actually do the math you
could just kind of do
x y equals j k and then you divide them
out and you're going to see the same
math but it works with probabilities
which makes it really nice
and so if you have a set you might have
uh eight or nine different studies going
on
in different areas different people have
done the studies they brought them
together
if we look at today's covet virus the
virus spread
certainly the studies done in china
versus the studies the way they're done
in the us
that data is different in each of those
studies but if you can find a place
where it overlaps
where they're studying the same thing
together you can then compute the
changes that you need to make in one
study to make them equal
and this is also true if you have a
study of
one group and you want to find out more
about it so this formula is very
powerful and it really has to do with
the data collection part of the math and
data science and understanding where
your data is coming from and how you're
going to combine different studies in
different groups
and we're going to go into a use case uh
let's find out the chance of a person
getting lung disease due to smoking
and this is kind of interesting the way
they word this
let's say that according to medical
report provided by the hospital states
that around 10 percent of all patients
they treated suffered lung disease
so we have kind of a generic medical
report
they further found out uh by a survey
that 15 of the patients that visit them
smoke
so we have 10 percent that are lung
disease and 15 of the patients smoke and
finally five percent of the people
continued smoke even when they had lung
disease uh not the brightest choice um
but you know it is an addiction so it
can be really difficult to kick and so
we can look at the probability of a uh
prior probability of 10 percent people
having lung disease
and then probability b probability that
a patient smokes is 15 percent
uh and the probability of b
if b then a the probability of a patient
smokes even though they have lung
disease is five percent
and probability of a is b probability
that the patient will have lung disease
if they smoke and then when you put the
formulas together you get a nice
solution here you get the probability of
a b probability that the patient will
have lung disease if they smoke
and you can just plug the numbers right
in and we get a 3.33 percent chance
hence there is a 3.33 chance that a
person who smokes will get a lung
disease
so we're going to pull up a little
python code i'm always my favorite roll
up the sleeves
keep in mind we're going to be doing
this um kind of like the back end way
so that you can see what's going on and
then later on we're going to create um
we'll get into another demo which shows
you some of the tools are already
pre-built for this let's start by
creating a set so we're going to create
a set with curly braces
this means that our set has
only unique values so you have a list
you have your tuples which can never
change and then you have
in this case the the set so four seven
you can't create a four seven comma four
it'll delete the four out so it's only
unique values
and if you use dictionaries
quick reminder this should look familiar
because it is a dictionary uh we have a
value and that value is assigned to or
that key is assigned to a value
so you could have a key value set up as
a dictionary so it's like a dictionary
without the value it's just the keys and
they all have to be unique
and if we run this we have a
set of four seven
we can also take a list a regular
setup and i'm going to go ahead and just
throw in another number in here four
and run it uh and you can see here if i
take my list one two three four four
and i convert it to a set and here it is
my set from list equals set my list
the result is one two three four so it
just deletes that last four right out of
there
and with the sets you can also go in
there and
print here is my set my set
three is in the set and then if you do
three in my set
that's going to be a logic function
and one in my set six is not in the set
and so forth if we run this
we get three is in the set true one is
in the set false because three five
seven is another one six is in the set
uh six is not in the set so not in my
set
you can also use this with the list we
could have just used three five seven
and it would have
the same response on there is three and
usually do if three is in but three in
my set is still works on just a regular
list
and we'll go ahead and do a little
iteration we're going to do kind of the
dice one remember
one two three four five six and so we're
going to bring in the iteration tool and
import product as product
and i'll show you what that means in
just a second so we have our two dice we
have dice a
and it's going to be a set of values
you can only have one value for each one
that's why they put it in a set
and if you remember from range it is up
to seven so this is going to be one two
three four five six it will not include
the seven and the same thing for our
dice b
and then we're going to do is we're
going to create a list
which is the product
of a and b so what's a plus b
and if we go ahead and run this it'll
print that out and you'll see
in this case when they say product
because it's an iteration tool
we're talking about creating a tuple of
the two
so we've now created a tuple of all
possible outcomes of the dice where dice
a is
one two three one to six and dice b is
one to six and you can see one to one
one to two one to three and so forth you
remember we had a slide on this earlier
where we talked about
the different all the different outcomes
of a dice
we can play around with this a little
bit we can do in dice equals two
dice faces one two three four five six
uh another way of doing what we did
before and then we can create an event
space where we have a set which is the
product of the dice faces
repeat equals indice and we'll go ahead
and just run this
and you can see here it just again puts
it through all the different possible
variables we can have
and then if we wanted to take the same
set on here and print them all out like
we had before
we can just go through for outcome and
event space outcome and equals
so the event space is creating
a sequence and as you can see here when
we print it out it stacks them versus
going through and putting them in a nice
line
and we'll go ahead and do something
let's go print
since we have the end printing with a
comma that just means it's just gonna
it's not going to hit the return going
down to the next line
and we'll go ahead and do the length
of our event space that'll be an
important variable we're going to want
to know in a minute
of course if i get carried away with my
typing of length uh we'll print it twice
and it'll give me an error
so we have 36 different possible
variations here
and we might want to calculate something
like um what about the multiple of three
what if we want to have
uh the probability of the multiple of
three in our setup
and so we can put together the code for
the outcome and event space of x y
equals outcome
if x plus y
remainder 3. so we're going to divide by
3 and look at the remainder and it
equals 0
then it's a favorable outcome we're
going to pop that outcome on the in
there
and we'll turn it into a set so the
favor outcome equals a set not necessary
because we know it's not going to be
repeating itself but just in case we'll
go ahead and do that
and if we want to print out the outcome
we can go ahead and see what that looks
like and you can see here these are all
multiples of three one plus two is three
five plus four is nine which divided by
3 is 3 and so forth
and just like we looked up the length of
the one before let's go ahead and print
the length
of our
f outcome
so we can see what that looks like
there we go
and of course i did forget to add the
print in the middle because we're
looping through and putting an end on
the on the setup on there so we're going
to put the print in there and if i run
this you can see
we end up with 12. so we have 36 total
options
uh we have 12 that are multiple that add
up to a multiple of three
and we can easily conv compute the
probability of this
uh by simply taking the length
of our favorable outcome over the length
of the event space
and if we print it out let me put that
in there
probability
last line so we just type it in we end
up with the 0.3333 chance
that's roughly a third
and we want to make this look nice so
let's go ahead and put in another line
there the probability of getting the sum
which is a multiple of three is
point three three three three
we can compute the same thing for five
dice
and if we do this for five dice and go
and run it
uh you can see we just have a huge
amount of choices
uh so it just goes on and on down here
and we can look at
the
length of the event space
and we have over 7776
choices that's a lot of choices
and if we want to ask the question like
we did above
what is the sum where the sum is a
multiple of five but not a multiple of
three
we can go through all of these different
options and then
you can see here
d1 d2 d3 d4 d5 equals the outcome
and if you add these all together and
the
division by five does not have a
remainder of zero but the remainder is
also of a division by three is not equal
to zero
so the multiple of five is equal to zero
but the multiple three is not we can
just append that on here and then we can
look at that uh favorable outcome
we'll go ahead and set that and we'll
just take a look at this what's our
length
of our favorable outcome
it's always good to see what we're
working with and so we have 904 out of
and then of course we can just do a
simple division to get the probability
on here what's the probability that
we're going to roll a multiple of 5 when
you add them together
but not a multiple of 3.
and so we're just going to divide those
two numbers and you can see here we get
0.116255 or 11.62 percent
and so you can really have a nice visual
that this is not really complicated math
right here on probabilities
it's just how many options do you have
and how many of those are you possibly
going to be able to come up with with
the solution you're looking for
and this leads us to a confusion matrix
a confusion matrix is a table which is
used to describe the performance of a
classification model on a set of test
data for which the true values are known
and so you'll see in the left we have
the predicted
and the actual
and we have a negative
false negative positive true positive
and then we have false positive and true
negative and you can think of this as
your predicted model what does that mean
that means if you divided your data and
you used two-third of this to create the
model
you might then test it against an actual
case for the last third to see how well
it comes out how many times was it uh
true positive versus a
false positive it gave a false positive
response
and you can imagine in medical
situations this is a pretty big deal you
don't want to give a false positive so
you might adjust your model accordingly
so you don't have a false positive say
with a covavirus test it'd be better to
have a false negative and they go back
and get retested then to have 30 false
positives where then the test is pretty
much invalid
so in a use case like cancer prediction
let's consider an example where a cancer
prediction model is put to the test for
its accuracy and precision actual result
of a person's medical report is compared
with the prediction made by the machine
learning model
and so you can see here here's our
actual predicted uh whether they have
cancer or not you know cancer a big one
you don't want to have a false positive
i mean a false negative in other words
you don't want to have it tell you that
you don't have cancer when you do so
that would be something you'd really be
looking for in this particular domain
you don't want a false negative
and this is again you know you've
created a model you have hundreds of
people or thousands of pieces of data
that come in
there's a real famous case study where
they have the imagery and all the
measurements they take and there's about
36 different measurements they take and
then if you run the a basic model you
want to know just how accurate it is how
many negative results do you have that
are either telling people they have
cancer that don't or telling people that
don't have cancer that they do and then
we can take these numbers and we can
feed them into our accuracy our
precision and our recall
so accuracy precision recall accuracy
metric to measure how accurately the
results are predicted
and this is your
total
true where you got the right results you
add them together the true positive the
two negative
over all the results so what percentage
of them were accurate versus what were
wrong
we talked about precision is a metric to
measure how many of the correctly
predicted cases are actually turned out
to be positive
uh so we have a precision on
true positive
again if you're talking about like covid
testing with the viruses uh you really
want this to be a high number you want
this true
that to be the center point where you
might have the opposite if you're
dealing with a cancer where you want no
false negatives
uh so this is your metric on here
precision is your test positive uh true
positive plus uh false positive
and then your recall how many of the
actual positive cases we were able to
predict quickly with our model
uh so test positive is the test positive
plus the
false negative on there let's look at an
example of a common use for linear
regression profit estimation of a
company if i was going to invest in a
company i would like to know how much
money i could expect to make so we'll
take a look at a venture capitalist firm
and try to understand which companies
they should invest in so we'll take the
idea that we need to decide the
companies to invest in we need to
predict the profit the company makes and
we're going to do it based on the
company's expenses and even just a
specific expense in this case we have
our company we have the different
expenses so we have our rnd which is
your research and development we have
our marketing
we might have the location we might have
what kind of administration is going
through based on all this different
information we would like to calculate
the profit now in actuality there's
usually about 23 to 27 different markers
that they look at if they're a heavy
duty investor we're only going to take a
look at one basic one we're going to
come in and for simplicity let's
consider a single variable r and d and
find out which companies to invest in
based on that so we take r and d and
we're plotting the profit based on the r
d expenditure how much money they put
into the research and development and
then we look at the profit that goes
with that we can predict a line to
estimate the profit so we draw a line
right through the data when you look at
that you can see how much they invest in
the r d is a good marker as to how much
profit they're going to have we can also
note that companies spending more on r d
make good profit so let's invest in the
ones that spend a higher rate in their r
d what's in it for you first we'll have
an introduction to machine learning
followed by machine learning algorithms
these will be specific to linear
regression and where it fits into the
larger model then we'll take a look at
applications of linear regression
understanding linear regression and
multiple linear regression finally we'll
roll up our sleeves and do a little
programming in use case profit
estimation of companies let's go ahead
and jump in
let's start with our introduction to
machine learning along with some machine
learning algorithms and where that fits
in with linear regression let's look at
another example of machine learning
based on the amount of rainfall how much
would be the crop yield so here we have
our crops we have our rainfall and we
want to know how much we're going to get
from our crops this year so we're going
to introduce two variables independent
and dependent the independent variable
is a variable whose value does not
change by the effect of other variables
and is used to manipulate the dependent
variable it is often denoted as x in our
example rainfall is the independent
variable this is a wonderful example
because you can easily see that we can't
control the rain but the rain does
control the crop so we talk about the
independent variable controlling the
dependent variable let's define
dependent variable as a variable whose
value change when there is any
manipulation the values of the
independent variables it is often
denoted as y and you can see here our
crop yield is dependent variable and it
is dependent on the amount of rainfall
received now that we've taken a look at
a real life example let's go a little
bit into the theory and some definitions
on machine learning and see how that
fits together with linear regression
numerical and categorical values let's
take our data coming in this is kind of
random data from any kind of project we
want to divide it up into numerical and
categorical so numerical is numbers age
salary
height where categorical would be
a description the color a dog's breed
gender categoricals limited to very
specific items where numerical is a
range of information now that you've
seen the difference between numerical
and categorical data let's take a look
at some different machine learning
definitions we look at our different
machine learning algorithms we can
divide them into three areas supervised
unsupervised reinforcement we're only
going to look at supervised today
unsupervised means we don't have the
answers we're just grouping things
reinforcement is where we give positive
and negative feedback to our algorithm
to program it and it doesn't have the
information until after the fact but
today we're just looking at supervised
because that's where linear regression
fits in in supervised data we have our
data already there and our answers for a
group and then we use that to program
our model and come up with an answer the
two most common uses for that is through
the regression and classification now
we're doing linear regression so we're
just going to focus on the regression
side and in the regression we have
simple linear regression we have
multiple linear regression and we have
polynomial linear regression now on
these three simple linear regression is
the examples we've looked at so far we
have a lot of data and we draw a
straight line through it multiple linear
regression means we have multiple
variables remember where we had the
rainfall and the crops we might add
additional variables in there like how
much food do we give our crops when do
we harvest them those would be
additional information add in to our
model and that's why it'd be multiple
linear regression and finally we have
polynomial linear regression that is
instead of drawing a line we can draw a
curved line through it now that you see
where regression model fits into the
machine learning algorithms and we're
specifically looking at linear
regression let's go ahead and take a
look at applications for linear
regression let's look at a few
applications of linear regression
economic growth used to determine the
economic growth of a country or a state
in the coming quarter can also be used
to predict the gdp of a country product
price can be used to predict what would
be the price of a product in the future
we can guess whether it's going to go up
or down or should i buy today housing
sales to estimate the number of houses a
builder would sell and what price in the
coming months score predictions cricket
fever to predict the number of runs a
player would score in the coming matches
based on the previous performance i'm
sure you can figure out other
applications you could use linear
regression for so let's jump in and
let's understand linear regression and
dig into the theory
understanding linear regression
linear regression is the statistical
model used to predict the relationship
between independent and dependent
variables by examining two factors
the first important one is which
variables in particular are significant
predictors of the outcome variable and
the second one that we need to look at
closely is how significant is the
regression line to make predictions with
the highest possible accuracy if it's
inaccurate we can't use it so it's very
important we find out the most accurate
line we can get
since linear regression is based on
drawing a line through data we're going
to jump back and take a look at some
euclidean geometry the simplest form of
a simple linear regression equation with
one dependent and one independent
variable is represented by y equals
m times x plus c and if you look at our
model here we plotted two points on here
x1 and y1 x2 and y2 y being the
dependent variable remember that from
before and x being the independent
variable so y depends on whatever x is m
in this case is the slope of the line
where m equals the difference in the y2
minus y1 and x2 minus x1 and finally we
have c which is the coefficient of the
line or where it happens to cross the
zero axes
let's go back and look at an example we
used earlier of linear regression we're
going to go back to plotting the amount
of crop yield based on the amount of
rainfall and here we have our rainfall
remember we cannot change rainfall and
we have our crop yield which is
dependent on the rainfall so we have our
independent and our dependent variables
we're going to take this and draw a line
through it as best we can through the
middle of the data and then we look at
that we put the red point on the y axis
is the amount of crop yield you can
expect for the amount of rainfall
represented by the green dot so if we
have an idea what the rainfall is for
this year and what's going on then we
can guess how good our crops are going
to be and we've created a nice line
right through the middle to give us a
nice mathematical formula let's take a
look and see what the math looks like
behind this
let's look at the intuition behind the
regression line now before we dive into
the math and the formulas that go behind
this and what's going on behind the
scenes
i want you to note that when we get into
the case study and we actually apply
some python script that this math that
you're going to see here is already done
automatically for you you don't have to
have it memorized it is however good to
have an idea what's going on so if
people reference the different terms
you'll know what they're talking about
let's consider a sample data set with
five rows and find out how to draw the
regression line we're only going to do
five rows because if we did like the
rainfall with hundreds of points of data
that would be very hard to see what's
going on with the mathematics so we'll
go ahead and create our own two sets of
data and we have our independent
variable x and our dependent variable y
and when x was 1 we got y equals 2 when
x was
2 y was 4 and so on and so on if we go
ahead and plot this data on a graph we
can see how it forms a nice line through
the middle you can see where it's kind
of grouped going upwards to the right
the next thing we want to know is what
the means is of each of the data coming
in the x and the y the means doesn't
mean anything other than the average so
we add up all the numbers and divide by
the total so 1 plus 2 plus 3 plus 4 plus
5 over 5 equals 3 and the same for y we
get 4. if we go ahead and plot the means
on the graph we'll see we get 3 comma 4
which draws a nice line down the middle
a good estimate
here we're going to dig deeper into the
math behind the regression line now
remember before i said you don't have to
have all these formulas memorized or
fully understand them even though we're
going to go into a little more detail of
how it works and if you're not a math
wiz and you don't know if you've never
seen the sigma character before which
looks a little bit like an e that's
opened up that just means summation
that's all that is so when you see the
sigma character it just means we're
adding everything in that row and for
computers this is great because as a
programmer you can easily iterate
through each of the xy points and create
all the information you need so in the
top half you can see where we've broken
that down into pieces and as it goes
through the first two points it computes
the squared value of x the squared value
of y and x times y and then it takes all
of x and adds them up all of y adds them
up all of x squared adds them up and so
on and so on and you can see we have the
sum of equal to 15 the sum is equal to
20 all the way up to x times y where the
sum equals 66. this all comes from our
formula for calculating a straight line
where y equals the slope times x plus
the coefficient c so we go down below
and we're going to compute more like the
averages of these and we'll explain
exactly what that is in just a minute
and where that information comes from is
called the square means error but we'll
go into that in detail in a few minutes
all you need to do is look at the
formula and see how we've gone about
computing it line by line instead of
trying to have a huge
set of numbers pushed into it and down
here you'll see where the slope m equals
and then the top part if you read
through the brackets you have the number
of data points times the sum of x times
y which we computed one line at a time
there and that's just the 66 and take
all that and you subtract it from the
sum of x times the sum of y and those
have both been computed so you have 15
times 20. and on the bottom we have the
number of lines times the sum of x
squared easily computed as 86 for the
sum minus i'll take all that and
subtract the sum of x squared and we end
up as we come across with our formula
you can plug in all those numbers which
is very easy to do on the computer you
don't have to do the math on a piece of
paper or calculator and you'll get a
slope of 0.6 and you'll get your c
coefficient if you continue to follow
through that formula you'll see it comes
out as equal to 2.2 continuing deeper
into what's going behind the scenes
let's find out the predicted values of y
for corresponding values of x using the
linear equation where m equals 0.6 and c
equals 2.2 we're going to take these
values
and we're going to go ahead and plot
them we're going to predict them so y
equals 0.6 times where x equals 1 plus
2.2 equals 2.8 so on and so on and here
the blue points represent the actual y
values and the brown points represent
the predicted y values based on the
model we created the distance between
the actual and predicted values is known
as residuals or errors
the best fit lines should have the least
sum of squares of these errors also
known as e-square if we put these into a
nice chart where you can see x
and you can see why what we actual
values were and you can see why i
predict it you can easily see where we
take y minus y predict it and we get an
answer what is the difference between
those two and if we square that y minus
y prediction squared we can then sum
those squared values that's where we get
the 0.64 plus the 0.36 plus 1 all the
way down until we have a summation
equals 2.4 so the sum of squared errors
for this regression line is 2.4 we check
this error for each line and conclude
the best fit line having the least e
square value in a nice graphical
representation we can see here where we
keep moving this line through the data
points to make sure the best fit line
has the least square distance between
the data points and the regression line
now we only looked at the most commonly
used formula for minimizing the distance
there are lots of ways to minimize the
distance between the line and the data
points like sum of squared errors sum of
absolute errors root mean square error
etc what you want to take away from this
is whatever formula is being used you
can easily using a computer programming
and iterating through the data calculate
the different parts of it that way these
complicated formulas you see with the
different summations and absolute values
are easily computed one piece at a time
up until this point we've only been
looking at two values x and y well in
the real world it's very rare that you
only have two values when you're
figuring out a solution so let's move on
to the next topic
multiple linear regression let's take a
brief look at what happens when you have
multiple inputs so in multiple linear
regression we have
we'll start with the simple linear
regression where we had y equals m plus
x plus c and we're trying to find the
value of y now with multiple linear
regression we have multiple variables
coming in so instead of having just x we
have x1 x2 x3 and instead of having just
one slope each variable has its own
slope attached to it as you can see here
we have m1 m2 m3 and we still just have
the single coefficient so when you're
dealing with multiple linear regression
you basically take your single linear
regression and you spread it out so you
have y equals m1 times x1 plus m2 times
x2
so on all the way to m to the nth x to
the nth and then you add your
coefficient on there implementation of
linear regression now we get into my
favorite part let's understand how
multiple linear regression works by
implementing it in python if you
remember before we were looking at a
company and just based on its rnd trying
to figure out its profit we're going to
start looking at the expenditure of the
company we're going to go back to that
we're going to predict his profit but
instead of predicting it just on the r d
we're going to look at other factors
like administration costs marketing
costs and so on and from there we're
going to see if we can figure out what
the profit of that company is going to
be to start our coding we're going to
begin by importing some basic libraries
and we're going to be looking through
the data before we do any kind of linear
regression we're going to take a look at
the data to see what we're playing with
then we'll go ahead and format the data
to the format we need to be able to run
it in the linear regression model and
then from there we'll go ahead and solve
it and just see how valid our solution
is so let's start with importing the
basic libraries now i'm going to be
doing this in anaconda jupiter notebook
a very popular ide i enjoy it it's such
a visual to look at and so easy to use
just any id for python will work just
fine for this so break out your favorite
python ide so here we are in our jupyter
notebook let me go ahead and paste our
first piece of code in there and let's
walk through what libraries we're
importing first we're going to import
numpy as np and then i want you to skip
one line and look at import pandas as pd
these are very common tools that you
need with most of your linear regression
the numpy which stands for number python
is usually denoted as np and you have to
almost have that for your sk learn
toolbox you always import that right off
the beginning pandas although you don't
have to have it for your sklearn
libraries it does such a wonderful job
of importing data setting it up into a
data frame so we can manipulate it
rather easily and it has a lot of tools
also in addition to that so we usually
like to use the pandas when we can and
i'll show you what that looks like the
other three lines are for us to get a
visual of this data and take a look at
it so we're going to import
matplotlibrary.pipelot as plt and then
seaborn as sns seaborn works with the
matplot library so you have to always
import matplot library and then seaborn
sits on top of it and we'll take a look
at what that looks like you could use
any of your own plotting libraries you
want there's all kinds of ways to look
at the data these are just very common
ones and the seaborne is so easy to use
it just looks beautiful it's a nice
representation that you can actually
take and show somebody and the final
line is the amber scion map plot library
inline that is only because i'm doing an
inline ide my interface in the anaconda
jupiter notebook requires i put that in
there or you're not going to see the
graph when it comes up let's go ahead
and run this it's not going to be that
interesting so we're just setting up
variables in fact it's not going to do
anything that we can see but it is
importing these different libraries and
setup the next step is load the data set
and extract independent and dependent
variables now here in the slide you'll
see companies equals pd.read csv and it
has a long line there with the file at
the end 1000 companies.csv you're going
to have to change this to fit whatever
setup you have and the file itself you
can request just go down to the
commentary below this video and put a
note in there and simply learn we'll try
to get in contact with you and supply
you with that file so you can try this
coding yourself so we're going to add
this code in here and we're going to see
that i have companies equals pd.reader
underscore csv and i've changed this
path to match my computer c colon slash
simply learn slash 1000 underscore
companies dot csv and then below there
we're going to set the x equals to
companies under the i location and
because this is companies as a pd data
set i can use this nice notation that
says take every row that's what the
colon the first colon is comma except
for the last column that's what the
second part is where we have a colon
minus one and we want the values set
into there so x is no longer a data set
a pandas data set but we can easily
extract the data from our pandas data
set with this notation and then y we're
going to set equal to the last row well
the question is going to be what are we
actually looking at so let's go ahead
and take a look at that and we're going
to look at the companies dot head which
lists the first five rows of data and
i'll open up the file in just a second
so you can see where that's coming from
but let's look at the data in here as
far as the way the pandas sees it when i
hit run you'll see it breaks it out into
a nice setup this is what pandas one of
the things pandas is really good about
is it looks just like an excel
spreadsheet you have your rows and
remember when we're programming we
always start with zero we don't start
with one so it shows the first five rows
zero one two three four and then it
shows your different columns r d spend
administration marketing spend state
profit it even notes that the top are
column names it was never told that but
pandas is able to recognize a lot of
things that they're not the same as the
data rows why don't we go ahead and open
this file up in a csv so you can
actually see the raw data so here i've
opened it up as a text editor and you
can see at the top we have rnd spend
comma administration comma marketing
spin comma state comma profit carries
return i don't know about you but i'd go
crazy trying to read files like this
that's why we use the pandas you could
also open this up in an excel and it
would separate it since it is a comma
separated variable file but we don't
want to look at this one we want to look
at something we can read rather easily
so let's flip back and take a look at
that top part the first five row now as
nice as this format is where i can see
the data to me it doesn't mean a whole
lot maybe you're an expert in business
and investments and you understand what
thousand three 165
forty nine dollars and twenty cents
compared to the administration cost of a
hundred and thirty six thousand eight
hundred ninety seven dollars and eighty
cents so on so on it helps to create the
profit of 192 261 and 83 cents that
makes no sense to me whatsoever no pun
intended so let's flip back here and
take a look at our next set of code
where we're going to graph it so we can
get a better understanding of our data
and what it means so at this point we're
going to use a single line of code to
get a lot of information so we can see
where we're going with this let's go
ahead and paste that into our notebook
and see what we got going and so we have
the visualization and again we're using
sns which is pandas as you can see we
imported the matte plot library dot pi
plot as plt which then the seaborn uses
and we imported the seaborn as sns and
then that final line of code helps us
show this in our
inline coding without this it wouldn't
display and you could display it to a
file in other means and that's the matte
plot library in line with the amber sign
at the beginning so here we come down to
the single line of code seaborne is
great because it actually recognizes the
panda data frame so i can just take the
companies dot core for coordinates and i
can put that right into the seaborn and
when we run this we get this beautiful
plot and let's just take a look at what
this plot means if you look at this plot
on mine the colors are probably a little
bit more purplish and blue than the
original one we have the columns and the
rows we have r and d spending we have
administration we have marketing
spending and profit and if you cross
index any two of these since we're
interested in profit if you cross index
profit with profit is going to show up
if you look at the scale on the right
way up in the dark why because those are
the same data they have an exact
correspondence so r and d spending is
going to be the same as r and d spending
and the same thing with administration
costs so right down the middle you get
this dark row or dark
diagonal row that shows that this is the
highest corresponding data that's
exactly the same and as it becomes
lighter there's less connections between
the data so we can see with profit
obviously profit is the same as profit
and next it has a very high correlation
with r d spending which we looked at
earlier and it has a slightly less
connection to marketing spending and
even less to how much money we put into
the administration so now that we have a
nice look at the data let's go ahead and
dig in and create some actual useful
linear regression models so that we can
predict values and have a better profit
now that we've taken a look at the
visualization of this data we're going
to move on to the next step instead of
just having a pretty picture we need to
generate some hard data some hard values
so let's see what that looks like we're
going to set up our linear regression
model in two steps the first one is we
need to prepare some of our data so it
fits correctly and let's go ahead and
paste this code into our jupyter
notebook and what we're bringing in is
we're going to bring in the sklearn
pre-processing where we're going to
import the label encoder and the one hot
encoder to use the label encoder we're
going to create a variable called label
encoder and set it equal to capital l
label capital e encoder this creates a
class that we can reuse for transferring
the labels back and forth now about now
you should ask what labels are we
talking about let's go take a look at
the data we processed before and see
what i'm talking about here if you
remember when we did the companies dot
head and we printed the top five rows of
data we have our columns going across we
have column 0 which is r and d spending
column 1 which is administration
column 2 which is marketing spending and
column 3 is state
and you'll see under state we have new
york california florida now to do a
linear regression model it doesn't know
how to process new york it knows how to
process a number so the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to
change that new york california and
florida and we're going to change those
to numbers that's what this line of code
does here x equals and then it has the
colon comma 3 in brackets the first part
the colon comma means that we're going
to look at all the different rows so
we're going to keep them all together
but the only row we're going to edit is
the third row and in there we're going
to take the label coder and we're going
to fit and transform the x also the
third row so we're going to take that
third row we're going to set it equal to
a transformation and that transformation
basically tells it that instead of
having a
new york it has a 0 or 1 or a two and
then finally we need to do a one hot
encoder which equals one hot inc or
categorical features equals three and
then we take the x and we go ahead and
do that equal to one hot encoder fit
transform x to array this final
transformation preps our data force so
it's completely set the way we need it
as just a row of numbers even though
it's not in here let's go ahead and
print x and just take a look at what
this data is doing you'll see you have
an array of arrays and then each array
is a row of numbers and if i go ahead
and just do row 0 you'll see i have a
nice organized row of numbers that the
computer now understands we'll go ahead
and take this out there because it
doesn't mean a whole lot to us it's just
a row of numbers
next on setting up our data we have
avoiding dummy variable trap this is
very important why
because the computer has automatically
transformed our header into the setup
and it's automatically transferring all
these different variables
so when we did the encoder the encoder
created two columns and what we need to
do is just have the one because it has
both the variable and the name that's
what this piece of code does here let's
go ahead and paste this in here and we
have x equals x colon comma one colon
all this is doing is removing that one
extra column we put in there when we did
our one hot encoder and our label
encoding let's go ahead and run that and
now we get to create our linear
regression model and let's see what that
looks like here and we're going to do
that in two steps the first step is
going to be in splitting the data
now whenever we create a predictive
model of data we always want to split it
up so we have a training set and we have
a testing set that's very important
otherwise we'd be very unethical without
testing it to see how good our fit is
and then we'll go ahead and create our
multiple linear regression model and
train it and set it up let's go ahead
and paste this next piece of code in
here and i'll go ahead and shrink it
down a size or two so it all fits on one
line so from the sk learn module
selection we're going to import train
test split and you'll see that we've
created four completely different
variables we have capital x train
capital x test smaller case y train
smaller case y test
that is the standard way that they
usually reference these when we're doing
different models you usually see that a
capital x and you see the train and the
test and the lowercase y what this is is
x is our data going in that's our rnd
spin our administration our marketing
and then y which we're training is the
answer that's the profit because we want
to know the profit of an unknown entity
that's what we're going to shoot for in
this tutorial the next part train test
split we take x and we take y we've
already created those x has the columns
with the data in it and y has a column
with profit in it and then we're gonna
set the test size equals point two that
basically means twenty percent
so twenty percent of the rows are going
to be tested we're gonna just put them
off to the side so since we're using a
thousand lines of data that means that
200 of those lines we're going to hold
off to the side to test for later and
then the random state equals zero we're
going to randomize which ones it picks
to hold off to the side we'll go ahead
and run this it's not overly exciting so
setting up our variables but the next
step is the next step we actually create
our linear regression model now that we
got to the linear regression model we
get that next piece of the puzzle let's
go ahead and put that code in there and
walk through it so here we go we're
going to paste it in there and let's go
ahead and since this is a shorter line
of code let's zoom up there so we can
get a good look and we have from the
sklearn
linear underscore model we're going to
import linear regression now i don't
know if you recall from earlier when we
were doing all the math let's go ahead
and flip back there and take a look at
that do you remember this where we had
this long formula on the bottom and we
were doing all this summarization and
then we also looked at setting it up
with the different lines and then we
also looked all the way down to multiple
linear regression where we're adding all
those formulas together all of that is
wrapped up in this one section so what's
going on here is i'm going to create a
variable called regressor and the
regressor equals the linear regression
that's a linear regression model that
has all that math built in so we don't
have to have it all memorized or have to
compute it individually and then we do
the regressor dot fit in this case we do
x train and y train because we're using
the training data x being the data n and
y being profit what we're looking at and
this does all that math for us so within
one click and one line we've created the
whole linear regression model and we fit
the data to the linear regression model
and you can see that when i run the
regressor it gives an output linear
regression it says copy x equals true
fit intercept equals true in jobs equal
one normalize equals false it's just
giving you some general information on
what's going on with that regressor
model now that we've created our linear
regression model let's go ahead and use
it and if you remember we kept a bunch
of data aside so we're going to do a y
predict variable and we're going to put
in the x test and let's see what that
looks like scroll up a little bit paste
that in here predicting the test set
results so here we have y predict equals
regressor dot predict x test going in
and this gives us y predict now because
i'm in jupiter inline i can just put the
variable up there and when i hit the run
button it'll print that array out i
could have just as easily done print
why predict so if you're in a different
ide that's not an inline setup like the
jupiter notebook you can do it this way
print y predict and you'll see that for
the 200 different test variables we kept
off to the side it's going to produce
200 answers this is what it says the
profit are for those 200 predictions but
let's don't stop there let's keep going
and take a couple look we're going to
take just a short detail here and
calculating the coefficients and the
intercepts this gives us a quick flash
at what's going on behind the line we're
going to take a short detour here and
we're going to be calculating the
coefficient and intercepts so you can
see what those look like what's really
nice about our regressor we created is
it already has a coefficients for us we
can simply just print regressor dot
coefficient underscore when i run this
you'll see our coefficients here and if
we can do the regressor coefficient we
can also do the regressor intercept and
let's run that and take a look at that
this all came from the multiple
regression model and we'll flip over so
you can remember where this is going
into where it's coming from you can see
the formula down here where y equals m1
times x1 plus m2 times x2 and so on and
so on plus c the coefficient so these
variables fit right into this formula y
equals slope 1 times column 1 variable
plus slope 2 times column 2 variable all
the way to the m into the n and x to the
n plus c the coefficient or in this case
you have minus 8.89 to the power of 2
etc etc times the first column and the
second column and the third column and
then our intercept is the minus one zero
three zero zero nine point boy it gets
kind of complicated when you look at it
this is why we don't do this by hand
anymore this is why we have the computer
to make these calculations easy to
understand and calculate now i told you
that was a short detour and we're coming
towards the end of our script as you
remember from the beginning i said if
we're going to divide this information
we have to make sure it's a valid model
that this model works and understand how
good it works so calculating the r
squared value that's what we're going to
use to predict how good our prediction
is and let's take a look at what that
looks like in code and so we're going to
use this from
sklearn.metrics we're going to import r2
score that's the r squared value we're
looking at the error so in the r2 score
we take our y test versus our y predict
y test is the actual values we're
testing that was the one that was given
to us so we know are true the y predict
of those 200 values is what we think it
was true and when we go ahead and run
this we see we get a
0.9352 that's the r2 score now it's not
exactly a straight percentage so it's
not saying it's 93 correct but you do
want that in the upper 90s oh and higher
shows that this is a very valid
prediction based on the r2 score and if
r squared value of 0.91 or 92 as we got
on our model remember it does have a
random generation involved this proves
the model is a good model which means
success yay we successfully trained our
model with certain predictors and
estimated the profit of the companies
using linear regression what is logistic
regression let's say we have to build a
predictive model or a machine learning
model to predict whether the passengers
of the titanic ship have survived or not
the shipwreck so how do we do that so we
use logistic regression to build a model
for this how do we use logistic
regression so we have the information
about the passengers their id whether
they have survived or not their class
and name and so on and so forth and we
use this information where we already
know whether the person has survived or
not that is the labeled information and
we help the system to train based on
this information with based on this
labeled data this is known as label data
and during the process of building the
model we probably will remove some of
the non-essential parameters or
attributes here we only take those
attributes which are really required to
make these predictions and once we train
the model we run new data through it
whereby the model will predict whether
the passenger has survived or not so
let's see what we will learn in this
video we will talk about what is
supervised learning and we will go into
details about classification which is
one of the techniques for supervised
learning and then we will further focus
on logistic regression is which is one
of the algorithms for performing
classification especially binary
classification then we will compare
linear and logistic regression and what
are some of the logistic regression
applications and finally we will end
with a use case or a demo of actual
python code for doing logistic
regression in jupyter notebook all right
so let's start with what is supervised
learning supervised learning is one of
the two main types of machine learning
methods here we use what is known as
labeled data to help the system learn
this is very similar to how we human
beings learn so let's say you want to
teach a child to recognize an apple how
do we do that we never tell the child
okay this is an apple has a certain
diameter on the top certain diameter at
the bottom and this has a certain rgb
color no we just show an apple to the
child and tell the child this is apple
and then next time when we show an apple
child immediately recognizes yes this is
an app supervised learning works very
similar on the similar lines so where
does logistic regression fit into the
overall machine learning process machine
learning is divided into two types
mainly two types there is a third one
called reinforcement learning but we
will not talk about that right now so
one is supervised learning and the other
is unsupervised learning unsupervised
learning uses techniques like clustering
and association and supervised learning
uses techniques like classification and
regression now supervised learning is
used when you have labeled data you have
historical data then you use supervised
learning when you don't have labeled
data then you used unsupervised learning
it's in supervised learning there are
two types of techniques that are used
classification and regression based on
what is the kind of problem we are
solved let's say we want to take the
data and classify it it could be binary
classification like a zero or a one an
example of classification we have just
seen whether the passenger has survived
or not survived like a zero or one that
is known as binary classification
regression on the other hand is you need
to predict a value what is known as a
continuous value classification is for
discrete values regression is for
continuous values let's say you want to
predict a share price or you want to
predict the temperature that will be
there what will be the temperature
tomorrow that is where you use
regression whereas classification are
discrete values is will the customer buy
the product or will not buy the product
will you get a promotion or you will not
get a promotion i hope you're getting
the idea or it could be multi-class
classification as well let's say you
want to build an image classification
model so the image classification model
would take an image as an input and
classify into multiple classes whether
this image is of a cat or a dog or an
elephant or a tiger so there are
multiple classes so not necessarily
binary classification so that is known
as multi-class classification so we are
going to focus on classification because
logistic regression is one of the
algorithms used for classification now
the name may be a little confusing in
fact whenever people come across
logistic regression it always causes
confusion because the name has
regression in it but we are actually
using this for performing classification
okay so yes it is logistic regression
but it is used for classification
and in case you are wondering is there
something similar for regression yes for
regression we have linear regression
keep that in mind so linear regression
is used for regression logistic
regression is used for classification so
in this video we are going to focus on
supervised learning and within
supervised learning we are going to
focus on classification and then within
classification we are going to focus on
logistic regression algorithm so first
of all classification so what are the
various algorithms available for
performing classification the first one
is decision tree there are of course
multiple algorithms but here we will
talk about a few decision trees are
quite popular and very easy to
understand and therefore they use for
classification then we have k nearest
neighbors this is another algorithm for
performing classification and then there
is logistic regression and this is what
we are going to focus on in this video
and we are going to go into little bit
of details about logistic regression all
right what is logistic regression as i
mentioned earlier logistic regression is
an algorithm for performing binary
classification so let's take an example
and see how this works let's say your
car has not been serviced for quite a
few years and now you want to find out
if it is going to break down in the near
future so this is like a classification
problem find out whether your car will
break down or not so how are we going to
perform this classification so here's
how it looks if we plot the information
along the x and y axis x is the number
of years since the last service was
performed and why is the probability of
your car breaking down and let's say
this information was this data rather
was collected from several car users
it's not just your car but several car
users so that is our labeled data so the
data has been collected and
for for the number of years and when the
car broke down and what was the
probability and that has been plotted
along x and y axis so this provides an
idea or from this
graph we can find out whether your car
will break down or not we'll see how so
first of all the probability can go from
zero to one as you all aware probability
can be between zero and one and as we
can imagine it is intuitive as well as
the number of years are on the lower
side maybe one year two years or three
years till after the service the chances
of your car breaking down are very
limited right so for example chances of
your car breaking down the probability
of your car breaking down within two
years of your last service are 0.1
probability similarly 3 years is maybe
0.3 and so on but as the number of years
increases let's say if it was 6 or 7
years there is almost a certainty that
your car is going to break down that is
what this graph shows so this is an
example of a application of the
classification algorithm and we will see
in little details how exactly logistic
regression is applied here one more
thing needs to be added here is that the
dependent variables outcome
is discrete so if we are talking about
whether the car is going to break down
or not so that is a discrete value the y
that we are talking about the dependent
variable that we are talking about what
we are looking at is whether the car is
going to break down or not yes or no
that is what we are talking about so
here the outcome is discrete and not a
continuous value so this is how the
logistic regression curve looks let me
explain a little bit what exactly how
exactly we are going to
determine the class at the outcome
rather so for a logistic regression
curve a threshold has to be said saying
that because this is a probability
calculation remember this is a
probability calculation and the
probability itself will not be 0 or 1
but based on the probability we need to
decide what the outcome should be so
there has to be a threshold like for
example 0.5 can be the threshold let's
say in this case so any value of the
probability below 0.5 is considered to
be 0 and any value above 0.5 is
considered to be 1. so an output of
let's say 0.8 will mean that the car
will break down so that is considered as
an output of 1 and let's say
an output of 0.29 is considered as 0
which means that the car will not break
down so that's the way logistic
regression works now let's do a quick
comparison between logistic regression
and linear regression because they both
have the term regression in them so it
can cause confusion so let's try to
remove that confusion so what is linear
regression linear regression is a
process is once again an algorithm for
supervised learning however here you're
going to find a continuous value you're
going to determine a continuous value it
could be the price of a real estate
property it could be your hike how much
hike you're going to get or it could be
a stock price these are all continuous
values these are not discrete compared
to a yes or no kind of a response that
we are looking for in logistic
regression so this is one example of a
linear regression let's say the hr team
of a company tries to find out what
should be the salary hike of an employee
so they collect all the details of their
existing employees their ratings and
their salary hikes what has been given
and that is the labeled information that
is available and the system learns from
this it is trained and it learns from
this labeled information so that when a
new employees information is fed based
on the rating it will determine what
should be the high so this is a linear
regression problem
linear regression example now salary is
a continuous value you can get 5
5 600 it is not discrete like a cat or a
dog or an apple or a banana these are
discrete or a yes or no these are
discrete values right so this way you're
trying to find continuous values is
where we use linear regression so let's
say just to extend on the scenario we
now want to find out whether this
employee is going to get a promotion or
not so we want to find out that is a
discrete problem right a yes or no kind
of a problem in this case we actually
cannot use linear regression even though
we may have labeled data so this is the
label data so based on the employee
rating these are the ratings and then
some people got the promotion and this
is the ratings for which people did not
get promotion that is a no and this is
the rating for which people got
promotion we just plotted the data about
whether a person has got an employer's
got promotion or not yes no right so
there is nothing in between and what is
the employees rating okay and ratings
can be continuous that is not an issue
but the output is discrete in this case
whether employee got promotion yes no
okay so if we try to plot that and we
try to find a straight line this is how
it would look and as you can see it
doesn't look very right because looks
like there will be lot of errors this
root mean square error if you remember
for linear regression would be very very
high and also the the values cannot go
beyond zero or beyond one so the graph
should probably look somewhat like this
clipped at zero and one but still the
straight line doesn't look right
therefore instead of using a linear
equation we need to come up with
something different and therefore the
logistic regression model looks somewhat
like this so we calculate the
probability and if we plot that
probability not in the form of a
straight line but we need to use some
other equation we will see very soon
what that equation is then it is a
gradual process right so you see here
people with some of these ratings are
not getting any promotions and then
slowly uh
at certain rating they get promotion so
that is a gradual process and
this is how the math behind logistic
regression looks so we are trying to
find the odds for a particular event
happening and this is the formula for
finding the odds so the probability of
an event happening divided by the
probability of the event not happening
so p if it is the probability of the
event happening probability of the
person getting a promotion and divided
by the probability of the person not
getting a promotion that is one minus p
so this is how you measure the odds now
the values of the odds range from 0 to
infinity so when this probability is 0
then the odds will the value of the odds
is equal to 0 and when the probability
becomes 1 then the value of the odds is
1 by 0 that will be infinity but the
probability itself remains between 0 and
1. now this is how an equation of a
straight line looks so y is equal to
beta 0 plus beta 1 x where beta0 is the
y-intercept and beta1 is the slope of
the line if we take the odds equation
and take a log of both sides then this
would look somewhat like this and the
term logistic is actually derived from
the fact that we are doing this we take
a log of px by 1 minus px this is an
extension of the calculation of odds
that we have seen right and that is
equal to beta0 plus beta1 x which is the
equation of the straight line and now
from here if you want to find out the
value of p x you will see we can take
the exponential on both sides and then
if we solve that equation we will get
the equation of p x like this p x is
equal to 1 by 1 plus e to the power of
minus beta0 plus beta 1 x and recall
this is nothing but the equation of the
line which is equal to y y is equal to
beta0 plus beta 1 x so that this is the
equation also known as the sigmoid
function and this is the equation of the
logistic regression all right and if
this is plotted this is how the sigmoid
curve is obtained
so let's compare linear and logistic
regression how they are different from
each other let's go back so linear
regression is solved or used to solve
regression problems and logistic
regression is used to solve
classification problems so both are
called regression but linear regression
is used for solving regression problems
where we predict continuous values
whereas logistic regression is used for
solving classification problems where we
have had to predict discrete values the
response variables in case of linear
regression are continuous in nature
whereas here they are categorical or
discrete in nature and
linear regression helps to estimate the
dependent variable when there is a
change in the independent variable
whereas here in case of logistic
regression it helps to calculate the
probability or the possibility of a
particular event happening and linear
regression as the name suggests is a
straight line that's why it's called
linear regression whereas logistic
regression is a sigmoid function and the
curve is the shape of the curve is s
it's an s-shaped curve this is another
example of application of logistic
regression in weather prediction whether
it's going to rain or not rain now keep
in mind both are used in weather
prediction if we want to find the
discrete values like whether it's going
to rain or not rain that is a
classification problem we use logistic
regression but if we want to determine
what is going to be the temperature
tomorrow then we use linear regression
so just keep in mind that in weather
prediction we actually use both but
these are some examples of logistic
regression so we want to find out
whether it's going to be rain or not
it's going to be sunny or not it's going
to snow or not these are all logistic
regression examples a few more examples
classification of objects this is a
again another example of logistic
regression now here of course one
distinction is that these are
multi-class classification so logistic
regression is not used in its original
form but it is used in a slightly
different form so we say whether it is a
dog or not a dog i hope you understand
so instead of saying is it a dog or a
cat or an elephant we convert this into
saying so because we need to keep it to
binary classification so we say is it a
dog or not a dog is it a cat or not a
cat so that's the way logistic
regression can be used for classifying
objects otherwise there are other
techniques which can be used for
performing multi-class classification in
healthcare logistic regression is used
to find the survival rate of a patient
so they take multiple parameters like
trauma score and age and so on and so
forth and they try to predict the rate
of survival
all right now finally let's take an
example and see how we can apply
logistic regression to predict the
number that is shown in the image so
this is actually a live demo i will take
you into jupiter notebook and
show the code but before that let me
take you through a couple of slides to
explain what we are trying to do so
let's say you have an eight by eight
image and there the image has a number
one two three four and you need to train
your model to predict what this number
is so
how do we do this so the first thing is
obviously in any machine learning
process you train your model so in this
case we are using logistic regression so
and then we provide a training set to
train the model and then we test how
accurate our model is with the test data
which means that like any machine
learning process we split our initial
data into two parts training set and
test set with the training set we train
our model and then with the test set we
test the model then we get good accuracy
and then we use it for for inference
right so that is typical methodology of
training testing and then deploying of
machine learning models so let's uh take
a look at the code and see what we are
doing so i will not go line by line but
just take you through some of the blocks
so first thing we do is import all the
libraries and then we basically take a
look at the images and see what is the
total number of images we can display
using matplotlib some of the images are
a sample of these images and
then we split the data into training and
test as i mentioned earlier and we can
do some exploratory analysis and
then we build our model we train our
model with the training set and then we
test it with our test set and find out
how accurate our model is using the
confusion matrix the heat map and use
heat map for visualizing this and i will
show you in the code what exactly is the
confusion matrix and how it can be used
for finding the accuracy in our example
we got we get an accuracy of about 0.94
which is pretty good or 94 which is
pretty good all right so what is a
confusion matrix this is an example of a
confusion matrix and
this is used for identifying the
accuracy of a
classification model or like a logistic
regression model so the most important
part in a confusion matrix is that first
of all this as you can see this is a
matrix and the size of the matrix
depends on how many outputs we are
expecting right
so
the most important part here is that the
model will be most accurate when we have
the maximum numbers in its diagonal like
in this case that's why it has almost 93
94 percent because the diagonals should
have the maximum numbers and the others
other than diagonals the cells other
than the diagonal should have very few
numbers so here that's what is happening
so there is a 2 here there are there's a
1 here but most of them are along the
diagonal this what does this mean this
means that the number that has been fed
is zero and the number that has been
detected is also zero so the predicted
value and the actual value are the same
so along the diagonals that is true
which means that let's let's take this
diagonal right if if the maximum number
is here that means that like here in
this case it is 34 which means that 34
of the images that have been fed or
rather actually there are two
misclassifications in there so 36 images
have been fed which have number four and
out of which 34 have been predicted
correctly as number four and one has
been predicted as number eight and
another one has been predicted as number
nine so these are two misclassifications
okay so that is the meaning of saying
that the maximum number should be in the
diagonal so if you have all of them so
for an ideal model which has let's say
100 accuracy everything will be only in
the diagonal there will be no numbers
other than zero in all other cells so
that is like a hundred percent accurate
model okay so that's uh just of how to
use this matrix uh how to use this
confusion matrix i know the name is a
little funny sounding confusion matrix
but actually it is not very confusing
it's very straightforward so you are
just plotting what has been predicted
and what is the labeled information or
what is the actual data or that's also
known as the ground truth sometimes okay
these are some fancy terms that are used
so predicted label and the actual name
that's all it is okay yeah so we are
showing a little bit more information
here so 38 have been predicted and here
you will see that all of them have been
predicted correctly there have been 38
zeros and the predicted value and the
actual value is exactly the same whereas
in this case
right it has there are i think 37 plus 5
yeah 42 have been fed the images 42
images are of digit 3 and
the accuracy is only 37 of them have
been accurately predicted three of them
have been predicted as number seven and
two of them have been predicted as
number eight and so on and so forth okay
all right so with that let's go into
jupiter notebook and see how the code
looks so this is the code in in jupiter
notebook for logistic regression in this
particular demo what we are going to do
is train our model to recognize digits
which are the images which have digits
from
let's say 0 to 5 or 0 to 9 and
and then we will see how well it is
trained and whether it is able to
predict these numbers correctly or not
so let's get started so the first part
is as usual we are importing some
libraries that are required and
then the last line in this block is to
load the digits so let's go ahead and
run this code then
here we will visualize the shape of
these digits so we can see here if we
take a look this is how the shape is
by 64. these are like eight by eight
images so that's that's what is
reflected in this shape now from here
onwards we are basically once again
importing some of the libraries that are
required like numpy and matplot and we
will take a look at uh some of the
sample images that we have unloaded so
this one for example creates a figure
and then we go ahead and take a few
sample images to see how they look so
let me run this code and so that it
becomes easy to understand so these are
about five images sample images that we
are looking at zero one two three four
so this is how the image is this is how
the data is okay and uh based on this we
will actually train our logistic
regression model and then we will test
it and see how well it is able to
recognize so the way it works is the
pixel information so as you can see here
this is an 8 by 8 pixel kind of a
image and
the each pixel whether it is activated
or not activated that is the information
available for each pixel now based on
the pattern of this activation and
non-activation of the various pixels
this will be identified as a zero for
example right similarly as you can see
so overall each of these numbers
actually has a different pattern of the
pixel activation and that's pretty much
that our model needs to learn
for which a number what is the pattern
of the activation of the pixels right so
that is what we are going to train our
model okay so the first thing we need to
do is to split our data into training
and test data set right so whenever we
perform any training we split the data
into training and test so that the
training data set is used to train the
system so we pass this probably multiple
times
and then we test it with the test data
set and the split is usually in the form
of the and there are various ways in
which you can split this data it is up
to the individual preferences in our
case here we are splitting in the form
of 23 and 77 so when we say test size as
20.23
that means 23 percent of that entire
data is used for testing and the
remaining 77 percent is used for
training so there is a readily available
function which is uh called train test
split so we don't have to write any
special code for the splitting it will
automatically split the data based on
the proportion that we give here which
is test size so we just give the test
size automatically training size will be
determined and
we pass the data that we want to split
and the the results will be stored in x
underscore train and y underscore train
for the training data set and what is x
underscore train these are these are the
features right which is like the
independent variable and why underscore
train is the label right so
in this case what happens is we have the
input value which is or the features
value which is in x underscore train and
since this is the labeled data for each
of them each of the observations we
already have the label information
saying whether this digit is a zero or a
one or a two so that this is what will
be used for comparison to find out
whether the the system is able to
recognize it correctly or there is an
error for each observation it will
compare with this right so this is the
label so the same way x underscore train
y underscore train is for the training
data set x underscore test y underscore
test is for the test data set okay so
let me go ahead and execute this code as
well and then we can go and check
quickly what is the how many entries are
there and in each of these so x
underscore train the shape is 13 83
by 64. and y underscore train has 1383
because there is nothing like the second
part is not required here and then x
underscore test shape we see is 414 so
actually there are 414 observations in
test and 1383 observations in train so
that's basically what these four lines
of code are are saying okay then we
import the
logistic regression library and
which is a part of scikit learn so
we we don't have to implement the
logistic regression process itself we
just call these the function and let me
go ahead and execute that so that
we have the logistic regression library
imported now we create an instance of
logistic regression right so logistic
regr is a is an instance of logistic
regression and then we use that for
training our model so let me first
execute this code so these two lines so
the first line basically creates an
instance of logistic regression model
and then the second line
is where we are passing our data the
training data set and this is our
the predictors and
this is our target we are passing this
data set to train our model all right so
once we do this in this case the data is
not large but by and large the training
is what takes usually a lot of time so
we spend in machine learning activities
in machine learning projects we spend a
lot of time for the training part of it
okay so here the data set is relatively
small so it was pretty quick so all
right so now our model has been trained
using the training data set and we want
to see how accurate this is so what
we'll do is we will test it out in
probably faces so let me first try out
how well this is working for
one image okay i will just try it out
with one image my the first entry in my
test data set and see whether it is
correctly predicting or not so
and in order to test it so for training
purpose we use the fit method there is a
method called fit which is for training
the model and once the training is done
if you want to test for a particular
value new input you use the predict
method okay so let's run the predict
method and we pass this particular image
and
we see that the
shape is or the prediction is 4. so
let's try a few more let me see for the
next 10
seems to be fine so let me just go ahead
and test the entire data set okay that's
basically what we will do so now we want
to find out how accurately this has
performed so we use the score method to
find what is the percentage of accuracy
and we see here that it has performed up
to 94 percent accurate okay so that's on
this part now what we can also do is we
can um also see this accuracy
using what is known as a confusion
matrix so let us go ahead and try that
as well uh so that we can also visualize
how well
this model has done so let me execute
this piece of code which will basically
import some of the libraries that are
required and
we we basically create a confusion
matrix and instance of con confusion
matrix by running confusion matrix and
passing these values so we have so this
confusion underscore matrix method takes
two parameters one is the y underscore
test and the other is the prediction so
what is the y underscore test these are
the labeled values which we already know
for the test data set and predictions
are what the system has predicted for
the test data set okay so this is known
to us
and this is what the system has
the model has generated so we kind of
create the confusion matrix and we will
print it and this is how the confusion
matrix looks as the name suggests it is
a matrix
and
the key point out here is that the
accuracy of the model is determined by
how many numbers are there in the
diagonal the more the numbers in the
diagonal the better the accuracy is
okay and first of all the total sum of
all the numbers in this whole matrix is
equal to the number of observations in
the test data set that is the first
thing right so if you add up all these
numbers that will be equal to the number
of
observations in the test data set and
then out of that the maximum number of
them should be in the diagonal that
means the accuracy is predicted if the
the numbers in the diagonal are less and
in all other places there are a lot of
numbers uh which means the accuracy is
very low the diagonal indicates a
correct prediction that this means that
the actual value is same as the
predicted value here again actual values
same as the predictor value and so on
right so the moment you see a number
here that means the actual value is
something and the predicted value is
something else right similarly here the
actual value is something and the
predicted value is something else so
that is basically how we read the
confusion matrix now how do we find the
accuracy you can actually add up the
total values in the diagonal so it's
like 38 plus 44 plus 43 and so on and
divide that by the total number of test
observations that will give you the
percentage accuracy using a confusion
matrix now let us visualize this
confusion matrix in a slightly more
sophisticated way
using a heat map so we will create a
heat map with some we'll add some colors
as well it's it's like a more visually
visually more appealing so that's the
whole idea so if we let me run this
piece of code and this is how the heat
map looks
and as you can see here the diagonals
again are all the values are here most
of the values so which means reasonably
this seems to be reasonably accurate and
yeah basically the accuracy score is 94
percent this is calculated as i
mentioned by adding all these numbers
divided by the total test values or the
total number of observations in test
data set
okay so this is the confusion matrix for
logistic regression
all right so now that we have seen the
confusion matrix let's take a quick
sample and see how well the system has
classified and we will take a few
examples of the data so if we see here
we we picked up randomly a few of them
so
this is number four which is the actual
value and also the predicted value both
are four
this is an image of zero so the
predicted value is also zero actual
value is of course zero
then this is the image of nine
so this has also been predicted
correctly nine and actual value is nine
and this is the image of one and again
this has been predicted correctly as
like the actual value okay so this was a
quick demo of logistic regression how to
use logistic regression to identify
images what is a decision tree let's go
through a very simple example before we
dig in deep decision tree is a tree
shape diagram used to determine a course
of action each branch of the tree
represents a possible decision or
current or reaction let's start with a
simple question how to identify a random
vegetable from a shopping bag so we have
this group of vegetables in here and we
can start off by asking a simple
question is it red and if it's not then
it's going to be the purple fruit to the
left probably an eggplant if it's true
it's going to be one of the red fruits
is it diameter greater than two if false
is going to be a what looks to be a red
chili and if it's true it's going to be
a bell pepper from the capsicum family
so it's a capsicum
problems that decision tree can solve so
let's look at the two different
categories the decision tree can be used
on it can be used on the classification
the true false yes no and it can be used
on regression where we figure out what
the next value is in a series of numbers
or a group of data in classification the
classification tree will determine a set
of logical if-then conditions to
classify problems for example
discriminating between three types of
flowers based on certain features in
regression a regression tree is used
when the target variable is numerical or
continuous in nature we fit the
regression model to the target variable
using each of the independent variables
each split is made based on the sum of
squared error
before we dig deeper into the mechanics
of the decision tree let's take a look
at the advantages of using a decision
tree and we'll also take a glimpse at
the disadvantages the first thing you'll
notice is that it's simple to understand
interpret and visualize it really shines
here because you can see exactly what's
going on in a decision tree little
effort is required for data preparation
so you don't have to do special scaling
there's a lot of things you don't have
to worry about when using a decision
tree it can handle both numerical and
categorical data as we discovered
earlier and non-linear parameters don't
affect its performance so even if the
data doesn't fit an easy curved graph
you can still use it to create an
effective decision or prediction
if we're going to look at the advantages
of a decision tree we also need to
understand the disadvantages of a
decision tree the first disadvantage is
overfitting overfitting occurs when the
algorithm captures noise in the data
that means you're solving for one
specific instance instead of a general
solution for all the data high variance
the model can get unstable due to small
variation in data low bias tree a highly
complicated decision tree tends to have
a low bias which makes it difficult for
the model to work with new data
decision tree important terms before we
dive in further we need to look at some
basic terms we need to have some
definitions to go with our decision tree
and the different parts we're going to
be using we'll start with entropy
entropy is a measure of randomness or
unpredictability in the data set for
example we have a group of animals in
this picture there's four different
kinds of animals and this data set is
considered to have a high entropy you
really can't pick out what kind of
animal it is based on looking at just
the four animals as a big clump of
entities so as we start splitting it
into subgroups we come up with our
second definition which is information
gain information gain it is a measure of
decrease in entropy after the data set
is split so in this case based on the
color yellow we've split one group of
animals on one side as true and those
who aren't yellow as false as we
continue down the yellow side we split
based on the height true or false equals
10 and on the other side height is less
than 10 true or false and as you see as
we split it the entropy continues to be
less and less and less and so our
information gain is simply the entropy
e1 from the top and how it's changed to
e2 in the bottom and we'll look at the
deeper math although you really don't
need to know a huge amount of math when
you actually do the programming in
python because they'll do it for you but
we'll look on the actual math of how
they compute entropy finally we went
into the different parts of our tree and
they call the leaf node leaf node
carries the classification or the
decision so it's the final end at the
bottom the decision node has two or more
branches this is where we're breaking
the group up into different parts and
finally you have the root node the
topmost decision note is known as the
root node
how does a decision tree work wonder
what kind of animals all get in the
jungle today maybe you're the hunter
with the gun or if you're more into
photography you're a photographer with a
camera so let's look at this group of
animals and let's try to classify
different types of animals based on
their features using a decision tree so
the problem statement is to classify the
different types of animals based on
their features using a decision tree the
data set is looking quite messy and the
entropy is high in this case so let's
look at a training set or a training
data set and we're looking at color
we're looking at height and then we have
our different animals we have our
elephants our giraffes our monkeys and
our tigers and they're of different
colors and shapes let's see what that
looks like and how do we split the data
we have to frame the conditions that
split the data in such a way that the
information gain is the highest note
gain is the measure of decrease in
entropy after splitting so the formula
for entropy is the sum that's what this
symbol looks like that looks like kind
of like a e funky e of k where i equals
1 to k k would represent the number of
animals the different animals in there
where value
or p
value of i would be the percentage of
that animal times the log base two of
the same the percentage of that animal
let's try to calculate the entropy for
the current data set and take a look at
what that looks like and don't be afraid
of the math you don't really have to
memorize this math just be aware that
it's there and this is what's going on
in the background and so we have three
giraffes two tigers one monkey two
elephants a total of eight animals
gathered and if we plug that into the
formula we get an entropy that equals
three over eight so we have three
giraffes a total of eight times the log
usually they use base two on the log so
log base two of three over eight plus in
this case it says yellow fence two over
eight two elephants over total of eight
times log base two two over eight plus
one monkey over total of eight log base
two one over eight and plus two over
eight of the tigers log base two over 8.
and if we plug that into our computer or
calculator i obviously can't do logs in
my head we get an entropy equal to 0.571
the program will actually calculate the
entropy of the data set similarly after
every split to calculate the gain now
we're not going to go through each set
one at a time to see what those numbers
are we just want you to be aware that
this is a formula or the mathematics
behind it gain can be calculated by
finding the difference of the subsequent
entropy values after a split now we'll
try to choose a condition that gives us
the highest gain we will do that by
splitting the data using each condition
and checking that the gain we get out of
them the condition that gives us the
highest gain will be used to make the
first split can you guess what that
first split will be just by looking at
this image as a human is probably pretty
easy to split it let's see if you're
right if you guessed the color yellow
you're correct let's say the condition
that gives us the maximum gain is yellow
so we will split the data based on the
color yellow if it's true that group of
animals goes to the left if it's false
it goes to the right the entropy after
the splitting has
decreased considerably however we still
need some splitting of both the branches
to attain an entropy value equal to zero
so we decide to split both the nodes
using height as a condition since every
branch now contains single label type we
can say that entropy in this case has
reached the least value and here you see
we have the giraffes the tigers the
monkey and the elephants all separated
into their own groups this tree can now
predict all the classes of animals
present in the dataset with a hundred
percent accuracy that was easy
use case loan repayment prediction let's
get into my favorite part and open up
some python and see what the programming
code in the scripting looks like in here
we're going to want to do a prediction
and we start with this individual here
who's requesting to find out how good
his customers are going to be whether
they're going to repay their loan or not
for this bank and from that we want to
generate a problem statement to predict
if a customer will repay loan amount or
not and then we're going to be using the
decision tree algorithm in python let's
see what that looks like and let's dive
into the code in our first few steps of
implementation we're going to start by
importing the necessary packages that we
need from python and we're going to load
up our data and take a look at what the
data looks like so the first thing i
need is i need something to edit my
python and run it in so let's flip on
over and here i'm using the anaconda
jupiter notebook now you can use any
python ide you like to run it in but i
find the jupiter notebook is really nice
for doing things on the fly and let's go
ahead and just paste that code in the
beginning and before we start let's talk
a little bit about what we're bringing
in and then we're going to do a couple
things in here we have to make a couple
changes as we go through this first part
of the import the first thing we bring
in is numpy as np that's very standard
when we're dealing with mathematics
especially with uh very complicated
machine learning tools you almost always
see the numpy come in for your num your
number it's called number python it has
your mathematics in there in this case
we actually could take it out but
generally you'll need it for most of
your different things you work with and
then we're going to use pandas as pd
that's also a standard the pandas is a
data frame setup and you can liken this
to
taking your basic data and storing it in
a way that looks like an excel
spreadsheet so as we come back to this
when you see np or pd those are very
standard uses you'll know that that's
the pandas and i'll show you a little
bit more we explore the data in just a
minute then we're going to need to split
the data so i'm going to bring in our
train test and split and this is coming
from the sk learn package cross
validation in just a minute we're going
to change that and we'll go over that
too and then there's also the sk.tree
import decision tree classifier that's
the actual tool we're using remember i
told you don't be afraid of the
mathematics it's going to be done for
you well the decision tree classifier
has all that mathematics in there for
you so you don't have to figure it back
out again and then we have
sklearn.metrics
for accuracy score we need to score our
setup that's the whole reason we're
splitting it between the training and
testing data and finally we still need
the sklearn import tree and that's just
the basic tree function is needed for
the decision tree classifier and finally
we're going to load our data down here
and i'm going to run this and we're
going to get two things on here one
we're going to get an error and two
we're going to get a warning let's see
what that looks like so the first thing
we had is we have an error why is this
error here well it's looking at this it
says i need to read a file and when this
was written
the person who wrote it
this is their path where they stored the
file
so let's go ahead and fix that
and i'm going to put in here my file
path i'm just going to call it full file
name
and you'll see it's on my c drive and
this is very lengthy setup on here where
i stored the data2.csv file
don't worry too much about the full path
because on your computer it'll be
different
the data.2 csv file was generated by
simply learn
if you want a copy of that you can
comment down below
and request it here in the youtube
and then if i'm going to give it a name
full file name
i'm going to go ahead and change it here
to full
file name so let's go ahead and run it
now and see what happens
and we get a warning
when you're coding
understanding these different warnings
and these different errors that come up
is probably the hardest lesson to learn
so let's just go ahead and take a look
at this and use this as a opportunity to
understand what's going on here if you
read the warning it says the cross
validation is depreciated so it's a
warning on it's being removed
and it's going to be moved in favor of
the model selection
so if we go up here we have
dot cross validation and if you research
this and go to the sklearn site you'll
find out that you can actually just swap
it right in there with
model selection
and so when i come in here and i run it
again
that removes a warning
what they've done is they've had two
different developers develop it in two
different branches
and then they decided to keep one of
those and eventually get rid of the
other one that's all that is and very
easy and quick to fix
before we go any further i went ahead
and opened up the data
from this file remember the the data
file we just loaded on here the data
underscore2.csv
let's talk a little bit more about that
and see what that looks like both as a
text file because it's a comma separated
variable file and in a spreadsheet
this is what it looks like as a basic
text file you can see at the top they've
created a header and it's got one two
three four five columns and each column
has data in it and let me flip this over
because we're also going to look at this
uh in an actual spreadsheet so you can
see what that looks like and here i've
opened it up in the open office calc
which is pretty much the same as excel
and zoomed in and you can see we've got
our columns and our rows of data a
little easier to read in here we have a
result yes yes no we have initial
payment last payment credit score
house number
if we scroll way down
we'll see that this occupies a thousand
and one lines of code or lines of data
with the first one being a column and
then one thousand lines of data
now as a
programmer if you're looking at a small
amount of data i usually start by
pulling it up in different sources so i
can see what i'm working with
but in larger data you won't have that
option it'll just be too too large so
you need to either bring in a small
amount that you can look at it like
we're doing right now or we can start
looking at it through the python code so
let's go ahead and move on and take the
next couple steps to explore the data
using python let's go ahead and see what
it looks like in python to print the
length and the shape of the data so
let's start by printing the length of
the database we can use a simple lin
function from python
and when i run this
you'll see that it's a thousand long and
that's what we expected there's a
thousand lines of data in there if you
subtract the column head
this is one of the nice things when we
did the
balance data from the panda read csv
you'll see that the header is row zero
so it automatically removes a row
and then shows the data separate it does
a good job sorting that data out for us
and then we can use a different function
and let's take a look at that
and again we're going to utilize the
tools in
panda and since the balance underscored
data was loaded as a panda data frame
we can do a shape on it and let's go
ahead and run the shape and see what
that looks like
what's nice about this shape is not only
does it give me the length of the data
we have a thousand lines it also tells
me there's five columns so we were
looking at the data we had five columns
of data and then let's take one more
step to explore the data using python
and now that we've taken a look at the
length and the shape let's go ahead and
use the pandas
module for head another beautiful thing
in the data set that we can utilize so
let's put that on our sheet here and we
have print data set
and balance data dot head and this is a
pandas print statement of its own so it
has its own print feature in there and
then we went ahead and gave a label for
a print job here of dataset just a
simple print statement
and we run that
let's just take a closer look at that
let me zoom in here
there we go
pandas does such a wonderful job of
making this a very clean
readable data set so you can look at the
data you can look at the column headers
you can have it when you put it as the
head
it prints the first five lines of the
data
and we always start with zero so we have
five lines we have zero one two three
four instead of one two three four five
that's a standard scripting and
programming set as you want to start
with the zero position and that is what
the data head does it pulls the first
five rows of data puts in a nice format
that you can look at and view very
powerful tool to view the data so
instead of having to flip and open up an
excel spreadsheet or open office cal or
trying to look at a word doc where it's
all scrunched together and hard to read
you can now get a nice open view of what
you're working with we're working with a
shape of a thousand long five wide so we
have five columns and we do the full
data head you can actually see what this
data looks like the initial payment last
payment credit scores house number so
let's take this now that we've explored
the data and let's start digging into
the decision tree so in our next step
we're going to
train and build our data tree and to do
that we need to first
separate the data out we're going to
separate into two groups so that we have
something to actually train the data
with and then we have some data on the
side to test it to see how good our
model is remember with any of the
machine learning you always want to have
some kind of test set to to weigh it
against so you know how good your model
is when you distribute it let's go ahead
and break this code down and look at it
in pieces
so first we have our x and y
where do x and y come from well x is
going to be our data
and y is going to be the answer or the
target you can look at source and target
in this case we're using x and y to
denote the data in and the data that
we're actually trying to guess what the
answer is going to be and so to separate
it we can simply put in x equals the
balance of the data.values the first
brackets
means that we're going to select all the
lines
in the database so it's all the data
and the second one says we're only going
to look at columns one through five
remember we always start with zero zero
is a yes or no and that's whether the
loan went default or not so we want to
start with one if we go back up here
that's the initial payment and it goes
all the way through the house number
well if we want to look at one through
five we can do the same thing for y
which is the answers and we're going to
set that just equal to the zero row so
it's just the zero row and then it's all
rows going in there so now we've divided
this into two different data sets
one of them with the
data going in and one with the answers
next we need to split the data
and here you'll see that we have it
split into four different parts
the first one is your x training your x
test your y train your y test
simply put we have x going in where
we're going to train it and we have to
know the answer to train it with
and then we have x test where we're
going to test that data and we have to
know in the end what the y was supposed
to be
and that's where this train test split
comes in that we loaded earlier in the
modules this does it all for us and you
can see they set the test size equal to
0.3 so it's roughly 30 percent will be
used in the test and then we use a
random state so it's completely random
which rows it takes out of there and
then finally we get to actually build
our decision tree and they've called it
here clf underscore entropy that's the
actual decision tree or decision tree
classifier and in here they've added a
couple variables which we'll explore in
just a minute and then finally we need
to fit the data to that so we take our
clf entropy that we created and we fit
the x train and since we know the
answers for x-trade or the y-train we go
ahead and put those in and let's go
ahead and run this and what most of
these sklearn modules do is when you set
up the variable in this case we set the
clf entropal decision tree classifier it
automatically prints out what's in that
decision tree there's a lot of variables
you can play with in here and it's quite
beyond the scope of this
tutorial to go through all of these and
how they work but we're working on
entropy that's one of the options we've
added that is completely a random state
of 100 so 100 percent and we have a max
depth of three now the max depth if you
remember above when we were doing the
different graphs of animals means it's
only going to go down three layers
before it stops and then we have minimal
samples of leaves is five so it's going
to have at least five leaves at the end
so i'll have at least three splits i'll
have no more than three layers and at
least five end leaves with the final
result at the bottom now that we've
created
our decision tree classifier not only
created it but trained it let's go ahead
and apply it and see what that looks
like so let's go ahead and make a
prediction and see what that looks like
we're going to paste our predict code in
here
and before we run it let's just take a
quick look at what's it's doing here
we have a variable y predict that we're
going to do
and we're going to use our
variable clf entropy that we created
and then you'll see dot predict and it's
very common in the sk learn modules
that their different tools have the
predict when you're actually running a
prediction
in this case we're going to put our x
test data in here now if you delivered
this for use in actual commercial use
and distributed it this would be the new
loans you're putting in here to guess
whether the person is going to be pay
them back or not
in this case though we need to test out
the data and just see how good our
sample is how good of our tree does at
predicting the loan payments and finally
since anaconda jupiter notebook is works
as a command line for python we can
simply put the y predict e in to print
it i could just as easily have put the
print
and put brackets around y predict en to
print it out we'll go ahead and do that
it doesn't matter which way you do it
and you'll see right here that runs a
prediction
this is roughly 300 in here remember
it's 30 of a thousand so you should have
about 300 answers in here
and this tells you which each one of
those lines of our test went in there
and this is what our y predict came out
so let's move on to the next step we're
going to take this data and try to
figure out just how good a model we have
so here we go since sklearn does all the
heavy lifting for you and all the math
we have a simple line of code to let us
know what the accuracy is and let's go
ahead and go through that and see what
that means and what that looks like
let's go ahead and paste this in and let
me zoom in a little bit
there we go
so you have a nice full picture
and we'll see here we're just going to
do a print accuracy is
and then we do the accuracy score
and this was something we imported
earlier if you remember at the very
beginning let me just scroll up there
real quick so you can see where that's
coming from
that's coming from here down here from
sklearn.metrics
import accuracy score
and you could probably run a script make
your own script to do this very easily
how accurate is it how many out of 300
do we get right and so we put in our y
test that's the one we ran the predict
on and then we put in our y predict e n
that's the answers we got and we're just
going to multiply that by a hundred
because this is just going to give us an
answer as a decimal and we want to see
it as a percentage
and let's run that and see what it looks
like
and if you see here we got an accuracy
of 93.66667
so when we look at the number of loans
and we look at how good our model fit we
can tell people it has about a 93 93.6
fitting to it so just a quick recap on
that we now have accuracy set up on here
and so we have created a model that uses
the decision tree algorithm to predict
whether a customer will repay the loan
or not the accuracy of the model is
about 94.6 percent the bank can now use
this model to decide whether it should
approve the loan request from a
particular customer or not and so this
information is really powerful we may
not be able to as individuals understand
all these numbers because they have
thousands of numbers that come in but
you can see that this is a smart
decision for the bank to use a tool like
this to help them to predict how good
their profit's going to be off of the
loan balances and how many are going to
default or not today we're going to be
looking at random forest one of the many
powerful tools in the machine learning
library before we dive into the topic
let's start by looking at a few of the
uses for random forest currently today
it's used in remote sensing for example
they're used in the etm devices if
you're a space buff that's the enhanced
thermatic mapper they use on satellites
which see
far outside the human spectrum for
looking at land masses and they acquire
images of the earth's surface the
accuracy is higher and training time is
less than many other machine learning
tools out there also object detection
multi-class object detection is done
using random forest algorithms a good
example is a traffic where you're trying
to sort out the different cars buses and
things and it provides a better
detection in complicated environments
they're very complicated up there and
then we have uh another example connect
and let's take a little closer look at
connect connect they use a random forest
as part of the game console
and what it does is it tracks the body
movements and it recreates it in the
game and let's see what that looks like
we have a user who performs a step in
this case it looks like elvis presley
going there
that is then recorded so the connect
registers the movement
and then it marks the user based on
accuracy and it looks like we have
prints going on this one
from
elvis press leader prince that's great
so mark's user based on the accuracy if
we look at that a little closer we have
a training set to identify body parts
where are the hands where the feet
what's going on with the body
that then goes into a random forest
classifier that learns from it
once we've trained the classifier
and then identifies the body parts while
the person's dancing it's able to
represent that in a computer format and
then based on that it scores the game
and how accurate you are as being elvis
presley or prince in your dancing let's
take an overview of what we're going to
cover today what's in it for you we're
going to start with is what is machine
learning we're not going to go into
detail on that we're going to
specifically look how the random force
fits in the machine learning hierarchy
then we're going to look at some
applications of random forest what is
classification which is his primary use
why use random force what's the benefits
of it and how does it actually come
together what is random forest and then
we'll get into random forest and the
decision tree how all that's like the
final step and how it works and finally
we'll get some python code in there and
we'll use the case the iris flower
analysis
now if you don't know what any of these
terms mean or where we're going with
this don't worry we're going to cover
all the basics and have you up and
running and even having doing some basic
script in python by the end let's take a
closer look at types of machine learning
specifically we're going to look at
where the decision tree fits in with the
different machine learning packages out
there we'll start with the basic types
of machine learning there's supervised
learning where you have lots of data and
you're able to train your models there's
unsupervised learning where it has to
look at the data and then divide it
based on its own algorithms without
having any training and then there's
reinforcement learning where you get a
plus or negative if you have the answer
correct this particular tool belongs to
the supervised learning let's take a
closer look at that what that means in
supervised learning supervised learning
falls into two groups classification and
regression we'll talk about regression a
little later and how that differs this
particular format goes underneath
classification so we're looking at
supervised learning and classification
in the machine learning tools
classification is a kind of problem when
the outputs are categorical in nature
like yes or no true or false or zero or
one in that particular framework there's
the knn where the nn stands for nearest
neighbor nave bays the decision tree
which is part of the random forest that
we're studying today so why random
forest it's always important to
understand
why we use this tool over the other ones
what are the benefits here and so with
the random forest the first one is
there's no overfitting if you use of
multiple trees reduce the risk of
overfitting training time is less
overfitting means that we have fit the
data so close to what we have as our
sample that we pick up on all the weird
parts and instead of predicting the
overall data you're predicting the weird
stuff which you don't want
high accuracy runs efficiently in large
database for large data it produces
highly accurate predictions
in today's world of big data this is
really important and this is probably
where it really shines this is where why
random forest really comes in it
estimates missing data data in today's
world is very messy so when you have a
random forest it can maintain the
accuracy when a large proportion of the
data is missing what that means is if
you have data that comes in from five or
six different areas and maybe they took
one set of statistics in one area
and they took a slightly different set
of statistics in the other so they have
some of the same same shared data but
one is missing like the number of
children in the house if you're doing
something over demographics and the
other one is missing the size of the
house it will look at both of those
separately and build two different trees
and then it can do a very good job of
guessing which one fits better even
though it's missing that data let us dig
deep into the theory of exactly how it
works
and let's look at what is a random
forest random forest or random decision
forest is a method that operates by
constructing multiple decision trees the
decision of the majority of the trees is
chosen by the random forest as a final
decision and this uh we have some nice
graphics here we have a decision tree
and they actually use a real tree to
denote the decision tree which i love
and given a random some kind of picture
of a fruit this decision tree decides
that the output is it's an apple and we
have a decision tree two where we have
that picture of the fruit goes in and
this one decides that it's a lemon and
the decision three tree gets another
image and it decides it's an apple and
then this all comes together in what
they call the random forest and this
random forest then looks at it and says
okay i got two votes for apple one vote
for lemon the majority is apples so the
final decision is apples to understand
how the random forest works we first
need to dig a little deeper and take a
look at the random forest and the actual
decision tree and how it builds that
decision tree in looking closer at how
the individual decision trees work we'll
go ahead and continue to use the fruit
example since we're talking about trees
and forests a decision tree is a tree
shaped diagram used to determine a
course of action each branch of the tree
represents a possible decision
occurrence or reaction so in here we
have a bowl of fruit and if you look at
that it looks like they switch from
lemons to oranges we have oranges
cherries and apples and the first
decision of the decision tree might be
is a diameter greater than or equal to
three and if it says false it knows that
they're cherries because everything else
is bigger than that so all the cherries
fall into that decision so we have all
that data we're training we can look at
that we know that that's what's going to
come up
is the color orange well goes hmm orange
or red well if it's true
then it comes out as the orange and if
it's false that leaves apples
so in this example it sorts out the
fruit in the bowl or the images of the
fruit a decision tree these are very
important terms to know because these
are very central to understanding the
decision tree and when working with them
the first is entropy
everything on the decision tree and how
it makes this decision is based on
entropy entropy is a measure of
randomness or unpredictability in the
data set
then they also have information gain
the leaf node the decision node and the
root node we'll cover these other four
terms as we go down the tree but let's
start with entropy
so starting with entropy we have here a
high amount of randomness what that
means is that whatever is coming out of
this decision if it was going to guess
based on this data
it wouldn't be able to tell you whether
it's a lemon or an apple it would just
say it's a fruit
so the first thing we want to do is we
want to split this apart and we take the
initial data set we're going to create a
data set 1 and a data set 2 we just
split it in 2 and if you look at these
new data sets after splitting them the
entropy of each of those sets is much
less
so for the first one whatever comes in
there it's going to sort that data and
it's going to say okay if this data goes
this direction it's probably an apple
and if it goes into the other direction
it's probably a lemon so that brings us
up to information gain it is the measure
of decrease in the entropy after the
data set is split what that means in
here is that we've gone from
one set which has a very high entropy to
two lower sets of entropy and we've
added in the values of e1 for the first
one and e2 for the second two which are
much lower and so that information gain
is increased greatly in this example and
so you can find that the information
grain simply equals
decision e1
minus e2 as we're going down our list of
definitions we'll look at the leaf node
and the leaf node
carries the classification or the
decision
so we look down here to the leaf node we
finally get to our set one or our set
two
when it comes down there and it says
okay this object's gone into set one
if it's gone into set one
it's going to be split by some means and
we'll either end up with apples on the
leaf node or a lemon on the leaf node
and on the right it'll either be an
apple or lemons those leaf nodes are
those final decisions or classifications
that's the definition of leaf node in
here if we're going to have a final leaf
where we make the decision
we should have a name for the nodes
above it and they call those decision
nodes
a decision node decision node has two or
more branches and you can see here where
we have the
five apples and one lemon and in the
other case the five lemons in one apple
they have to make a choice of which tree
it goes down
based on some kind of measurement or
information given to the tree
and that brings us to our last
definition
the root node the top most decision node
is known as the root node and this is
where you have all of your data and you
have your first decision it has to make
or the first split in information
so far we've looked at a very general
image
with the fruit being split let's look
and see exactly what that means to split
the data and how do we make those
decisions on there
let's go in there and find out how does
a decision tree work
so let's try to understand this and
let's use a simple example and we'll
stay with the fruit we have a bowl of
fruit and so let's create a problem
statement and the problem is we want to
classify the different types of fruits
in the bowl based on different features
the data set in the bowl is looking
quite messy and the entropy is high in
this case so if this bowl was our
decision maker it wouldn't know what
choice to make it has so many choices
which one do you pick apple
grapes or lemons and so we look in here
we're going to start with a dra a
training set
so this is our data that we're training
our data with and we have a number of
options here we have the color and under
the color we have red yellow purple
we have a diameter
and we have a label apple lemon grapes
apple lemon grapes and how do we split
the data we have to frame the conditions
to split the data in such a way that the
information gain is the highest
it's very key to note that we're looking
for the best gain we don't want to just
start sorting out the smallest piece in
there we want to split it the biggest
way we can and so we measure this
decrease in entropy that's what they
call it entropy there's our entropy
after splitting and now we'll try to
choose a condition that gives us the
highest gain we will do that by
splitting the data using each condition
and checking the gain that we get out of
them the conditions that give us the
highest gain will be used to make the
first split so let's take a look at
these different conditions we have color
we have diameter and if we look
underneath that we have a couple
different values we have diameter equals
three color equals yellow red diameter
equals one and when we look at that
you'll see over here we have one two
three four threes that's a pretty hardy
selection so let's say the condition
gives us a maximum gain of three so we
have the most pieces fall into
that range so our first split from our
decision node is we split the data based
on the diameter is it greater than or
equal to three if it's not that's false
it goes into the grape bowl and if it's
true it goes into a bowl fold of lemon
and apples the entropy after splitting
has decreased considerably so now we can
make two decisions if you look at
they're very
much
less chaos going on there this note has
already attained an entropy value of
zero as you can see there's only one
kind of label left for this branch so no
further splitting is required for this
node however this node on the right is
still requires a split to decrease the
entropy further so we split the right
node further based on color if you look
at this if i split it on color that
pretty much cuts it right down the
middle it's the only thing we have left
in our choices of color and diameter too
and if the color is yellow it's going to
go to the right bowl and if it's false
it's going to go to the left bowl so the
entropy in this case is now zero so now
we have three bowls with zero entropy
there's only one type of data in each
one of those bowls so we can predict a
lemon with a hundred percent accuracy
and we can predict the apple also with
100 accuracy along with our grapes up
there so we've looked at kind of a basic
tree
in our forest but what we really want to
know is how does a random forest work as
a whole so to begin our
random forest classifier let's say we
already have built three trees and we're
going to start with the first tree that
looks like this
just like we did in the example this
tree looks at the diameter if it's
greater than or equal to three
it's true otherwise it's false so one
side goes to the smaller diameter one
side goes to larger diameter and if the
color is orange it's going to go to the
right true we're using oranges now
instead of lemons and if it's red it's
going to go to the left false we build a
second tree very similar but split
differently instead of the first one
being split by a diameter uh this one
when they created it if you look at that
first bowl it has a lot of red objects
so it says is the color red because
that's going to bring our entropy down
the fastest and so of course if it's
true it goes to the left if it's false
it goes to the right and then it looks
at the shape false are true and so on
and so on and tree 3 is the diameter
equal to 1 and it came up with this
because there's a lot of cherries in
this bowl so that would be the biggest
split on there is is the diameter equal
to one that's going to drop the entropy
the quickest and as you can see it
splits it into true if it goes false and
they've added another category does it
grow in the summer and if it's false
it goes off to the left if it's true it
goes off to the right let's go ahead and
bring these three trees so you can see
them all in one image so this would be
three completely different trees
categorizing a fruit and let's take a
fruit now let's try this and this fruit
if you look at it we've blackened it out
you can't see the color on it so it's
missing data remember one of the things
we talked about earlier is that a random
forest works really good if you're
missing data if you're missing pieces so
this fruit has an image but maybe the
person had a black and white camera when
they took the picture and we're going to
take a look at this and it's going to
have they put the color in there so
ignore the color down there but the
diameter equals 3 we find out it grows
in the summer equals yes and the shape
is a circle and if you go to the right
you can look at what one of the decision
trees did this is the third one
is a diameter greater than equal to
three is the color orange well it
doesn't really know on this one but if
you look at the value and say true and
go to the right tree two classifies it
as cherries is the color equal red
is the shape a circle true it is a
circle so this would look at it and say
oh that's a cherry and then we go to the
other classifier and it says is the
diameter equal one well that's false
does it grow in the summer true so it
goes down and looks at as oranges so how
does this random forest work the first
one says it's an orange
the second one said it was a cherry and
the third one says it's an orange
and you can guess if you have two
oranges and one says it's a cherry when
you add that all together the majority
of the vote says orange so the answer is
it's classified as an orange even though
we didn't know the color and we're
missing data on it i don't know about
you but i'm getting tired of fruit so
let's switch and i did promise you we'd
start looking at a case example and get
into some python coding today we're
going to use the case the iris flower
analysis
this is the exciting part as we roll up
our sleeves and actually look at some
python coding before we start the python
coding we need to go ahead and create a
problem statement wonder what species of
iris do these flowers belong to let's
try to predict the species of the
flowers using machine learning in python
let's see how it can be done so here we
begin to go ahead and implement our
python code and you'll find that the
first half of our implementation is all
about organizing and exploring the data
coming in let's go ahead and take this
first step which is loading the
different modules into python and let's
go ahead and put that in our favorite
editor whatever your favorite editor is
in this case i'm going to be using the
anaconda jupiter notebook which is one
of my favorites certainly there's
notepad plus plus and eclipse and dozens
of others or just even using the python
terminal window any of those will work
just fine to go ahead and explore this
python coding so here we go let's go
ahead and flip over to our jupyter
notebook and i've already opened up a
new page for python 3 code and i'm just
going to paste this right in there and
let's take a look and see what we're
bringing into our python the first thing
we're going to do is from the
sklearn.datasets
import load iris now this isn't the
actual data this is just the module that
allows us to bring in the data the load
iris and the iris is so popular it's
been around since 1936 when ronald
fisher published a paper on it and
they're measuring the different parts of
the flower and based on those
measurements predicting what kind of
flower it is and then if we're going to
do a random forest classifier we need to
go ahead and import a random forest
classifier from the sklearn module so
sklearn.ensemble import random forest
classifier and then we want to bring in
two more modules
and these are probably the most commonly
used modules in python and data science
with any of the
other modules that we bring in and one
is going to be pandas we're going to
import pandas as pd pd is a common term
used for pandas and pandas is basically
creates a data format for us where when
you create a pandas data frame it looks
like an excel spreadsheet and you'll see
that in a minute when we start digging
deeper into the code panda is just
wonderful because it plays nice with all
the other modules in there and then we
have numpy which is our numbers python
and the numbers python allows us to do
different mathematical sets on here
we'll see right off the bat we're going
to take our np and we're going to go
ahead and seed the randomness with it
with 0. so
np.random.seed is seating that is 0.
this code doesn't actually show anything
we're going to go ahead and run it
because i need to make sure i have all
those loaded and then let's take a look
at the next module on here the next six
slides including this one are all about
exploring the data remember i told you
half of this is about looking at the
data and getting it all set so let's go
ahead and take this code right here the
script and let's get that over into our
jupiter notebook and here we go we've
gone ahead and run the imports and i'm
going to paste the code down here
and let's take a look and see what's
going on the first thing we're doing is
we're actually loading the iris data and
if you remember up here we loaded the
module that tells it how to get the iris
data now we're actually assigning that
data to the variable iris and then we're
going to go ahead and use the df to
define data frame
and that's going to equal pd and if you
remember that's pandas as pd so that's
our pandas
and panda data frame and then we're
looking at iris data
and columns equals iris feature names
and we're going to do the df head
and let's run this you can understand
what's going on here
the first thing you want to notice is
that our df has created what looks like
an excel spreadsheet
and in this excel spreadsheet we have
set the columns so up on the top you can
see the four different columns and then
we have the data iris.data down below
it's a little confusing without knowing
where this data is coming from so let's
look at the bigger picture and i'm going
to go print i'm just going to change
this for a moment and we're going to
print all of iris and see what that
looks like
so when i print all of iris i get this
long list of information
and you can scroll through here and see
all the different titles on there
what's important to notice is that first
off there's a brackets at the beginning
so this is a python dictionary
and in a python dictionary
you'll have a key or a label and this
label pulls up whatever information
comes after it so feature names which we
actually used over here under columns is
equal to an array of sepal length sepal
width petal length petal width these are
the different names they have for the
four different columns and if you scroll
down far enough you'll also see data
down here oh goodness it came up right
towards the top and data is equal to the
different data we're looking at
now there's a lot of other things in
here like target we're going to be
pulling that up in a minute and there's
also the names the target names which is
further down and we'll show you that
also in a minute let's go ahead and set
that back
to the head
and this is one of the neat features of
pandas and panda data frames
is when you do df.head or the
pandadataframe.head it'll print the
first five lines of the dataset in there
along with the headers if you have it in
this case we have the column header set
to iris features and in here you'll see
that we have zero one two three four in
python most arrays always start at zero
so when you look at the first five it's
going to be zero one two three four not
one two three four five so now we've got
our iris data imported into a data frame
let's take a look at the next piece of
code in here and so in this section here
of the code
we're going to take a look at the target
and let's go ahead and get this into our
notebook this piece of code so we can
discuss it a little bit more in detail
so here we are in our jupiter notebook
i'm going to put the code in here and
before i run it
i want to look at a couple things going
on so we have df species
and this is interesting because right
here you'll see where i have df species
in brackets which is uh the key code for
creating another column and here we have
iris.target
now these are both in the pandas setup
on here so in pandas we can do either
one i could have just as easily done
iris and then in brackets target
depending on what i'm working on both
are acceptable let's go ahead and run
this code and see how this changes and
what we've done is we've added the
target from the iris data set
as another column on the end
now what species is this is what we're
trying to predict so we have our data
which tells us the answer for all these
different pieces and then we've added a
column with the answer that way when we
do our final setup we'll have the
ability to program our neural network to
look for these this different data and
know what a setosa is or a vera color
which we'll see in just a minute or
virginica those are the three that are
in there and now we're going to add one
more column i know we're organizing all
this data over and over again it's kind
of fun there's a lot of ways to organize
it what's nice about putting everything
onto one data frame is i can then do a
print out and it shows me exactly what
i'm looking at and i'll show you that
where you where that's different where
you can alter that and do it slightly
differently but let's go ahead and put
this into our script up to that now and
here we go we're going to put that down
here
and we're going to run that
and let's talk a little bit about what
we're doing now we're exploring data
and
one of the challenges is knowing how
good your model is did your model work
and to do this we need to split the data
and we split it into two different parts
they usually call it the training and
the testing and so in here we're going
to go ahead and put that in our database
so you can see it clearly and we've set
it df remember you can put brackets this
is creating another column is train so
we're going to use part of it for
training and this equals np remember
that stands for numpy.random.uniform
so we're generating a random number
between 0 and 1 and we're going to do it
for each of the rows that's where the
length df comes from so each row gets a
generated number and if it's less than
0.75 it's true and if it's greater than
0.75 it's false this means we're going
to take
75 percent of the data roughly because
there's a randomness involved and we're
going to use that to train it and then
the other 25 we're going to hold off to
the side and use that to test it later
on so let's flip back on over and see
what the next step is so now that we've
labeled our database for which is
training and which is testing
let's go ahead and sort that into two
different variables train and test and
let's take this code and let's bring it
into our project and here we go let's
paste it on down here and before i run
this let's just take a quick look at
what's going on here is we have up above
we created remember there's our def dot
head which prints the first five rows
and we've added a column is train at the
end and so we're going to take that
we're going to create two variables
we're going to create two new data
frames one's called train
one's called test 75 and train 25
percent in test and then to sort that
out
we're going to do that by doing df our
main original data frame with the iris
data in it
and if df is trained equals true
that's going to go in the train and if
df is train equals false it goes in the
test
and so when i run this
we're going to print out the number in
each one let's see what that looks like
and you'll see that it puts 118 in the
training module and it puts 32 in the
testing module which lets us know that
there was 150 lines of data in here so
if you went and looked at the original
data you could see that there's 150
lines and that's roughly 75 and one and
25 for us to test our model on afterward
so let's jump back to our code and see
where this goes in the next two steps
we want to do one more thing with our
data and that's make it readable to
humans
i don't know about you but i hate
looking at zeros and ones
so let's start with the features and
let's go ahead and
take those and make those readable to
humans and let's put that in our code
let's see here we go paste it in
and you'll see here we've done a couple
very basic things we know that the
columns in our data frame again this is
a panda thing the df columns
and we know the first four of them zero
one two three that'd be the first four
are going to be the features or the
titles of those columns and so when i
run this
you'll see down here that it creates an
index sepa length sepa width petal
length and petal width and this should
be familiar because if you look up here
here's our column titles going across
and here's the first four
one thing i want you to notice here is
that when you're in a command line
whether it's jupyter notebook or you're
running command line in the terminal
window if you just put the name of it
it'll print it out this is the same as
doing print
features
and the shorthand is you just put
features in here if you're actually
writing a code
and saving the script and running it by
remote you really need to put the print
in there but for this when i run it
you'll see it gives me the same thing
but for this we want to go ahead and
we'll just leave it as features because
it doesn't really matter and this is one
of the fun thing about jupiter notebooks
is i'm just building the code as we go
and then we need to go ahead and create
the labels for the other part so let's
take a look and see what that for our
final step in prepping our data before
we actually start running the training
and the testing is we're going to go
ahead and convert the species on here
into something the computer understands
so let's put this code into our script
and see where that takes us
all right here we go we've set y equal
to
pd.factorize train species of zero
so let's break this down just a little
bit we have our pandas right here pd
factorize what's factorized doing i'm
going to come back to that in just a
second
let's look at what train species is
and why we're looking at the group zero
on there
and let's go up here and here is our
species
remember this on that we created this
whole column here for species
and then it has setosa setosa setosa
setosa and if you scroll down enough
you'd also see virginica and vera color
we need to convert that into something
the computer understands zeros and ones
so the trained species of zero because
this is in the format of a of an array
of arrays so you have to have the zero
on the end
and then species is just that column
factorize goes in there and looks at the
fact that there's only three of them so
when i run this you'll see that y
generates an array that's equal to in
this case it's the training set and it's
zeros ones and twos representing the
three different kinds of flowers we have
so now we have something the computer
understands and we have a nice table
that we can read and understand and now
finally we get to actually start doing
the predicting so here we go
uh we have
two lines of code oh my goodness that
was a lot of work to get to two lines of
code but there is a lot in these two
lines of code so let's take a look and
see what's going on here and put this
into our full script that we're running
and let's paste this in here and let's
take a look and see what this is we have
we're creating a variable clf and we're
going to set this equal to the random
forest classifier and we're passing two
variables in here and there's a lot of
variables you can play with as far as
these two are concerned they're very
standard
in jobs all that does is to prioritize
it not something to really worry about
usually when you're doing this on your
own computer you do in jobs equals two
if you're working in a larger or big
data and you need to prioritize it
differently this is what that number
does is it changes your priorities and
how it's going to run across the system
and things like that and then the random
state is just how it starts
0 is fine for here
but let's go ahead and run this
we also have clf.fit train features
comma y and before we run it let's talk
about this a little bit more clf
dot fit so we're fitting we're training
it we are actually creating our random
forest classifier right here this is the
code that does everything and we're
going to take our training set remember
we kept our test off to the side and
we're going to take our training set
with the features and then we're going
to go ahead and put that in and here's
our target the y
so the y is 0 1 and 2 that we just
created and the features is the actual
data going in that we put into the
training set
let's go ahead and run that
and this is kind of an interesting thing
because it printed out the random force
classifier
and everything around it
and so when you're running this in your
terminal window or in a script like this
this automatically treats us like just
like when we were up here and i typed in
y and i printed out y instead of print y
this does the same thing it treats this
as a variable and prints it out but if
you're actually running your code that
wouldn't be the case and what is printed
out is it shows us all the different
variables we can change and if we go
down here you can actually see in jobs
equals two
you can see the random state equals zero
those are the two that we sent in there
you would really have to dig deep to
find out all these different meanings of
all these different settings on here
some of them are self-explanatory if you
kind of think about it a little bit like
max features as auto so all the features
that we're putting in there is just
going to automatically take all four of
them whatever we send it it'll take some
of them might have so many features
because you're processing words there
might be like 1.4 million features in
there because you're doing legal
documents and that's how many different
words are in there at that point you
probably want to limit the maximum
features that you're going to process
and leaf nodes that's the end nodes
remember we had the fruit and we're
talking about the leaf nodes like i said
there's a lot in this we're looking at a
lot of stuff here so you might have in
this case there's probably only think
three leaf nodes maybe four you might
have thousands of leaf notes at which
point you do need to put a cap on that
and say okay can only go so far and then
we're going to use all of our resources
on processing this and that really is
what most of these are about is limiting
the process and making sure we don't
overwhelm a system and there's some
other settings in here again we're not
going to go over all of them warm start
equals false warm start is if you're
programming it one piece at a time
externally since we're not we're not
going to have like we're not going to
continually train this particular
learning tree and again like i said
there's a lot of things in here that
you'll want to look up more detail from
the sk learn
and if you're digging in deep and
running a major project on here for
today though all we need to do is fit or
train our features and our target y so
now we have our training model what's
next if we're going to create a model
we now need to test it remember we set
aside the test feature test group 25 of
the data so let's go ahead and take this
code and let's put it into our script
and see what that looks like okay here
we go
and we're going to run this
and it's going to come out with a bunch
of zeros ones and twos which represents
the three type of flowers the setosa the
virginica and the versacolor and what
we're putting into our predict is the
test features
and i always kind of like to know what
it is i am looking at
so real quick we're going to do test
features and remember features is an
array
of sepal length simple width pedal
length pedal width so when we put it in
this way it actually loads all these
different columns that we loaded into
features so if we did just features let
me just do features in here seeing what
features looks like
this is just playing with the with
pandas data frames you'll see that it's
an index so when you put an index in
like this
into
test features into test
it then takes those columns and creates
a panda data frames from those columns
and in this case
we're going to go ahead and put those
into our predict
so we're going to put each one of these
lines of data
the 5.0 3.4 1.5 0.2 and we're going to
put those in and we're going to predict
what our new
forest classifier is going to come up
with and this is what it predicts it
predicts zero zero zero one two one one
two two two and and uh again this is the
flower type setosa virginica and
versacolor so now that we've taken our
test features
let's explore that let's see exactly
what that data means to us so the first
thing we can do with our predicts is we
can actually generate a different
prediction model when i say different
we're going to view it differently it's
not that the data itself is different so
let's take this next piece of code and
put it into our script
so we're pasting it in here and you'll
see that we're doing a predict and we've
added underscore proba for probability
so there's our clf.predict probability
so we're running it just like we ran it
up here but this time with this we're
gonna get a slightly different result
and we're only going to look at the
first 10.
so you'll see down here instead of
looking at all of them
which was what 27 you'll see right down
here that this generates a much larger
field on the probability and let's take
a look and see what that looks like
and what that means
so when we do the predict underscore
prabha
for probability it generates three
numbers so we had three leaf nodes at
the end and if you remember from all the
theory we did this is the predictors the
first one is predicting a 1
for setosa it predicts a 0 for virginica
and it predicts a 0 for versa color and
so on and so on and so on and let's um
you know what i'm going to change this
just a little bit let's look at 10
to 20 just because we can
and we start to get a little different
of data and you'll see right down here
it gets to this one this line right here
and this line has zero 0.5 0.5
and so if we're going to vote and we
have two equal votes it's going to go
with the first one so it says setosa
gets zero votes virginica gets 0.5 votes
versacolor gets 0.5 votes but let's just
go with the virginica since these two
are equal and so on and so on down the
list you can see how they vary on here
so now we've looked at both how to do a
basic predict of the features and we've
looked at the predict probability
let's see what's next on here so now we
want to go ahead and start mapping names
for the plants we want to attach names
so that it makes a little more sense for
us and this we're going to do in these
next two steps we're going to start by
setting up our predictions and mapping
them to the name so let's see what that
looks like
and let's go ahead and paste that code
in here and run it and this goes along
with the next piece of code so we'll
skip through this quickly and then come
back to a little bit so here's iris
dot target names
and uh if you remember correctly this
was the the names that we've been
talking about this whole time the setosa
virginica versus color and then we're
going to go ahead and do the prediction
again we've run that we could have just
set a variable equal to this instead of
re-running it each time but we're going
to run it again clf dot predict test
features remember that returns the zeros
the ones and the twos and then we're
going to set that equal to predictions
so this time we're actually putting it
in a variable and when i run this
it distributes it it comes out as an
array and the array is setosa satosa
satosa satosa setosa we're only looking
at the first five we could actually do
let's do the first 25 just so we can see
a little bit more on there and you'll
see that it starts mapping it to all the
different flower types the versacolor
and the virginica in there and let's see
how this goes with the next one so let's
take a look at the top part of our
species in here and we'll take this code
and put it in our script
and let's put that down here and paste
it there we go and we'll go ahead and
run it
and let's talk about both these sections
of code here
and how they go together
the first one is our predictions and i
went ahead and did predictions through
25 let's just do five
and so we have setosa satosa satosa
satoshi that's what we're predicting
from our test model
and then we come down here we look at
test species i remember i could have
just done test.species.head
and you'll see it says satosa satosa
setosa and they match
so the first one is what our forest is
doing
and the second one is what the actual
data is now is we need to combine these
so that we can understand what that
means we need to know how good our
forest is how good it is at predicting
the features so that's where we come up
to the next step which is lots of fun
we're going to use a single line of code
to combine our predictions and our
actuals so we have a nice chart to look
at and let's go ahead and put that in
our script in our jupyter notebook here
let's see let's go ahead and paste that
in and then i'm gonna because i'm on the
jupiter notebook i can do a control
minus so you can see the whole line
there there we go resize it
and let's take a look and see what's
going on here we're going to create in
pandas remember pd stands for pandas and
we're doing a cross tab this function
takes two sets of data and creates a
chart out of them so when i run it
you'll get a nice chart down here
and we have the predicted species
so across the top you'll see the setosa
versus color virginica and the actual
species setosa versacolor virginica and
so the way to read this chart and let's
go ahead and take a look on how to read
this chart here when you read this chart
you have setosa where they meet you have
versus color where they meet and you
have virginica where they meet and
they're meeting where the actual and the
predicted agree
so this is the number of accurate
predictions so in this case it equals
30. if you had 13 plus 5 plus 12 you get
30. and then we notice here where it
says virginica but it was supposed to be
versacolor this is inaccurate so now we
have two two inaccurate predictions and
30 accurate predictions so we'll say
that the model accuracy is 93 that's
just 30 divided by 32 and if we multiply
it by a hundred we can say that it is 93
percent accurate so we have a 93
accuracy with our model i did want to
add one more quick thing in here on our
scripting before we wrap it up so let's
flip back on over to my script in here
we're going to take this line of code
from up above i don't know if you
remember it but predix equals the iris
dot target underscore names
so we're going to map it to the names
and we're going to run the prediction
and we read it on test features but you
know we're not just testing it we want
to actually deploy it so at this point i
would go ahead and change this
and this is an array of arrays this is
really important when you're running
these to know that
so you need the double brackets and i
could actually create data maybe let's
just do two flowers so maybe i'm
processing more data coming in and we'll
put two flowers in here
and then i actually want to see what the
answer are is so let's go ahead and type
in preds and print that out and when i
run this
you'll see that i've now predicted two
flowers that maybe i measured in my
front yard as versacolor and versacolor
not surprising since they put the same
data in for each one
this would be the actual
end product going out to be used on data
that you don't know the answer for
so that's going to conclude our
scripting part of this today we're going
to cover the k nearest neighbors like
referred to as k n n and k n n is really
a fundamental place to start in the
machine learning it's the basis of a lot
of other things and just the logic
behind it is easy to understand and
incorporated in other forms of machine
learning so today what's in it for you
why do we need k n n
what is k n
how do we choose the factor k
when do we use k n n
how does knn algorithm work and then
we'll dive in to my favorite part the
use case predict whether a person will
have diabetes or not that is a very
common and popular used data set as far
as testing out models and learning how
to use the different models in machine
learning by now we all know machine
learning models make predictions by
learning from the past data available so
we have our input values our machine
learning model builds on those inputs of
what we already know and then we use
that to create a predicted output
is that a dog little kid looking over
there
watching the black cat cross their path
no dear you can differentiate between a
cat and a dog based on their
characteristics
cats
cats have sharp claws uses to climb
smaller length of ears meows and purrs
doesn't love to play around dogs they
have dull claws bigger length of ears
barks loves to run around you usually
don't see a cat running around people
although i do have a cat that does that
where dogs do and we can look at these
we can say we can evaluate the sharpness
of the claws how sharp are their claws
and we can evaluate the length of the
ears and we can usually sort out cats
from dogs based on even those two
characteristics
now tell me if it is a cat or a dog not
a question usually little kids know cats
and dogs by now unless they live a place
where there's not many cats or dogs so
if we look at the sharpness of the claws
the length of the ears and we can see
that the cat has smaller ears and
sharper claws than the other animals its
features are more like cats it must be a
cat
sharp claws length of ears and it goes
in the cat group because knn is based on
feature similarity we can do
classification using knn classifier so
we have our input value the picture of
the black cat it goes into our trained
model and it predicts that this is a cat
coming out so what is knn what is the k
n algorithm
k nearest neighbors is what that stands
for is one of the simplest supervised
machine learning algorithms mostly used
for classification so we want to know is
this a dog or is not a dog is it a cat
or not a cat it classifies a data point
based on how its neighbors are
classified knn stores all available
cases and classifies new cases based on
a similarity measure and here we've gone
from cats and dogs right into wine
another favorite of mine k n stores all
available cases and classifies new cases
based on a similarity measure and here
you see we have a measurement of sulfur
dioxide versus the chloride level and
then the different wines they've tested
and where they fall on that graph based
on how much sulfur dioxide and how much
chloride k and knn is a perimeter that
refers to the number of nearest
neighbors to include in the majority of
the voting process and so if we add a
new glass of wine there red or white we
want to know what the neighbors are in
this case we're going to put k equals 5.
we'll talk about k in just a minute a
data point is classified by the majority
of votes from its five nearest neighbors
here the unknown point would be
classified as red since four out of five
neighbors are red so how do we choose k
how do we know k equals five i mean
that's what's the value we put in there
so we're going to talk about it how do
we choose a factor k k n algorithm is
based on feature similarity choosing the
right value of k
is a process called parameter tuning and
is important for better accuracy so at k
equals three we can classify we have a
question mark in the middle as either a
as a square or not is it a square or is
it in this case a triangle and so if we
set k equals to 3 we're going to look at
the three nearest neighbors we're going
to say this is a square and if we put k
equals to 7 we classify as a triangle
depending on what the other data is
around and you can see as the k changes
depending on where that point is that
drastically changes your answer and we
jump here we go how do we choose the
factor of k you'll find this in all
machine learning choosing these factors
that's the face you get it's like oh my
gosh did i choose the right k did i set
it right my values in whatever machine
learning tool you're looking at so that
you don't have a huge bias in one
direction or the other and in terms of k
n n the number of k if you choose it too
low the bias is based on it's just two
noises it's right next to a couple
things and it's gonna pick those things
and you might get a skewed answer and if
your k is too big then it's gonna take
forever to process so you're going to
run into processing issues and resource
issues so what we do the most common use
and there's other options for choosing k
is to use the square root of n so it is
a total number of values you have you
take the square root of it in most cases
you also if it's an even number so if
you're using like this case squares and
triangles if it's even you want to make
your k value odd that helps it select
better so in other words you're not
going to have a balance between two
different factors that are equal so
usually take the square root of n and if
it's even you add one to it or subtract
one from it and that's where you get the
k value from that is the most common use
and it's pretty solid it works very well
when do we use k n n we can use k n when
data is labeled so you need a label on
it we know we have a group of pictures
with dogs dogs cats cats data is noise
free and so you can see here when we
have a class and we have like
underweight 140 23 hello kitty normal
that's pretty confusing we have a high
variety of data coming in so it's very
noisy and that would cause an issue data
set is small so we're usually working
with smaller data sets where you might
get into a gig of data if it's really
clean doesn't have a lot of noise
because k n is a lazy learner i.e it
doesn't learn a discriminative function
from the training set so it's very lazy
so if you have very complicated data and
you have a large amount of it you're not
going to use the knn but it's really
great to get a place to start even with
large data you can sort out a small
sample and get an idea of what that
looks like using the knn and also just
using for smaller data sets k n works
really good how does a k n algorithm
work consider a data set having two
variables height in centimeters and
weight in kilograms and each point is
classified as normal or underweight so
we see right here we have two variables
you know true false they're either
normal or they're not they're
underweight on the basis of the given
data we have to classify the below set
as normal or underweight using knn so if
we have new data coming in that says 57
kilograms and 177 centimeters is that
going to be normal or underweight to
find the nearest neighbors we'll
calculate the euclidean distance
according to the euclidean distance
formula the distance between two points
in the plane with the coordinates x y
and a b is given by distance d equals
the square root of x minus a squared
plus y minus b squared and you can
remember that from the two edges of a
triangle we're computing the third edge
since we know
the x side and the y side let's
calculate it to understand clearly so we
have our unknown point and we placed it
there in red and we have our other
points where the data is scattered
around the distance d1 is the square
root of 170 minus 167 squared plus 57
minus 51 squared which is about 6.7 and
distance 2 is about 13 and distance 3 is
about 13.4 similarly we will calculate
the euclidean distance of unknown data
point from all the points in the data
set and because we're dealing with small
amount of data that's not that hard to
do it's actually pretty quick for a
computer and it's not a really
complicated mass you can just see how
close is the data based on the euclidean
distance hence we have calculated the
euclidean distance of unknown data point
from all the points as shown where x1
and y1 equal 57 and 170 whose class we
have to classify so now we're looking at
that we're saying well here's the
euclidean distance
who's going to be their closest
neighbors now let's calculate the
nearest neighbor at k equals three and
we can see the three closest neighbors
puts them at normal and that's pretty
self-evident when you look at this graph
it's pretty easy to say okay what we're
just voting normal normal normal three
votes for normal this is going to be a
normal weight so majority of neighbors
are pointing towards normal hence as per
k and n algorithm the class of 57 170
should be normal so a recap of knn
positive integer k is specified along
with a new sample we select the k
entries in our database which are
closest to the new sample we find the
most common classification of these
entries this is the classification we
give to the new sample so as you can see
it's pretty straightforward we're just
looking for the closest things that
match what we got so let's take a look
and see what that looks like in a use
case in python so let's dive into the
predict diabetes use case so use case
predict diabetes the objective predict
whether a person will be diagnosed with
diabetes or not we have a data set of
768 people who were or were not
diagnosed with diabetes and let's go
ahead and open that file and just take a
look at that data and this is in a
simple spreadsheet format the data
itself is comma separated very common
set of data and it's also a very common
way to get the data and you can see here
we have columns a through i that's what
one two three four five six seven eight
eight columns with a particular
attribute and then the ninth column
which is the outcome is whether they
have diabetes as a data scientist the
first thing you should be looking at is
insulin well you know if someone has
insulin
they have diabetes because that's why
they're taking it and that could cause
issue in some of the machine learning
packages but for a very basic setup this
works fine for doing the k n and the
next thing you notice is it didn't take
very much to open it up i can scroll
down to the bottom of the data there's
it's pretty much a small data set you
know at 769 i can easily fit this into
my ram on my computer i can look at it i
can manipulate it and it's not going to
really tax just a regular desktop
computer you don't even need an
enterprise version to run a lot of this
so let's start with importing all the
tools we need and before that of course
we need to discuss what ide i'm using
certainly you can use any particular
editor for python but i like to use for
doing uh very basic visual stuff the
anaconda which is great for doing demos
with the jupiter notebook and just a
quick view of the anaconda navigator
which is the new release out there which
is really nice you can see under home i
can choose my application we're going to
be using python36 i have a couple
different versions on this particular
machine if i go under environments i can
create a unique environment for each one
which is nice and there's even a little
button there where i can install
different packages so if i click on that
button and open the terminal i can use a
simple pip install to install different
packages i'm working with let's go ahead
and go back under home and we're going
to launch our notebook and i've already
you know kind of like
the old cooking shows i've already
prepared a lot of my stuff so we don't
have to wait for it to launch because it
takes a few minutes for it to open up a
browser window in this case i'm going to
it's going to open up chrome because
that's my default that i use and since
the script is pre-done you'll see have a
number of windows open up at the top the
one we're working in and since we're
working on the k n predict whether a
person will have diabetes or not let's
go and put that title in there and i'm
also going to go up here and click on
cell actually we want to go ahead and
first insert a cell below and then i'm
going to go back up to the top cell and
i'm going to change the cell type to
markdown that means this is not going to
run as python it's a markdown language
so if i run this first one it comes up
in nice big letters which is kind of
nice remind us what we're working on and
by now you should be familiar with doing
all of our imports we're going to import
the pandas as pd import numpy is np
pandas is the pandas data frame and
numpy is a number array very powerful
tools to use in here so we have our
imports so we've brought in our pandas
our numpy our two general python tools
and then you can see over here we have
our train test split by now you should
be familiar with splitting the data we
want to split part of it for training
our thing and then training our
particular model and then we want to go
ahead and test the remaining data to see
how good it is pre-processing a standard
scalar preprocessor so we don't have a
bias of really large numbers remember in
the data we had like number of
pregnancies isn't going to get very
large where the amount of insulin they
take and get up to 256 so 256 versus 6
that will skew results so we want to go
ahead and change that so they're all
uniform between minus one and one and
then the actual tool this is the k
neighbors classifier we're gonna use
and finally the last three are three
tools to test all about testing our
model how good is it we just put down
test on there and we have our confusion
matrix our f1 score and our accuracy so
we have our two general python modules
we're importing and then we have our six
modules specific from the sk learn setup
and then we do need to go ahead and run
this so these are actually imported
there we go and then move on to the next
step and so in this set we're going to
go ahead and load the database we're
going to use pandas remember pandas is
pd and we'll take a look at the data in
python we looked at it in a simple
spreadsheet but usually i like to also
pull it up so we can see what we're
doing so here's our data set equals
pd.read csv that's a pandas command and
the diabetes folder i just put in the
same folder where my ipython script is
if you put in a different folder you
need the full length on there we can
also do a quick length of the data set
that is a simple python command len for
length we might even let's go ahead and
print that we'll go print
and if you do it on its own line link
that data set in the jupyter notebook
it'll automatically print it but when
you're in most of your different setups
you want to do the print in front of
there and then we want to take a look at
the actual data set and since we're in
pandas we can simply do data set head
and again let's go ahead and add the
print in there
if you put a bunch of these in a row you
know the data set one head data set two
head it only prints out the last one so
i use i always like to keep the print
statement in there but because most
projects only use one data frame panda's
data frame doing it this way doesn't
really matter the other way works just
fine and you can see when we hit the run
button we have the 768 lines which we
knew and we have our pregnancies it's
automatically given a label on the left
remember the head only shows the first
five lines so we have zero through four
and just a quick look at the data you
can see it matches what we looked at
before we have pregnancy glucose blood
pressure all the way to age and then the
outcome on the end and we're going to do
a couple things in this next step we're
going to create a list of columns where
we can't have zero there's no such thing
as zero skin thickness or zero blood
pressure zero glucose
any of those you'd be dead so not a
really good factor if they don't if they
have a zero in there because they didn't
have the data and we'll take a look at
that because we're going to start
replacing that information with a couple
of different things and let's see what
that looks like so first we create a
nice list as you can see we have the
values talked about glucose blood
pressure skin thickness
and this is a nice way when you're
working with columns is to list the
columns you need to do some kind of
transformation on a very common thing to
do and then for this particular setup we
certainly could use the there's some
panda tools that will do a lot of this
where we can replace the n a but we're
going to go ahead and do it as a data
set column equals dataset column.replace
this is this is still pandas you can do
a direct there's also one that's that
you look for your nan a lot of different
options in here but the nan
numpy nan is what that stands for is
none doesn't exist so the first thing
we're doing here is we're replacing the
zero with a numpy none there's no data
there that's what that says that's what
this is saying right here so put the
zero in and we're going to place zeros
with no data so if it's a zero that
means the person's well hopefully not
dead hope they just didn't get the data
the next thing we want to do is we're
going to create the mean which is the
integer from the data set from the
column dot mean where we skip n a's we
can do that that is a pandas command
there the skip n a so we're going to
figure out the mean of that data set and
then we're going to take that data set
column and we're going to replace all
the npn with the means why did we do
that and we could have actually just uh
taken this step and gone right down here
and just replaced zero and skip anything
were except you could actually there's a
way to skip zeros and then just replace
all the zeros but in this case we want
to go ahead and do it this way so you
could see that we're switching this to a
non-existent value then we're going to
create the mean well this is the average
person so if we don't know what it is if
they did not get the data and the data
is missing one of the tricks is you
replace it with the average what is the
most common data for that this way you
can still use the rest of those values
to do your computation and it kind of
just brings that particular value of
those missing values out of the equation
let's go ahead and take this and we'll
go ahead and run it doesn't actually do
anything so we're still preparing our
data if you want to see what that looks
like we don't have anything in the first
few lines just not going to show up but
we certainly could look at a row let's
do that let's go into our data set with
the printed data set
and let's pick in this case let's just
do
glucose and if i run this this is going
to print all the different glucose
levels going down and we thankfully
don't see anything in here that looks
like missing data at least on the ones
it shows you can see i skipped a bunch
in the middle that's what it does if you
have too many lines in jupiter notebook
he'll skip a few and go on to the next
in a data set let me go and remove this
and we'll just zero out that and of
course before we do any processing
before proceeding any further we need to
split the data set into our train and
testing data that way we have something
to train it with and something to test
it on and you're going to notice we did
a little something here with the pandas
database code there we go my drawing
tool we've added in this right here
of the data set and what this says is
that the first one in pandas this is
from the pd pandas it's going to say
within the data set we want to look at
the eye location and it is all rows
that's what that says so we're going to
keep all the rows but we're only looking
at 0 column 0 to 8. remember column 9
here it is right up here we printed it
in here is outcome well that's not part
of the training data that's part of the
answer yes column 9 but it's listed as 8
number 8 so 0 to 8 is 9 columns so 8 is
the value and when you see it in here 0
this is actually 0 to 7 it doesn't
include the last one and then we go down
here to y which is our answer and we
want just the last one just column eight
and you can do it this way with this
particular notation and then if you
remember we imported the train test
split that's part of the sklearn right
there and we simply put in our x and our
y
we're going to do random state equals
zero you don't have to necessarily seat
it that's a seed number i think the
default is one when you seed it i'd have
to look that up and then the test size
test size is 0.2 that simply means we're
going to take 20 of the data and put it
aside so that we can test it later
that's all that is and again we're going
to run it not very exciting so far we
haven't had any printout other than to
look at the data but that is a lot of
this is prepping this data once you prep
it the actual lines of code are quick
and easy and we're almost there but the
actual writing of our knn we need to go
ahead and do a scale the data if you
remember correctly we're fitting the
data in a standard scalar which means
instead of the data being from you know
5 to 303 in one column and the next
column is 1 to six we're going to set
that all so that all the data is between
minus one and one that's what that
standard scalar does keeps it
standardized and we only want to fit the
scalar with the training set but we want
to make sure the testing set is the x
test going in is also transformed so
it's processing it the same so here we
go with our standard scalar we're going
to call it sc underscore x for the
scalar and we're going to import the
standard scalar into this variable and
then our x train equals sc underscore x
dot fit transform so we're creating the
scalar on the x train variable and then
our x test we're also going to transform
it so
we've trained and transformed the x
train and then the x test
isn't part of that training it isn't
part of that of training the transformer
it just gets transformed that's all it
does and again we're going to go and run
this and if you look at this we've now
gone through these steps all three of
them we've taken care of replacing our
zeros for key
columns that shouldn't be zero and we
replace that with the means
of those columns that way that they fit
right in with our data models we've come
down here we split the data so now we
have our test data and our training data
and then we've taken and we've scaled
the data so all of our data going in no
no we don't we don't train the y part
the y train and y test that never has to
be trained it's only the data going in
that's what we want to train in there
then define the model using k neighbors
classifier and fit the train data in the
model so we do all that data prep and
you can see down here we're only going
to have a couple lines of code where
we're actually building our model and
training it that's one of the cool
things about python and how far we've
come it's such an exciting time to be in
machine learning because there's so many
automated tools let's see before we do
this let's do a quick length of and
let's do y we want let's just do length
of y
and we get 768 and if we import
math we do math dot square root let's do
y
train there we go it's actually supposed
to be x train
before we do this let's go ahead and do
import math and do math square root
length of y test and when i run that we
get 12.409
i want to show you where this number
comes from we're about to use 12 is an
even number so if you know if you're
ever voting on things remember the
neighbors all vote don't want to have an
even number of neighbors voting so we
want to do something odd and let's just
take one away we'll make it 11. let me
delete this out of here this one the
reasons i love jupiter notebook is you
can flip around and do all kinds of
things on the fly so we'll go ahead and
put in our classifier we're creating our
classifier now and it's going to be the
k neighbors classifier n neighbors equal
11. remember we did 12 minus 1 for 11 so
we have an odd number of neighbors p
equals 2 because we're looking for is it
are they diabetic or not and we're using
the euclidean metric there are other
means of measuring the distance you
could do like square square means value
there's all kinds of measure this but
the euclidean is the most common one and
it works quite well it's important to
evaluate the model let's use the
confusion matrix to do that and we're
going to use the confusion matrix
wonderful tool and then we'll jump into
the f1 score
and finally accuracy score which is
probably the most commonly used quoted
number when you go into a meeting or
something like that so let's go ahead
and paste that in there and we'll set
the cm equal to confusion matrix why
test y predict so those are the two
values we're going to put in there and
let me go ahead and run that and print
it out and the way you interpret this is
you have the y predicted which would be
your title up here you could do let's
just do pred
predicted across the top
and actual going down actual
it's always hard to to write in here
actual that means that this column here
down the middle that's the important
column and it means that our prediction
said 94 and prediction in the actual
agreed on 94 and 32 this number here
the 13 and the 15 those are what was
wrong so you could have like three
different if you're looking at this
across three different variables instead
of just two you'd end up with the third
row down here and that column going down
the middle so in the first case we have
the the and i believe the 0 has a 94
people who don't have diabetes the
prediction said that 13 of those people
did have diabetes and were at high risk
and the 32 that had diabetes it had
correct
but our prediction said another 15 out
of that 15 it classified as incorrect so
you can see where that classification
comes in and how that works on the
confusion matrix then we're going to go
ahead and print the f1 score let me just
run that and you see we get a 0.69 in
our f1 score
the f1
takes into account both sides of the
balance of false positives where if we
go ahead and just do the accuracy
account and that's what most people
think of is it looks at just how many we
got right out of how many we got wrong
so a lot of people when you're a data
scientist and you're talking to other
data scientists they're going to ask you
what the f1 score the f score is if
you're talking to the general public or
the decision makers in the business
they're going to ask what the accuracy
is and the accuracy is always better
than the f1 score but the f1 score is
more telling it lets us know that
there's more false positives than we
would like on here but 82 percent not
too bad for a quick flash look at
people's different statistics and
running an sk learn and running the knn
the k nearest neighbor on it so we have
created a model using knn which can
predict whether a person will have
diabetes or not or at the very least
whether they should go get a checkup and
have their glucose checked regularly or
not the print accuracy score we got the
0.818 was pretty close to what we got
and we can pretty much round that off
and just say we have an accuracy of 80
percent tells us it is a pretty fair fit
in the model what is k-means clustering
k-means clustering is an unsupervised
learning algorithm in this case you
don't have labeled data unlike in
supervised learning so you have a set of
data and you want to group them and as
the name suggests you want to put them
into clusters which means objects that
are similar in nature similar in
characteristics need to be put together
so that's what k means clustering is all
about the term k is basically is a
number so we need to tell the system how
many clusters we need to perform so if k
is equal to two there will be two
clusters if k is equal to three three
clusters and so on and so forth that's
what the k stands for and of course
there is a way of finding out what is
the best or optimum value of k for a
given data we will look at that so that
is k means clustering so
let's take an example k-means clustering
is used in many many scenarios but let's
take an example of cricket the game of
cricket let's say you received
data of a lot of players from maybe all
over the country or all over the world
and this data has information about
the runs scored by the people ordered by
the player and the wickets taken by the
player and based on this information we
need to cluster this data into two
clusters batsman and bowlers so this is
an interesting example let's see how we
can perform this so we have the data
which consists of primarily two
characteristics which is the runs and
the wickets so the bowlers basically
take wickets and the batsmen score runs
there will be of course a few bowlers
who can
score some runs and similarly there will
be some batsmen who will who would have
taken a few wickets but with this
information we want to cluster those
players into batsmen and bowlers so how
does this work let's say this is how the
data is so there are information there
is information on the y-axis about the
run scored and on the x-axis about the
wickets taken by the players so if we do
a quick plot this is how it would look
and
when we do the clustering we need to
have the clusters like shown in the
third diagram rtms we need to have a
cluster which consists of people who
have scored high runs which is basically
the batsman and then we need a cluster
with people who have taken a lot of
wickets which is typically the bowlers
there may be a certain amount of overlap
but we will not talk about it right now
so with k-means clustering we will have
here that means k is equal to 2 and we
will have two clusters which is batsman
and bowlers so how does this work the
way it works is the first step in
k-means clustering is the allocation of
two centroids randomly so two points are
assigned as so-called centroids so in
this case we want two clusters which
means k is equal to two so two points
have been randomly assigned as centroids
keep in mind
these points can be anywhere there are
random points they are not initially
they are not really the centroids
centroid means it's a central point of a
given data set but in this case when it
starts off it's not really the centroid
okay so these points though in our
presentation here we have shown them one
point closer to these data points and
another closer to these data points they
can be assigned randomly anywhere okay
so that's the first step the next step
is to determine the distance of each of
the data points
from each of the randomly assigned
centroids so for example we take this
point and find the distance from this
centroid and the distance from this
center right this point is taken and the
distance is found from this centroid and
this center and so on and so forth so
for every point the distance is measured
from both the centroids
and then
whichever distance is less that point is
assigned to that centroid so for example
in this case visually it is very obvious
that all these data points are assigned
to this centroid and all these data
points are assigned to this centroid and
that's what is represented here in blue
color and in this yellow color the next
step is to actually determine
the central point or the actual centroid
for these two clusters so we have this
one
initial cluster this one initial cluster
but as you can see these points are not
really the centroid centroid means it
should be the central position of this
data set central position of this data
set so that is what needs to be
determined as the next step so the
central point of the actual centroid is
determined and the original randomly
allocated centroid is repositioned to
the actual centroid of these new
clusters and this process is actually
repeated now what might happen is some
of these points may get reallocated in
our example that is not happening
probably but it may so happen that the
distance is found between each of these
data points once again with these
centroids and if there is if it is
required some points may be reallocated
we will see that in a later example but
for now we will keep it simple so this
process is continued till the centroid
repositioning stops and that is our
final cluster so this is our so after
iteration we come to this position this
situation where the centroid doesn't
need any more repositioning and that
means our algorithm has converged
convergence has occurred and we have the
cluster two clusters we have the
clusters with a centroid so this process
is
repeated the process of calculating the
distance and repositioning the centroid
is repeated till the repositioning stops
which means that the algorithm has
converged and we have the final cluster
with the data points and the centroids
so this is what you're going to learn
from this session we will talk about the
types of clustering what is k-means
clustering application of k-means
clustering k-means clustering is done
using distance measure so we will talk
about the common distance measures and
then we will talk about how k-means
clustering works and go into the details
of k-means clustering algorithm and then
we will end with a demo and a use case
for k-means clustering so let's begin
first of all what are the types of
clustering there are primarily two
categories of clustering hierarchical
clustering and then partitional
clustering and each of these categories
are further subdivided into
agglomerative and divisive clustering
and k-means and fuzzy c means clustering
let's take a quick look at what each of
these types of clustering are
in hierarchical clustering the clusters
have a tree-like structure and
hierarchical clustering is further
divided into agglomerative and divisive
agglomerative clustering is a bottom-up
approach we begin with each element as a
separate cluster and merge them into
successively larger clusters so for
example we have a b c d e f we start by
combining b and c form one cluster d e
and e form one more then we combine d e
and f one more bigger cluster and then
add bc to that and then finally a to it
compared to that divisive clustering or
divisive clustering is a top-down
approach we begin with the whole set and
proceed to divide it into successively
smaller clusters so we have abcdef we
first take that as a single cluster and
then break it down
into a b c d
e and f
then we have partitional clustering
split into two subtypes k means
clustering and fuzzy c means in k means
clustering the objects are divided into
the number of clusters mentioned by the
number k that's where the k comes from
so if we say k is equal to 2 the objects
are divided into two clusters c1 and c2
and the way it is done is the features
or characteristics are compared and all
objects having similar characteristics
are clubbed together so that's how k
means clustering is done we will see it
in more detail as we move forward and
fuzzy c means is very similar to k means
in the sense that it clubs objects that
have similar characteristics together
but while in k means clustering two
objects cannot belong to or any object a
single object cannot belong to two
different clusters in c means objects
can belong to more than one cluster so
that is the primary difference between k
means and fuzzy c means so what are some
of the applications of k-means
clustering k-means clustering is used in
a variety of examples or variety of
business cases in real life
starting from academic performance
diagnostic systems search engines and
wireless sensor networks and many more
so let us take a little deeper look at
each of these examples academic
performance so based on the scores of
the students students are categorized
into a b c and so on clustering forms a
backbone of search engines when a search
is performed the search results need to
be grouped together the search engines
very often use clustering to do this
and similarly in case of wireless sensor
networks the clustering algorithm plays
the role of finding the cluster heads
which collects all the data in its
respective cluster so clustering
especially k means clustering uses
distance measure so let's take a look at
what is distance measure so while these
are the different types of clustering in
this video we will focus on k-means
clustering so distance measure tells how
similar some objects are so the
similarity is measured using what is
known as distance measure and what are
the various types of distance measures
there is euclidean distance there is
manhattan distance then we have square
euclidean distance measure and cosine
distance measure these are some of the
distance measures supported by k-means
clustering let's take a look at each of
these
what is euclidean distance measure this
is nothing but the distance between two
points so we have learnt in high school
how to find the distance between two
points this is a little sophisticated
formula for that but we know a simpler
one is square root of y 2 minus y 1
whole square plus x 2 minus x 1 whole
square so this is an extension of this
formula so that is the euclidean
distance between two points what is the
squared euclidean distance measure it's
nothing but the square of the euclidean
distance as the name suggests so instead
of taking the square root
we leave the square as it is and then we
have manhattan distance measure in case
of manhattan distance it is the sum of
the distances across the x-axis and the
y-axis
and note that we are taking the absolute
value so that the negative values don't
come into play so that is the manhattan
distance measure then we have cosine
distance measure in this case we take
the angle between the two vectors formed
by joining the points from the origin so
that is the cosine distance measure okay
so that was a quick overview about the
various distance measures that are
supported by k-means now let's go and
check how exactly k-means clustering
works
okay so this is how k means clustering
works this is like a flowchart of the
whole process there is a starting point
and then we specify the number of
clusters that we want now there are a
couple of ways of doing this we can do
by trial and error so we specify a
certain number maybe k is equal to 3 or
4 or 5 to start with and then as we
progress we keep changing until we get
the best clusters or there is a
technique called elbow technique whereby
we can determine the value of k what
should be the best value of k how many
clusters should be formed so once we
have the value of k we specify that and
then the system will assign that many
centroids so it picks randomly that to
start with randomly that many points
that are considered to be the centroids
of these clusters and then it measures
the distance of each of the data points
from these centroids and assigns those
points to the corresponding centroid
from which the distance is minimum so
each data point will be assigned to the
centroid which is closest to it and
thereby we have k number of initial
clusters however this is not the final
clusters the next step it does is
for the new groups for the clusters that
have been formed it calculates the main
position thereby calculates the new
centroid position the position of the
centroid moves compared to the randomly
allocated one so it's an iterative
process once again the distance of each
point is measured from this new centroid
point and if required the data points
are reallocated to the new centroids and
the mean position or the new centroid is
calculated once again if the centroid
moves then the iteration continues which
means the convergence has not happened
the clustering has not converged so as
long as there is a movement of the
centroid this iteration keeps happening
but once the centroid stops moving which
means that the cluster has converged or
the clustering process has converged
that will be the end result so now we
have the final position of the centroid
and the data points are allocated
accordingly to the closest centroid i
know it's a little difficult to
understand from this simple flowchart so
let's do a little bit of visualization
and see if we can explain it better
let's take an example if we have a data
set for a grocery shop so let's say we
have a data set for a grocery shop and
now we want to find out how many
clusters this has to be spread across so
how do we find the optimum number of
clusters there is a technique called the
elbow method so when these clusters are
formed there is a parameter called
within sum of squares and the lower this
value is the better the cluster is that
means
all these points are very close to each
other so we use this within sum of
squares as a measure to find the optimum
number of clusters that can be formed
for a given data set so we create
clusters or we let the system create
clusters of a variety of numbers maybe
of 10
10 clusters and for each value of k the
within ss is measured and the value of k
which has the least amount of within ss
or wss
that is taken as the optimum value of k
so this is the diagrammatic
representation so we have on the y axis
the within sum of squares or wss and on
the x-axis we have the number of
clusters so as you can imagine if you
have k is equal to 1 which means all the
data points are in a single cluster the
within s value will be very high because
they are probably scattered all over the
moment you split it into two there will
be a drastic fall in the within ss value
and that's what is represented here but
then as the value of k increases the
decrease the rate of decrease
will not be so high it will continue to
decrease but probably the rate of
decrease will not be high so that gives
us an idea so from here we get an idea
for example the optimum value of k
should be either two or three or at the
most four but beyond that
increasing the number of clusters is not
dramatically changing the value in wss
because that pretty much gets stabilized
okay now that we have got the value of k
and let's assume that these are our
delivery points
the next step is basically
to assign two centroids randomly so
let's say c1 and c2 are the centroids
assigned randomly now the distance of
each
location from the centroid is measured
and each point is assigned to the
centroid which is closest to it so for
example
these points are very obvious that these
are closest to c1 whereas this point is
far away from c2 so these points will be
assigned which are close to c1 will be
assigned to c1 and these points or
locations which are close to c2 will be
assigned to c2 and then so this is the
how the initial grouping is done this is
part of c1 and this is part of c2 then
the next step is to calculate the actual
centroid of this data because remember
c1 and c2 are not the centroids they've
been
randomly assigned points and only thing
that has been done was the data points
which are closest to them have been
assigned to them but now in this step
the actual centroid will be calculated
which may be for each of these data sets
somewhere in the middle so that's like
the main point that will be calculated
and the centroid will actually be
positioned
or repositioned there
same with c2
so the new centroid for this group is c2
in this new position and c1 is in this
new position
once again the distance of each of the
data points is calculated from these
centroids now remember it's not
necessary that the distance still
remains the or each of these data points
still remain in the same group by
recalculating the distance it may be
possible that some points get
reallocated like so you see this
so this point earlier was closer to c2
because c2 was here
but after recalculating repositioning it
is observed that this is closer to c1
than c2 so this is the new grouping so
some points will be reassigned and again
the centroid will be calculated and if
the centroid doesn't change so that is
the repetitive process iterative process
and if the centroid doesn't change once
the centroid stops changing that means
the algorithm has converged and this is
our final cluster with this as the
centroid c1 and c2 as the centroids
these data points as a part of each
cluster so i hope this helps in
understanding the whole process
iterative process of k-means clustering
so let's take a look at
the k-means clustering algorithm let's
say we have x1 x2 x3 n number of points
as our inputs and we want to split this
into k clusters or we want to create k
clusters so the first step is to
randomly pick k points and call them
centroids they are not real centroids
because centroid is supposed to be a
center point but they are just called
centroids and we calculate the distance
of each and every input point from each
of the centroids so the distance of x1
from c1 from c2 c3 each of the distances
we calculate and then find out which
distance is the lowest and assign x1 to
that particular random centroid repeat
that process for x2 calculate its
distance from each of the centroids c1
c2 c3 up to ck and find which is the
lowest distance and assign x2 to that
particular centroid same with x3 and so
on so that is the first round of
assignment that is done now we have k
groups because there are we have
assigned the value of k so there are k
centroids
and so there are k groups all these
inputs have been split into k groups
however remember we picked the centroids
randomly so they are not real centroids
so now what we have to do we have to
calculate the actual centroids for each
of these groups which is like the mean
position which means that the position
of the randomly selected centroids will
now change
and they will be
the main positions of this newly formed
k groups and once that is done we once
again repeat this process of calculating
the distance right so this is what we
are doing as a part of step four we
repeat step two
and three so we again calculate the
distance of x one
from the centroid c1
c2 c3 and then c which is the lowest
value and assign x1 to that
calculate the distance of x2 from c1 c2
c3 or whatever
up to ck and find whichever is the
lowest distance and assign x2 to that
centroid and so on in this process there
may be some reassignment x1 pro was
probably assigned to cluster c2 and
after doing this calculation maybe now
x1 is assigned to c1 so that kind of
reallocation may happen so we repeat the
steps 2 and 3 till the position of the
centroids don't change or stop changing
and that's when we have convergence
so let's take a detailed look at it at
each of these steps so we randomly pick
k cluster centers we call them centroids
because they are not initially they are
not really the centroids so we let us
name them c1 c2 up to ck and then step
two we assign each data point to the
closest center so what we do we
calculate the distance of each x value
from each c value so the distance
between
x1 c1 distance between x1 c2 x1 c3 and
then we find which is the lowest value
right that's the minimum value we find
and assign x1 to that particular
centroid then we go next to x2 find the
distance of x2 from c1 x2 from c2 x2
from c3 and so on up to ck and then
assign it to the point or to the
centroid which has the lowest value and
so on so that is step number two in step
number three we now find the actual
centroid for each group so what has
happened as a part of step number two we
now have all the points all the data
points
grouped into k groups because we we
wanted to create k clusters right so we
have k groups each one may be having a
certain number of input values they need
not be equally distributed by the way
based on the distance we will have k
groups but remember the initial values
of the c1 c2 were not really the
centroids of these groups right we
assign them randomly so now in step
three we actually calculate the centroid
of each group which means the original
point which we thought was the centroid
will shift to the new position which is
the actual centroid for each of these
groups okay and we again calculate the
distance so we go back to step two which
is what we calculate again the distance
of each of these points from the newly
positioned centroids and if required we
reassign these points to the new
centroids so as i said earlier there may
be a reallocation so we now have a new
set or a new group we still have k
groups
but the number of items and the actual
assignment may be different from what
was in step
to here okay so that might change then
we perform step three once again to find
the new centroid of this new group so we
have again a new set of clusters new
centroids and new assignments
we repeat this step two again once again
we find and then it is possible that
after iterating through three or four or
five times the centroid will stop moving
in the sense that when you calculate the
new value of the centroid that will be
same as the original value or there will
be very marginal change so that is when
we say convergence has occurred and that
is our final cluster that's the
formation of the final cluster
all right so let's see a couple of demos
of k-means clustering we will actually
see some live demos in
python notebook using pattern notebook
but before that let's find out what's
the problem that we are trying to solve
the problem statement is let's say
walmart wants to open a chain of stores
across the state of florida
and
it wants to find the optimal store
locations now the issue here is if they
open too many stores close to each other
obviously they will not make profit but
if they if the stores are too far apart
then they will not have enough sales
so how do they optimize this now
for an organization like walmart which
is an e-commerce giant
they already have the addresses of their
customers in their database so they can
actually use this information or this
data and use k-means clustering to find
the optimal location now before we go
into the python notebook and show you
the live code
i wanted to take you through very
quickly a summary of the code in the
slides and then we will go into the
python notebook so in this
block we are basically
importing all the required libraries
like numpy
matplotlib and so on
and we are loading the data that is
available in the form of let's say the
addresses for simplicity sake we will
just take them as some data points then
the next thing we do is quickly do a
scatter plot to see
how they are
related to each other with respect to
each other so in the scatter plot we see
that there are a few distinct
groups
already being formed so you can actually
get an idea about how the cluster would
look and how many clusters what is the
optimal number of clusters and then
starts the actual
k-means clustering process
so we will assign each of these points
to the centroids and then check whether
they are
the optimal distance which is the
shortest distance and assign each of the
points data points to the centroids and
then go through this iterative process
till the whole process converges and
finally we get an output like this
so we have four distinct clusters
and
which is we can say that this is how the
population is probably distributed
across florida state and
the centroids are
like the location where the store should
be the optimum location where the store
should be so that's the way we determine
the best locations for the store and
that's how we can help walmart find the
best locations for their stores in
florida so now let's
take this into python notebook let's see
how this looks when we are running
running the code live all right so this
is the code for k-means clustering in
jupiter notebook we have a few examples
here which we will demonstrate how
k-means clustering is used and even
there is a small implementation of
k-means clustering as well okay so let's
get started okay so this block is
basically importing the various
libraries that are required like
matplotlib and numpy and so on and so
forth which would be used as a part of
the code then we are going and creating
blobs which are similar to clusters now
this is a very neat feature which is
available in scikit learn make blobs is
a nice feature which creates clusters of
data sets so that's a wonderful
functionality that is readily available
for us to create some test data kind of
thing okay so that's exactly what we are
doing here we are using make blobs and
we can specify how many clusters we want
so centers we are mentioning here so it
will go ahead and so we just mentioned
four so it will go ahead and create some
test data for us
and this is how it looks as you can see
visually also we can figure out that
there are four distinct classes or
clusters in this data set and that is
what make blobs actually
provides
now from
here onwards we will basically
run the standard k-means functionality
that is readily available so we really
don't have to implement k-means itself
the k-means functionality or the
function is readily available you just
need to feed the data and we'll create
the clusters
so this is the code for that
we import k-means and then we create an
instance of k-means and we specify the
value of k this n underscore clusters is
the value of k remember k means in k
means k is basically the number of
clusters that you want to create and it
is a
integer value so this is where we are
specifying that so we have k is equal to
and so that instance is created we take
that instance and as
with any other machine learning
functionality fit is what we use the
function or the method rather fit is
what we use to train the model here
there is no real training kind of thing
but that's the call okay so we are
calling fit and what we are doing here
we are just passing the data so x has
these values the data that has been
created
right so that is what we are passing
here
and
this will go ahead and create the
clusters
and
then we are using
after doing uh fit we run the predict
which basically assigns for each of
these observations which cluster where
it belongs to all right so it will name
the clusters maybe this is cluster one
this is two three and so on or i will
actually start from 0 cluster 0 1 2 and
3 maybe and then for each of the
observations it will assign based on
which cluster it belongs to it will
assign a value so that is stored in
y underscore k means when we call
predict that is what it does
and we can take a quick look at these uh
y underscore k means or with the cluster
numbers that have been assigned for each
observation so this is the cluster
number assigned for observation 1 maybe
this is for observation 2 observation 3
and so on so we have how many about i
think 300 samples right so all the 300
samples there are 300 values here each
of them the cluster number is given and
the cluster number goes from 0 to 3 so
there are 4 clusters so the numbers go
from 0 1 2 3. so that's what is seen
here okay now so this was a quick
example of generating some dummy data
and then clustering that okay and this
can be applied if you have proper data
you can just load it up into x for
example here and then run the cable so
this is the central part of the k-means
clustering program example so you
basically create an instance and you
mention how many clusters you want by
specifying this parameter and underscore
clusters and that is also the value of k
and then pass the data to get the values
now the next section of this code is the
implementation of a k-means now this is
kind of a rough implementation of the
k-means algorithm so we will just walk
you through i will walk you through the
code
at each step what it is doing and then
we will see a couple of more examples of
how k-means clustering
can be used in maybe some real-life
examples real-life use cases all right
so in this case here what we are doing
is basically implementing k-means
clustering and there is a function or a
library calculates for a given two pairs
of points it will calculate the the
distance between them and see which one
is the closest and so on so this is like
this is pretty much like what k means
does right so it calculates the distance
of each point or each data set from
predefined centroid and then based on
whichever is the lowest this particular
data point is assigned to that centroid
so that is basically available as a
standard function and we will be using
that here so as explained in the slides
the first step that is done in case of
k-means clustering is to randomly assign
some centroids so as a first step we
randomly allocate a couple of centroids
which we call here we are calling as
centers
and then we put this in a loop and we
take it through an iterative process
for each of the data points we first
find out using this function pairwise
distance argument for each of the points
we find out which one which center or
which randomly selected centroid is the
closest and accordingly we assign the
data or the data point to that
particular centroid or cluster and once
that is done for all the data points
we calculate the new centroid by finding
out the mean position which is the
center position right so we calculate
the new centroid and then we check if
the new centroid is the coordinates or
the position is the same as the previous
centroid the positions we will compare
and if it is the same that means the
process has converged so remember we do
this process till the centroids or the
centroid doesn't move anymore right so
the centroid gets relocated each time
this reallocation is done so the moment
it doesn't change anymore the position
of the centroid doesn't change anymore
we know that convergence has occurred so
till then so you see here this is like
an infinite loop while true is an
infinite loop it only breaks when the
centers are the same the new center and
the old center positions are the same
and once that is uh done we return the
centers and the labels now of course as
explained this is not a very
sophisticated and advanced
implementation very basic implementation
because one of the flaws in this is that
sometimes what happens is the centroid
the position
will
keep moving but in the change will be
very minor so in that case
also with that is actually convergence
right so for example the change is
0.0001 we can consider that as
convergence otherwise what will happen
is this will either take forever or it
will be never ending so that's a small
flaw here so that is something
additional checks may have to be added
here but again as mentioned this is not
the most sophisticated implementation
this is like a kind of a rough
implementation of the k-means clustering
okay so if we execute this code this is
what we get as the output so this is the
definition of this particular function
and then we call that find underscore
clusters and we pass our data x and the
number of clusters which is four
and if we run that and plot it this is
the output that we get so this is of
course each cluster is represented by a
different color so we have a cluster in
green color yellow color and so on and
so forth and these big points here these
are the centroids this is the final
position of the centroids and as you can
see visually also this appears like a
kind of a center of all these points
here right similarly this is like the
center of all these points here and so
on so this is the example or this is an
example of an implementation of k means
clustering
and
next we will move on to see a couple of
examples of how k-means clustering is
used in maybe some real life scenarios
or use cases in the next example or demo
we are going to see how we can use
k-means clustering to perform color
compression we will take a couple of
images so there will be two examples and
we will try to use k-means clustering to
compress the colors this is a common
situation
in image processing when you have an
image with millions of
colors but then you cannot render it on
some devices which may not have enough
memory so that is the
scenario where something like this can
be used
so
before again we go into the python
notebook let's take a look at quickly
the the code
as usual we import the libraries and
then we import the image and
then we will flatten it so the reshaping
is basically we have the image
information is stored in the form of
pixels and if the image is like for
example 427 by 640 and it has three
colors so that's the overall dimension
of the of the initial image
we just reshape it and
then feed this to our algorithm and this
will then create clusters of only 16
clusters so this this colors there are
millions of colors and now we need to
bring it down to 16 colors so we use k
is equal to 16
and
this is how when we visualize this is
how it looks there are these are all
about 16 million possible colors the
input color space has 16 million
possible colors and we just
sub compress it to 16 colors so this is
how it would look when we compress it to
16 colors and this is how the original
image looks and
after compression to 16 colors this is
how the new image looks as you can see
there is not a lot of
information that has been lost
though
the image quality is definitely reduced
a little bit
so this is
an example which we are going to now see
in python notebook let's go into the
python node and once again as always we
will import some libraries and
load this image called
flower.jpg okay so let we load that and
this is how it looks this is the
original image which has i think 16
million colors and this is the shape of
this image which is basically what is
the
shape is nothing but the overall size
right so this is 427 pixel by 640 pixel
and then there are three layers which is
this three basically is for rgb which is
red green blue so color image will have
that right so that is the shape of this
now what we need to do is data let's
take a look at how data is looking so
let me just create a new cell and show
you
what is in data basically we have
captured this information
so data is what let me just show you
here
all right so
let's take a look at
china what are the values in china and
if we see here this is how the data is
stored this is nothing but the pixel
values okay so this is like a matrix and
each one has about four for this 427 by
640 pixels all right so this is how it
looks now the issue here is these values
are
large the numbers are a large so we need
to normalize them to between zero and
one right so that's why we will
basically create one more variable which
is data which will contain the values
between zero and one and the way to do
that is divide by 255 so we divide china
by 255 and we get the new values in data
so let's just run this piece of code and
this is the shape so we now have also
yeah what we have done is we changed
using reshape we converted into the
three-dimensional into a two-dimensional
data set and let us also take a look at
how
let me just insert
uh probably a cell here
and take a look at how data is looking
all right so this is how data is looking
and now you see this is
the values are between zero and one
right so if you earlier noticed in case
of china the values were large numbers
now everything is between 0 and 1. this
is one of the things we need to do
all right so after that the next thing
that we need to do is to visualize this
and
we can take random set of maybe 10 000
points and plot it and check and see how
this looks let us just plot this
and so this is how the original the
color the pixel distribution is these
are two plots one is red against green
and another is red against blue and this
is the original distribution of the
color so then what we will do is we will
use k-means clustering to create just 16
clusters for the various colors and then
apply that to the image now
what will happen is since the data is
large because there are millions of
colors using regular k-means may be a
little time consuming so there is
another version of k-means which is
called mini batch gaming so we will use
that which is which processes in the
overall concept remains the same but
this basically processes it in smaller
batches that's the only thing okay so
the results will pretty much be the same
so let's go ahead and execute this piece
of code and also visualize this so that
we can see that there are these this is
how the 16 colors
would look
so this is red against green and this is
red against blue there is quite a bit of
similarity between this original color
schema and the new one right so it
doesn't look very very completely
different or anything like that now we
apply this the newly created colors to
the image and we can take a look uh how
this is looking now we can compare both
the images so this is our original image
and this is our new image so as you can
see there is not a lot of information
that has been lost it pretty much looks
like the original image yes we can see
that for example here there is a little
bit it appears a little dullish compared
to this one right because we kind of
took off some of the finer details of
the color but overall the high level
information has been maintained at the
same time the main advantage is that now
this can be this is an image which can
be rendered on a device which may not be
that very sophisticated now let's take
one more example with a different image
in the second example we will take an
image of the summer palace in china and
we repeat the same process this is a
high definition color image with
millions of colors and also
three-dimensional
now we will reduce that to 16 colors
using k-means clustering
and
we do the same process like before we
reshape it and then we cluster the
colors to 16
and then we render the image once again
and we will see that the color the
quality of the image
slightly deteriorates as you can see
here this has much finer details in this
which are probably missing here but then
that's the compromise because there are
some devices which may not be able to
handle
this kind of high density images
so let's run this chord in python
notebook all right so let's apply the
same technique for another picture which
is
even more intricate and has probably
much complicated color schema so
this is the image now once again we can
take a look at the shape which is 427 by
640 by 3
and this is the new data would look
somewhat like this compared to the
flower image so we have some new values
here
and we will also bring this as you can
see the numbers are much big so we will
much bigger so we will now have to
scale them down to values between 0 and
1 and that is done by
dividing by 255 so let's go ahead and do
that
and reshape it okay so we get a two
dimensional matrix
and we will then as a next step we will
go ahead and visualize this how it looks
does the 16 colors
and this is basically how it would look
16 million colors and
now we
can create the clusters
out of this the 16
k means clusters we will create so this
is how the distribution of the pixels
would look with 16 colors
and then we go ahead and apply this
and visualize how it is looking for with
the new just the 16 color so once again
as you can see this looks much richer in
color but at the same time and this
probably doesn't have as we can see it
doesn't look as rich as this one but
nevertheless the information is not lost
the shape and all that stuff and this
can be also rendered on a slightly a
device which is probably
not that sophisticated okay so that's
pretty much it so we have seen two
examples of how color compression can be
done
using k-means clustering
and we have also seen in the previous
examples of how to implement k-means the
code to roughly how to implement k-means
clustering and we use some sample data
using
blob to just execute the k-means
clustering
now you'll notice here
uh we've got we're using pandas whoops
drew it through the pandas and we're
going to go ahead and read it as a
panda's data frame
and of course pandas sits on numpy so a
lot of stuff you do with pandas can go
right into numpy very easily
and the reason i bring this up is
because pandas has a lot of tools in
there for just looking at the data real
quick and easy
and so the first one we want to go ahead
and do is do credit.df or credit
underscore df our data we read in info
and just see what that looks like
and when we go ahead and print this out
you can see here we have
13 columns
remember we were looking at our data and
it had those that row you couldn't read
across the top
then it has non-null count how many
values don't have null what kind of
objects are they they're an object an
integer
different things like that and we look
at object is it a checking account this
is probably text on here
duration how long credit history
amount savings account present employee
employed sense
so a lot of different numbers coming in
here and these are just the columns
we're looking at
and if you're going to look at the
columns it's kind of nice to actually
look at the data
and so we'll use the pandas to go ahead
and print it out just like you would on
a spreadsheet
hard to see them all on here but you can
see we have here's our row across the
top because panda does such a good job
sorting out columns
and the actual data
checking account a11 a12 a14
not sure what that means
duration how long they've had it credit
history
not sure what the a33 or a34 means i'm
sure it has a special meaning on there
the amount here's our savings account
and all the information on that
and this is actually a very a much more
easy to read view than what we had
before
as far as like that text file when
you're just looking at data through the
database sometimes those can be really
hard to read
this you can really see and if i take it
down a notch i can get all the columns
in here
we'll go ahead and keep it zoomed in
just so we can see that what's going on
a little easier
and then we can also do
credit df.i location the ilocation
feature in the pandas
is going to go ahead and do rows 0
through 5 and we're going to look at
columns 1 through 7. and let's go ahead
and just run that and you can see right
here
how we just split it up so it's really
easy to manipulate our data and get a
smaller view of different parts of the
data as we're going through it
and just like we can look at the first
seven columns we can also look at the
last seven columns
same kind of format we're looking at
rows zero through 5 column 7 to the end
if you leave the number out there
and you can see we can easily now look
at this on a smaller screen
much
better for displaying those are just
tricks to help you display
your information so that when you
present this in front of a group of
people
it makes it very easy to read or you
just copy this out and put it into a
document that kind of thing
and then we also like to go ahead and do
like credit status value counts and
things like that
again we're just looking at the
different uh
sets of information on here
and in
our pandas data frame value counts is
we're looking at unique values so
there's a lot of unique values in here
that's
700 and 300
that's a significantly diverse set of
data
and if we look at the data one of the
things we're looking at is the
status 0 1 0 0 1
and i'm going to guess that that means
that it is either default or not default
so that's probably what we're going to
want to look for
hopefully you've had your
specialty and domain remember we talked
about the different parts of data
science
domain is what field it is in
this would be in banks and loans
and so if we want to figure out what the
status of a new loan is
we're going to separate the status out
and so if we take our x features equals
a list of the columns that's all this is
credit underscore df dot columns
we remove status
and then we go ahead and this will print
our features out and you can see it's
everything but the status on the end
because that's what we want to predict
we want to predict the new data whether
that stat is zero or one or not and next
we want to do a little bit more data
preparation we're going to go ahead and
encode
um and we're going to take an encode
credit df we're going to create that off
of our
setup on here
and you're going to ask well what are we
encoding on here well when we go up to
here let me just go back all the way
when we're looking at all this
information up here
you can see there's
object
well
if i'm doing a prediction and
something's just a random object it
doesn't really mean anything there's no
numbers to process
and so when we come down a little
further
we can see down here that we are looking
at
a65 i'm not sure what a 65 means
we're looking at a93 personal status
we're looking at a143 these aren't
actual numbers there's some kind of
code that the bank put in probably
and so for our model they really don't
mean anything unless we convert them to
numbers
and you convert them to numbers by
literally creating a bunch of yes no's
so instead of thinking it as as
a173 and a172 as being 0 1 and if you
had a 174 maybe 0 1 2 you would think of
this as a label a173 is true or false
and then you'd have another label
a172 as true or false
so for every unique job in here that it
becomes another feature added in and
it's on or off it's true or false that's
what this
encoding is doing
and we'll go ahead and list our encoding
as it comes out
and if you come up here
you can see it did exactly what i was
describing we've now encoded it so
here's checking account a13 checking
account
a1214
a31 here's all of our
checking account numbers so there was
three of them uh here's our credit
history a31 a32 833 34.
again the computer has no idea of
knowing what those are all it knows is
those are each unique features and the
same thing with the
savings account a62 and so on going down
and so once we have our nice list of
there we can go ahead and do
pull this in here we go let's look at
our new data set
and if we go ahead and run the new data
set we have our income credit df
checking and we're just going to look at
these and look at the head this is just
the first few of these so we can see
what it actually looks like in the data
and just like i said it's now
0 0 0 0 1 1 0 0
this first column is just the count 0 1
2 3 4 that's not part of the data
but you can see here
that it just puts a check mark of 1
because it's an ac
a12
and we have a checking account ac a14
where it's also a check mark of one
going across
so we've done a little data preparation
we've come in here and done some
exploratory data analysis
and now we want to start building our
data model and we'll kind of go back and
forth between exploratory data analysis
and data model and then interpreting the
results on this
and so when we go ahead and import our
stats models as api
as sm
now a lot of times we use the
sk learner the scikit models in this one
we're going to go ahead and use the sm
model from stats models which is pretty
common for doing a very basic logistics
regression model and then from the
scikit we're going to have our trained
test split
with any data you want to go ahead and
train your model and then you need
something to test it on some unknown
data so you can see how well you did
very common in your day in your setting
up your models is to split it up into
your training set and your
testing set
and what i want you to notice on here is
we have x train well what is x train
that's all the columns except for the
last one which was the status was it
default or was it um in good standing
and then of course our x test is part of
the data we're going to split that up
by 0.3 so 30 of the data is going to be
30 of our rows are going to be put in
the x test and the y train and y test is
just the status and then we create our
once we've created our data and split it
up we go and create our model and it's a
logit we're just going to call it logit
but you a lot of times you end up seeing
logic model
with logit
it equals the sm logit x train
y train x train in sk learn it's always
x-train y-train
uh but in the
stats model it's it's reversed on there
uh and then they go ahead and run the
fit so we load the data up and then we
fit it
uh and then we can go ahead and
summarize that model and see what it
looks like let's go ahead and run that
it takes it just a moment
and we get a nice summary of our data
again we're still looking at the data
and we have
takes just a moment to to kind of feed
through and you can certainly see where
we have our coefficient
which has to do with the weights in the
model
standard error that's very important as
we look at this coefficient and how it
affects the model
p is greater than the absolute value of
z 0.025 these are all your statistical
notes on here
so as you look at these you might look
at like how big is a standard error
that's one of the big ones that i
usually look at
as we go up
and we start looking at the different
things
uh the higher the error the less
the more we want to be a little careful
of it the lower the error the better in
more general terms they also
have dealing with the model and its
iterations you can see some general
status on here how many iterations did i
have to go through uh before i was able
to come up with the numbers because it
kind of guesses it's playing a high-low
game and it takes six iterations until
it finds what it considers the best fit
and you can see there's more information
up here as far as when it converts how
it converts and so on now when we have
our
summary up there
one of the questions starts coming in
remember i told you we're looking at
like our standard error and you know how
these numbers all are telling us how
important each one of these features is
in running our prediction and if you
have a ton of features
and some of them are
just kind of all over the place all they
do is create noise
so we really want to get rid of them
they also cause issues in that if you're
running a huge amount of data and you
have to re-run this model over and over
again
this can really text your time and so
you're losing both time money and your
results might not be as good because
they might be weighted based on some of
these very fuzzy numbers
uh so we're going to look at significant
variables and put together a little
routine for that again we're
we've come in if you remember from
back here
we're still in kind of an exploratory
data analysis and data modeling they
kind of go hand in hand sometimes we
haven't quite got to interpreting the
results in running predictions and so
we'll go ahead and build this thing on
here it looks at the
lm values so that's coming up here where
this was generated
i have to actually look that up for the
this particular model because i usually
use the
sk learned version of this
so as we look at this we're going to
look at the p-values
of our variables and basically we're
looking to see how good the p-values are
if they're less than or equal to 0.05 we
probably
those are probably solid values
and if they're greater than that then
probably we're not interested in them
and so let's go ahead and run this and
we see that when we pull out all the
values that are less than or equal to
0.05 for the p values and if we go up
here
here we go here's our p i knew it was up
here i just wasn't seeing it correctly
so you can probably see duration that's
going to be good
amount 0.01 that looks good instance
instant
inst rate
which i'm guessing is the percentage
rate or the interest
it's trying to say in inst and interest
at the same time
so we have our interest rate and all
that if we come down here we see
duration amount
our instant rate age
checking account a13 checking account
a14
credit history a34 savings account 65.
these are our primary features these
ones are related when we look at the
data
these are the ones that are going to
predict whether it's a good or bad loan
and so now that we know which ones work
we want to go ahead and create our
recreate our
sm model or our final logit model and
you'll see here we now have the
x tray the y train and then instead of
the x train it's x train significant
variables right there
so all we're doing is is running this
just on the significant variables in the
setup and we'll go ahead and fit it and
you can see here you can actually
double bracket and do it all in one line
up above we had to do it in the two
lines this is how the
setup is for this particular module
and then we'll go ahead and do a final
legit summary and just see what that
looks like
and we can see here here's our p scores
remember they're all supposed to be
under 0.0
um underneath the 0.05 these are all
under 0.05
you can see up here are different
statuses as far as how it ran it still
took six iterations to go through the
data
the date and so forth and now that we
have a solid model
and that's if you remember correctly let
me flip back on over here we've done our
data modeling
we've created a solid model and so now
we need to actually run a prediction
so that we can interpret the results and
weigh in on that and see how good they
are
and so for that i'm going to go ahead
and let's find it over here
why
predict
so we have our model that we created we
want to go ahead and create our y
predict
and it's based on our final object and
here's the magic word predict or dot
predict
um and so this is where we're going to
come in and actually get our predictions
on here
that our model comes up and remember
we're testing
x test is going in there's our x test
and it's only the significant variables
so we've created our model now we want
to push in our test version that's never
seen this data before
so this is all new and then we're just
going to take a random sample to see
what it looks like
what do those predictions look like
in this random sample we're just looking
at 10 of these
and you can see here is the actual
number it says 0.08 gives us a 1
0.07
this is our probability number which is
i would have to actually look to see
whether
higher or lower is better
i'm guessing the closer to
zero the better it is but i'm not
completely sure on that i have to
actually look up on and see with this
particular framework
uh but you can see the actual prediction
one zero zero zero so i guess this is a
good loan a bunch of defaults and some
good loans that's what it predicts it's
going to come out as now just looking at
the data
you know it's confusing this is you have
different models they have different
setup they have the
predicted probability comes out on this
and other models it doesn't so you
really need a tool
to dig deeper into the setup to
understand what this means
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to take our predicted values which
you can see right here has an actual
predicted probability
and then we're going to go ahead and
insert on there
from a sample let me just run this
because it'll make a lot more sense we
have our actual value and our predicted
value so this is what we predicted and
this is the actual setup
if we just look at this right off the
bat we can see that we predicted zero
and this was a one
these all came out correct
uh number 332 came out correct 917 was
an actual they were good on their loan
they predicted it's going to be a
default
you start to see that there's some
variance so how do we measure that how
do we know whether our model was any
good or not
well for that we're going to go ahead
and
load up
a nice graph and we'll use
for our graph we'll import matplot
library pi plot
and seaborn seaborn sits on matplot
library
and this
matplot library inline is just because
i'm using jupyter notebook with the new
version i'm in it doesn't even need it
but i tend to leave it in for older
versions and then we rope import from
our sk learn
metrics this is your scikit
scikit is the main package and sklearn
is how it looks on here
and we'll go ahead and
run that so it's nicely loaded
and then we'll go ahead and create a
little routine
in just a moment here
to print this out so we can see what
that looks like
and this metrics
it's kind of a fun matrix because it it
tells you like how many you have
correct on the correct one
how many you had wrong on the wrong one
and this top part is just all
a draw routine
so it comes in here and has our actual
and are predicted and it's our cm
metrics it breaks it up
puts it into the heat map the sn heat
map gives it some colors
add some labels
and then we go ahead and show it and
we're just going to dump that in there
and run that
and you can spend forever building
graphics is so much fun
we come in here we have bad credit good
credit
uh we have bad credit good credit we
have predicted label
and so when you look at this you can see
here if it had
on the good credit
it tells you how well it predicted it
and how many false
positive it has
and on our bad credit
here we have bad credit bad credit it
said 30 of those
were bad credit it predicted them bad
credit
well 21 were good credit that it
predicted would be bad credit
and then we have here we have 188 that
were good credit
uh but the actual val and then they had
61 there were bad credit that it said
were predicted good credit
uh so at this point you'd look at this
and you'd say well
if i'm predicting uh
these are
this is our good credit here let me flip
this on over here
and this is our bad credit
there we go
um so we have bad credit good credit you
start looking at and you say okay can we
afford that many defaults after five
years or whatever it is
and so those are the questions you start
asking is does this model work good
enough to predict whether we should give
these people loans or not you're always
going to have somebody default on them
and again that starts going into domain
uh banking domain something i don't know
very much about
clearly i know whether i default that
alone or not which i don't and i try
very hard not to and then if we're going
to draw the chart which is
really nice to have just a clear visual
chart
metrics also has our classification
report
and you can see these are just the
numbers we are looking at
they let us know the precision
uh our f score and recall and all that
stuff on here you can just print a
straight up metrics classification
report now we looked at a regression
model let's go ahead and look at a
clustering model to see what that looks
like
and we'll go ahead and create a new
group
python on there
and this is going to be our
clustering setup let me flip this off
and switch on over to my clustering menu
in this case we're going to be looking
at k means clustering
so let's just put that up here okay
means
clustering
now the last one was a regression model
so it figured out coefficients for lines
you can go back to your old euclidean
geometry
or the algebra expression for a slope on
a line y equals mx plus b or whatever
and it goes on from there as far as
finding distances and
figuring out the lines on there this is
a little bit different we talk about
clustering it uses similar
ideas but it has to do with edges
two points and how do you figure out a
distance between two points and what
does that mean
now you'll see here we have our pandas
pd our numpy as np our matplot library
seaborn sits on matplot libraries we
talked about
they've added some parameters here as
far as colors and then we did an inline
for the matplot library again that's not
really necessary even in the new version
of the
jupiter notebook in the old version
jupiter notebook if you didn't do that
it would just kind of hang or disappear
and then we're going to import some data
it's important to have our data set up
in here
and instead of looking at this and
guessing what the data is
usually open up the csv file at this
time let's just go ahead and print it
under the df head
because really those those text files
are so messy and you look at the df head
it's easy to look at
oops had a path issue there
so college data
it's a csv so automatically knows
there's a dot csv on there
and we can see here that they downloaded
from a number of colleges
abilene christian university adelphi
university adrian college
and then it has whether it's private
i'm guessing yes or no
apps i'm not sure what that is
acceptance rate
applications i'm betting and then the
acceptance rate enrollment
top 10 percent top two five percent
undergrad so on so these are just
statistics based on
the college their college getting into a
college
and just like we did before let's
explore the data if you can remember
from the chart we were looking at we're
going through our data discovery data
preparation
and exploratory data analysis so we're
really kind of looking at the data and
what do we have here what came in
at this point the data has already been
prepared we're not doing a whole lot as
far as
getting rid of null values and finding
out whether it's bad data or good data
and that kind of thing and data
discovery would be figuring out which
data to send so that we've already done
so we're going to do the exploratory
data
jump into data modeling and interpret
the results just like we did with the
other one
and we'll go ahead and use the panda
tool to get the info
df you'll see df very commonly it just
stands for data frame a lot of people
use it as a generic setup when they
import from pandas
and so we have our info and you can see
right here
non-null numbers here's our count so
each one of these has 777 non-null
values
and again here's our type of data we're
dealing with
and if you remember from last time
here's an object
um this was our yes or no everything
else looks like it's integer we do have
a float value here
uh integer integer
floats and integers usually they're when
you're running them on a prediction
they're pretty interchangeable in a lot
of cases but whether it's private true
or false that's pretty important on here
the fact that they could probably be
switched to a zero or one
is pretty helpful also
and if we're going to look at all that
data we can go ahead and describe it so
there's our data frame describe
and you have the same thing here's our
count all these should be 777
we have the mean value so you can
actually look at what our average is
standard deviation
minimum different quartiles 25 50 the
third quartile that so on and of course
our max value on there min and max
and as we explore the data we can do a
lot of fun things on here
we're going to use our seabourn
and we're going to look at a room and
board versus graduation date we're going
to add this is going to be a heat map so
we're going to add
whether it's a private college or not
how it fits the size the aspect ratio
and all that that's what this line is
here seabourn
you can almost do your own class on
matplot library and seaborn because
there's so many features in there but
when you look at the very basics you can
throw up some data
and have a nice colorful map set up
and here we have our graduation rate
um compared to room and board costs
and in private or
public
so you can see that the graduation rate
uh compared to room and board hit play
interesting thought how much should i
spend on room and board
am i going to graduate the more i spend
on room and board and you can see
numbers go up there on graduation rate
and you can see that the
graduation rate tends to go way up for
your private schools
uh and the room and board also goes
continues to grow on private schools
kind of thing it's kind of just a fun
heat map and we can explore other things
in our doing our heat maps
we can look at
out state
whether it's out of state undergrad
private again is one of our setups on
here
and you can see here that um
for undergrad uh there certainly is a
lot more uh public schools and whether
it's out of state um interestingly
enough the out of state number goes way
up how many people coming from out of
state into the school for the private
schools
just kind of fun things if you're trying
to figure out where you're going to go
maybe you'd want to do this for picking
a bachelor's degree or a master's degree
or something or
certainly you could also plot this with
fun locations and download information
on
tourism sites if you're traveling that
kind of thing you do the same kind of
thing with
and we'll go ahead and throw out another
map on here
let me go and run this
this is a slightly different
setup on here with the outer state
and so we're running let's see pull this
up
bins 20
the bins is each how many
bins are you going to split it into
and this is kind of a fun one where you
can see private versus public
we have how many out of state
and
i'd have to look this up to see what
they picked on here
oh there we go okay so you can see we
have another chart that has to do with
the outer state and the number of
students coming in and private and
public
uh so a lot of different setups on here
as we dig into the different
graphing
so at this point we've just been kind of
looking at uh the graphs on here let's
go ahead and import our
cluster our k-means cluster
and you can see here we have we're going
to call it km i guess for k means or
maybe it's k means model
i always label mine with model
equals k means in clusters equals 2
random state equals 90.
and so we're when we cluster it we're
only going to cluster into two groups
that's what this this is meaning here um
across the different settings on there
and then we're gonna go ahead and fit
uh and we're gonna drop private
uh so we don't we're not going to be
looking at whether it's a private or
public school we're just going to go
ahead and
run the cluster on there
and then once we run the cluster on
there we can actually look at cluster
centers let's go ahead and do that on
this
we talk about k means let me run this
boom there we go
so we have
all these different columns and each of
those columns has the center and we
start looking how the data comes
together on those centers
that's what all these numbers this is
the hidden stuff behind the clusters on
here
and so we can now do maybe we'll create
a little converter here
if private equals yes return one else
returns zero
we're going to run our cluster private
and apply the converter
and then we'll go ahead and print that
out let me just show you what that looks
like so you can see what we're doing
here
and then we go ahead and do df cluster
we'll create a new column on here
private apply converter
and we can see here it creates some
private apps except
we've just added on to our data frame on
here
and we did that so that we can run the
confusion matrix
make sure we import our confusion matrix
we're going to do a classification
report confusion matrix and we'll go
ahead and run this on our clustering
and as you can see here as we're
predictions
uh here's our confusion matrix up here
just like we had on the other setup
where it has how many
um
false true false false uh true false and
false false as your accuracy and are set
up on there this is really uh if you're
looking at which where you want to go
maybe you're looking at where you want
to go in a i think more of a tourism
thing but um for colleges this is a
great way for looking for a bachelor's
or a masters
coming in here you can start finding out
which one you want to go to based on
this accuracy whether it's private or
public
or how many graduations are on there
so we looked at a couple examples went
through some of the parts of the cycle
whether using a k-means or linear
regression model
and certainly this cycle and these
models you start to see that there are
some similarities we're doing the same
thing and each model has
a better setup depending on what you're
trying to accomplish on there the need
for feature selection to train a model
we collect huge quantities of data to
help the machine learn better consider a
table which contains information on old
cars the model decides which cars must
be crushed for spare parts and when we
talk about huge quantities of data there
they save everything from people's
favorite cat pictures to
and you can imagine there's so much data
out there even in a company they'll save
all these little pieces of information
about people and companies and
corporations you need some way to sort
through because if you try to run your
models on all of it
you'll end up with these very clunky
models and they might have issues which
we'll talk about later but in this case
we're talking about cars and crushing
but not all this data will be useful to
us some classes or part of the data may
not contribute much to our model and can
be dropped and you can see right here we
have who was the owner of the car
in our data a car will not be crushed
based on its previous owner
so yeah that's kind of a clear cut you
can see that why would i care who owned
the car before once it's in the junkyard
and we're crushing the cars we're not
going to really care about that
so here we have dropped the owner column
as it does not contribute to the model
having too much unnecessary data can
cause the model to be slow the model may
also learn from this irrelevant data and
be inaccurate
so feature selection is a process of
reducing the input variable to your
model by using only relevant data and
getting rid of the noise in the data
consider the database given below a
library wants to donate some old books
to make place in their shells for new
books
we want to train a model to automate
this task
in this case the color of the book does
not matter and keeping it can cause a
model to learn to donate books based on
color we can remove this as a feature
using feature selection we can optimize
our model in several ways
and so the number one is to prevent
learning from noise and overfitting
that's actually the huge one because we
we don't want it to give us the wrong
prediction and that means also improved
accuracy
so instead of giving us a wrong
prediction we also want it to be as
close to the right answer as we can get
and we want to reduce the training time
it's an exponential growth in some of
these models so the each feature you add
in increases that much
more training time we talk about feature
selection methods we put together a
lacil flow chart that shows the various
methods used for feature selection
and you have your basic feature
selection and then there is supervised
and unsupervised
under supervised there's intrinsic
wrapper method filter method
so we talk about unsupervised feature
selection refers to the method which
does not need the output label class for
feature selection and that was uh you
can see here under super unsupervised we
don't have i mean that's really a
growing market right now
unsupervised learning and so feature
selection is the same thing
supervised feature selection refers to
the method which uses the output label
class for the feature selection and if
you remember we looked at three
different
we have intrinsic wrapper and filter
method so we're going to start with the
filter method on this now remember we
know what the output is so we're going
to be looking at that output to see how
well it's doing versus the features in
this method features are dropped based
on their relation to the output or how
they are correlating to the output
you can see here we have a set of
features selecting best feature learning
algorithm and then performance
and so we want to find out which feature
correlates to the performance on the
output consider the example of book
classifier here we drop the color column
based on simple deduction
and that kind of sums it up in the in a
nutshell as we want to filter out things
that clearly do not go with what we're
looking for we look at the wrapper
method in the wrapper method we split
our data into subsets
and train a model using this based on
the output of the model we add and
subtract features and train the model
again
and you can see here in the wrapper
method we have a set of features we
generate a subset we run it through the
algorithm and we see how each one of
those subset of features performs
consider the book data set by using the
wrapper method we would use a subset of
different features to train the machine
and adjust the subset according to the
output and so you can see here let's say
we take name a number of times red and
we run just those and we look at the
output and if we looked at him with all
four inputs and look at the output we'd
see quite a different variation in there
and we might say you know what condition
of the book and color really doesn't
affect what we're looking for and you
can see here we've run it on condition
of the book and color
depending on the output of the model we
will choose our final set of features
these features will give us the best
result for our model
and it might come up that the name
number of times red is probably pretty
important
the intrinsic method
this method combines the qualities of
both filter and wrapper method to create
the best subset
the model will train and check the
accuracy of different subsets and select
the best among them
we kind of looked at a little overview
of some of the stuff
some of the common feature selection
algorithms based on which method they
belong to are given below
and you'll see it's primarily under
supervised there's not like i said a lot
of unsupervised methods and the ones
that are usually used these methods
and finds a way to create a supervised
connection between the data
and we talk about supervised methods we
have our filter method which we talked
about and it uses like the pearson's
coefficient uh t squared anova
coefficient those are all under the
filter method and in the wrapper method
recursive feature elimination so
remember we're choosing a subset and we
want to go through there and look at
each one so you're just doing a lot of
loops or recursive calculations to see
which one works best and which ones
don't have an impact on the output
and there's a lot of genetic algorithms
to go with this too on the wrapper
method and how they evaluate it and with
the intrinsic method
there's the two main ones we're looking
at is the lasso regularization
the lasso algorithms are basically your
standard
regression model so it's finding out how
these
different methods fit together in which
ones have the best
add together to have the least amount of
error
the other one used in the intrinsic
method is the decision tree it says hey
if this one is this one produces this
result this one produces this result yes
no which way do we go based on the input
and the output variables we can choose
our feature selection model so you have
your numeric input coming in you have a
numeric output if you use the pearson's
correlation coefficient or spearman's
rank coefficient
you can then
select what features you're going to
feed into that specific model and you
maybe have a numerical input and a
categorical input so we're going to be
looking more at a nova correlation
coefficient or kindles rank coefficient
and if you have a core categorical input
and a numerical output we might be
looking at anova correlation coefficient
in kindle's rank coefficient
so based on the input and the output
variables we can choose our feature
selection model and you can see we have
categorical to categorical we might be
looking at the
chi squared test
contingency tables and mutual
information let's go and take a look and
see
in the python code what we're talking
about here
and i'm going to go ahead and use for my
ide the jupiter notebook in the and i
always launch it out of anaconda on here
and we'll go ahead and go up here and
create a new python 3 module
and we'll call it
feature
select
and since we're in python we're going to
be working mainly with your numpy your
pandas your matplot library so we have
our number array our data frame setup
which goes with the number array the
numpy the pandas data frame and then we
want to go ahead and graph everything so
we're going to import these three
modules
and then we put together some data
we're going to read this in it's kobe
bryant i guess he's a basketball player
our guys in the back we have a number of
them guys it's both we have a lot of men
and women so it's probably a misnomer
our team in the back
um they have a some of them have a
liking for basketball and they know who
kobe bryant is and they want to learn a
little bit more about kobe bryant what's
going in for what whatever is going on
with his game in basketball so we're
going to take a look at him
uh and once we import the data we can
see what columns are available
uh original features count so we can see
how many features there are
um
the length of it and we'll actually have
a list of them and then print just
the data head the top five rows
and so when we do this
we can see from the csv file uh we have
25 original features
our original features are your action
type combine shot type game event id and
so forth there's a lot of features in
here that they're recorded on all of his
shots this is we talk about like a
massive amount of data
i mean
people are sitting there and they record
all this stuff and they import this
stuff for different reasons
but depending on what we want to look at
do we really want all those features
maybe the question we're going to ask is
what's the chance of him making any one
specific shot
in right from the beginning we can look
at the some of these things and say team
name
team name probably
maybe it does matter because the other
team might be really good at defense
game date maybe we don't really want to
look at the game date team id definitely
not of importance in any of this
so we look at this we have 25 features
and some of these features just really
don't matter to us
we also have location x location y
latitude and longitude i'm guessing
that's the same data we've actually
imported the
the very similar data maybe they're
slightly zoned differently
but as far as our program we don't want
to repeat data some of the models when
you repeat data into them and this is
true for most models create a huge bias
they weigh that data over other data
so just at a glance these are the things
we're looking at we want to find out
well how do we get this these features
down and get rid of this bias and all
these
extraneous features that we don't really
want to
spend time running our models on and
programming on
and as i pointed out there's a location
x a location y latitude and longitude
let's take a look at that and see what
we're looking at here we'll go ahead and
create a plot of these
and we'll just plot we'll do a scatter
plot of location x and location y
and then we'll do a
scatter plot of
data lawn data lat which is probably
longitude and latitude
and the scatter plot let's go ahead and
actually put a little title here
location and scatter on there and we'll
just go ahead and plot these and when
you look at this
coming in
these two graphs are pretty identical
except they're flipped
and so when we look at the location from
which they're shooting from
they're probably the same and at this
point we can say okay we can get rid of
one of these sets of datas we don't need
both x and y and latitude and longitude
because it's the same data coming in and
as we look at this particular data the
latitude longitude we might also ask
does it really make a difference which
side of the court you're on whether
you're on the left side or the right
side
and so we might go ahead and explore
instead of looking at this as
x y we might look at it as a distance
and an angle we can easily compute that
and you can see we can create our data
distance equals the location x
plus the location y squared standard
euclidean geometry or
triangular geometry
hypotenuse squared equals the each side
squared
and then once we've done that
uh we can also compute the angle
so the data angle is based on the arc
tangent
uh and so forth on here so this is all
this is is we're just going to compute
the angle here
and then set that up
pi over 2 to get our
angle and we'll go ahead and run that
and you'll see some errors run come up
and that's because when we took slices
over here we took a slice of a slice
there's ways to fix that but it's really
not important for this example
so if you do see that you want to start
looking up here for
instead of data location x of
not location x0
this would be like
i believe the term is ilo dot eye
location uh if this was yeah this is in
pandas
uh so there's different things in there
but for this it doesn't really matter
these are just warnings that's all they
are and then let's combine our remaining
minutes and seconds column into one
there's another one so if you remember
up here we're trying to get rid of these
columns
do we really need let me see if i can
find it on here there we go there's our
minutes remaining
and then they had what was it it was uh
minus remaining and seconds column so
there's also a seconds column on here
see if i can find that one
this is where it really gets kind of
crazy because here's our seconds
remaining so you can see that here's our
minutes remaining this gets crazy when
you're looking at hundreds of these
features and you can see that if if i'm
going to
say
write a model that's going to predict a
lot of this and i want it to run in this
case it's a basketball and how good his
shots are as the data comes in let's say
i want to have it run on your phone
if i'm running it across hundreds of
features
it's going to just hang up on your phone
where if i can get it down to just a
handful
we'll actually be able to come in here
and run it on a smaller device and not
use up as much memory
or processing power
so we'll go ahead and take data
remaining time here
um
and data minutes remaining times 60 plus
data seconds remaining so we're just
going to combine those
and we'll go ahead and reprint our data
so we can see what we got
coming across we have our action type
combined and this is we do this a lot
we want to take a look at oops i got so
so zoomed in let me see if i can zoom
out just a little bit
there we go
boom
all right so we come up here you can see
that we now have our distance our angle
remaining time which is now just a
number
uh that computes both the minutes and
seconds together
and we still have we've
we've been adding columns i thought you
said we're supposed to subtract columns
right
we're going to delete the obsolete
columns when we get to them uh so we're
just filtering out and then this is a
filter method we're just filtering
through the things
that we really
don't need
and next let's go ahead and explore team
id and team name let me just go ahead
and run that and if you look at this we
have los angeles lakers and then they
have the team id here and they're unique
there's not that's not really anything
that's going to come up
because that's
this particular
athletes
works for that team so it's the same on
every line so there's another thing we
can filter out on there team id and t
name is just useless the whole column
contains only one value each and it's
pretty much useless
let's go ahead and take a look at match
up an opponent that's an interesting one
and we see here that we have
the lal versus por and the opponent is
por and ind
again here's a lot of duplicate
information
so
this basically contains the same
information on here
again we're filtering all this stuff out
and this is because we're only looking
at one athlete and this might change if
you're looking at multiple athletes that
kind of thing now these are easy to see
we might have something that looks more
like this
we might have something where we're
looking at the distance which we
computed and the shot distance are they
the same thing
and what we can do is we can plot that
and plot them against each other on here
and we see it just draws a nice straight
line
and so
again we're looking at the same
information so again we're repeating
stuff and we really don't want to be
running our model on
repeat information on here so again it
contains the same information so now
let's look at the shot zone area
shot zone basic shot zone range
so now we're looking at the zones and
what does that mean and we'll go ahead
and and do this also in a scatter plot
in this case we're going to just create
three of these side by side so we're
going to create
our plot figure side 20 by 10
and then we're going to define our
scatter plot by category feature and
we're going to do each one
set up on here give it a slightly
different color and so our shot zone
area is going to be plot subplot 131
scatter 131 is how that's read by the
way
meaning that
it's number one
we have three across
and this is the first one down so one
one one our scatter plot by category is
going to be the shot zone area we're
going to plot that
and then we're going to do the
shot zone basic and then the shot zone
range and each just push them through
our definition so each of those areas go
through and you'll see one three one one
three two one three three
again it's a one by three
setup and then it's just a place on each
one and so we look at this we can see
that
these shots
they map out the same so it's very again
redundant information
that should be intuitive um when we're
looking at this
in this color graphs
it kind of helps you start looking at
something you it's very intuitive like
this is you start to realize that some
of the stuff
you'll be looking for in data you might
not understand
and you'll see these circular patterns
where they match or they mostly match
and you start to realize um when you're
looking at these that they're repetitive
data and then you want to explore them
more closely depending on what domain
you're working in so we we look at these
we look at them and they look just like
the regions of the court but we already
have stored this information in angle
and distance columns so we've seen this
image before we go back up here and
here's our the similar image
and repeating that image is down here
and so let's go ahead and drop some of
this in this stuff so now let's drop all
the useless columns
and we can drop the shot id team id team
name
shot zone area shot zone range shot zone
basic
uh the match up uh the longitude and
latitudes we're putting that into
distance seconds remaining minutes
remaining because we combine that into
one column
shot distance because we have just
distance on there location x location y
the game event id game id all this stuff
is just being dropped on here and we'll
just go ahead and loop through our drops
and this is a nice way of doing this
because as you're playing with this
this kind of data
putting your list into one setup helps
because then you're just writing it
through an iteration
and you can come back and change it you
might be playing with different models
and do this with models you might be
looking at all kinds of different things
that you can drop and add in as you test
these out and again we're working in the
filter method so this is a lot of human
interaction with the data and it takes a
lot of critical thinking to look at this
stuff and say what matches and what
doesn't
and so we look at the remaining features
let me go ahead and just run this
the original to the new count we had 25
features now we have 11 features you can
see that right there we just circle that
there's our 25 and there's uh old new
now we're down to 11. so we've cut it
down to less than half
and you can just see
the actual different information on here
and the remaining time
at this point we filtered it through and
then we'd move into the next process
which would be to run our model on this
and maybe we would drop
some of the features and see if it runs
better or worse and what happens
uh that's kind of would be the next step
on there versus the filter setup and
that would be one of the other setups
depending on which algorithm you use
so that wraps up our demo on
filter the feature selection and going
through and seeing how these different
features are being repeated in this
particular in a basketball
setup the need for cost function comes
in a number of points one of them is
that after
training our model
we need to see how badly our model is
performing while accuracy function tells
us how well our model is performing they
do not provide us with the insight on
how to improve them better and when
we're talking about the training process
i'm not talking about you you train a
model and then you run this on there
we're talking about each time you train
the model the model itself is
continually going through iterations and
finding a better solution and hence we
need a correctional function which can
help us compute when our model is the
most accurate
a cost function is used to measure just
how wrong the model is in finding a
relation between the input and the
output
it tells us how badly our model is
behaving predicting consider a robot
which is used to stack boxes in a
factory
the robot might have to consider certain
changeable parameters called variables
which influence how it performs
let's say our robot comes across an
obstacle like a rock
the robot might bump into the rock and
realize that's not the correct action it
will learn from this and next time it
will learn to avoid rocks hence our
machine uses variable to better fit to
the data the outcome of all these
obstacles will further optimize our
robot and help it perform better the
outcome acts as a cost function which
helps us optimize our variable to get
the best variables and fit our model the
outcome of all these obstacles will
further optimize our robot and help it
perform better the outcome acts as a
cost function which helps us optimize
our variable to get the best variables
and fit our models
so to kind of understand this we're
going to look at a linear regression
model
and the cost function for linear
regression it uses a straight line to
fit the model this is done using the
equation for a straight line as shown
this should look familiar as your
euclidean geometry you have y equals
ax plus b where a and b a is a slope and
b is the intercept in this case we'll
call it output equals a times input plus
b for the intercept
in the equation we can see there are two
entities which can have changeable
valuables or variables we have a which
is the slope of the line
and b which is the intercept on the y
axis
if at first the variables are not
properly optimized we get a line which
might not properly fit our model
and you can see this line as you draw it
through the data might give us a very
skewed setup it might predict one point
of data
have a small error and a couple of them
and then a huge error on the other four
pieces of data going in
and this is when we start talking about
error
we're looking more at numbers
than a single on off obstacle
so it's more regression you'll think
regression numbers if you've seen some
of our other videos
so we're looking at the numbers how can
we minimize the error and as we optimize
the values of our model for some
variables we will get the perfect fit
for our linear regression model the cost
function will be the minimum of the root
mean squared error of our model
obtained by subtracting the predicted
values from our actual values our cost
function will be the minimum of these
error values
and you can see we have our output y
equals a input you could say a input x
plus b
and so in this case i just went ahead
and left it as
output well let's look at the cost
function the cost function j equals 1
over n so we're summing up all of our
you know outputs to inputs
and it's based on what we predicted it's
going to be so that was the output of
our formula minus the actual value that
we're looking for
and we square that
for our linear regression model the cost
function will be the minimum of the root
mean squared error for our model
obtained by subtracting the predicted
values from the actual values our cost
function will be the minimum of these
error values
when you think of this and you're
computing this in on a computer like you
know my mind is trying to look at this
long formula it's not really that long
really you're adding them up one at a
time so that makes it a lot easier your
data comes in and you say hey this is
what the answer is and then it goes back
and says oh these are what the answer
was supposed to be
and then you can compute each line one
at a time and easily add them up to get
your cost function on there
and we talk about cost functions we
certainly look at that in the linear
regression model and there's a couple
other ways to do a linear regression
model
but certainly we want to minimize the
error and we'd look at a cost function
for our neural networks
neural networks are interesting because
they have multiple layers on there
and a neural network is a machine
learning algorithm which takes in
multiple inputs runs them through an
algorithm and essentially sums the
output of the different algorithms to
get a final output
the cost function of a neural network
will be the sum of the errors in each
layer this is done by finding the error
at each layer first and then summing the
individual errors up to get a total
error the cost function of our neural
network will be the sum of errors in
each layer this is done by finding the
air at each layer first the error
function will depend on the model used
at each layer
and that's important to note if you're
working with neural network it's based
on the model used on each layer so
there's a whole nother level in here
that we're not going to address on
neural networks maybe i'll mention a
little bit when we look at the
code down here in just a minute
the below function is for linear
regression model
so we have a cost function which equals
the sum of the actual minus the
predicted
there's our error squared
one over the number of observations
so if you have if you're if you have a
hundred points of data going in and you
calculate your actual values minus the
predicted values you have to divide it
by a hundred
that way when you look at the cost
function over the next set up they're
very uniform and you don't end up
getting a bias on there
and so we can see here the cost function
equals one over n times i equals 0 to n
of y of i minus mx of i plus b squared
now when we're solving this
we have a gradient descent gradient
descent is an algorithm which is used to
optimize the cost function or the error
of the model it is used to find the
minimum value of error possible in our
model when you're writing code this
comes up there isn't a maximize
function if you go into most of like
learn a lot of the other packages in
python they have a minimize function not
a maximize function because we are
expecting this that the error will never
be unlimited you're always your error
can go to zero it can't go to negative
infinity and so you always are looking
for the minimum because you know it's
not going to be
an open-ended formula when you look for
that minimum and so the gradient descent
can be visualized as a ball rolling down
a hill in this case the ball will row to
the lowest point in the hill this point
can be taken as a point where the error
is leased
for any model the error will be minimum
at one point and will increase again
after that the graph shows the error in
a model and again this comes off of the
fact that we're squaring the error
the error that the best area you can
have is zero um but even if you have
like a negative error it gets squared
and so you have uh it's plus or minus
one it's not looked at as a negative
error and a plus error it's just how far
off are we from the
least amount of error in gradient
descent we find the error in our model
for different values of input variables
you can see here we have our error 1
listed there
this is repeated and soon we see that
the error values keep getting smaller
and smaller
this is repeated and soon we see that
the error values keep getting smaller
and smaller and it just keeps going down
until you find the bottom of our little
downward loop on our errors
and so we can take that and the air
graph for linear regressions is given
this graph is obtained using the cost
function j
you can see the cost function j this
should look familiar now we have our
predict minus our actual squared and
we're summing it up over the total
number that we're computing that under
we must reach the lowest point in the
graph this can be done by traversing the
graph from any point and moving to the
point where the error is lower now i
know this is a little repetitive but
this is going to make a sense why why
we're repeating here in just a minute
so
as we keep going down the hill the co
the small difference between each errors
can be attained by differentiating the
cost function and subtracting it from
the previous gradient descent to move
down the slope
so here's our cost function of j and
then we go ahead and try new numbers and
the gradient descent is going to be our
difference in those and that's how we're
going to look at finding that new value
in there
and if this is you know they put it in
the
differential of j and the differential
of theta so you have theta j minus alpha
times the differential we're just
looking at the differences just a fancy
way of saying hey what's the difference
of our last last cost function
minus the difference of our new cost
function and so you get a gradient
descent the gradient descent
full formula looks like this with the
the original difference minus the new
difference summation
and
and as we continue to go down we can
continue to compute the differences on
there to find our new values in the
above equation alpha is known as
learning rate it decides how fast we
move down the slope if alpha is large we
take big steps
now remember i said we're doing a lot of
repeating that we're going down the
slope and you're going to see why we
keep repeating that and
where the complications come in and it's
important to note that we have this
value in there of alpha hey how far are
we going to try on the next number are
we going to jump way ahead are we going
to take little steps
uh and you can see that this happens we
might completely miss the least error
point and our results will not be
accurate
so that's one of the dangers of hi
having a very high alpha
and as you go down uh if alpha is small
we take small steps and we may take a
very long time to reach the error point
and waste computational power to do it
when we're playing with this alpha we
might be talking the difference between
um a hundred iterations and uh 2 000
iterations when you're talking a large
neural network and suddenly instead of
solving this in the course of an hour
you're looking at days processing time
on your computer so it's very this is a
big deal to start understanding how that
alpha comes in and understanding your
data and how it all fits together
hence we need to optimize value for
alpha to attain the correct minimum
error value so we want it to go down as
quickly as we can without missing where
we want to go
for neural networks each layer will have
a cost function and each cost function
will have its own least minimal error
value the error graph for neural
networks is showing and this gets
interesting because you're going to see
that we have multiple minimal error
areas that come out from the neural
network
and this is also true even on
some of our regular models are more
complex that when you look at a
polynomial
regression model as opposed to linear
where we're fitting a curve versus a
straight line through the data
you start having multiple minimals and
depending on where we start we can
arrive at different value for the
minimum error
we need to find the minimum value out of
all local minima
and you can see here we have a
global minima and then the two local
minima and depending on where we start
we can arrive at different values for
the minimum error we need to find the
global minimum value out of all local
minima
and this can be a real challenge because
if you're looking at just one of those
loops
you run into the issue that you don't
know whether there's other minimal
minima out there
minimal values and if one of those is
the global minimal value and so this can
be quite a challenge when we're
programming and writing these putting
together these different models is
finding these different points
especially in a neural network
again it's not just a neural network
that has it come up that comes up in a
lot of regular solutions in our
different regression models the gradient
is sent for a neural network is just a
differentiation of this cost function it
can be written as gradient descent
equals
the theta j and then the differential of
j over the differential of theta
cost function j equals one over the
total number we're going to do and then
you sum up the total number of the
differences
of
the y of i minus mx of i plus b where m
and b is your slope and your intercept
of your linear regression model
the difference is is we're doing that
linear regression model
across
all the different neural nodes in the
different layers and that's where you're
summing them all up on there and it
still looks very similar
but it is done in a larger scale the
gradient descent for a neural network is
just the differentiation of its cost
function and the equation m
is the weight of the layer and b is a
constant called the bias
and you'll you'll see that a lot because
like in a neural network you might have
each node will have all the nodes from
above going into it so if you have 10
nodes going into it
you have to add all those nodes and they
have a weight the m value
and then the summation of all those
nodes going in all the values going in
from the above layer then has a bias in
there the bias weight that's an added in
and then you get the full you can see
down here we have the gradient descent
of the differential of j and the
differential of theta equals the total
number
and i'm not going to go too detailed on
the actual formulas we'll show that in
the code
a lot of times these formulas are always
being updated so when you're writing
code for this it's important to know
these formulas a little bit if it comes
up you can understand why it's doing
what it is but there's more than one
formula to compute this and so as you
start understanding these different
formulas you can start seeing how they
fit and how one works better than
another
these are the most basic formulas that
are currently used today
and you can see here
we form a nice little matrix with the 1
over n of n of i of 0
minus 2 x of i y minus m x of i plus b
there's our linear regression kind of
set up right in the middle of the
formula
and then you have that with the 1 over n
of n of i equals 0 minus 2 y i m x i
plus b so you're forming a matrix out of
it
so as we continue looking at gradient
descent for neural networks in the
following picture we are computing the
errors for each layer separately and to
this gradient descent will be applied we
also know that each layer has a weight
which is assigned to it
and so we have a total error at the end
and here's those nodes i was talking
about you have your input layer it goes
into a layer of algorithms
you use the error from those algorithms
to program each one of those nodes
and one of the things they're not
showing here is each input goes to each
one of the nodes to summit so i guess in
this particular image the sum would be a
single node
and then you have your layers each layer
goes into the lower layer and so forth
until you sum them up and you get a
total
error on the end the weight will be
different for each node in each layer
consider a node in layer 3.
the node will have an output which may
differ from the desired
output
so layer 3 has our predicted versus our
actual wanted
output on there and then we create a
weight equals a new weight as a value
the predicted output depends on the
weight applied to the layer we can tweak
it to get the desired output
we can similarly tweak the weight of
each node in the layer we use gradient
descent on the cost function to get the
best value of the weights
which is a variable in the cost function
using the corrected values of the
outermost layer we can tweak the weight
of the layer before that this will help
us minimize the error in the second last
layer too we keep using the corrected
weight of layer to further tweak the
weight of the layer before that and get
the desired output from the network this
is called
back propagation as we move backwards
so to kind of put that more in
perspective uh you have your output you
have your all of your inputs you know
maybe it's a picture with a million
pixels on it and you have a million
inputs
and it comes out and says it's a cat
picture or dog picture so you might have
just one output
or maybe
you have all your inputs and you're
trying to figure out what the next
predicted value for the stock market is
you have a number coming out
we look at that error at the very end
and we push it back to the layer right
before it and we kind of split it up
between all the nodes in that layer
and each one of those nodes computes an
error
then all of those nodes
push back their error to the layer
before and so forth that's what back
propagation is it starts at the end and
goes in reverse
so we've actually looked a lot of stuff
here as far as cost functions and neural
networks are probably the most labor
intensive as cost functions because
you're solving that cost function for
each layer and for each node in the
layer they're all working together so it
gets very complicated
but the cost function is the same we're
still looking at the same thing even in
a simple linear regression model so
let's go ahead and take a look at a demo
on a cost function
and i'm going to do this in
python
through i'm using the anaconda navigator
to open up a jupiter notebook in chrome
we'll go up here in our chrome setup
and do a new python 3
give it a moment
there and so we're going to be looking
at cost
function
i'm going to rename that
and let's go ahead and start by just
importing our numpy
in our map plot library so we have a
little view of what's going on here
and then i have a
data set that has a just a bunch of
random points on it kind of
we'll go ahead and just bring that in
this is a simple numpy load text because
we put it as a text file probably could
have put it as a comma separated file or
whatever
and you can see it's just a bunch of
pairs of numbers we have
6 11 17 592 whatever on there
and we can take that
list of numbers on there that was pretty
much randomly
uh set up on this
and we'll go ahead and plot it so you
can see what we're looking at run
and i would probably spend a little bit
more time on here
um
playing with this to see what the
numbers are
these are just random numbers so
you know don't write too much into them
there's nothing fancy going on here
they do kind of group along a nice line
that's what we're going to look up at
this graph and let me switch this this
is
sometimes we'll do graphs where we put
the x's in to make it very clear that
these are points on the thing but let's
just do a scatter plot on here that's
all this is if you looked at the last
one we had
we did a plot x y
rx marker size 10
this plot would normally do lines but we
change it to rx and we put a marker size
and that's what gives it the nice little
x's
but i like the scatter plot better so
we'll just do a scatter plot and you can
see the values kind of go from 5 to 22.5
0 to 25 on the y axis and if we drew a
line through here
which is what we're going to be working
with
this line would have a y-intercept our b
number and our slope m and we'd want to
just fit this
with the least amount of error between
all this data
and so uh we're going to go ahead and
create
and bear with me on this just for a
minute this part gets just a little
confusing here
let's lift a t off theta
we're going to take our theta equals our
numpy zeros we're just going to create a
zero array and it's um two by one uh so
it's just one row that's two wide
and our new x
numpy delete points numpy s one to one
insert
new x zero one axis equals one
learning rate equals zero initial
initialize b equals zero and iterates
fifteen hundred times
what this means
is that we're going to start with a flat
line that equals the x axis
this is y equals 0 times x plus 0.
there's our m there's our b there's our
slope there's our intercept
and the learning rate's going to be
looking at going 0.01 in its steps to
find the minimal error
now we're not talking this is the
distance between this line what it
predicts which is going to be very small
here on this point
let me just
there we go
you'll see this point here here's the
distance because right now we have a
flat line our flat line we just draw
that in there for you goes here and we
look at this the
the squared value of this difference
here
versus the squared value of this
distance here the squared value of this
distance this distance
and we're going to look at all these
errors and so we look at all the sum of
these errors
that is the area we're looking at is the
predicted which is all going to be 0
so we can just put 0 squared and the
actual
and actually did this backwards so
the actual would be here would be y
square y minus 0
squared
so y is our actual output and then zero
is our predicted output the first time
through because we set everything equal
to zero
usually you guess a little bit more in
the first one um i would take when i
write a script on here
it pulls the first two data points in
so maybe pull these two data in and it
says okay here's our line with our first
two data points and then it starts
looking for then it goes through and
looks for the error on there
but this is fine we start with zero on
here
and so let's go ahead and load this up
uh so we have our theta which is going
to track the differences
uh it starts off with pretty much
just a simple two points our first beta
and our first our first slope and our
first intercept
and so we need to start putting together
a cost function
and again a lot of this stuff is in your
scikit learning packages to find
minimums and stuff like that
and so our cost function goes in here
and it says m equals the length of the
points we're going to look at all our
points
y equals
delete points number s so we're going to
kind of skip through on looking at the y
and how they compare
and we end up with a
let's see here we go if we look at next
1 over 2 times n times numpy dot sum
this is just summing all of these values
up for us
and we have our numpy.power numpy
subtract numpy.x theta not be such a
powerful array it's just so fun to play
with it's a little hard to go backwards
and dissect this but this is just our
cost function on here
it's what we expected and what we're
actually going to get
and so
when we come out we print this we come
out we look at this we go okay so this
has an error of 32 that's what that
number is
that's just the first time through
the error is the summation of all those
lines to the x axes on there
and we're going to go ahead and do theta
second equals numpy array
and it's going to be the same thing but
we're going to
let me just run this
guessing at a second number uh based on
the first number and it gets an error of
54.
really this is telling us because we're
not doing we're not actually going
through the implementation of 0.01
remember up here we're going to iterate
learning rate of 0.01
we just went in and said hey what
happens if i take this error up here and
i adjust for it based on this error what
do i get well my new error is 54 it
actually got worse
that's why you need a gradient descent
when we play high low
you might look at it and just pick some
random huge number you end up with that
kind of return on there
and there's a lot of ways there's
actually a lot of math that can go into
this
you might do something where okay this
is this error maybe we would
try a value on each side of that error
that is a quarter of it
so there's some math in here that they
do when they do the optimization inside
kit which which really does a good job
zeroing in on this but to understand it
it's better to go ahead and do an actual
gradient descent
and so we're going to go ahead here and
do cost history this is just kind of fun
equals the numpy zeros iteration and
then we have our theta history
theta second
and so
it's going to have our first theta
oops
yeah that's right theta history
which we start off by just putting in
the number of iterations it's going to
go down and we're going to have our
theta second
which is we're going to start stacking
on them and tracking them and that's
really not what we're interested we're
interested in the cost history
but it's kind of fun to generate these
values down here the cost history is
what we're looking at
and we start with iterating through the
total number of iterations that's what
we set up above which was what 1500 yeah
there it is
1500 so we're going to go through 1500
iterations
we're going to do our production our
prediction which equals numpy dot
product x theta second
so right here we're just creating
what we guess a new number is based on
in this case our theta second
is our
is our slope on there that's why we're
doing the dot product
slope and intercept theta second so we
create our new theta theta second minus
one half times the learning rate there's
our 0.005
times our x dot
t
dot product which is a prediction minus
y
now
this code looks a little confusing it's
when you're digging through and you go
back you'll see how the numbers match up
playing with numpy arrays in itself is
a lot of fun and once you start playing
with them
looking at somebody else's code is
really hard to do the guys in the back
put this together for me
building your own code just becomes like
a very creative fun challenge to see how
it all fits and how you flip the numbers
around the dot t means i'm transposing
it
in a numpy array so i'm turning it from
columns to rows
and we're just going to take our theta
history and our iteration
and create a theta history and then
here's our temp cost
this is the one that's really important
uh it's going to be
1 over 2 times n numbi sum and we have
our numpy power numpy subtract numpy dot
x theta second of y
two so we're looking at the cost of each
iteration on there and this form
comes from here where we're summing the
all the different values and finding our
error
and then we're adding it on to theta
history and so here is our slope here's
our intercept and it just keeps guessing
for each one of these
and we could look at pieces of the
history and you can see it slowly
changes on here
a lot of times i'll do something like
this and just look at the end of the
data
the last
oh let's look at the last 20
run that
and the last 20 you can see that
62103261 602 this becomes a 5. a 0 is
kind of bouncing back and forth on the
slope
and it kind of zeros in to the 630 down
here 629 630 gets closer and closer to
this one answer on there
uh but that's not the part we want to
look at
the part we want to look at
is the
there we go is the
cost history we want to take a remember
we're dumping on here um
our temp cost and we're just going to
keep adding it on to the cost history so
let's go ahead and run that
there we go and you can see we have a
nice curve here and what you want to
notice on this curve what's really
important uh one of the things a lot of
programs look for would be the elbow
not as important on this particular
graph
and somewhere right around here
we jump from 800
to 1400
with almost no improvement look how
small this prove improvement is a lot of
times this improvement as you get down
to here
is
less than the actual error that we have
coming off of it
and so
when you're looking at statistics if my
error
is something like this here's my error
that means that these values right here
supposedly are getting better but they
might not be
so when you have
when you start looking at
the
craziness of data coming in
and how it varies at some point you cut
it off and you say okay right here we've
got to cut it off and you might actually
find an intercept here
usually though on the curve like this i
would look around 800 to 1000 around a
thousand you really are
just bouncing back and forth between the
bottom
and in this size of data that is way
beyond what this size of data would
actually be able to predict
and that's why this way you look at
these things you want to know where
where your points are and there's a lot
of algorithms to guess where this best
spot is
but as far as understanding
how we minimize the error you can see we
use a basic
setup to do our gradient descent to find
the minimal error
finding that bottom of our whoops that's
a horrible
loop finding that bottom of this
graph right here how close can we get to
zero there might be our zero line
so we've gone through a lot we have our
we went through a quick demo to show you
what that looks like and what's going on
in that minimize routine
using the most commonly used gradient
descent with a linear model
and we talked a little bit about how
that fits in with neural networks
pointed out that there's a global
and local minimals all important things
to understand when you start looking at
minimizing the error one of the most
common used tools to train our models in
our machine learning tool in our machine
learning kits
we talk about the principal component
analysis we're going to cover
dimensionality reduction principle
component analysis what is it
important pca terminologies and you'll
see it abbreviated normally as pca
principal component analysis pca
properties pca example and then we'll
pull up some python code in our jupyter
notebook and have some hands-on demo on
the pca and how it's used dimensionality
reduction dimensionality reduction
refers to the technique that reduces the
number of input variables in a data set
and so you can see on the table on the
right shows the orders made at an
automobile parts retailer the retailer
sells different automobile parts from
different companies and you can see we
have company bpex isomax and they have
the item the tire the axle an order id a
price number and a quantity in order to
predict the future cells
we find out that using correlation
analysis
that we just need three attributes
therefore we have reduced the number of
attributes from five to three
and clearly we don't really care about
the part number i don't think the part
number would have an effect on how many
tires are bought
and even the store who's buying them
probably does not have an effect on that
in this case that's what they've
actually done is remove those and we
just have the item the tire the price
and the quantity one of the things you
should be taking away from this is in
the scheme of things
we are in the descriptive phase we're
describing the data and we're
pre-processing the data what can we do
to clean it up
why dimensionality reduction well number
one less dimensions for a given data set
means less computation or training time
that can be really important if you're
trying a number of different models
and you're re-running them over and over
again and even if you have seven
gigabytes of data that can start taking
days to go through all those different
models
so this is huge this is probably the
hugest part as far as reducing
our data set
redundancy is removed after removing
similar entries from the data set
again pre-processing some of our models
like a neural network if you put in two
of the same data it might give them a
higher weight than they would if it was
just once we want to get rid of that
redundancy
it also increases the processing time if
you have multiple
data coming in
space required to store the data is
reduced
so if we're committing this into a big
data
pool we might not send the company that
bought it why would we want to store two
whole extra columns when we added into
that pool of data
makes the data easy for plotting in 2d
and 3d plots this is my favorite part
very important you're in your
shareholder meeting
you want to be able to give them a
really good
clear
and simplified version you want to
reduce it down to something people can
take in
it helps to find out the most
significant features and skip the rest
which also comes in in post scribing
leads to better human interpretation
that kind of goes with number four what
makes data easy for plotting you have a
better interpretation when we're looking
at it
principle component analysis
so what is it
principal component analysis is a
technique for reducing the
dimensionality of data sets increasing
interpretability but at the same time
minimizing information loss so we take
some very complex data set with lots of
variables we run it through the pca
we reduce the variables we end up with a
reduced variable setup
this is very confusing to look at
because if you look at the end result
we have the different colors all lined
up so what we're going to take a look at
is let's say we have a picture here uh
let's say you are asked to take a
picture of some toddlers and you are
deciding which angle would be the best
to take the picture from so if we come
up here we look at this we say okay this
is you know one angle
we get the back of a lot of heads not
many faces
uh so we'll do it from here we might get
the one person up front smiling a lot of
the people in the class are missing so
we have a huge amount off to the right
of blank space
maybe from up here again we have the
back of someone's head
and it turns out that the best angle to
click the picture from might be this
bottom left angle you look at it you say
hey that makes sense it's a good
configuration of all the people in the
picture now when we're talking about
data
it's not
you really can't do it by what you think
is going to be the best we need to have
some kind of mathematical formula so
it's consistent and so it makes sense in
the back end
one of the projects i worked on many
years ago
has something similar to the iris if
you've ever done the iris data sets
probably one of the
most common ones out there where they
have the flower
and they're measuring the stamen in the
petals and they have width and they have
length of the petal
instead of putting through the width and
the length of the petal we could just as
easily do the
width-to-length ratio we can divide the
width by the length and you get a single
number where you had two
that's the kind of idea that's going on
into this in pre-processing and looking
at what we can do to bring the data down
the very simplified example on my
iris
pedal example
when we look at the similarity in pca we
find the best picture or projection of
the data points
and so we look down at from one angle
we've drawn a line down there
we can see these data points based on in
this case just two variables now keep in
mind we're usually talking about 36 40
variables
almost all of your
business models usually have about 26 to
27 different variables they're looking
at
same thing with like a bank loan model
we're talking 26 to 36 different
variables they're looking at that are
going in
so we want to do is we want to find the
best view in this case we're just
looking at the x y
we look down at it and we have our
second
idea pc2 and again we're looking at the
x i this x y this time from a different
direction
here for our e's we can consider that we
get two principal components namely pc1
and pc2
comparing both the principal components
we find the data points are sufficiently
spaced in pc1
so if you look at what we got here we
have pc1 you can see along the line how
the data points are spaced versus the
spacing in pc2 and that's what they're
coming up with what is going to give us
the best look for these data points when
we combine them and we're looking at
them from just a single angle
whereas in pc2 they are less spaced
which makes the observation and further
calculations much more difficult
therefore we accept the pc1 and not the
pc2 as the data points are more spaced
now obviously the back end calculations
are a little bit more complicated when
we get into the math of how they decide
what is more valuable
this gives you an idea though that when
we're talking about this we're talking
about the perspective
which would help in understanding how
pca analysis works
we want to go ahead and do is dive into
the important terminologies under pca
and important terminologies are views
the perspective through which data
points are observed
and so you'll hear that if someone's
talking about a pca presentation and
they're not taking the time to reduce it
to something that the average person
shareholders can understand you might
hear them refer to it as the different
views what view are we taking
dimension number of columns in a data
set are called the dimensions of that
data set
and we talked about you'll hear features
dimensions um
i was talking about features there's
usually when you're running a business
you're talking 25 26 27 different
features minimal and then you have the
principal component new variables that
are constructed as linear combinations
or mixtures of the initial variables
principal component is very important
it's a combination
if you remember my flower example it
would be the
width over the length of the petal as
opposed to putting both width and length
in you just put in the
ratio instead which is a single number
versus two separate numbers projections
the perpendicular distance between the
principal component and the data points
and that goes to that line we had
earlier it's that right angle line of
where those point how those points fall
onto the line
important properties important
properties number of principal
components is always less than or equal
to the number of attributes
that just makes common sense you're not
going to do
10 principal properties with only three
features
you're trying to reduce them so it's
just kind of goofy but it is important
to remember that people will throw
weird code out there and just randomly
do stuff with instead of really thinking
it through principal components are
orthogonal
and this is what we're talking about
that right angle from the line when we
when we do pc1 we're looking at how
those points fall on to that line
same thing with pc2
we want to make sure that pc1 does not
equal pc2 we don't want to have the same
two principal points
when we do two points
the priority of principal components
decreases as their numbers
increase
this is important to understand
if you're going to create
one principle
component
everything is summarized into that one
component as we go to two components the
priority
how much it holds value decreases as we
go down so if you have five different
points each one of those points is going
to have less value than just the one
point which has everything summarized in
it
how pca works
i said there was more in the back end we
talked about the math this is what we're
talking about is how does it actually
work
so now we have understanding that you're
looking at a perspective
now we want to see how that math side
works pca performs the following
operations in order to evaluate the
principal components for a given data
set
first we start with the standardization
then we have a covariance matrix
computation
and we use that to generate our i gene
vectors and i gene values
which is the feature vector and if you
remember the i gene vector
is like a translation for
moving the data
from x equals one to x equals two or
whatever we're altering it and the i
gene value is the final value that we
generate
when we talk about standardization
the main aim of this step is to
standardize the range of the attributes
so that each one of them lie within
similar boundaries
this process involves removal of the
mean from the variable values and
scaling the data with respect to the
standard deviation
and you can see here we have z equals
the variable values minus the mean over
the standard deviation
the covariance matrix computation
covariance matrix is used to express the
correlation between any two or more
attributes in multi-dimensional data set
the covariance matrix has the entries as
the variance and the covariance of the
tribute values the variance is denoted
by var and the covariance is denoted by
cov
on the right we can see the covariance
matrix for two attributes and their
values
when we do a hands-on and look at the
code we'll do a display of this so you
can see what we're talking about and
what that looks like
for now you can just notice that this is
a matrix that we're generating with the
variance and then the covariance of x to
y
on the right side we can see the
covariance
table for more than two attributes in a
multi-dimensional data set
this is what i was talking about we
usually are looking at not just one
feature two features
we're usually looking at 25 30 features
going on
and so if we do a setup like this we
should see all those different features
as the different variables
covariance matrix tells us how the two
or more variables are related positive
covariance indicate that the value of
one variable is directly proportional to
the other variable
negative covariance indicate that the
value of one variable is inversely
proportional to the other variable that
is always important to note whenever
we're doing any of these matrixes that
we're going to be looking at that
positive and negative whether it's
inverted or not
and then we have the i gene values and
the i gene vectors
i gene values and hygiene vectors are
the mathematical value
that are extracted from the covariance
table
they are responsible for the generation
of a new set of variables from the old
set of variables which further lead to
the construction of the principal
components
iogene vectors do not change directions
after linear transformation
i-gene values are the scalars or the
magnitude of the i gene vectors
and again this is just chain
transforming that data so we're going to
change
the vector b
to the b
prime as denoted on the chart
and so we have like multiple variables
how do we calculate that new variable
and then we have feature vectors feature
vectors is simply a matrix that has igen
vectors of the components that we decide
to keep as the columns here we decide
whether we must keep or discard the less
significant principal components that we
have generated in the above steps
this becomes really important as we
start looking at
the back end of this and we'll do this
in the demo
but one of the more important steps to
understand
and so we have the pca example consider
matrix x within rows or observations and
k columns or variables now for this
matrix we would construct a variable
space with as many dimensions as the
variable
but for our simplicity let's consider
this three dimensions for now
now each observation row of the matrix x
is placed in the k dimensional variable
space such that the rows in the data
table form a swarm of points in this
space
now we find the mean of all the
observations and then place it along the
data points on the plot
the first principle component
is a line that best accounts for the
shape of the point swarm it represents a
maximal variance direction in the data
each observation may be projected onto
this line in order to get a coordinate
value along the pc1 this value is known
as a score
usually only one principal component is
insufficient to model the systematic
variation for a data set thus a second
principal axis is created
the second principle component is
oriented such that it reflects the
second largest source of variation in
the data while being orthogonal to pc1
pc2 also passes through the average
point
let's go ahead and pull this up and just
see what that means
inside our python scripting
i'm going to use the anaconda navigator
and i will be in
3.6
for this example
i believe there's even like a 3.9 out
i tend to stay in 3.6 because a lot of
the models i use especially with the
neural networks are stable in 3 6.
and then we open up our
jupiter i'm in chrome and we go ahead
and create a new python 3.
and for ease of use uh our team in the
back was nice enough to put this
together for me
and we'll go and start with the
libraries
the first thing i like to do whenever
i'm looking at
any new setup
uh well you know what let's do let's do
the libraries first we're going to do
our basic libraries which is matplot
library
the plt from the matplot library pandas
are data frame
pd numpy our numbers array np
seaborn for graphing sns that goes with
the plot that actually sits on matplot
library so the seaborn sits on there
and then we have our amber sign because
we're in jupiter notebook map plot
library in line the newer version
actually doesn't require that but i put
it in there either anyway just because
i'm so used to it
and then we want to go ahead and take a
look at the data
and in this case we're going to pull in
certainly you can have lots of fun with
different data but we're going to use
the cancer data set
and one of the reasons the cancer data
set is it has like 36 35 different
features
so it's kind of fun to use that as our
base for this
and we'll go ahead and run this and look
at our keys
and the first thing we notice in our
keys for the cancer data set as we have
our data we have our target our frame
target names description feature names
and file name
so
what we're looking for in all this
is um well let's take a look at the
description let's go in here and pull up
the description on here
i'm not going to spend a huge amount of
time on the description
because this is we don't want to get
into a medical domain we want to focus
on our pca setup
what's important is you start looking at
what the different attributes are what
they mean
if you were in the medical field you'd
want to note all these different things
whether what they're measuring where
it's coming from
you can actually see the actual
different
measurements they're taking
no missing attributes
we page all the way to the bottom and
you're going to have your data in this
case our target
and if you dig deep enough to the target
let's actually do this
let's go ahead and print target names
real quick here i always like to just
take a look and see what's on the other
end of this
target
names
run that
and so the target name is is it
malignant or is it b9
so in other words is this
a dangerous growth or is it something we
don't have to worry about that's the
bottom line with the cancer in this case
and then we can go ahead and load our
data
and you know let me go up a just a notch
here for easy of reading
sorry to get that just right that's all
you have to do
uh so let's go ahead and look at our
data uh our we're going to use our
pandas
and we're going to go ahead and do our
data frame it's going to equal cancer
data columns equals cancer feature
equals feature names so remember up here
we already loaded the the
names up of our of the features in there
what is going to come out of this let me
just see if we can get to that
it's at the top of target names um
that's just this list of names here in
the setup
and we can go ahead and run this code
and it'll print the head
and you can see here we have the mean
radius the mean texture mean perimeter i
don't know about you this is a wonderful
data set if you're playing with it
because
like many of the data that cut most the
data that comes in half the time we
don't even know we're looking at
we're just handed a bunch of stuff as a
data scientist going what the heck is
this
and so this is a good place to start
because this has a number of different
features in there we have no idea what
these feature means or where they come
from we want to just look at the data
and figure that out
and now we actually are getting into the
pca side of it as we've noticed before
is difficult to visualize high
dimensional data
we can use pca to find the first two
principal components and visualize the
data this new two-dimensional space with
a single scatter plot
before we do this we need to go ahead
and scale our data
now
i haven't run this to see if you really
have to scale the data on this
but as just a general
run time i almost do that as the first
step of any modeling even if it's
pre-modeling as we're doing here
in neural networks that is so important
with pca visualization it's already
going to scale it when we do the means
and deviation inside the pca
but just in case it's always good to
scale it
and then we're going to take our pca
with the scikit learn uses very similar
process to other pre-processing
functions that come with scikit-learn
we instantiate a pca object find the
principal components using the fit
method then apply the rotation and
dimensionality reduction by calling
transform we can also specify how many
components we want to
keep when creating the pca object
and so the code for this
oops getting a little bit
ahead let me go and run this code
so the code for this
is
from sklearn decomposition import pca
pca equals pca in components equals two
and that's really important to note that
because we're only going to want to look
at two components
i would never go over four components
especially if you're going to demo this
with somebody else if you're showing
this to the shareholders
the whole idea is to reduce it to
something people can see
and then the pca fit we're going to is
going to take the scaled data that we
generated up here
and then you can see we've created our
pca model with in components equals two
now whenever i use a new tool
i like to go in there and actually see
what i'm using so let's go to the scikit
webpage for the pca
and you can see in here here's our call
statement it describes what all the
different uh setups you have on there
probably the biggest one to look at
would be
well the biggest one is your components
how many components do you want
which you have to put in there pretty
much
and then you also might look at the svd
solver it's on auto right now but you
can override that and do different
things with it it does a pretty good job
as it is
and if we
go down all the way down to
there we go
to our methods
if you notice we have fit
and we have fit transform
nowhere in here is predict because this
is not used for prediction
it's used to look at the data again
we're in the described setup
we're fitting the data we're taking a
look at it
we've already looked at our minimum
maximum we've already looked at what's
in each quarter we've done a full
description of the data this is part of
describing the data
that's the biggest thing i take away
when i come zooming in here and of
course i have examples of it down here
if you forget
and the biggest one of course is the
number of components
and then i mean the rest you can play
with
the actual solver whether you're doing a
full randomizers different things it
does pretty good on the auto
and now we can transform this data to
its first two principal components
and so we have our xpca
we're going to set that equal to pca
transform scaled data
so there we go there's our first
transformation
and let's just go ahead and print the
scaled data shape and the xpca data
shape
and the reason we want to do this is
just to show us uh
what's going on here we've taken 30
features i think i said 36 or something
like that but it's 30.
and we've compressed it down to two
features and we decided we wanted two
features and that's where this comes
from
we still have 569 data sets
i mean data rows data sets we still have
569 rows of data but instead of
computing 30 features we're now only
doing our model on two features
so let's go ahead and
plot these and take a look and see
what's going on
and uh
we're just going to use our plt figure
we'll set the figure size on here here's
our scatter plot
xpca
x underscore pca of
one these are two different
perceptions we're using
and then
you'll see right here c for color cancer
equals target
and so remember we have zero we have one
and if i remember correctly zero was
malignant one was b9
so everything in the zero column is
going to be one color and the other
color is going to be one and then we're
going to use the plasma map just kind of
telling you what color it is add some
labels first principle component second
principal component and we'll go ahead
and run this
and you can see here instead of having a
chart one of those heat maps with 30
different
columns in it
we can look at this and say hey this one
actually did a pretty good job
of separating the data
and a couple things when i'm looking at
this that i notice is first
we have a very clear area where it's
clumped together
where it's going to be benign
and we have a huge area it's still
clumped together more spread out where
it's going to be malignant or i think i
had that backwards
and then in the middle
because we're dealing with something
in this particular case cancer
we would try to separate i would be
exploring how to separate this middle
group out
in other words there's an area where
everything overlaps and we're not going
to have a clear result on it
just because those are the people you
want to go in there and have extra tests
or treat it differently
versus going in and saying just cutting
into the can into the cancer so the body
absorbs it and it dissipates versus uh
actively going in there removing it
testing it going through chemo and all
the different things that's a big
difference you know as far as what's
going to happen here and that middle
line where the overlap is going to be
huge
that's domain specific going back to the
data
we can see here
clearly by using these two components we
can easily separate these two classes
so the next step is what does that mean
interpreting the components
unfortunately with this great power of
dimensionality reduction comes the cost
of not being able to easily understand
what these components represent
i don't know what principle component
one looks work represents or second
principle
the components correspond to
combinations of original features the
components themselves are stored as an
attribute of the filtered pca object
and so we talk look at that we can go
ahead and do uh look at the pca
components this is in our model we built
we've trained it we can run that and you
can see here's the actual components
it's the two components have each have
their own array
and within the array you can see the
what the scores they're using
and these actually give weight to what
features are doing what
so in this numpy matrix array each row
represents a principal component and
each column relates back to the original
features
what's really neat about this is we can
now go in reverse
and drop this onto a heat map and start
seeing uh what this means and so let me
go ahead and just put this down i'll
probably already get it down here
uh we'll go ahead and put this in here
we're going to use our
df comp data frame and we do our pca
components
and i want you to notice how easy this
is uh
we're going to set our columns equal to
cancer feature names
that just makes it really easy
and we're dumping it into a data frame
what's neat about a data frame is when
we get to seaborn it will pull that data
frame apart and
and set it up for us when we want
and so we're just going to do the cn the
seaborn heat map
of our data frame composition
and we'll use the plasma coloring
and it creates a nice little
color graph here
you can see we have the mean radius and
all the different features along the
bottom
on the right we have a scale so we can
see we have the dark colors all the way
to the really light colors which are
what's really shining there this is like
the primary stuff we want to look at
so this heat map in the color bar
basically represent the correlation
between the various features and the
principal component itself
so you know very powerful map to look at
and then you can go in here and we might
notice that the mean radius
look how on the bottom of the map it is
on some of this
so you have some interesting
correlations here that change the
variations on that and what means what
this is more when you get to
a post scribe you can also use this to
try to guess as what these things mean
and what you want to change to get a
better result
hi everyone welcome to this exciting
session by simply learn today we have a
really interesting topic for you
in this video we'll be analyzing the
upcoming united states presidential
election using twitter sentiment
analysis in python
in the course of this session we will
understand in brief about the upcoming
election the candidates fighting the
2020 u.s election and throw light on the
result of the 2016 new year's election
we look at the election forecast by some
of the popular news agencies
as well as pole analysis websites such
as 538
before we begin
i want to make it clear that this video
is solely for learning purposes
we had simply learned to not lean
towards any party in the united states
or are buyers towards any candidate
the analysis is based on what people
have tweeted and we will understand the
mood and sentiment of the public
the main objective of this video is to
help you understand how to extract
tweets from twitter handles using python
libraries
store it in a csv file and perform
textual analysis
the results obtained are purely based on
the data that we have collected
let's begin
the battle for the 2020 u.s presidential
election has begun with the 59th united
states presidential election scheduled
to be held on the 3rd of november 2020
this will decide who will be in the
white house for the next four years
all 435 seats in the united states house
of representatives 35 of the 100 seats
in the united states senate and office
of the president of the united states
will be contested
both the republican party and the
democratic party have nominated their
respective president and vice
presidential candidates
the incumbent president donald trump is
the republican nominee
while the 47th vice president of the
united states joe biden is the
democratic party's nominee
the current vice president mike pence is
the republican party's vice presidential
nominee and is running for a second term
in office
senator kamala harris of california was
chosen by joe biden as his running mate
on 11th of august 2020.
now
let's see the results of the last u.s
presidential election in 2016.
the republican ticket of businessman
donald trump and indiana governor mike
pence had defeated the democratic ticket
of former secretary of state hillary
clinton and u.s senator from virginia
tim kaine
donald trump received a total of 304
electoral votes while hillary clinton
got 227 electoral votes
a significant number of central states
in the united states were swept by the
republican party
it was surprising to see that donald
trump getting nearly 46.4 popular vote
as compared to hillary clinton who got
48.5 percent votes
donald trump's victory came after
crucial wins in the battleground streets
of florida ohio iowa north carolina and
pennsylvania
will donald trump be re-elected to the
white house or are we going to see a new
president and vice president of the
united states is the big question
let's see what our pollsters have to say
and what has been their forecast for the
upcoming election according to 538
donald trump has not gained ground since
the final debate on 22nd of october
at this moment joe biden is favored to
win the election and he leads in both
national and state pools
the economist is analyzing polling
economic and demographic data to predict
the u.s elections
their model thinks joe biden is very
likely to beat donald trump in the
electoral college as per their forecast
joe biden has 96 chance of winning the
electoral college and this 99 chance of
biden winning the most votes
the democrats have 75 chance of
controlling the senate while the
republicans have around 25 percent
the democrats are highly likely to keep
their majority in the house of
representatives
according to the guardian
joe biden is leading donald trump in the
national polls for the presidential
election
but to keep in mind this does not
guarantee the democratic candidate joe
biden's victory hillary clinton also had
a clear lead over donald trump in the
polls for almost the entire 2016
campaign she ended up losing the
electoral college
now the bbc forecast tells that biden is
leading national presidential polls with
51 percent
he has hovered around 50 percent in
recent months and has had a 10 point
lead on occasions
so clearly joe biden is set to be the
next u.s president let's wait and watch
what happens on the 3rd of november
the voters of america will decide on 3rd
of november whether donald trump remains
in the white house for another 4 years
let's perform a two-day sentiment
analysis to understand the sentiments of
people tweeting about donald trump and
joe biden by tagging them in their
tweets
we have our code implemented already
i'll run through each line of code and
explain our analysis in detail
the objective is to check the polarity
of each tweet to figure out if it's
positive negative or neutral we'll
compare the tweets of donald trump and
joe biden to see who people are favoring
the most
finally we learn to create a word cloud
i have already extracted the tweets and
stored them in two separate csv files it
takes some time to fetch 10 000 tweets
hence it won't be possible for me to
show it to you live
if you want to know how we extracted the
tweets for donald trump and joe biden
then please put your email ids in the
comments section of the video we'll
share the code file and the source file
with you
now you would need to install the tweepy
library fetch the twitter keys and
access tokens and then authenticate the
twitter api
i've extracted 5000 tweets each for
donald trump and joe biden converted
into a data frame and stored it in a csv
file
so let me open and show you both the
files
so here is my data set for donald trump
on the top you can see trump underscore
data 5000 which means there are 5000
tweets here
the first column
has the number of tweets it starts from
zero and goes all the way to 4999
the next column
is the text column which has the content
of the tweet
you can see
they have tagged at the rate real donald
trump
there are links as well there are
special characters like emoticons
and the third column is the user
which means
it's the username who had put that tweet
similarly
i have another data for biden
you can see these are
for joe biden
and here you can see the content they
have tagged kamala harris also
similarly we have the username
now let me take you straight to my
jupyter notebook where i have
implemented the code
okay so first and foremost let's import
all the required libraries so we have
the numpy library for numerical
computation
then we have the pandas library for data
manipulation next we are importing two
libraries matplotlib and c bond for data
visualization
then we have
text blob and word cloud
to get the sentiment and to build the
word cloud
and finally we are importing the plotly
library for creating graphs
let me run this cell
in the current cell we'll import the
data sets using read underscore csv
function present in the pandas library
so i have passed in my location where
the data file is so i placed it on my
desktop
and
the index underscore
col parameter or column parameter refers
to the columns to be used as the row
labels of the data frame here 0
indicates that the first column will be
used as row labels
let me run it
okay now we have imported both the data
files
let me go ahead and
print the shape of one of the data
frames
so i'll write print
let's say we'll check the shape of
biden data frame so i'll write print
biden dot
shape
i'll hit shift enter
you can see there are 5000 rows and
there are two columns one is the text
column and the next column is the user
column
now let me
go ahead and print the head of the data
sets
so the head function will return the
first five rows
i'll write
trump
dot head
you can see these are the first
five rows from the trump
data frame and similarly if you want to
check for biden i can write biden dot
head
you can see it here
now you can also use the info method
so let me
show you that you can write drum dot
info
and this is the result so it tells there
are 5000 entries from 0 to 4 99 there
are two columns
and these are the number of
rows
and similarly you have the data types
okay
moving ahead in the next cell i am
displaying the
200th tweet present in the trump data
frame so i have my data frame name
mentioned then i have my text column
and inside one more square bracket i
have put 200 which means i want to see
what's there in the
200th row
if i hit enter
so you can see this was the tweet fake
fake precedent
next
let me show you
the tweet number 1000 for biden
so i'll write biden
and inside square brackets i'll give the
text column
and
the number is
if i hit shift enter
so this is the tweet
now
the text blob function is used in
natural language processing
the sentiment property returns a named
tuple in the form of sentiment
in brackets polarity and subjectivity
let's check the sentiment of the 200th
tweet made for donald trump
if i hit shift enter
you can see this was the polarity
now minus
0.399 means
the polarity was negative and you can
see the subjectivity is around
0.933
similarly
let's check for biden's tweet number
so i'll write
text
blob which is my function name and
inside brackets i'll give biden
then
pass in my column name that is text
and
i'll give the row number which is 1000
and then i'll give
the
parameter
or the attribute sentiment
if i hit shift enter you can see the
polarity and the subjectivity
now moving ahead
here
i have defined a function that will add
another column called polarity to our
two data frames trump and biden
let me run this
ok
in the next cell
i have used the apply function that will
return the polarity based on the tweets
you can see we have the apply function
this might take some time to run it okay
we are done now
let me now display the top five rows of
the data frame
so
what i'll do is i'll click on this cell
go to insert and
i'll hit
insert cell below
let's do one more
okay now here
i'll display the head of the data frame
once again so that you can see the
polarity column added
you can see it here
so for donald trump
we have the polarity you can see the
tweet and the polarity now 0.0 which
means these are neutral
minus is negative and anything
that's in positive value
indicates it's a
positive tweet or it has positive
polarity
similarly let's see for biden
i'll write biden dot head
okay so here you can see the
polarity for biden now this 0.5 means
it's a positive tweet
okay
now
i want to create another column called
expression where we will classify the
tweets as positive negative or neutral
based on the polarity value so i have
used the np dot where function and the
condition we have here is
if polarity is greater than 0 it's a
positive tweet
else if it is less than 0 it's a
negative to it and if the polarity is
equal to zero it means it's a neutral
tweet
let me run this
okay
so here you can see we have the column
called expression
and it has classified the polarity based
on negative
neutral as well as positive
similarly let's do the same for biden
data frame as well
okay
before moving ahead if you want to get
access to the source code and the data
sets we have used in this demo then
please put your email address in the
chat section
we'll send it to you via mail
also please subscribe to simply learn
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an update from simply learn
in the next cell of code
we have another function that will
basically help us creating a bar plot
based on the expression column from both
the data frames so this is my user
defined function name and it has two
parameters reviews and title
you can see we have
grouped the expression column and found
out the count using the count function
then we have created or converted it
into a list
similarly
below you can see here
we have defined the
color for the bars using rgb values
now let me run it
okay
so we have successfully created our user
defined function
now let me go ahead and call the
function
and pass in my two parameters reviews
and title so here we have the function
name
and
under reviews we have the data frame
name trump and the title we have given
is analysis for trump
let me run this
ok
so you can see we have a horizontal
bar plot on the top you can see the
title of the plot which is analysis for
trump
and
as per the tweets it has classified as
positive neutral or negative
if i hover over you can see there were
831 neutral tweets
1211 positive tweets and similarly there
were
958 negative tweets for donald trump
now
let me call that function once again so
i'll write
exp underscore graph
which is my function name
then i'll pass in my
parameters this time i'll take biden and
the title i'll put is
analysis
for
biden
if i run it
okay
you can see the plot for biden now
if i hover over
there were 1290 positive tweets for
biden
and
747 negative tweets
okay
let's
scroll down
now let me check the number of rows that
have polarity equal to zero
the number of rows that have polarity
less than 0 and greater than 0 for both
the data frames using the
dot shape attribute
so first we have
for trump now equal to equal to 0 means
we are checking the total number of
neutral tweets
you can see the result
now let's check for biden we have the
result below
let me run it
okay
now
we'll drop those columns that have a
polarity equal to 0 from both the data
frames and display the shape
you can see
we have the condition mentioned
and we have also used the drop function
so all the neutral tweets will be
deleted
and i'm printing the shape of the data
frame
there you go
so out of the 5000 tweet it has deleted
all the neutral tweets or dropped all
the neutral treats and this is the final
result
in the current cell
we have defined another function called
balanced underscore data
now this will help us get an equal
number of rows and columns and delete a
specified number of rows
let me run it all right
now i'll call that function to delete
169 rows from the trump's data frame and
37 rows from biden's data frame this
will help us subset the data frames
you can see
we have now
2000 tweets from each of the data frames
up next we'll create some visualizations
to analyze the textual data
so first i'm using the c bond library
and creating
a distribution plot for donald trump
if i hit shift enter
you can see this is the distribution
plot this
there are bars at the back and there's a
trend line
okay similarly let me now create a box
plot
so this is
a box plot here you can see there are
some outliers
now let me add
a few cells below so that i can show
that plot for biden
so i'll write sns
dot
i'll use the function
dist plot
and under this plot i'll give
biden underscore
subset
and
i'll pass in my column that is polarity
let me run it so this is the
distribution plot for joe biden
and now
let me also create the box plot so i'll
use the
c bond library and the box plot function
i'll pass in my data frame which is
biden underscore subset
and i'll give my column name that is
polarity
i'll run it
so here you can see the box plot for joe
biden
let me tell you how you can create a
cross table using the group by function
so before coming to this cell of code
let me insert cell above
okay
now using group by function you can
create a cross table
so i'll use
the trump underscore subset data frame
and then i'll give my group by function
and inside group by function i'll give
my expression column
and i'll
count the number of expressions
if i run this
you can see this is a cross table
similarly you can do it for
joe biden as well
i'll just replace the
names i'll write biden
and the rest is the same
you can see
this is the cross table for biden
underscore subset
now moving
ahead let's find the polarity percentage
for negative and positive tweets to do
this i have defined a function called
pole underscore
percent
and we have two parameters declared
subset and total
let me run this
okay
now here
i am calling the above defined function
and printing the polarity percentage for
biden and trump
and i have mentioned my two parameters
subset
and the total number
so these are the values moving ahead
now let's create a bar graph that will
show the negative and positive polarity
percentage for donald trump and joe
biden
let me hit shift enter
you can see we have a
really good bar graph now if i hover the
mouse cursor you can see
donald trump had 27.825
percent of positive tweets
and
22.17 negative
similarly joe biden had
31.6 positive tweets
and
18.4 negative tweets
now we want to find the public sentiment
based on trump and biden tweets
let me run this two cells first
okay
now for donald trump
the total positive polarity is a
combination of trump's total positive
percentage and biden's negative
percentage
similarly
for joe biden the total positive
polarity is a combination of biden's
total positive percentage and
trump's negative percentage
let me run this
you can see the result here next
let's plot a horizontal bar graph to
visualize the public sentiment
we have our x and y labels defined
we also have set our bar colors with the
help of rgb values
and we have the title as well
now if i go up you can see this is the
public sentiment
so
26.88
is the percentage that is in favor of
joe biden and for donald trump you have
23.11
now coming down
now in the next cell of code
we have a user defined function that
will basically plot a table which has
the most positive tweets for donald
trump and joe biden
the condition we are checking is that
the polarity should be equal to one
so if it's close to 1 or equal to 1
which means
the tweet has positive polarity
let me run it
ok
now let me go ahead and call the
function
now let me scroll over to the top
you can see
these are the top five positive tweets
for donald trump
and
here you can see the top five positive
tweets for joe biden
likewise
let's check the polarity for most
negative tweets here the condition will
be the polarity should be
equal to minus 1 which means it's highly
negative
let me run it
okay
now
let's go ahead and call the function
negative tweets so i'll write neg
underscore
tweets
and then inside bracket i'll give my
parameters
which is trump underscore subset
and then
i'll give my title as
negative
tweets
for
donald trump
okay
now
let's copy this
we'll also check for joe biden so i'll
just replace this with
biden
and let's say
negative tweet for
joe biden
let's run it
okay
if i go on top here you can see
the top
negative tweets for donald trump and
similarly we have the
top five negative tweets for joe biden
all right
finally
let's see how to create a word cloud
now word cloud is a method to show which
words are most frequently occurring
among the given text
i have defined a function called word
cloud you can see here and it has two
parameters data and title
inside
the built-in function or the word cloud
function we have
mentioned the max font size
the maximum words
scale value there's also background
color which is white
okay
let's run it
now this will create
a word cloud
so let me go ahead and
call the word cloud function and pass in
the arguments
so i'll write
word cloud which is my user defined
function
and i'll give my parameters
trump underscore subset
comma
i'll give my title as
word
cloud
for
donald trump
let's say donald trump tweet
replies
okay
similarly
let's
do it for
joe biden
write word cloud
biden underscore subset
and then i'll give the title as
word
cloud
for
joe biden
to it
replies
okay let me run it
there you go
you can see we have a nice
word cloud
so on the top you can see the title
which says word cloud for donald trump
tweet replies
so here you can see
some of the words like real donald trump
then there's president
love
right
all these
similarly if i scroll down you can see
the word cloud for joe biden tweet
replies you can see there's the handle
joe biden
falls there are some
other words like due taxes belief even
will it's fact
and you can see kamala had his name here
okay now that brings us to the end of
this demo on twitter sentiment analysis
using text data
you learned how to classify tweets and
find the polarity we also looked at how
to create interesting visualizations
with this data and understood the mood
of the public
finally you saw how to create a word
cloud that had the most frequently
occurring words in the tweets who is a
data science engineer are you a data
science engineer or are you going to be
looking for a different field what
exactly is a data science engineer well
a data science engineer is someone who
has
programming experience in python and our
expert level knowledge ability to write
proficient codes and they we have python
and our i'm going to say python or r
once you become really proficient at one
language transferring those skills into
another one is usually fairly easy now r
is a little different because it is an
analytics platform so going from python
to r if you already know the data
analytics and python moving to r is
pretty easy uh now r doesn't have all
the other code that you can access with
python there's so many things you can do
with python that are not data analytics
so it's important to keep in mind that
you should probably be pretty
well-rounded in python and really have a
solid foundation in r or have a solid
foundation in r and be well-rounded in
another programming language where you
really get the programming side of it
strong sql and big data experience so
you have to have a strong coding skill
with hands-on big data experience and of
course we're showing sql here most
commonly used whether you're using a
microsoft sql server or mysql server you
can also start thinking hadoop and spark
in big data access hadoop file system is
not a huge jump if you've already
learned your sql and you've already
learned your basics and coding hadoop
sits on top of all that and does a
wonderful job creating huge clusters of
data but you really need to know your
sql because that is so common in most of
the large companies now accessing their
data and an ability to visualize models
and troubleshoot code of the models this
is a kind of an interesting one because
these models are can get very
complicated so you have to be able to
break them down into something that you
can put the pieces together and digest
each of the pieces so being able to
visualize these models is very important
and then being able to drill down and
troubleshoot the different models or the
pieces in those models you need to be a
versatile problem solver equipped with
strong analytical and quantitative
skills a self-starter with a strong
sense of personal responsibility and
technical orientation this is an
interesting one because when you talk
about data science engineer it's such a
new field that most companies don't have
it well defined they don't know what
they're looking for you might not even
know what you're looking for you might
have an idea and you're looking for
patterns but where do those patterns
lead you so you really need that
self-starter side to jump in there and
figure out where to go and be able to
communicate that back to the team and
there we go we have a strong product
intuition data analysis skills and
business presentation skills and this
was talking about is you got to bring
that back to the team so if you don't
have a strong product intuition if you
don't know what's going on with the
company what they need and where you're
going with your analysis it's going to
be a dead end and you've got to be able
to present that to the shareholders to
your co-workers which leads us to great
teammate with excellent interpersonal
skills and this is kind of a strange one
because you spend so much time behind
your desk so you have to be able to kind
of float between you're studying all the
data and being able to explain this to
people in simple terms that they can
understand no one wants somebody to come
up and say yeah the p score and the f
score is this that and the other thing
and you might have two people in the
room understand you you have to be able
to sit down and explain what that means
and why so let's take a look at the data
science skill set we talk about data
science engineer skill set we're talking
about database knowledge statistics
programming tools data wrangling
probably the least favorite and most
used machine learning data visualization
and then the touch on big data and so
we'll start with database knowledge
the most common databases of course your
sql structured query language
think rows and columns it's an essential
language for extracting a large amount
of data from data sets so knowledge of
the sql is mandatory for data science
engineers and you can see there's tools
required there's the oracle database i
mentioned mysql server microsoft sql
server teradata there are so many
different forms of sql and it'll just
keep coming back and coming back so if
you don't have a solid basic
understanding of sql go get it very
important because it will come up you
know it's if you don't know it it's
going to bite you and statistics of
course we are you know that's what this
is all about is figuring out and
predicting things so you need to know
your statistics statistics is a subset
of mathematics that deals with
collecting analyzing and interpreting
data therefore data scientist needs to
know statistics so you need to
understand your probabilities and what
that means and what the p score means
and the f score and means and mode and
median all that information standard
deviation all of those you need to be
aware of and then we get into the
programming tools and i mentioned this
earlier a little bit but you need to
master any one of these specific
programming languages programming tools
such as r python sas are essential to
perform analytics in data and again you
know you can move in there and you can
be an expert in just r you can be an
expert in just sas and a little bit you
can be an expert in python because
most of these when we're talking about
data science and data wrangling you
really kind of get down to the point
where you really need to have a full
programming language at least the basics
and if you're going to be working in
data science python right now is the
main one but you know there's also java
c plus plus so you need to know a solid
language at least the basics of it so
you can understand how to do basic
iterations and things like that i always
found that interesting that uh my sister
who runs a university data analytics
center that's the first question she
asks for people candidates to come and
work for is how do you iterate through
data you'd be amazed at how many people
don't understand that very basic concept
in programming so when we look at r r is
a free software environment for
statistical computing and graphs
supports most machine learning
algorithms for data analytics like
regression association clustering and
etc python python is an open source
general purpose programming language and
there's our general purpose i was just
talking about you need to know a little
bit about python libraries like numpy
and scipy are used in data science scipy
yeah numpy and scipy are very central to
python and i'd throw pandas in there
also that module those are very central
to working with python and data
analytics and then sas sas can mine
alter manage and retrieve data from a
variety of sources it can perform
statistical analysis on the data so
where r is the open source platform sas
is more like the paid for platform and
so it has some things more automated
because people are paying for it
developing it but it's also if you
really start using it as a company
you're going to have to pay for it where
rs free store a free software python is
also open source and free to use so
we're going to talk a little bit about
data wrangling and i mentioned earlier
that is both the probably people's least
favorite aspects of data science and
also probably one of the places you
spend the most time so we talk about
data wrangling it is a process of
transforming raw data into an
appropriate format to make it useful for
analytics and it involves cleaning raw
data structuring raw data and enriching
raw data and this gets interesting
because you'll get stuck on something
like
in python you might get stuck on
something that is a date time based on
an integer 64 numpy set you might not
know what all those terms mean because
you work in r or something like that but
you get the point that it's all one
particular format and then you have to
figure out how to switch it so that the
computer can see it correctly in
whatever format you're using or whatever
analytics platform you're using
knowledge of machine learning techniques
such as supervised machine learning
decision trees linear regression k n etc
is useful for few job roles so this is
kind of interesting because sometimes
that's the center of the job role of a
data scientist and sometimes you just
have to be able to apply the programming
skills to it so you can get the answer
and let somebody else fine-tune your
machine learning techniques so it really
depends on what it is you're working
with and you can see here we have our
nearest neighbor set up where it groups
things together that look alike linear
regression you're drawing a line through
the data or curve so you can predict
what uh the next value is going to be
and then our nice decision tree would
start splitting things up and says you
know it's sunny out yes let's go
swimming uh no it's raining we're not
gonna go swimming yes it's sunny out we
might go swim it's raining uh we'll stay
indoors yes we'll walk the dog no so you
have a decision tree that helps uh
figure out how you get to the end result
so decision trees can be pretty powerful
and data visualization data
visualization is the study and creation
of visual representation of data data
visualization uses algorithms
statistical graphs
plots information graphics and other
tools to communicate information clearly
and effectively this one you really have
to master as a data science this one you
really have to master as a data
scientist and there certainly are so
many different tools to use to visualize
it but when you're communicating a
picture is worth a thousand words when
you can put a picture up and and people
can look at and go oh i see what's going
on that's worth a lot more than saying
yeah yeah this is good people hear that
and they just kind of go okay it's good
but why and you might say you know okay
these numbers make it look good no
people want something they can see and
there certainly is uh tabloo is probably
um one of the most popular ones out
there caleb view
power bi google data studio
in python there's
the pi kit and seaborn there's all kinds
of different options for visualization
you need to master
probably at least one or two of them so
you understand how they work and how
they're different and then big data
big data is a massive amount of data
which cannot be stored and processed
using traditional methods big data has
various benefits like access to social
data can enable organizations to tune
their business strategies big data can
improve customer experience uh and so
we're usually when you say big data
we're almost
always talking about hadoop and apache
spark it used to be hadoop as your file
system so that's how you store all your
data going across the nodes and there
certainly are other ways to store it
when we talk about hadoop we're usually
talking about at least 10 terabytes of
data when you're dealing with a hadoop
file structure and then you can use
spark where hadoop processes on and off
the hard drive so it's continually
reading and writing to the hard drive
spark is running in your ram and so when
you're doing a very intensive data
process you'll run a spark setup which
will spread those processes over
multiple computers and of course now the
two uh combine and spark sits on top of
hadoop and you get your big data there's
also uh talent tableau has its own
server set up there's splunk uh
cassandra you'll hear the cassandra
database pentaho i'm not even sure how
to pronounce that one it's not one i've
worked with certainly there's a lot of
options for big data the two big players
are of course hadoop and spark and even
your sql servers and mysql servers will
spread across five different servers and
you can be talking about big data across
five servers with those pulling them
into say apache spark to do your
high-end processing and then there's
non-technical skills probably the most
important one in data science and any of
our data analytics is intellectual
curiosity updating knowledge by reading
contents and relevant books on trends in
data science this is such there's so
much going on in this field and it's
exploding now that it's hard to keep
track of it all
so you really need to have that
curiosity in the data science probably
even more so than a lot of other fields
but i would say in just today's world
you need intellectual curiosity because
things are changing so rapidly in
today's world the way it's going with
our technology understanding how the
problem solved can impact the business
business acumen this is the one where a
lot of people kind of skip over you have
to have a little business sense if you
don't know how it's going to impact the
business you're going to be in trouble
why do they want to even pay you to be
there unless they know what's going on
and they're getting something in return
so this is your bottom line for your
paycheck is what's going on with the
business how is this going to impact the
business what are you doing for them and
communication skills companies look for
someone who can clearly and fluently
translate technical findings to a
non-technical team and i've talked about
this a bunch and i i can't even iterate
this enough if you are struggling with
your communication skills work on
building them they don't have to be you
know this isn't rocket science where you
have to know all these complicated terms
what you need to do is take the
complicated terms you know from data
science and reduce that down to
something that anybody can understand so
when you come up and you have you know
knn no one knows what k n is you know
unless they're in data science nearest
neighbor looking for things that match
together you got to explain that to
people who do not have the technical
skill in the data science arena and a
data science engineer needs to work with
everyone in the organization including
customers
so it's team work and that's always one
that throws people for a loop but
ultimately
you are
analyzing your customers information and
so sometimes getting in there and
rolling up your sleeves if you're let's
say you're doing data analysis for the
sales team and you're backing a sales
team you might have to get in there and
go start making some cells and making
some phone calls and see what it's like
what is that team doing when they call
15 people in cold calls and then they do
a follow-up two weeks later or three
weeks later which one works better two
or three does it work better to call and
send a fax call and send an email you
know when you should you show up in
person if it's that kind of business so
working with everybody including the
customer is very important with the data
and with this kind of setup and
non-technical skills for a data
scientist so let's take a look at some
of the roles data science plays in the
job market let's drill in there just a
little bit here so when you have a data
scientist they're going to perform
predictive analysis and identify trend
and patterns that can help in better
decision making companies hiring data
scientists include apple adobe google
microsoft i would say that's even
expanding down to smaller companies you
know where you're talking about only 100
employees or something like that they're
starting to look at data scientists
because they need them to come in and be
a part of that team and the role is
understanding challenges of a system and
offer best solutions this should always
be the goal of a data scientist is to be
looking at the whole system and then
trying to find those patterns that are
going to best enhance the company or the
business or the whatever group maybe
you're working with the sales team or
the marketing team and you can see
languages um pretty important to have a
these are a number of different
languages and again it depends on your
own specialty there's all kinds of
different variations but we have r sas
python matlab sql hive pig spark you
should have at least a knowledge of all
of these maybe a python programmer never
used r download it go through the basics
so at least you know what's going on in
r versus python because r is pretty
powerful for doing a very quick display
and then of course a lot of things you
can do in python you have to be able to
do queries on database from time to time
create and modify algorithms which can
be used to reduce information from large
databases and usually this is one of
those things you do at the beginning you
set it up and then you kind of let it go
until it breaks and you have to go back
and fix it because your query isn't
working that certainly is a very common
thing to to have happen especially if
you're pulling data off the web and the
internet and then we have some more
companies that are hiring data analysis
like ibm dhl hp and so we're talking
about data analyst the role is
responsible for a variety of tasks such
as visualization optimization and
processing large amount of data and so
we're talking about a data analyst we're
also we're still talking a lot of the
same stuff but you'll see we now thrown
in javascript and html in here because
that's pretty common with the data
analyst versus a data scientist and you
can see that sql is still pretty solid
and also
cc plus is pretty big so some companies
also use java so i'd put java in the
languages also on that for a data
analyst and then you have a data
architect ensuring that data engineers
have best tools and systems to work with
and so companies hiring a data architect
are like visa logitech coca-cola they
create blueprints for data management
with the best security measures i cannot
highlight
that a data architect really spends a
lot of time with security measures
that's big how many hacks have we seen
in the last year on large companies have
lost data for millions of their
customers and how badly that affects
them and we're looking at languages as
you see that sql is pretty solid across
all of these under a data architect xml
that's one that a lot of the data
science jobs don't really you don't see
as much but you're going to see more xml
with a data architect because there's a
lot of xml files that are that have your
security measures embedded in them and
of course your hive pig those are hadoop
systems we're doing some basic queries
so instead of doing the high end queries
you know how these simplified query
systems built into hadoop and spark so
if you're using big data you're going to
want to know your spark also and then we
have our data engineer the data engineer
updates the existing systems with better
version of the current technologies to
improve the efficiency of the databases
think admin here a lot of work tracking
down what version you're in of the
different programs what version of
python are you using what version of r
are using what version of c plus so
companies hiring data engineers or like
amazon spotify facebook and they develop
construct test and maintain
architectures such as databases and long
scale processing systems and here we
have our languages our sql our matlab
sas spss python java ruby c plus plus
pearl hive pig you pretty much as a data
engineer at this level when you talk
about admin and updating all these
databases need to know all the different
stuff that's being used in the company
and you're testing out these structures
to make sure they work and so you really
are talking admin level uh kind of setup
so if you like spinning up an admin onto
a google cloud service or amazon cloud
service now you start to get an idea
what we're talking about because then
you can test it out up there and then
you can bring it back and update it to
the company statition creates new
methodologies for engineers to apply and
so when we look at this this is where
we're digging into the math of which
models to use what setup is going to
work what kind of activation do we have
on our neural network these little
tweaks are going to make a big
difference and we look for methodologies
at a large level what kind of data are
we going to be looking at how we're
going to pull it together companies
hiring a data engineer or we're talking
about stations we're talking about
linkedin pepsico johnson and johnson and
of course these companies probably hire
a little bit of everything but they have
a lot of statisticians working for them
and so we look at the role extract and
offer valuable reports from the data
clusters through statistical theories
and data organization and the languages
across the board we're still seeing sql
r matlab sas spss data that's a new one
seen in some of the other roles python
pearl an older version and that
shouldn't be a surprise because a lot of
these companies probably built a lot of
the original packages on perl if you go
look at johnson and johnson and of
course your big data hive pig and spark
and then our database administrator i
mentioned the other one is an admin
they're more an admin level for the
software itself so administrator is
another level some of the tasks involved
are monitoring operating and maintaining
databases installation configuration
defining schemas training users etc and
this is interesting training users
because when you build a database and
you define all the different
tables that are embedded in that
database and how they're all connected
the end user's got to have that
information otherwise you're in trouble
when we have companies hiring data
engineers of course tabloo twitter
reddit
the role ensures that all the databases
are available to all relevant users
again a little security in there what
role do they have is allowed in and not
and is performing correctly and is being
kept safe and you better be ready to
spend some time in security because
again that's a very big thing nowadays
with the number of people who hack into
these databases and the languages are
going to be covered you have your c
sharp your java sql ruby on rails xml
again there's that xml because a lot of
your security is embedded in xml files
um python all the main players depending
on what the company's using data and
analytics manager so when you see
manager that means that somebody's going
to sit on top and organize the people
underneath so they're going to improve
the business process as an intermediary
between business and i.t oh you better
have some really good communication
skills for this one some of the
companies hiring a data engineers are
coursera motorola slack and of course
these companies are hiring data
scientists in almost all of these fields
so the role oversees the data science
operations and assigns the duties to the
team according to skills and expertise
so that's a big one you better be able
to communicate what's going on help your
team members come out and be able to
communicate with other people so
sometimes your job is just being able to
get people to talk to each other the big
thing on that is is the whole
communication line going from one end to
the other because you can't communicate
all the information that everybody's
working on you have to pretty much come
in there and and help people communicate
what there's going on and also know what
they're up to without being
micromanagement because that will crash
a company if you micromanage everybody
but if you just let them do whatever
they want and they never talk to each
other that will also destroy the company
you gotta find that nice middle ground
and you really have to have an overview
of everything as a data and analytics
manager one of the things i mean you
know it's good to have at least one or
two solid bases of programming under
your belt for a data analytics manager
but you do need to have a very general
understanding of all the different tools
being used so that you know what's going
on with your different team members of
course sql r sas java python matlab all
of those are big business analytics
so this is when you're talking about
your bi or business intelligence and
your business analytics very important
to know this is kind of a subdivision of
a lot of the other stuff we've talked
about a lot of the other roles we've
looked at
so you possess specialized knowledge of
their business domain and apply that
knowledge and analysis specifically to
the operation of the business uh so you
might be a specialist in banking you
might be a
genetics engineer so you know about
genetics you might just be general
business
helping the marketing so a lot of
companies hiring data engineer oracle
uber dell and the role act as a link
between the data engineers and the
management executives so it's very
similar to when we go back up here we
look at data analytics manager a
business and analytics is going to also
kind of fill that role in between but
they're more specialized in business and
you better know sql because we're
talking about business specifically uh
most of the large companies are storing
their data that's up and running right
now that people are accessing to
purchase something on the home depot
website or the uber they're logging in
you better know your sql it's very
central to business analytics so let's
go ahead and take a look at the data
science engineer salary trends
and you'll see that our source is glass
door that's we're pulling a lot of our
data from average base pay is around 117
000 in the us the average salary and
when we look at india we're talking
about 950 000 a year and those are based
on some of them you need to go ahead and
dig deeper to find out what education
level versus entry level but those are
pretty solid base once you're in the
industry and once you created your
career in there we look at the job
titles the most common job title is data
scientist business intelligence manager
is the second greatest one
that's kind of good to note that's why
they put that up there as being its own
little subcategory of data science
managers a business intelligence manager
because it's such a high level of
jobs and then we looked at some of the
other ones data architect business
intelligence architect again your bi
your business intelligence gets its own
ranking because it's such a
high level you know it's a business
people want their businesses to make
money so that's who's hiring of course
data engineer business intelligence
developer business intelligence
consultant business intelligence analyst
business analyst and data analyst so you
can look at the data analysis being the
general one that doesn't go specific to
business so if you're looking just for
your career as far as getting a job
probably should have some kind of
business understanding in the background
and again you know your companies want
to make money so they're going to hire
someone who knows business if banking
business if you specialize in banking or
retail if you specialize in retail and
marketing and you can see here on the
data science salary trends and the
growth and data science job listings
it's continually going up it's um since
2014 to 2012 we've gone from 400 to 600
that's a pretty big increase so you know
huge growth in this markets one of the
biggest growing markets right now for
jobs and careers so let's go ahead and
take a look at building a resume always
exciting putting ourselves out selling
ourselves and if you looked at some of
our other videos dealing with resumes
you'll see a trend here
the top part is so different than what
resumes were in the 90s uh in the 2000
to 2010 they've evolved they've really
evolved it used to be 2000 2010 maybe
linkedin
maybe one other reference now you're
going to see that we want those
references
this is a sales tactic which now has
come into resumes used to be that if
you're a real estate agent every real
estate agent i knew i used to deal with
real estate software for the real estate
industry back in the 90s every real
estate agent won their picture on their
business card they wanted them their
picture if they could put on their
contracts they want people to see the
face so that's really a big change is to
make sure that it stands out you stand
out here's a picture of somebody so
you're more than just a couple letters
and a name but of course you need your
contact information should always be at
the top uh you have your summary what
are you focusing on be a little careful
with your summary because if you have
everything in your summary and then they
scroll down to experience and education
and skills they're going to stop the
second you repeat yourself in your
resume that usually means to the reader
hey this person doesn't have anything
more to offer me i'm done so be a little
careful how you word your summary most
companies appreciate when you come in
here and you've adjusted this summary to
be both about you and how you're going
to serve that company so it's worth
researching that company to find out how
those connect and put that in the
summary take some time to do that that's
actually a pretty big deal and the
references are huge also especially in
data science when you're talking about
any of the programming or data science
data analytics having a place to go
where they can look it up and scroll
down and see different things you're
doing whether it's linkedin in this case
which is the business profile most
commonly used github where you have
stuff published facebook
i'm always hesitant because that tends
to push more towards uh social media
type jobs and other jobs but certainly
there's people who have facebook
who do marketing and stuff like that but
these links having these basic links
here is important uh people are starting
to look for that for some other uh setup
maybe you have a personal website this
is a good place to put that so that they
now have a multitude of links that go
back to you and highlight who you are
and then the next part or next four
parts so for the next four parts we have
a combination of experience education
skills
certifications and you can see they're
organized if you have
you know a lot of people like to see
what kind of degree you have they want
to know where it came from and if you
just got out of college you're going to
put education at the top and then maybe
you'll put skills after that and then
your experience at the bottom if you've
been in the field for years
you know my degree just to give you my
age goes back to the 90 early 90s so i
usually put education at the very bottom
and then because a lot of the stuff i'm
trying to sell myself on right now is my
skills i actually put that at the top
and i'll put my education my
certifications at the bottom my skills
and then my experience is since it's a
huge part of my resume goes next you can
organize these in whatever order you
want is going to work best for you and
sell you so remember you're selling
yourself this is your image probably
don't wear an old tie-dye t-shirt with
holes in it you know something nice
because it is professional and of course
your summary your and then what do you
have to offer the company and again when
i put out resumes and i haven't done a
resume in a while you go in there and
you can take this and reorganize this so
if the company's looking for something
specific you might put the experiences
specific to that company you might even
take experience if you have like a long
job history like i do i've gone into a
lot of different things you might leave
out those companies or those experiences
that had nothing to do with data science
because it just becomes overwhelming
resume should only take about 30 seconds
to glance over maybe a minute tops
because after that point you've lost the
person's interest and if they want to
dig deeper they now have links they have
your website they have linkedin and they
can now take this and they come back to
it and they go okay let's look at this
person a little closer so quick overview
this is your sell sheet selling you to
the company so always tie it to the
company so that you have that what am i
going to give this company what are they
going to get from me we've covered a lot
on data science engineer in general and
we've gone over a basic resume remember
keep it simple short and direct that is
so important with that resume today's
topic of discussion is how to become a
data scientist in 2021
so here are the topics we'll be
discussing today a brief introduction to
data science
laying the groundwork for a data science
career
a short note on who is a data scientist
later we'll discuss the in-demand
technical skills for data scientists
and then the salary of data scientists
after which we'll discuss the future of
data science and data scientists
so now let's have a brief introduction
to the field of data science
there is no specific definition to
describe data science
if you ask 500 people to describe what
data science is you will probably end up
getting 500 different responses because
data science is a continually evolving
field
well under wikipedia data science is an
interdisciplinary discipline using
computational methods processes
algorithms and systems to derive
information and insights from both
structural and unstructured data
in simple terms data science is the
domain of study that deals with vast
volumes of data using modern tools and
techniques
these tools and techniques are used to
find unseen patterns derive meaningful
information and make business decisions
the data used for analysis can be from
multiple sources and present in various
formats
there is a saying a jack of all traits
and a master of none
when it comes to being a data scientist
you need to be a bit like this but
perhaps a better saying would be a jack
of all trades and a master of some
let's now discuss about laying the
groundwork for a data science career
let's now look at some of the
prerequisites for getting a data science
job
have a relevant degree
a solid educational background is
required to be a data scientist
pursue an undergraduate degree in data
science or any closely related fields
like statistics computer science or
mathematics
after the undergraduate course a
master's degree in one of the relevant
areas is an added advantage
creativity and critical thinking
creativity in data science is very much
needed in this field you will need it
for creating a storyline for innovative
modeling for developing new tools
different ways to collect your data and
lots more
parallely critical thinking is very
useful in data science a data scientist
should be able to develop questions and
at the same time question the data as
well required technical and
non-technical skills
we'll be discussing in depth the
required technical skills later on in
this video
talking about the other necessary skills
in this field you will need problem
solving skills risk analysis and many
more
good communication skills
having a strong command over your
communication skills is very much needed
in this field
the outcomes that are delivered through
data science are quite complicated and
hard to explain
you will have to translate your
technical findings clearly and fleeingly
to the other teams
you will need good presentation skills
storytelling skills writing skills and
listening skills
in short make sure you focus on building
lasting relationships through your
communication
here are some of the roles in the field
of data science
data scientist machine learning engineer
machine learning scientist data engineer
data analyst statistician
business intelligence developer
infrastructure architect enterprise
architect
applications architect
data scientist is most likely one of the
most sizzling job titles among the lot
and now
let's talk about who is a data scientist
in simple terms a data scientist is the
one who practices the art of data
science
a data scientist analyzes business data
to extract meaningful insights
in other words a data scientist solves
business problems through various
methods
dj patil and jeff hammerbacker coined
the term data scientist
a data scientist's work typically
revolves around data and his role will
be a combination of three main subjects
computer science
statistics and mathematics
it's time to discuss the in-demand
technical skills for data scientists
to become a data scientist you need
various skills as mentioned earlier some
of the significant technical skills you
will need to master include
programming
there are several programming languages
for data scientists
learning and mastering at least one of
them is essential to realize various
functions of data science
but at the same time just a single
language can't solve problems in all
areas
python is the most widely used
programming language in the world today
when it comes to data science
the next widely used language is r
there are still some data scientists who
use r instead of python
but if you're doing applied data science
these days then you've got to learn
python because that's the most valuable
programming language for data scientists
some other languages include javascript
scala
sql etc
talking about python programming
language it is open source and easy to
use language
you will need to understand the basic
syntax of this language initially
you will need to know how to write
functions
loops and modules
you should be familiar with both object
oriented and functional programming in
python
it is a general purpose and dynamic
programming language that supports
multiple paradigms
one of the factors that make python
stand out from the rest is its
flexibility
you can use python for almost all the
steps involved in data science
the next skill we'll be talking about is
machine learning
the concept of machine learning has been
around for a while now
however the ability to automatically and
quickly apply mathematical calculations
to big data is now gaining a bit of
momentum
you will need to learn techniques such
as supervised machine learning
decision trees logistic regression and
natural language processing
one of the crucial reasons why you need
machine learning in data science is
because of the high value predictions
that can guide better decisions
and smart actions in real time without
human intervention
there are in fact a lot of advantages of
machine learning in data science
it helps analyze large chunks of data
and it changes the way data extraction
and interpretation works
to sum it up machine learning and data
science can work hand in hand
with machine learning being such a craze
data scientists need to learn it
this is why simply learn has introduced
a revolutionary machine learning
certification program that provides
advanced level training on the
applications and algorithms it uses
we have provided the link in the
description box for the same do not
forget to check that out here's to yet
another essential skill in data science
math
mathematics is the bedrock of any
contemporary discipline in science
it's one of the major requirements for
data science
some of the major math topics you will
need to know are
calculus
linear algebra probability and
statistics some other math topics that
will help you solve data science
problems are discrete math graph theory
information theory and many more
up next we have analytical tools
they help you extract useful meaningful
insights from data and provide you with
valuable frameworks for processing big
data
data analysis is a core practice of
modern day businesses and choosing the
right analytical tools is very
challenging as no tool fits every need
anyway some of the most used analytical
tools in data science are sql spark
hadoop hive and many more
coming to data visualization
it is an interdisciplinary field that
deals with the graphic representations
of data data visualization plays two
prominent roles
communicating results clearly to a
general audience and organizing a view
of data that suggests a new hypothesis
of the next step in a project
some of the data visualization tools are
matplotlib
ggplot and d3.js
data visualization encompasses
techniques that are used to communicate
data or information by encoding it as
visual objects that are contained in
graphics
well as big data keeps growing data
visualization becomes an increasingly
crucial tool
up next we have data of wrangling
this is the process of gathering
selecting and transforming data to
answer an analytical question
it will help the data scientists fast in
decision making and hence get better
insights in less time
data wrangling is also known as data
cleaning or munching
at last we have business acumen
when you are a data scientist you must
have more business sense in analyzing
the data in other words you need to know
whether the insights gained from the
data is of value to the business or not
hence business acumen plays a very vital
role in structuring business data
analytics
when we are talking about business
knowledge three things come into the
picture general business knowledge
industry specific knowledge and company
specific knowledge
knowing these are very much important
when you are a data scientist
so guys this sums up the end demand
technical skills for data scientists
well let's now discuss the salary of
data scientists
before we go into the topic we would
like to introduce our new platform skill
up where you can find some of our best
courses for free we are offering more
than 1000 hearts of content for free
which can help you acquire more than 300
skills across a number of different
categories
take the next step to grow in your
career by joining skill up by checking
out the link in the description
when we are talking about the salary of
data scientists many factors come into
the picture the salary would depend on
the experience he or she holds
the industry the company size
educational background and finally the
region
according to glassdoor the average
salary of a data scientist in india is
close to 10 lakh rupees and that in the
united states is close to 1 lakh 13
309 dollars in the i.t field
the driving factor behind high data
assigned salaries is that the companies
and organizations are realizing the
power of big data and they want to use
it to drive smart business decisions
coming to our last topic of today future
of data science and data scientists
with every passing year data science is
improving and expanding at a
significantly faster pace
data science has found its applications
in almost every industry
healthcare companies are using data
science to build sophisticated medical
instruments to detect and cure diseases
video and computer games are now being
created with data science and that has
taken the gaming experience to the next
level
similarly data science has taken various
other fields to a whole new level
the top three most common search terms
in july 2020 are data science machine
learning and artificial intelligence
according to the 2020 emerging jobs
report linkedin listed data scientists
as the top third job with an annual
growth rate of 37 percent
for four years in a row data scientist
has been named the number one job in the
us by glassdoor
pursuing a career in data science is a
smart move
not just because it pays well and is
trendy it is because data is the pivot
point on which the entire economy turns
however you can also go through our
video on the topic tips for becoming a
data scientist for more information
thank you all for watching this video
tutorial on python for data science full
course i hope you liked it if you have
any questions then please put them in
the comments section below thanks for
watching stay tuned for more from simply
learn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here